this is a beginner-friendly introduction
to common data structures and algorithms
in python this course is taught by akash
ns the co-founder and ceo of jovian
data structures and algorithms in python
is a practical beginner friendly and
coding focused online course that will
help you improve your programming skills
solve coding challenges and ace
technical interviews
you can also earn a verified certificate
of accomplishment by completing this
course
learn more and register at pythondsa.com
this course runs over six weeks with two
hour video lectures every week with live
interactive coding using the python
programming language you will get a
chance to practice and improve your
coding skills with weekly programming
assignments consisting of real interview
questions and you will also build a
course project that you can showcase on
your resume or linkedin profile this is
a beginner-friendly course and some
basic programming knowledge will help
you follow along with the course don't
worry if you're new to programming you
can learn it as you work on this course
with a little extra effort
you will also get to access the course
community forum where you can ask
questions participate in discussions and
share what you're working on during the
course this course is created by jovian
a platform for learning data science and
machine learning with a global community
of tens of thousands of learners from
over 150 countries i'm your instructor
akash co-founder and ceo of jovian and
i'm really excited to kick off this
course with you
register now and invite your friends to
join the course at pythondsa.com
hello and welcome to data structures and
algorithms in python
this is an online certification course
brought to you by jovian
and today we are at lesson one binary
search linked lists and complexity
analysis
my name is akash
i am the ceo and co-founder of jovian
and i will be your instructor
you can find me on twitter at rcacheness
this course runs over six weeks and over
the six weeks if you enroll with for the
course work on four programming
assignments and build a course project
you can earn a certificate of
accomplishment
along the process you will also learn
about common data structures and
algorithms in python
and how to use these skills to
ace coding interviews and technical
assessments
so let's get started then
to begin we need to go to the course
website pythondsa.com
so if you open up pythondsa.com in your
browser that will bring you to this page
this is the course page and you can
watch an introductory video about the
course here you can enroll for the
course for free you will need to sign in
into jovian you can use your google
github or email to sign in into jovian
and once you're enrolled into the course
you can also invite your friends to join
the course the course is still open for
enrollments
so please invite your friends and
colleagues
this course is a beginner friendly
introduction to common data structures
and algorithms in python and this course
will help you prepare for coding
interviews
we have coding focused hands-on video
tutorials every week
so you can either follow along with this
video you can pause and run the code as
we speak
and you can practice coding on the cloud
or you can watch the video right now and
you can practice later
in this course we will solve questions
from real programming interviews
and you can earn a verified certificate
of accomplishment
so let's go to lesson one binary search
linked lists and complexity
on the lesson one page you can see a
recording of the lesson once it is
completed
and you will also be able to see a hindi
version here
and all the code used in this lesson is
linked below
so the first
set of code that we will look at today
is called linear and binary search so
let's open it up
so this is the first tutorial that we
will work through in this lesson
and you will be able to work through
with it as well
and this is part one
and there are a total of 12
notebooks or 12 tutorials we will go
through
now this course assumes very little
background in programming and
mathematics but you still do need to
know a little bit for instance you do
need to know basic programming with
python things like variables data types
loops and functions and don't worry if
you don't know them already you can
click through and follow these links
each of these is a separate tutorial the
tutorial will take you about half an
hour or so each of these and you can
learn the basic programming with python
in just a couple of hours
you will also need to know some high
school mathematics
and if you want to brush up things like
polynomials vectors matrices and
probabilities you can click through and
read these
but no prior knowledge of data
structures or algorithms is required you
do not need to have an extensive coding
background
and we will cover any additional
mathematical and theoretical concepts as
we
we need as we go along
so how to run the code what you will see
here
is that some explanations and then you
will also see some code so you can see
here that there is some code written
here and there is some
func so the library is imported and a
function from the library is used here
now to run this code you have two
options you can either run this code
using free online resources which is
what we recommend or you can run it on
your computer locally and you can read
these instructions i am going to use
free online resources provided by jovin
so we just scroll up here at the top of
this page and click run and then click
run on binder
so this will take a second or two and
what we're doing here essentially is
setting up a machine for you on the
cloud using a software called binder
it's an open source software
and now what you were looking at here
this was actually not a
blog post this is actually something
called a jupiter notebook a jupiter
notebook
is something that can
not only contain explanations but can
also contain code and you can look at
the code and its outputs right here in
an interactive fashion so if i scroll
down here you can see that we have all
the same content that we were looking at
except this time we can actually run
this code so we can click the run button
here
and the run button will run the code
and here we click the second run button
that is going to run the second
line of code
now we will be using jupyter notebooks
extensively throughout this course
because jupyter notebooks are a great
way to do interactive programming you
can change the code
for example instead of the math mat dot
square root you can use mat dot seal and
you can change the value here
so jupyter notebooks are great for
experimenting with code
now just a couple of tips that you want
to do as soon as you run a jupyter
notebook
you can click on kernel and click
restart and clear output
what this will do is this will remove
all the pre-executed outputs from your
code
so you can now see that the output of
the function is gone and you can see
that the numbers here go away so now you
can execute the code
line by line yourself and see the output
discover the output
and then one other thing you can do if
you want to hide the ui a little bit is
to toggle the header
and also toggle the toolbar
now you might need the toolbar for the
run button but there's a tip here
instead of pressing the run button you
can use shift plus enter so if you press
shift plus enter that will execute a
cell and that's a pretty handy shortcut
so once again you go on the lesson page
on the lesson page you will find a link
to the notebook called linear and binary
search
on the linear and binary search you can
read the explanations but you can't run
them to run the code you need to click
run and then select run on binder and
clicking run on binder will
set up a cloud machine for you
and all the code that you see here will
get executed on the cloud
so you do not need to set up anything on
your computer you do not need to
download anything we've done all that
for you
so let's get started then
this course takes a coding focused
approach towards learning and in each
notebook or each tutorial we will focus
on solving one problem and then learn
the techniques algorithms and data
structures to device an efficient
solution for that specific problem we
will then generalize the technique and
apply it to other problems
so in this specific tutorial we will
focus on solving this problem
and here's the problem we're solving
and this is a typical problem that you
will come across in a coding challenge
or a coding interview so here's how the
problem goes alice has some cards with
numbers written on them and then she
arranges the cards in decreasing order
and lays them out face down in a
sequence on a table so this is what it
looks like these are cards each of these
cards has a number below it and the
numbers are in decreasing order she
challenges bob to pick out the card
containing a given number for example
she could say bob i want you to pick out
the number 7
by turning over as few cards as possible
so this is a puzzle that's given to us
and we're not told how many cards alice
has so you need to write a function to
help bob locate the card
so alice can put down any number of
cards and the target number that bob has
to pick out could be anything so we have
to tell bob
not
us not the solution for a specific
problem but a general strategy that he
can use
to turn over as few cards as possible
so for instance look at these seven
cards and maybe put some imaginary
imaginary numbers before them below them
and try to figure out a strategy try to
start thinking about the problem
and this may seem like a simple problem
especially if you're familiar with the
concept of binary search but the
strategy and technique that we're
learning here will be widely applicable
and we will soon use it to solve harder
problems
now before while you think about the
problem and before we start solving it
i just want to talk about why you should
learn data structures and algorithms and
whether you're pursuing a career in
software development or data science
it's almost certain that you will be
asked programming problems like
reversing a linked list or balancing a
binary tree in a technical interview or
coding assessment now it's well known
that you never face these problems in
your job as a software developer so it's
okay to wonder why such problems are
asked in interviews
and they're asked because they
demonstrate the following traits and
these are very important traits for a
programmer number one is that you can
think about a problem systematically and
then solve it systematically step by
step too
and the number two is that you can
envision the different inputs and
outputs in edge cases for your problem
because programs when you put them out
in the wild as part of software can
encounter any kind of inputs and
as you have thousands or millions of
users you will encounter any and every
possible input
and often this has many security
implications it can take down the server
it can take down your application or you
can have a loss of data or loss of
property
you can communicate your ideas clearly
to co-workers that's a very important
part of problem solving
and most importantly you can convert
your thoughts and ideas into working
code
and the code should also be readable to
other people so it's not really the
knowledge of specific data structures or
algorithms that's tested in an interview
but it is your approach towards the
problem so you may fail to solve the
problem but you may still clear the
interview or vice versa you may solve
the problem
and still not clear the interview so in
this course we will focus on the skills
to both solve the problem and to clear
interviews successfully
so that's why you need to learn data
structures and algorithms
so coming back to the problem at hand
now you've read the problem and you may
have been thinking about it and maybe
you have some ideas on how to solve it
and your first instinct might be to just
start writing the code for it
but that is not the optimal strategy and
you may actually end up spending a
longer time
to solve the problem due to coding
errors or you may not be able to solve
the problem at all
so what we are going to cover here is a
systematic strategy that you should
apply in interviews or in coding
problems
on encoding assessments or in general
whenever you are faced with a problem
like this
so here's the strategy that we will
apply step one state the problem clearly
identify the input and output formats
step two come up with some example
inputs and outputs and try to cover all
the edge cases
step three come up with a correct
solution for the problem it can be as
simple as possible and state it in plain
english
step four
and this is a step that is optional
sometimes implement the solution and
test it using example inputs and then
fix any bugs in your in your first
solution
in step five analyze the algorithms
complexity and identify any
inefficiencies
and finally step six
apply the right technique to overcome
the inefficiency and then go back to
step three which is come up with a new
correct solution which is also efficient
then implement the solution and analyze
the algorithms complexity so this is the
technique that we will apply over and
over for the course of
six weeks to many different problems
and applying the right technique is
where the knowledge of common data
structures and algorithms comes in handy
so this is the method we'll be using so
let's jump into the solution
step one state the problem clearly
now you will often encounter detailed
word problems in coding challenges and
interviews they will go on for
paragraphs and paragraphs for instance
here we are talking about alice having a
deck of cards and then shuffling them
putting them out on a table talking to
bob etc etc etc
the first step is to state the problem
clearly and precisely in abstract terms
because computers don't understand
people computers don't understand cards
computers understand numbers so for in
this case we can represent the sequence
of cards as a list of numbers so a list
is a basic data structure in python
and the turning over of a specific card
is equivalent to the accessing of the
value of the number at a certain
position in the list for instance if we
think of
this set of cards being represented by
this list
you can see here that this list is
sorted in decreasing order then turning
over a certain card is equivalent to
accessing that specific element from the
list so turning over card number two or
as we say in computer science card
number one because this is card number
zero and this is one thing that you
might want to get into your head as well
that whenever you're counting always
start counting from zero otherwise you
may run into many off by one errors
so this is position zero and this is
position one so if you turn over the
card at position one it is as good as
accessing an element from a given list
which in this case will turn out to be
11. so these are the positions in the
list starting from 0.
and now what we have to figure out is
how many elements do we need to access
so we need to access the minimum number
of elements
to get to a particular element right so
the problem can now be stated as follows
we need to write a program to find the
position of a given number in a list
arranged in decreasing order
we also need to minimize the number of
times we access the elements from a list
so we're finding the position of the
given number 7 and the position in this
case is 3
and we want to minimize the
number of times we access elements from
the list so if we go in this direction
for example we would need to access 13
11 12 and finally we discover 7 we come
from this end we may discover 7 6 5 4
and finally we may discover 7. so
definitely coming from the left is
better than coming from the right but is
that the best
that's what we're solving
now once we've defined the problem and
what you should do is you should try to
write down the problem in your own words
and primarily this is for you to make it
clear to yourself uh either speak it out
loud to the interviewer or write it down
in your own words as short as make it as
short as as long as possible so that you
clearly understand what's in it and then
come up with the inputs and the outputs
so there are two inputs here there's the
input cards which is a list of numbers
sorted in decreasing order
and then the second input is a query
which is a number whose position in the
array is to be determined
and there is one output which is
position and the position is simply the
position of query in the list of cards
for example seven is at position three
counting from zero of course and as soon
as you've written the input and output
out you can now write what is called the
signature of our function which is a
structure of our function without any
actual code inside it so now we can call
it def locate card
with cards and query and the single
statement inside it called pass because
a function in python cannot have an
empty body you need to put in at least
one statement so you always put in the
pass statement first because
it doesn't do anything
there you go so now we have framed our
problem
in abstract terms
and now we have a function signature to
work with
now a couple of tips here this is
something that
interviewers specifically will look for
but also encoding assessments because
your code is also shared with the
company so you may want to name your
functions properly and think carefully
about the signature for example here you
should not call your function f1 or func
one or f or something like that it's
better to call it locate card because
that's what it is doing
and the similar thing
is true for variable names as well
use descriptive variable names one
because it's good for coding practice
and second because
as you work on the problem you may lose
track of what a variable represents for
example if you call this a and you call
this b now
20 minutes down the line
talking about the problem writing
different lines of code you may forget
what a and b represent so please call
them what they represent even if it can
get a little long
and finally if you're unable to come up
with a function signature if you're
unable to come up with a simple
description then discuss the problem
with the interviewer if you're unsure
how to frame it in abstract terms
so keep that in mind and this is really
the first and most important step
which is stating the clarifying the
problem statement and stating it clearly
do not start coding before you have done
this otherwise you may get halfway into
the code and realize that you have not
understood the problem at all
so step two
now we will come up with some examples
take some example inputs and outputs and
our goal will be to cover all the edge
cases so before we start implementing a
function
we want to have some examples so that
once we implement it the first thing we
want to know is is it correct
and in general the answer is no because
coding especially when you get getting
started is hard because you have to
think about many different scenarios
so and especially especially interviews
or coding assessments are also stressful
situations so you may not be able to
focus and think about all the different
things that you need to keep in mind so
simplest way to reduce the risk of going
wrong is to use
a test cases
so here's one test case that we came up
with you know we what we've done is
we've taken the information that we've
listed above in the inputs and outputs
and we've written it in as code so now
we have a variable called cards which is
a list of cards a list of numbers then
we have a query which has the value 7
and then we have the output which has
the value three so the expected output
from the function is three
and once you have a test case you can
test your function at any point anything
you want to test you can simply pass the
input for example cards and query into
the locate card function and get back
the result
and you can see here right now because
there's nothing inside the function the
result you get back is none but later
you'll start getting back a proper
result from your function and what you
can then do is you can compare the
result with the output of the test case
so in this case when we compare them
obviously the output is 3 the result is
none we get back false
now one thing we will do in this course
to make testing easier because we will
be testing our algorithms again and
again as we keep improving them
is that we will represent our test cases
as dictionaries
so here for example this this test case
will be represented or every test case
will be represented as a dictionary
containing two keys input
and output
and the input
will contain one key for each argument
to the function so if your function
arguments are called cards and query
in the function signature and that's why
we wrote down a function signature first
so that we don't get
confused here so if your function
arguments are called cards and query
then we can take
one one key called cards
and put the value of cards there one key
called query put the value of query
there and then in in the output we
simply contain
we simply put the output that we expect
from the function
and now you can test this function like
this
so how you might want to test it first
is maybe by actually passing values like
this so you have test input cards and
then test input query
but there's a trick here whenever you
have a dictionary so here we have a
dictionary with two keys and we want to
pass these two keys as two arguments to
a function so we want to pass cards as
the cards argument to the function
locate card and query as a query
argument to locate cards what you can do
is you can simply
put the dictionary itself
and just write star star
now if you write star star what python
does is it takes the keys from this
dictionary and the values are then used
as arguments for
parameters with these names
so there we are now calling locate card
on test input and we can compare it with
test output
and you can see that we get back false
so that's one test case for us
but is that enough is that enough for
you to now start writing code
probably not because
out in the wild your function should be
able to handle any number or any set of
valid inputs that we pass into it
and here are some possible variations
that we might encounter and it really
helps to list them in fact while i was
writing these variations i realized that
there are many cases that i had not
thought of
so even after coding for 12 15 years
almost i still find it really useful to
list out all the scenarios that
we can find our input in
so the simplest scenario is that the
query occurs somewhere in the middle on
the list of cards this is what you
imagine when you read the question this
is what is called the general case
but then there are some special
scenarios as well what if the query is
the first element in cards and what if
the query is the last element in cards
what if the
list cards contains just one element
which is the query itself
or and this is something that i had not
thought of what if the list cards does
not even contain the number query what
if
alice is bluffing
so what should be bob's strategy then to
figure out that the number does not
exist
what if the list of cards is empty
and what if the list contains repeating
numbers this is again another
interesting thing that may not come to
mind because we said a list of numbers
and we did not specify that the numbers
are unique so the list can contain
repeating numbers and finally what if
the number the query itself occurs more
in more than one position in cards so
those are eight cases that i could think
of and just see if you can think of any
more variations
and it's likely that when you first
heard the problem you did not think of
all these cases
because you often tend to just focus on
one generic case it's hard to hold too
many cases in mind and that's why it
helps to list them down actually write
them down in a coding interview or in a
coding assessment or an interview you
may want to put this in comments if you
have a
page coding page you can just create a
comments and list out all the test cases
and some of these
especially things like the empty array
or query not occurring in cards are
called edge cases because they represent
rare or extreme examples and while edge
cases may not occur very frequently your
program should be able to handle edge
cases otherwise they may fail in
unexpected ways or somebody with the
with male intentions can use the edge
cases
to hack your software
so let's create some more test cases for
the variations that we've listed and
we'll store all our test cases in a list
for easier testing
so here we are creating a list called
tests and this time we will
create all our test cases in the format
that we discussed which is a dictionary
format and we will keep appending them
to our list
now if you do not understand lists and
dictionaries and appending then you can
go back and review some of the basic
material on python which is linked at
the top of this notebook
so first we take the one test case that
we already have we put that and we take
maybe one more example of the query
occurring somewhere in the middle so
here you can see this is the cards list
and then the query one occurs somewhere
in the middle although it's closer to
one end
then here's one case where the query is
the first element
four and the output obviously the output
expected is zero here's one case where
the query is the last element minus 127
and this is another thing the numbers
could be negative as well something you
may want to keep in mind
here's another one the weather card
contains where cards contains just one
element the query itself
now the problem does not state what to
do if the list cards does not contain
the number query
and you may often face these questions
where
it may not be clear what to do in a
certain situation or if a certain
situation can occur and when you have
questions like this this is a process
you should follow step one read the
problem statement carefully or ask the
interviewer to repeat the question
so read the problem statement carefully
and you me you will often find hints and
sometimes these hints are just single
number single words somewhere often you
will also find some examples provided
with the problem you will also find if
you scroll down to the bottom you will
find some conditions you will find
limits on what the numbers can be
whether they can be integers or can be
decimals whether they can be negative or
positive so it's important to read the
problem carefully before you start
coding
and look through the examples
and then ask the interviewer or maybe
post a question on the platform for a
clarification often it happens that
interviewers because they take so many
interviews they may forget to specify a
certain detail and or they might expect
you to ask the question because you
should not be coding with an
insufficient requirement so to clarify
the specifications of the problem is
very important so if you have any doubt
ask the interviewer even if you are
somewhat sure about it but just want to
verify
it's a good idea to ask
then finally if you
are
done with all of these and you still do
not have a solution then you just make a
reasonable assumption state it and move
forward
so we will assume that our function will
return -1 in case cards does not contain
query
so if cards does not contain query
then
we return we expect the function to
return -1 now here's one other case
where the card's array is empty and
obviously then it does not contain the
query as well
and finally there's one last case which
is the number itself can repeat
in cards
numbers can repeat in cards and then the
query itself can repeat in cards so here
the query does not repeat three does not
repeat but the numbers on the
in the cards that i do repeat
and the last case is when the query
itself repeats so you can see here in
cards the query occurs many times
once again it is not specified what to
do here and sometimes it may be okay
sometimes the problem statement may just
say that return any one position but
more likely than not what you will want
to do is you may want to make it more
deterministic
and that will also make it easy for you
to test the function so what we can say
we can impose this additional
restriction
that we will
expect our function to return the first
occurrence of query
and that will make it easier for us to
test so that when we when we're testing
our problem we we know that if we're
getting a failure it's not because
of multiple possible answers but it's
because of some issue in our code right
so you want to get good feedback from
failures and that's why you want your
tests to be deterministic so here is the
final test
and now we can see the full list of test
cases
so now we can see the list of test cases
here
so you have about eight or ten test
cases here you may not need to create
this many test cases in an interview or
a coding assessment depending on how
much time you have but you should create
at least a few at least cover the
three or four edge cases a good number
to aim for would be five and this will
not only help you in the coding
interview help you solve the problem
this will also be appreciated by the
interviewer because it shows that you're
thinking about the problem
so definitely take a minute or two now
we've spent 10 15 minutes talking about
this but once you start applying this
technique over and over you will see
that you will start creating test cases
in seconds so as soon as you read the
problem and you state the problem
find the
find the input format find the output
format write a function signature
and write the test and then you will
start working on tests the ideas will
automatically start coming to you and
within maybe two or three minutes you
will be done with both all to both of
these steps
so great we now have a fairly exhaustive
set of test cases
and creating test cases beforehand
allows you to identify different
variations and edge cases and sometimes
it may happen that you may have no clue
how to work on the problem you may feel
completely confused but if you simply
start writing multiple test cases and
start looking at them like literally
list just staring at the test cases the
question and the answer the solution
will reveal itself to you
so don't underestimate the power of
writing things down
and don't stress it don't stress out if
you can't come up with an exhaustive
list of test cases because this takes
time it's a skill that you cultivate
with time so what you can do is you can
list out maybe the test cases that come
to your mind right now and put them in a
single place and keep coming back
whenever a new test case comes to mind
while coding or while discussing or
while analyzing you can just come back
to the same place and
write down the test case the important
thing is that you have a single place
where you're listing all test cases
so we've written our test cases now
and now we can come up with a correct
solution and how do you come up with the
correct solution
not by writing code but by first stating
it in plain english so your first
goal
and
by correct we do not mean the best
or the most efficient solution
first we want to solve the problem we
want to figure out
where the particular number lies in the
list
and not to minimize because that's
solving two problems at once and
sometimes that can get tricky so first
aim for correctness then aim for
efficiency
and the simplest or the most obvious
solution which almost always exists and
is almost always very easy to see
involves checking all the possible
answers and this is also called the
brute force solution so in this problem
coming up with the brute force solution
is quite easy
bob can simply turn over the cards in
order one by one till he finds the card
with the given number on it so this is
what this is how it might work
if we want to implement it in code and
this is where writing it in your own
words becomes important
so we create a variable called position
inside a function with the value 0 then
we check that the number at the index
position in the card list
equals query or not now if it does since
we're starting from the beginning if it
does then position is the answer and we
can return it from our function but if
it doesn't then we simply increment the
value of position by one and then we
repeat the steps so we go back to step
two and then we check whether the number
at the index position on in cards equals
query and once again if it does we
return position if not we increment the
position once again and repeat and we
repeat that till we reach the last
position and if the number was not found
we return -1 so it's a simple
four-five-step description
doesn't take very long you can either
say it out loud to the interviewer they
will also appreciate it that they will
know you know you may know that you know
the brute force solution and you may not
say it because
it seems too simple or obvious but the
interview does the interviewer doesn't
know that so it's important to state the
brute force solution you may say that i
the brute force solution is fairly
straightforward and it goes like this
steps one two three four just take 30
seconds but at the very least it informs
the interviewer that you're able to
think of
some solution
and it happens very often i've seen it
in interviews where
30 40 minutes have passed out of 45
minutes and not a single solution has
been proposed so far even though many
lines of code have been written so it's
important to state your solution and if
you state your solution the interviewer
will also help you and correct you as
you go forward right so it is a
collaborative experience it is a
discussion so use that and if you are in
a coding assessment you may just want to
write out a few comments
and what we've
implemented here is congratulations is
just our first algorithm and an
algorithm is simply a list of statements
a list of
steps that can be converted into code
and executed by a computer on different
sets of inputs
so
this particular algorithm
is called linear search because it
involves searching through a list in a
linear fashion element by element
so now we're ready to implement the
solution
and just a quick tip
as i've already said always try to
express the algorithm in your own words
and it can be as brief or as detailed as
you like
and don't underestimate the power of
writing writing can be a great tool for
thinking it's likely that you will find
that some part of the solution is
difficult for you to express and that
simply suggests that you are probably
unable to think about that part clearly
so the most more clearly you are able to
express your thoughts the easier it will
be for you to turn it into code and you
will not have to come up with a strategy
while you're writing the code so you can
focus on coding and focus on avoiding
errors
and that brings us to the next step
implement the solution
and then test it using the example input
so now you can see how everything comes
together
we've already know what the function
signature looks like what the inputs
look like we already have some test
cases and through the test cases we've
also identified what are the different
edge cases we need to handle and we've
already written out a description a
rough description of what the algorithm
looks like and in fact what you can do
is you can simply write out comments
within your function
as the english description then you
simply need to fill out code for those
comments so for instance here are the
five steps that we have just written
down create a variable position with the
value zero set up a loop check if the
element is matches the query
if yes the answer is found if not
increment the position
and then go back and then check if
you've reached the end of the array if
we have then we return -1
so then the code now is pretty
straightforward we create the position
variable 0
we set while true so while true kicks
off a loop and we just want to first set
up a loop and then we can break out of
it when we need to
then we check if the element at the
value position matches the query if it
does we return the position if it
doesn't so if it doesn't then this we
come to this part if it does then we say
the function exits and none of this code
gets executed but if it doesn't then we
increment the position
and then we check if we have reached the
end now if you have the hdn obviously we
don't want to continue so
we can simply return minus one and exit
the loop and exit the function itself
but if it if we have not reached the end
then we go back to the top of the loop
and now position starts out with value
one so we check value zero one two three
so on up to the end of the array
simple enough
great so now we have our first function
and let's test our function with the
first test case
so here's our test case once again
and we can simply call
locate card with the test input and the
test the cards in the query
and this is the result we get and you
can already see that the result matches
the output and that's why when we
compare them we get the value true
so yeah the results match the output and
because this is something that you
should be doing very often in this
course we have put together a small
function for you within the jovian
python library so the jovian platform
also offers a python helper library that
is
that contains some utility functions so
we've put together a small function for
you called evaluate test case and you
can write it on your own as well but you
can use this library version so let's
install the library we will install
the jovian library using pip install
jovian minus minus upgrade
and then from jovian.python dsa so joven
is the name of the library and then
inside the joven library since we have
many courses the python dsa course the
utilities for this course are present
inside the python dsa module
from that module we import the function
evaluate test case
and finally we can
call evaluate test case and then we can
give it the function that we want to
test so you know test the locate card
function and the test case the test case
needs to be defined in this format
so all it is going to do is it is going
to pick out the input pass it into the
function
get the output compare that output
with the expected output and also print
some information for you to see
so here's what it does it prints out the
input
it prints out the expected output
it prints out the actual output
it prints the execution time
and
this is something that will become
important later and it tells you whether
the test has passed or not
so it's nice to have this you know
because so we don't have to look through
the output
and input and compare them especially
when you are
in a situation where you need to think
fast it's helpful to create a small
function that can just print pass or
fail for a test case
so now while it may seem like we have a
working solution because our test case
has passed we can't be sure about it
until we test the function with all the
test cases
so for doing that we can use the
evaluate test cases function so just as
you have evaluated test case you have
evaluate test cases
also part of the jovian library
and you can call evaluate test cases
with the same function locate card and
this time pass it a list of test cases
each of the test cases is a dictionary
again you don't have to use this
function you can simply put things into
a loop so you can always just do for
test in tests
and then simply call evaluate test
with locate card
and test or you can even just directly
call
locate card
with
the test
inputs
and the test out and compare the output
with the test output right so you can do
this as well and you can simply print
that
so here's a simple way to do this what
we are doing here
but what we'll do is we'll use the
evaluate test cases function because it
prints out a lot of useful information
for us
so now you can see that it prints out
case case by case now test k0 we have
input expected output actual output
the
case has test cases passed that's what
we saw it in fact it's the same test we
just did
test case one passes as well test case
two passes test is three four five six
okay all of them are fine okay test case
six seems to have caused an error so
here is the error it says list index out
of range
so that's okay it's perfectly all right
for your functions to encounter an error
so the first thing the most important
thing is not to panic
in fact it's a good thing that we know
exactly where the function is failing if
you look back here you can see what the
issue is and then we'll see how to fix
the error but one one good strategy to
approach this is to keep in mind that
there will always be bugs in your code
and
approach
writing code not with the assumption
that your code will be correct but go
with the default assumption that your
code will be wrong that there will be
issues what that lets you do is one you
do not feel
demotivated or you do not panic when you
see an error and second you then tend to
be a little more careful while actually
writing the code so the way you should
be writing code is every time you write
a line of code you should be asking
yourself
how can this line of code go wrong
or in this particular case how can
card's position equals equals query in
an if statement go wrong and throw an
error
and let's look at it one easy way to
check this is to add what is called a
logging or what is called printing the
information inside a function so we'll
just rewrite our function
in in our locate card function we will
put in cards and we will written query
the exact same function that we have
we'll set the position
but before we create the value we'll
simply print the cards in the query so
just for our information just so that we
can see what the function is working
through we can get some visibility into
the function we print out cards and
query and then while
true so this is the same loop
at the beginning of the loop we will
print out the position that we are
tracking
okay so let's do that we've simply added
some print statements and this print
statement will
give us an insight into the inner
working of the function now if you do
not put in a print statement then you
will have to work it out yourself by
reading the code and executing it in
your head it's always easier to just
print all the all the information and
then print it nicely just say cards and
query you know we could also have done
this without saying cards here but then
that would make it a little harder to
read then that would be more cognitive
overload apart from already dealing with
the stress of solving an error right so
just add nice pretty print statements to
make it very obvious what we are
printing
so let's see now let us get the test
case out so let's get from test 6 get
the input get the cards get the query as
well and pass it into locate card
and now we see that initially the cards
array is empty
and the query is seven
and the position is zero
and then we encounter an error we
encounter the error list index out of
range
on the line cards position
equals equals query and now at this
point it should be fairly obvious what
the issue is the issue obviously is that
we have an empty list an empty list has
no elements but we're trying to access
the position 0 which is
in
normal human conversation the first
element of a list
but there is no first element to access
and that is why we get the error list
index out of range
so this is very important whenever you
get an error do not try to start looking
at the code first just try to understand
the error first and if you're unable to
understand the error just add some print
statements there are tools like
debuggers that people use but i
personally in 15 years haven't used a
debugger i maybe used it a couple of
times but i don't know how to use it
print statements are really simple you
just put them in
chuck them into the function wherever
you need them as many print statements
as you need with nice clear messages
make it very obvious
and that will
almost certainly solve the issue for you
so the cards area is empty we cannot
access position zero so what's the
solution here the solution obviously is
that before we access anything from
a list we need to make sure that we can
access that list
and this is the way to do it so now
we've rewritten our function slightly we
once again start out with position 0 but
this time instead of putting in a while
true instead of assuming that we can
access the zeroth element
of the list we say that
the position should be less than the
length of cards now if you have a cards
list of n elements
the indices go from zero to n minus one
or in the case of zero elements there
are no indices to access
so
the position
has to be less than the length of cards
for you to be able to access it and in
this case the length of the cards will
be zero so zero is not less than zero so
the while loop will not run at all and
we will directly return -1
but if the card does have elements then
we can check the element at the value
position compare it to the query and
return the position
if it does not if it does not match the
query we can increment the position
so that was a fairly straightforward fix
easy save
so let's test the failing case again
great so looks like the failing case is
now passing because we have output minus
one and
the expected output matches the actual
output of the function minus one because
the query does not exist in the
array which is empty of course
now this is not enough it is every time
you make a change to the code you want
to go back and test all the test cases
because what have what may happen is
while fixing one error you may introduce
another error and that is where having a
good set of test cases is very important
so let's run evaluate test cases once
again you can see here this time that
all the test cases are passing
and it's just nice to
it just makes you feel good as well
makes you feel motivated as well to see
that a bunch of test cases are passing
now in a real coding assessment or a
real interview you can probably skip the
step of implementing and testing the
brute force solution in the interest of
time
because it may take about five to ten
minutes to implement the solution and
then if you have errors in the solution
it may take some more time to fix those
errors so it's generally
quite easy to figure out the complexity
which we'll talk about in a second of
the brute force solution from the plain
english description and that is why you
should first state it in plain english
which only takes
around 20 seconds or so and
the computer doesn't throw errors at you
for speaking so you can just state the
plain english description and move on
talk about the complexity and start
optimizing it but while you're
practicing
always always
implement the brute force solution too
and there's an important reason why you
should know how to implement the brute
force solution because in case you're
not able to figure out the optimal
solution to the problem
you can still go back and implement the
brute force solution and in a lot of
cases that's okay sometimes interviewers
ask hard questions just to push your
boundaries a little bit but if you're
unable to figure out the optimal
solution then they will allow you to
implement a brute force solution so that
is why you should state it and that is
why you should know how to implement it
okay
so we are done with
so we're done now with
the implementation of our brute force or
simplest solution
and now we need to analyze it
and this is where we'll now learn about
what is called the complexity of an
algorithm what does it mean now recall
the statement from the original question
alice challenges bob to pick out the
card containing the given number by
turning over as few cards as possible
but right now what we're doing is we can
say we're simply turning over cards one
by one and before we talk about what
does it mean to minimize the number of
times we turn over cards or the number
of times we access elements we need a
way to measure it and let's think about
it you know it's it's as simple as just
thinking about it since we access the
list element once in every iteration so
here's the code
our code is pretty straightforward and
this is where we are accessing an
element from the list
so since we access the element
since we access the element once
in every iteration
for a list of size n
we access the elements
from the list up to n times because we
may have to access this element and then
this element and this element and so on
so bob may need to overturn up to n
cards in the worst case to find the
required card
now let's introduce an additional
condition that suppose bob is only
allowed to overturn one card per minute
so that means it may take him 30 minutes
to find the required card in the worst
case if 30 cards are laid out on the
table
now is this really the best he can do
or is there a way for bob to arrive at
the answer by turning over just five
cards and save 25 minutes instead of
turning over all 30
and this field of study and
by the way bob in this case
is represented of what our computer does
and a computer takes some amount of
finite time to perform each instruction
so each array access actually takes some
time although it's so fast that we do
not see it especially for small inputs
but this is something that will become
increasingly important as we go week
over week where we see that
we will start to see the limits of how
long it takes computers to solve certain
problems
so the field of study concerned with
finding the amount of time or the amount
of space or the amount of other
resources required to complete the
execution of a program is called the
analysis of algorithms and the process
of figuring out the best algorithm to
solve a problem is called algorithm
design and that is what we are doing
here we are actually doing the analysis
of algorithms right now and algorithm
design next
so there are a couple of terms we need
to understand and then we will go back
to writing code
first thing is complexity and the second
thing is the big o notation and both of
these are terms that you will hear very
frequently in
when you're talking about data
structures and algorithms when you're
talking about coding interviews
assessments
so these are terms that you need to
understand and they're fairly simple
terms although
the term itself is complexity but all it
means
is that the complexity of an algorithm
is simply a measure some some measure of
the amount of time or space required by
an algorithm
to process an input of a given size
example if you have a list of size n
then the complexity is the amount of
time required or the amount of space
required on the ram to process an input
of that size
now unless otherwise stated the term
complexity always refers to worst case
complexity so
it's possible that the bob turns over
the first card and that is the answer
but we always talk about what is the
longest or the highest possible time or
space that may be taken by the program
to process an input right so we need to
design our programs keeping the worst
case in mind
now in case of a linear search which is
what we've implemented just now the time
complexity of the algorithm is some
constant c times n assuming n is the
size of the list
n is the number of cards
right so now this constant c obviously
depends on the number of operations that
we perform in each iteration so in each
loop for example we have four to five
statements
and then the time taken to execute a
statement on your specific hardware now
if you have a two gigahertz computer
that may be twice as fast as a one
gigahertz computer if you're running it
on a phone it may be different so the c
captures all of these things so
information about the number of specific
operations that we perform in each
iteration and information about
the actual hardware that you're running
on
so cn is the time complexity and n is
the size of the input so in some sense
what we understand from this is that the
time complexity is proportional to the
size of the input and that's the
important part here the constant you
know it doesn't change as you change the
input the constant doesn't really change
now similarly the space complexity now
since we are already given an array the
additional space that our linear search
requires
is simply a single constant when we are
calling it c prime or c dash
and it is independent of n so no matter
how many uh no matter how large a list
is given to you and the list is already
present in memory we just need to
allocate one new variable called
position and that variable is used to
iterate through the array and it
occupies a constant space in the
computer memory because we keep go on
updating the variable right so the space
complexity is c or constant it is
independent of n
now
what we do normally is to represent the
worst case complexity we often use the
big o notation
and in the big o notation what we do is
we drop any fixed constants
and we lower the powers of the and we
drop any fixed constants and we drop any
lower powers of variables so
the idea here is to capture just the
trend just the trend of the relationship
between the size of the input and the
complexity of the algorithm for example
if the time complexity of an algorithm
is some constant times n cube plus some
constant times n square plus some
constant time n plus some constant
where n is the size of the input in the
big o notation we simply say that it is
order of n cube
which is that you know in the long run
in the if you just study the trend it
the trend will be
some
something which looks a little bit like
the n cube function and it may be offset
by a constant or such
so putting it this way the time
complexity of linear search is order n
because we just drop the constant c and
the space complexity is order one so we
again drop the constant c prime
and we'll see why it's okay to drop the
constant sometimes you may find that
okay we're not exactly doing n
iterations but we're doing n minus one
iteration so we drop the minus one
sometimes you'll find that we are just
doing n by two iterations and that's
simply half of n so we drop the half
and you might wonder that okay that that
might take twice or three times the
amount of time how why are we dropping
that constant because that's probably an
important thing to keep in mind but
we'll see we'll see soon as we implement
our efficient solution to the problem
so before we move forward before we
optimize the algorithm
we are just going to save our work
because this notebook as i mentioned to
you is
running on an online platform we've set
up everything for you you've not had to
install anything but because thousands
of people are using this
using this platform this will shut down
this will not keep running forever and
what you need to do is you need to save
your work from time to time
and here is how you can save your work
and then pick it up everything happens
on the jovian platform there's no need
to download anything although you could
download it if you want but you there's
no need to download anything so all you
need to do is use the jobin library once
again we've got another helpful function
for you so you say import jovian and
then run jovian.commit so you run
joven.commit and then give it a project
name the
project name
by which you want to identify this
specific notebook
and then there are some other arguments
it's not too important so you can even
skip this and that should be perfectly
fine
so now when you run jobin dot commit
we will capture a snapshot of your
notebook
from this online platform
or wherever it is running even if you're
running it on your own computer we will
capture a snapshot of your notebook from
your computer
wherever it's running and we will upload
it and give you a link where you can
access it
so let's open up this link here
so now you will be able to see this page
called python binary search and it will
be on your profile
and you can see you can scroll down and
see that it contains all the
explanations and it contains all the
code so this is a read-only version of
the jupyter notebook so the read-only
version of the jupyter notebook
obviously does not require us to keep
servers running so that you can run this
code and when when you need to run it
you know your work is saved to whatever
extent you have executed things and now
when you need to run it you simply click
run
and then click run on binder once again
okay so and that is how you resume your
work so what this will do is this will
set up a new machine for you and on the
new machine it will post the jupyter
notebook
and it will start up the machine for you
open up the jupyter notebook and you
will be able to start running the code
and not just you now you can make your
notebooks public or you can keep them
private you have multiple viewership
options so you're public and private not
just you but anybody else so you can
take this link
and
tweet it out
if there's an interesting problem that
you worked on you want to tweet it out
you can just share this link online and
anybody will be able to read through
your solution
and they can run it as well right in
fact the notebook that i have shared
with you is hosted on my profile so
jovin is not just a platform for you to
learn it's also a platform for you to
build a repository of projects now if
you go back to your profile you click on
your profile or click on the jovian logo
and you can see here that you will find
a notebooks tab and in the notebooks tab
you will find all the notebooks that you
have worked on in the past okay so
anything that you have committed using
juventus comment you will be able to
resume working on it
so that's uh that's how you
save your work and keep saving your work
from time to time all you need to do is
run jobian.comit you do not even need to
put in this project argument this is
just something if you want to actually
give your project a name otherwise the
name will be picked automatically so
just keep running jovian.com from time
to time especially if you're leaving
your computer for half an hour or so
then and your computer get goes to sleep
then this server will shut down and you
may lose your work coming back to our
problem
we've just implemented linear search and
we understood that it has the complexity
of order n which is
and that's why it's called linear it
runs in a linear time is another
expression that is used it is also
called linear because we are going
through the array step by step
now the next step is to apply the right
technique to overcome this efficiency
now of course we've not learned any
techniques yet but we can probably
figure it out if you think about it and
maybe this is something that occurred to
you right at the beginning and
the idea that occurred to you is
something that we will now
implement so at the moment we are simply
going over the cards one by one and not
even utilizing the fact that they are
sorted and that's why our approach is
pretty poor we're basically checking
everything
so it's not a great solution but it
would be great if somehow this would be
the this would be the best case if
somehow bob realized somehow bob could
guess the card at the first attempt
that would be perfect then that would be
an order one
that would be a constant time solution
but
with all the cards turned over it's
simply impossible to guess the right
card
now the next best idea is to maybe pick
a random card so maybe let's say bob
picks this card
and this card turns out to be a nine
now bob can use the fact that the cards
are in sorted order so if this card
turns out to be nine that means all of
these cards
have numbers greater than nine and the
target card is seven so the target card
cannot lie in this region
so the target card has to lie in this
region and just by picking a random card
rather than picking the first card
bob has eliminated
four out of seven cards to be checked
right so with one check bob has
eliminated a total of five cards one two
three four five and of course if this
number turns out to be seven perfect
great guess but even if it doesn't we've
still eliminated quite a few if this
number turns out to be less than seven
we've still eliminated three cards
so that's the basic idea here that we
pick something
not from the edges but somewhere in the
middle now what is the best place to
pick something in the middle now
obviously when we are picking a card we
do not know whether it is going to be
less than or greater than the number
that we want
especially when everything is close so
we it's best to just pick the middle
card so that whichever case turns it
turns out to be
we're still left with ads
at most three cards to process right so
if you pick this card and it doesn't
turn out to be seven you either need to
look at these three or you need to look
at these three
so that is the strategy we'll follow
and this technique is called binary
search
and why do it just once
just keep repeating it so each time you
pick the middle card and you can
eliminate half of the array
and this is what the strategy looks like
so here we have the array
and in the array we want to figure out
the number six so the slightly different
problem but still decreasing order we
want to figure out the number six so we
access the middle element
okay we compare it with six now it is
not six okay it was a bad guess no
problem but we know that four is less
than six so that means that six lies to
the left of four so we've
suddenly eliminated half of the array
we've done one access and eliminated
half of it and now we're left with three
numbers we pick the middle number
we get seven
seven is greater than six that means the
number lies on the right now we are left
with just one card we overturned that
last card or we checked that last number
okay it is equal to six great if it is
not
well nothing more left to check all the
numbers here are greater than 6 are less
than 6 and all the numbers before this
are greater than 6. so if this number
isn't 6 then there's no 6.
and just like that for an array of
seven elements we have done just three
checks and arrived at the answer and
that was the worst case right it mean it
will never take you can verify that it
will never take more than three checks
if six comes at this position we guess
it immediately if six comes at this
position or this position we guess it in
two checks and then if six comes at any
of the other positions we will guess it
in three checks
so that's pretty good
and now the idea if you if you read this
part it says
apply the right technique to overcome
the inefficiency and then repeat the
steps three to six so now we're going to
go back to step three which was come up
with a correct solution for the problem
and stated in plain english and we have
come up with a solution already we just
need to state it so here is how this
technique called binary search is
applied to the problem it's called
binary because
well we take a left and right decision
so
first we find the middle element of the
list
if it matches the query number then we
return the middle position as the answer
and if it is less than the queried
number
then we search the first half of the
list
and if it's greater than the query
number then we search the second half of
the list so the exact thing that we saw
here
we apply it here
and finally if no more elements remain
we simply return -1
so let's just save our work now let's
from this point on we'll keep saving our
work from time to time using
jovian.commit so now we've come up with
the algorithm and you can
again it's important to write it in your
own words
whether you want to write a short
description a paragraph or a step by
step guide but write it in your own
words and you'll do this in the
assignment
so let's implement the solution now and
test it using the example inputs so
here's the implementation so what we'll
do is
we will look at once again let's go back
to this visual representation and we
will keep a track of our search space so
current initially our search space is
the entire array so that means we have
an array of seven numbers so our search
space goes from position zero to
position six
and slowly we'll keep reducing our
search space over time so to keep track
of the search space we will create two
variables low and high
low will have the value 0 which is it
will point to the first position in the
array and high will have the value
pointing to the last position last valid
position in the array which is
which is len cards minus one
so while low
and then the while loop becomes very
simple because as long as we have at
least one element in our search space we
can go ahead now to have at least one
element in a search space
the low value which is the starting
index
should
be less than or equal to the end value
right so while low is less than equal to
high because if the starting index is
higher than the
end index basically we've exhausted and
we've covered the entire list
and there's nothing more that we can
search for so we should exit at this
point okay so now once we have uh once
this condition is satisfied and it is
initially let's say you have seven cards
lower zero
cards is uh len cards minus one is six
then you find the middle position and
you can get the middle position by doing
low plus i divided by two
and now let's start applying that
strategy here where we say that every
time we write a line of code we should
think about how it can go wrong now if
you write it like this low plus high
divided by two
and think about how it can go wrong okay
low plus high may not be divisible by 2.
if low plus is not divisible by 2 you
may end up with a decimal number now if
you do end up with a decimal number in
fact
the division operator in python always
retains a floating point number
then you cannot use it as an array index
because we want to use this as a
position within the array so that's why
we need the double slash which is the
which is the integer division which
simply returns the quotient
so we get the middle position
and then we get the number at the middle
position so we also get cards made so we
access that element from the array now
this is where we it makes it easy for us
to count the number of times we access
because here is one axis happening
inside the list and there are no other
accesses then we get the mid number and
remember
last time we faced an error and we had
to add print statements
you might as well just add print
statements right away
so here's what you can do we can just
print the value of low the value of high
the value of mid and the value of mid
number what this will do is this will
help you check
whether the number is working as expect
whether the function is working as
expected or not so now here comes the
actual check and the meat of the problem
if the middle number matches the query
then we return the middle number great
we found it well done
now if the middle number is less than
the query now remember the elements are
in sorted array and we are looking for
the number
query
now the middle number is less than the
so that means the query probably lies to
the left of it because the query
because the elements are in a decreasing
order
right
so if
the query lies to the left of it so then
we need to search we decrease the search
space from the beginning
to the position just before the middle
number right
so what we can do is we can simply set
high to mid minus one
on the other hand if mid number is
greater than query
so that means because of the decreasing
order of the array the query lies to the
right now we need to move the starting
of the search space to beyond the middle
number so we simply said low to mid plus
one
and that's it and you can see that we've
written a we've used if lf lf loop here
so lf stands for elsif in python
and here the last condition could might
as well just have been else because
there are only three possibilities
either they're equal or mid number is
less or it's greater but sometimes it's
nice to list out all possibilities just
to make it super clear and it makes it
easy for you while debugging fixing
issues as well okay
so that's our binary search
based
algorithm and finally when we exit out
of the loop
if you have not returned the middle
number if you have not exited the
function yet then we return -1 that the
number was not found
so let's test it out using our test
cases
and we have our handy evaluate test
cases function here but you can also
test it manually if you want by passing
individual test cases but i'll just do
this from now on
so great so now we have test case 0 this
is the input
and this is the query
and it passed
here we have test case 1 this is the
input and this is the query and it
passed and now because we have these
print statements we can clearly look
into our test cases and actually tell
if the if this is tested correctly or
not because now you can see here that we
started out with low 0 high 7
and a mid mid value of three
so zero one two three we we found the
number seven the query is one
so we need to check this half of the
array and that's exactly what we did we
moved low to four and high remained
seven
then mid number became three
so that means once again we need to
check this half of the array and then we
check this number and then we found the
output so now you can see exactly how
the algorithm works and this is in
general what you want as a programmer
you want to have a full understanding of
the code that you've written you don't
want your code to work incidentally
you don't want it to you don't want to
be in a position where you are just
fixing things
trying out different things and somehow
at once the code works you want to be in
complete control you want to know that
these this is exactly what the code is
doing and if it is failing why it is
failing so we go to test case two three
four five six
uh looks good looks like we may have
solved everything ah probably not so
test case eight seems to have failed
so test case eight is this number this
list and this list contains repeating
numbers and not just repeating numbers
but the query itself occurs multiple
times
and now if we look here
and maybe let's go go down and evaluate
just a test case separately
so here we are now using the singular
version of the evaluate function so if
you look here
you can see you have eight eight six six
a bunch of sixes then three two two zero
the query is six so we start out with a
low of zero higher fourteen total of
fifteen elements that gives you a middle
position of seven
and the mid number at that position so
let's count one zero one two three four
five six seven okay and the mid number
at that position is six
great uh six is also the query so that's
why our function returns seven
but remember that we had decided that
our function should return the first
position
of the number within the array
so
a function is failing that condition
and why is that happening because unlike
linear search where we start from the
left and so we'll always bump into the
first position because of the decreasing
order of elements
so we'll hit we'll encounter this six
before we encounter this six
binary search does not access elements
in an order it access elements sort of
randomly there's still a strategy but it
goes left and right and it also depends
on the values of specific elements
whether this element is accessed before
this element can depend on the value of
let's say this element right so
as such it's kind of a pseudo random
kind of order
and so we need an additional condition
condition to keep track of it right
so
how do we fix it
so the way to fix it is actually quite
simple
when we find that the middle position in
a particular range is equal to the query
we simply need to check whether it is
the first occurrence of the query
in the list
or not that is whether the number come
that comes before it is it equal to
query or not if the number that comes
before the middle element is also equal
to query then obviously the middle
element is not the first occurrence so
that simply means that we can go back
and because it can occur multiple times
before that simply means that we can go
we can now search the left half on the
other hand if the middle element if the
number before the middle element is not
equal to query and obviously because it
is a sorted list it will be greater than
query
then all the numbers here are going to
be greater than the query and you know
the the and and so
this must be the first or the only
position
okay so make sure you understand that
this must be the first or the only
position where the query occurs
so once again to make it easier what we
will do
is because there is some logic involved
here what we'll do is we'll define a
helper function called test location
and this is a very helpful thing that
you can do every time you find that okay
you have to you have to cover these
special cases and your function may
start to get slightly longer and
slightly more complicated what you may
want to do is create a helper function
and a good rule of thumb is not to have
functions that are more than 10 lines of
code or so i try to keep my functions
below seven lines of code because seven
eight lines is
approximately the amount of information
that you can hold in your head at once
so if a function is about
seven eight lines you can probably take
a quick glance and tell what it's doing
identify issues but anywhere beyond that
it's very hard and
if you're writing functions that are
going into hundreds of lines please stop
doing that please start breaking your
code into small functions
there's a there's a code by
i forget who it is by but he's a creator
of
i think it's eric meyer he created the
rx library for reactive programming and
he said that great programmers write
baby code which is
really small bits of code that
anybody can understand with a single
look so you should be writing as many
functions as many small pieces of code
small pieces of logic as possible
so let's see our test location function
its purpose
is to take the query and then take just
a specific position so forget about
binary search for now just take a
specific position and tell if that
position
is the answer and how do we do that we
first get the mid number from the cards
so we get a mid number from cards
so we then we print out mid and we print
out mid number and then we compare the
mid number with the query
so this is the special case that we need
to handle this is where we had the error
now what we need to check is if the
element before the mid number
is also equal to query so if the element
before the mid number is also equal to
query then we need to go left so just to
make it super clear what we'll do is
instead of setting high low etc we'll
simply say that we need to go left so
we'll return the the actual string left
but one thing to keep in mind here
because once again whenever you're
accessing an array you need to make sure
that the index is valid so we simply
check that mid minus one should be
greater than or equal to zero that we
made is not this position and which can
happen as your search space decreases
for example if this is your search space
your mid will actually be this position
so if
it is equal to if the number before the
mid number is equal to query then we
return left
otherwise we return found once again
making it very obvious that we have
found the number so we return found
else the other case is if the mid number
is less than query
that means that the query lies on the
left because of the decreasing order of
the list so once again we need to search
on the left else it returns right so a
test location simply tells us whether we
found the solution or we need to look on
the left or we need to look on the right
now
in sometimes you will see programs
especially in c plus plus java return
something like minus 1 0 and 1 and then
use that to represent whether you should
go left and right but python is a high
level language and strings are a first
class
things are first class feature of the
language so just use strings because
they are really descriptive they make
your code readable somebody else reading
your code will be able to understand now
if you're looking at minus one plus one
etc
that is going to be difficult for people
to understand
so now we can now simplify a locate card
function once again we have our low high
len cards minus one uh zero and len cart
minus one
the while loop is the same and we print
low and high as well so we are planting
row and high inside the locate card
function and then we are printing mid
and mid number inside the test location
function wherever is the right place to
print something you print it
then we get the mid position
and now we simply call test location so
we are testing if
mid
is the answer and if it is not the
answer should we go left or should we go
right now that makes it really simple
because now we get this result and we
check this result and if it says found
then we return mid
that's the answer if it says left then
we return mid minus one and then we
simply move high to mid minus one and if
it returns right then we simply set low
to mid plus one so we are simply
changing the start position of the
search space
to after the middle element and here we
are changing the end position of the
search space to before the middle
element right so this makes it extremely
obvious and it's really hard to go wrong
when you write code like this
especially so when you have and binary
search problems are specially tricky
because they always have certain these
special cases that you need to handle
and if you start handling them within
this if loop so now you have a while
loop inside which you have an if loop
inside which you have another another if
statement and it can get pretty tricky
and difficult to debug
so let's evaluate that test case and
looks like that test case has passed
this time
perfectly you can go through the
logs here to verify it
let's evaluate the test case all the
test cases as well we should do this
every time we change the function and
that is why it's helpful to have a
function where you can every time you
make a change you can just run the test
and on a coding platform like elite code
or hacker rank you will be given some
test cases although those test cases
will not be visible to you so you can
submit your solution but you may not get
an actual result you may not get to know
what the test case was or where your
answer was wrong and that's where you
may want to create your own test cases
if you're getting a lot of errors
and in fact once you've written out the
algorithm you may realize that okay
maybe you need to add more test cases
what if the number lies in the first
half of the array what if the number
lies in the second half of the rate so
this was not an important factor when we
were not thinking about binary search
but now that we are thinking in this
direction of splitting the array into
half we may want to add some test cases
where the number lies exactly in the
middle in the left in the right and the
simplest way to do that is now go back
to the tests array so you can open you
can create a new cell here
by pressing the character b so if you
click outside and press the character b
you can create a new cell and then you
can simply do tests dot append and then
write your test case
so here is the final code for the
algorithm
without
without the print statements
so we have test location and then we
have locate card
and try creating a few more test cases
to test your algorithm more extensively
and once again at every step we are
going to save our work by running
jobin.commit
so now we are down to analyzing the
algorithms complexity and identifying
inefficiencies if there are any now you
may have just read online you can
actually look it up say just search for
complexity of binary search and you will
read and you will find an answer
but
and and you may even just say that in
interviews but it's always nice to just
come up with that answer from first
principles it's always nice especially
in an interview if you can talk through
it if you can talk through why it is
order why it is whatever it is and we'll
see what that is
so now let's once again try to count the
number of iterations in the algorithm
because
we need to minimize the number of times
we access elements from the array
and
to do that we know that in each
iteration we are accessing the element
just once
and then we are comparing it so we're
doing a bunch of other operations but in
each iteration we're accessing one
element
so we need to count just the number of
iterations the number of times the while
loop was executed now if we start out
with an array of n elements then each
time
each time the size of the array reduces
to half for the next iteration now
that's roughly true because
when you come when you check the middle
element and then you decide whether to
go left or right it's actually probably
n by 2 minus 1 if n is
if n is even and if n is odd it is the
floor of n by two but again
with algorithms with complexities we are
generally
interested in studying the trend so we
can ignore that small part in the
calculation so let's say
uh the important part is that
even if it's okay to overestimate a
little bit but try not to underestimate
so after the first iteration we may be
left with the search space of size n by
two
it may be slightly less than that but
it's okay to overestimate
so we have n so we after n we have after
the first iteration we we are left with
the search space of n by two then we
split it into half again so next time we
may be left with a search space of n by
four which is n divided by 2 square and
then we may be left by we may be left
with n by 8
and it's possible that at any of these
iterations we may just exit because we
may have found the right number but what
we always try to analyze is the worst
case complexity of an algorithm what is
the longest possible
amount of time or the largest amount of
space it can take so right now we are
talking about time because we are
counting iterations and each iteration
takes some time
so n by 8 after iteration 3 that's 2 to
the power 3 and i think then you can
start to see the trend here that after
the kth iteration you will end up with
n divided by 2 to the power k elements
now when does the iteration stop so the
final iteration is on an array of length
1 and that is when we access that last
element and check whether after all this
checking the last element is equal to
the index or not
so we can do n divided by 2 to the power
k and if we set that to 1 we can
rearrange the terms
and we get back n equals 2 to the power
k
so
after the kth iteration if you want to
be left with one element then that means
n divided by 2 to the k should be equal
to 1 or n should be 2 to the k or in
other words
k should be equal to log
log n remember logarithms
and here obviously log refers to log to
the base 2
but what i will argue is that you can
change the base of the logarithm and
that will simply add a constant
so that will simply if you're taking the
natural log then that will simply add a
constant here
and remember when we talk about time
complexity we ignore constants so
we can just generally say that our
algorithm binary search
has the time complexity of order of log
n
that means as the input grows
the amount of time taken by binary
search is proportional to the logarithm
of the number of elements in the list
passed to it
or the amount of time taken is logarithm
to the size of the initial search space
and you can verify this you can verify
that the space complex you can you can
check this out by simply writing it out
as well you can take some examples let's
say you take a card list of size 10
and then work through it the worst case
and count how many iterations you have
and compare if that is close to login or
not
and then as an exercise you can verify
that the space complexity of binary
search is order one
can you you can try posting in the
youtube comments or in the youtube live
chat how the space complexity of binary
search is order one
i'll let that
steam so let's now compare linear search
with binary search
how are the two different and what we'll
do is we will create a large test case
because
you start to see the benefits of the
difference between the order n algorithm
and the order login algorithm
only when you have larger test cases
because small test cases everything runs
instantly so it's not really that much
of a hassle
so here we have a locate card linear
and this is the linear version of the
algorithm where we simply go through
each of the cards one by one
and then we have a really large test
case here so we have the input and then
we have the cards which goes in the
range okay let's see
so that's
one two three so that's thousand another
three that's million so we have 10
million elements here so we have 10
million elements
and
we are looking and so we are actually
creating a range here so we are using a
function in python so we are creating a
list of numbers
going down from 10 million all the way
to one so a decreasing list going from
10 million to one and this is how you
create it and you can check it out
and in this list we are looking for the
number two which occurs at the very end
so we are sort of creating this is as we
will see if you want to really analyze
it this is going to be a worst case
scenario both for linear search and for
binary search
approximately worst case
so the query is two
and then the output is
this is the output that we expect
obviously because 0 to nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine is are the array
indices and the last element is one so
the element just before is two so this
is the expected output
great so now we have this large test
let us call evaluate test case and let
us pass a check the linear
search pass in the last test and
because this is a huge list we may want
to turn off the display of the output we
may not not want to actually see the
input being displayed so we can simply
turn off the display by passing display
equals false
and we can just get back the result from
the evaluate test case function so the
result will give the output the actual
output of the function whether the test
passed and the running time of the
algorithm
so it takes a second so it looks like
the test did pass our algorithm is
correct so that's great
and it took one two two four point two
nine one milliseconds or
about 1.2 seconds to answer it
and you can probably tell why because it
because this is the result so it
probably took nine nine nine nine nine
nine eight iterations so it had to go
through all the elements to get to the
very end
on the other hand when we talk about
binary search so now we are passing in
the binary search version once again
turning display to false
and we are displaying the output
okay so this time the result is the same
the test did pass but the execution time
is
0.019 milliseconds so that's
55 000 times faster than the linear
search version and in fact you can tell
how many elements we actually had to
access so if we just check log of
so log of this number is about seven
and maybe you know if you're checking
log two we can maybe check something
like this so not more than twenty
elements had to be accessed so where we
linear search needed to access about
10 million elements binary search was
able to get to the answer with just
about 20
checks
so that's a lot of time saved
and you can increase the size of the
array by a factor of 10
and increase this by a factor of 10 as
well and then you will see far bigger
difference where
for a 10 times larger array
linear search would run for 10 times
longer whereas binary search would only
require three additional operations
so the linear search would
go from 10 million operations to 100
million operations binary search would
go from 20 operations to 23
and that is the real difference between
the complexities order n and order login
and as the size of as the size of the
arrays grows bigger another way to look
at it is that if you just divide the
complexities binary search runs n by
login times faster than linear search
for some fixed constant because there's
always some constraints involved and as
the size of the input grows larger the
difference only gets bigger the
difference in performance
and that is what algorithm analysis of
algorithms and optimization of
algorithms is all about
it's about
overcoming the limitations of computers
by devising clever techniques to solve
problems
and it's something that you can actually
apply in real life as well in a lot of
cases there are a lot of things that you
may
see a brute force solution to but if you
just apply your mind you may find a more
optimal solution a more easy way or a
more lazy way to do it with less work
so think about that
and here is a graph showing
how the comp how you can compare common
functions
how the
how the running times of common
functions vary so we will look at all
kinds of functions we look at constant
time functions order one for example
accessing an element from an array is
order one so even if you have an element
of
10 a list of 10 million elements you can
access the last element in constant time
on the other hand we've looked at binary
search which has which is order log n
and we've also looked at linear search
which is order n now in the future we
will look at other techniques which have
complexities of
n square n cube n to the power n are far
far higher and somewhere in between
there is a very nice
special type of complexity called n log
n which is rather nice so we'll talk
about that as well n login in fact a lot
of questions in
coding assessments and coding interviews
tend to be
taking algorithms which would be
which would have n square complexity in
in a brute force approach
and optimizing them either to order n
or to order n log n
so we'll we'll discuss all of this so
don't worry if this doesn't make sense
just yet
but i hope you see now why we ignore
constants and lower order terms while
expressing the complexity of the big-o
notation
so we've covered binary search but
we've seen it in the context of a
problem
and now we can step away one more step
and abstract it out further and identify
the general strategy behind binary
search and this general strategy is
actually applicable to a wide variety of
problems and this is what you want to
keep doing as a programmer you need to
abstract away peel away the layers of
specific problem specific details and
find the general technique find the
general strategy and then encode that
using your functions and programs so
here's the general strategy
come up with a condition
to determine whether
the answer
lies before
after or at a given position so we are
assuming here that we have some kind of
a range
and we have to identify a position
within a range or maybe an element
within that range but we can access
elements using the position so come up
with a condition that that first tells
you whether given a position the answer
lies at
or before or after that position
once you have that condition
first retrieve the midpoint
and the middle element of the list now
if the middle element or the midpoint is
the answer then return the middle
position that is the answer you're done
if the answer lies before it
repeat the search so repeat the process
with the first half of the list
or the first half of the search space
and if the answer lies after it repeat
the search with the second half of the
search space
so here is the generic algorithm for
binary search
implemented in python
and you can see a
classic detailed documentation here
so while
so here you have the binary search is
going to take a search space low and
high so low is going to be zero
and high is going to be
well we will pass in maybe the final
we will pass it may be the final
position the final index of the array
but writing it this way rather than
passing passing an array also allows you
to use binary search for problems that
are not based on arrays sometimes these
could just be numbers
for example
if i ask you to find a number
between 1 million and 10 million that is
a perfect square
then you can use binary search to do
that
then it takes a condition
so what it does is it starts a loop so
while low less than equals high
we get the midpoint so low plus high
divided by 2 that gives us a midpoint
then remember earlier we had this
condition
test location so our condition simply is
supposed to take the middle position and
identify
if the middle position is the answer or
we need to go left or right so the
condition should return either found
left or right so if the condition
returns found we return the midpoint as
the answer if the condition returns left
we return the high we we move to the
left side so which is we take the end of
the search space and set it to before
the midpoint so we set high equal to mid
minus one and if the condition returns
right which is the else case here we set
low to mid plus one so we take the start
point of the search space and move it
after the element then we return minus
one so that's your binary generic binary
search algorithm and if you start using
this
what will happen is now this is a tested
piece of code and in fact we can see it
here
now now we can rewrite locate card
and locate card can be
we are passing in cards and we are
passing in the query and we need to
write a condition and here we're using a
very interesting feature of python
we are writing a function inside a
function so this is called function
closure and it's a very handy feature so
now we can simply write condition inside
locate card and what that does is
binary search is going to pass the
middle value the middle position
but condition can also access cards and
query so which is because it lies inside
locate
so what we do inside condition is okay
we check them we get the middle element
cards made if cards made is equal to
query then here we have that check we
check whether it is the first
occurrence of query or can query occur
before it if query occurs before it we
return left else we return found and
then these are the original conditions
that we already had so you can verify
this by going back and checking
but the important part here is now the
while loop has gone away now we can
simply call binary search with zero
len cards minus one so the
start index the end index
and the condition
and we can evaluate the test cases and
you can see that the test cases are
correct
and now you can use this binary search
function because we have not tested it
with one problem you can use this exact
same function to solve other problems
too in some sense it is a tested piece
of logic so here's what we'll do we'll
take a quick question and we will
implement it now we've spent what one
and a half hour talking about a
particular problem but let's spend maybe
two minutes talking about a new problem
and solving it
so now here's a slightly related
question given an array of integers
sorted in increasing order find the
starting and ending position of a given
number so once again you have a sorted
array this time they are increasing the
only difference is now apart from the
fact that they are sorted in increasing
order the other
difference is that we are looking for
both the
start index
and the end index so we're looking for
both the start index and the end index
of a particular number because the
number can repeat like we saw one
example
and
there's a very simple way to solve this
a simple strategy is
do binary search once to find the first
position and that's what this function
does i'll let you
read through
it the only changes here are this
variable
this has changed this order because now
the
now the elements are in increasing order
and then the second change and there's
no other change here so that there's
just one change here and then there is
another function called last position
here
instead of checking the left we are
checking the right so instead of
checking mid minus 1 we are checking mid
plus 1 and if mid plus 1 equals the
target we go to the right and of course
we have the same change here in this
code because instead of decreasing we
have increasing order right so now we
write two position now we write two
functions first position last position
and then first and last position is
simply getting the first position once
so that's one binary search and getting
the last position once that's two binary
searches and that's not bad now the
complexity is still order login two
times login or two times some constant
times login when you express it in the
big o notation is still login so that's
okay
and that was quick we were able to reuse
most of the code that we have written
and that's the benef benefit of
making generic functions like binary
search and in fact we can test a
solution by making a submission here
so let's go to leadcode.com
let us
here what i've done is i have already
copied over the binary search
function the first position function
and the last position function so by the
way lead code is a great platform for
practicing so you can go to leadcode.com
sign up with
any account and you will find a lot of
problems especially on the
in the problems tab
and here you can see that this is
exactly the problem that we have been
solving just now
so we just post the code here binary
search first position last position
first and last position and lead code
requires you to write this class called
solution this is something that they
give you beforehand and inside the
solution you need to define a function
called search range where we are simply
calling our first and last position
here i'll let you see
and we simply we can test this code with
a test case so you can pass a test case
here
and test it out
great
or we can simply submit it
and here you can see that the problem
was submitted successfully
and it tells you things like how much
runtime it used what was the memory it
used and your solution was accepted
right so check out leadcode.com go to
the problem section
and you can see all the different
problems that they have you can also
explore
and you have different problems that
come up every day it's a great place to
practice
so that's binary search for you but i
just want to revisit the method once
again so this is the systematic strategy
that we've applied for solving the
problem we state the problem clearly and
we identify the input and the output
formats
this this shows that you've understood
the problem you know what the solution
will look like then come up with some
example inputs and outputs and try to
cover all the edge cases so this shows
that
you are envisioning what are the
different inputs that can come in
before you write code
then you come up with the correct
solution not necessarily the most
efficient one and state it in plain
english
now when you try to state it you will
have to clarify it
and that will help you clarify your own
thoughts and then you can
analyze the algorithms complexity and
you can implement the solution and test
it using example inputs so this is the
basic solution now in interviews and in
coding assessments maybe you know where
there is a time limit you may not want
to implement the brute force brute force
solution because then you may get stuck
in fixing issues with brute force and
you can directly jump ahead to step five
but while you're practicing always
implement brute force then step five
analyze the algorithms complexity and
most of the time it is simply a matter
of counting the number of iterations how
many times a while loop or maybe a loop
within a loop is getting executed
and identify inefficiencies and if it is
a brute force solution
it's generally quite easy to see the
inefficiency for example in this case
the inefficiency was that we know that
the array is sorted that anything we do
will be better than going line by line
right we could pick a random element and
that would help us eliminate a good
chunk of the array
so that is the inefficiency and then
apply the right technique and we are
learning the techniques so we've learned
binary search today and then we are
going to learn a lot more techniques
that are asked in interviews so apply
the right technique to overcome the
inefficiency and repeat steps three to
six
which is go back and come up with the
correct solution with the optimized
technique implement the solution and
test it using some example inputs and
then analyze that algorithm's complexity
and identify any inefficiencies
so what we've done for you is we have
created a
template
so you can see this python problem
solving template
and how you can use this template
is to
simply run it so you run the code you
run this template and then when you run
the template inside it you will see this
question mark in a bunch of places so
you can give it a nice project name and
you can commit it to your profile one
way you can save a copy over this
template to your profile is by clicking
the duplicate button now if you click
the duplicate button you can copy it in
your profile and you don't have to look
for it you can just find it on your
jovian profile but anyway once you have
it copied you can
click the run button and then click run
on binder
and run run the template then you go
down once you run it and you can copy
over a problem statement
you can copy over a link to the problem
so that when you need to make a
submission you can go back and refer
and then here the method is summarized
for you
and here we have
created sections for you so you can
simply start filling out this method
step one step two step three step four
step five so whenever you're faced with
a difficult problem just use this
template and
i guarantee it one if you work through
this course you will be able to solve a
majority of the problems that you come
across
and specifically even if you are able to
follow
maybe about 30 to 40 percent of this
course you will easily be able to solve
most questions that are asked in
interviews
because questions asked in interviews
are fairly simple in terms of the data
structures or algorithms they test but
the intention there is more to test your
approach look at the quality of your
code and see how clearly you're
expressing yourself right and this is
what this is exactly what this method
teaches you to do
now to encourage you to do this to
encourage you to try it out and you can
take problems from places like lead code
uh code chef code forces there are a few
links listed here you can see practice
problems there are a bunch of links
listed here so that was today's lesson
for the next lesson
common data structures in python
so this is data structures and
algorithms in python
an online certification course brought
to you by jovian
thank you hello and welcome to data
structures and algorithms in python this
is an online certification course
being offered by jovian
today we're looking at assignment one
binary search practice
so let's get started
first thing we'll do is go to the course
website
pythondsa.com
on the course website you can enroll for
the course and view all the previous
lectures and assignments
for assignment 1 you may want to review
the video and notebook for lesson 1.
let's open up assignment one
it's called binary search practice
now in this assignment you will apply
and practice the concepts that we
covered in the first lesson so you will
understand and solve a system
solve a problem systematically
implement linear search and analyze it
and optimize the solution using binary
search and ask questions and help others
on the forum
let's open up the starter notebook for
the assignment
which contains that problem statement
and other information
now this is a notebook you're looking at
hosted on jovian
you can see some description here and if
you scroll down below you can also see
some code
and you will need to execute this
notebook modify the code with within it
and record a new version which you can
then submit
to see your score
so let's start reading through it
as you go through the notebook you will
find three question marks in certain
places to complete the assignment you
have to replace the question marks with
appropriate values expressions or
statements to ensure that the notebook
runs properly end to end
now keep in mind that you need to run
all the cells
otherwise you may get errors like name
error or undefined variables
you should not be changing any variable
names or deleting any cells or disturb
any existing code
you can add new code cells or new
statements
but do not redefine or do not change
some of the existing variables
you will be using a temporary online
service for code execution and we'll see
how to use it in a moment so keep saving
your work by running jobin.com at
regular intervals
and then the question marks optional
will not be considered for evaluation
although we recommend doing them they
are for your learning but you can make a
submission before you have solved the
optional questions
now you can make a submission back on
the assignment notebook page and we'll
see how to do that
and if you're stuck you can ask for help
on the community forum
it's listed here
and we'll see how to do that as well
now one final thing i want to mention is
you can get help with errors or ask for
hints you can even share your code and
errors that you are getting in the code
but please don't ask or share
the full working answer code on the
forum this is so that everybody has the
opportunity to work through the problem
statement on their own make mistakes
learn from their own mistakes and arrive
at the right solution
now how do you run this code the
recommended way to run this code is by
clicking the run button at the top of
the page and selecting run on binder but
you can also run it using some other
options like google collab or kagger
or you can run it on your computer
locally
so we're going to use the recommended
method run on binder
now we have the notebook running in
front of us
the first thing i like to do is go to
kernel and click restart and clear
output so that we can see all the
outputs of the notebook from scratch
and i'm also going to toggle the header
and the toolbar
so that we can zoom in a bit
so now the same jupyter notebook is now
running online on a platform called
binder
and before starting the assignment let's
save a snapshot of the assignment to our
jovian profile so that we can access it
later and continue our work i'm going to
run pip install jovian
this is going to install the jovian
library
then run import jovian to import the
and set a project name
here i'm just calling it binary search
assignment and run jovian.commit now you
have taken a starter notebook which was
hosted on my profile and then you've run
it on binder where as soon as you run
jovian.comit a copy of the starter
notebook gets saved to your profile so
what you will see here is a link to a
notebook hosted on your jovian profile
let's open it up here and see so now
this
is your personal copy of the assignment
notebook any changes that you make here
and run jovian.comit will get added to
your profile so if you want to come back
and continue your work then you do not
have to go back to the original starter
notebook which contains all blanks
rather you can come back to your profile
and you can come to your profile simply
by opening jobin.ai
and on your profile you can go to the
notebooks tab
and on the notebooks tab you will be
able to find
as you can see here you will be able to
find the
binary search assignment here
there you go this is the binary search
assignment that we just created
and you can open it and run it on binder
to continue your work
so moving along this is the problem
we're looking at here
you are given a list of numbers obtained
by rotating a sorted list an unknown
number of times
okay so we have two new terms here
rotating a sorted list and don't worry
if you don't know what that means
normally if you see any new terms in a
problem
they will be explained somewhere within
the problem itself
for instance here you can see that
there's a definition we define rotating
a list as removing the last element of
the list and adding it before the first
element for instance rotating the number
the list three two four one
leads to removal of the last number and
then placing it at the very beginning so
you end up with the list one three two
four this is a new operation that we are
defining this is not something standard
but you will find that a lot of problems
will define new terms or new operations
so that they it becomes easier for you
to understand the problem so that's
rotating a list now rotating a list once
produces one three two four now if you
rotate that list again the resulting
list one more time then you will end up
with four one three two and so on
and then the other term is sorted so
sorted refers to a list where the
elements are arranged in increasing
order
in this case we have numbers and the
numbers 1 3 5 7 are increased arranged
in increasing order so this is a sorted
list
but if this was 3 2 4 1 well that's not
the numbers are not arranged in
increasing order so that's not a sorted
list
so you are given a list of numbers
update obtained by rotating a sorted
list an unknown number of times for
instance this sorted list 0 2 3 4 5 6 9
is rotated a certain number of times and
you can verify that if you rotate this
three times you end up with the list
five six nine
zero two three four right you can see
that first
nine comes to the beginning then six
comes comes to the beginning and then
five comes to the beginning
so you need to write a function
and you're given just this the list
you're not given the original sorted
list you're given the list obtained by
rotating some sorted list and unknown
number of times now you need to write a
function to determine the minimum number
of times the original sorted list was
rotated to obtain the given list
your function should have the worst case
complexity of order log n where n is the
length of the list
and you can assume that all the numbers
in the list are unique okay so three
parts write a function to determine the
minimum number of times you need to
rotate the original sorted list in this
in this case it is three the function
should have the worst case complexity of
log n so this determines correctness and
this determines efficiency
and then this is some additional
information to help you that you can
assume all the numbers in the list are
unique
if this was not mentioned you would also
have to handle the case where your list
does not contain unique numbers
now we will apply the method that we
have been applying all throughout
this course for solving the problems
number one state the problem clearly
identify the input and output formats
number two come up with some example
inputs and outputs and try to cover all
the edge cases number three come up with
a correct solution for the problem and
state it in plain english
number four implement the solution and
test it using some example inputs and
having test cases and then
implementing a solution allows you to
test them using the example inputs and
fix any bugs that's why it's very
important to have some test cases number
five analyze the algorithm's complexity
and identify any inefficiencies and
number six apply the right technique to
overcome the inefficiency
and then you go back and repeat steps
three to six come up with the correct
solution implement the solution and test
it and analyze the algorithm's
complexity
and you can review lesson one for a
detailed explanation of this method
now let's apply it step by step
the first step is to state the problem
clearly and identify the input and
output formats now while it is stated
clearly enough it always helps to
express it in your own words in the way
that it makes it most clear for you and
this is something that you can keep
returning to rather than the original
problem statement
because this is something that you will
understand better
and it's okay if your problem
overlaps with the original problem
statement but do try to express it in
your own words so in this case what i've
just done is i have double clicked here
once you double click you can now edit
this text cell and now we can start
writing a problem
so let's say given a rotated list
we need to find the
number of times
it was rotated and okay i think what
i've probably missed here is that it is
a sorted list so given a
sorted list that was
rotated
some unknown number of times
we need to find the number of times it
was rotated right maybe i'm just going
to say given a rotated sorted list
because technically the input is not a
sorted list it's a rotated sorted list
so given a rotated short test list that
was rotated an unknown number of times
we need to find the number of times it
was rotated now doing this exercise
helps you
determine
if you've understood the problem
correctly
and you may often find that okay there's
a certain detail in the problem that you
missed
okay but at this point i'm happy with my
description
and you will see that it is matching the
description to a large extent
but it's something that i understand
better so i'll just refer to this from
this point
now i'm assuming here that i know what
rotation and sorted means otherwise i
could also include those
then
here's a question
the function will you will write will
take one input called nums
what does it represent and give an
example okay so
once again we double click on this and
one input is
nums so this is
a sorted
rotated list
and let's give an example here
let's say we take the sorted list three
five
six seven
nine
and then we rotate it a few times
let's say we rotate it a couple of times
so we end up with this
sorted rotated list
so that's our input so we've answered
the question here now the first question
was to express the problem in your own
words this is the solution
the second question was what does the
input norms represent give an example it
represents a sorted rotated list 79356
the third question is the function you
will write will return a single output
called rotations what does that
represent well you have to write a
function that identifies how many times
the list was rotated so
this is the number of times the sorted
list was
rotated
okay
and in this case the example that we
have is that this sorted list was
rotated twice
three five six seven nine was rotated
two times
so you mentioned two here now you can
see these back quotes that i'm using
here this is next to
the number one on your keyboard or below
the escape key
what these backwards let you do is they
let you
express text as code within markdown you
can see that they have a gray background
and they have a different font this
looks a lot more like code same is here
true for nums so you can use markdown
and its features
to your advantage to organize your
descriptions and your text better
okay so now based on the above we can
now create a signature of our functions
we have a function called counts
rotations it takes the num list of
numbers and it returns well right now
we're just putting pass in here but we
know that it's going to return a single
number rotations
now after each step remember to save
your notebook so we are going to just
run joven dot commit
and now if you leave your computer you
do not have to be worried that your work
may be lost
so you can go in here
and you can
open up this notebook from your joven
profile and
press run at any point to run this
notebook
now step two is to come up with some
example inputs and outputs and try to
cover all the edge cases and our
function should be able to handle any
set of valid inputs so here is some
variations that you can encounter
a list of size 10 rotated three times a
list of size eight rotated five times so
these are two generic examples and then
a list that wasn't rotated at all a list
that was rotated just once a list that
was rotated n minus 1 times
where n is the size of the list
a list that was rotated n times
and what do you mean by rotating the
list n times well
let's see
an empty list and a list containing just
one element and if you can think of more
test cases you should definitely add
more test cases here
and what we'll do is we will express our
test cases as dictionaries so
this will help us
organize the test cases and test them
all at once more easily using helper
functions
so you can see here that we've organized
one test case here and we've expressed
the task as a dictionary so here we have
the input to the test case that is the
input key and then we have the output to
the test case now because a function can
take many arguments
the input itself is going to be a
dictionary and then for each argument in
this case there's just one so we just
call it nums
we have the input here
and this is the size of the output
okay
so
let's create this test case
and let us then
if you want to fetch the actual input
and output out of it so here we can
fetch test input nums that's going to
give us the nums we can use test input
the output should be
test outputs
this seems to be an error
and the result is count rotations num0
okay so this is the actual result
obtained by passing the test case into
count rotations
and you can see that the result we get
back is none because right now we do not
have any code we it just says pass
inside
and the result and the output are not
equal because the output is the number
three but the result is none so that's
okay our test case is failing right now
because we have not yet implemented the
function
but as soon as we implement it we expect
to see the test case passing
now to help you avoid all of this work
we have given you a function called
evaluate test case so from jovian.python
dsa you can just import evaluate test
case and then call evaluate test case
with the function you want to test and
the actual test case
and you can see here it prints the out
input that was passed in the expected
output the actual output that was
obtained and the test result in this
case the test result was failed
and the execution time is also printed
here if you just want to evaluate
if a certain implementation is faster
than another
so now your job is to create test cases
for each of the scenarios listed above
so here is test zero that is same as the
original test case that we had created
now here is test one a size a list of
size eight rotated five times i will let
you create this
but it will look something like this you
will open up you'll replace the three
question marks with let's say a list of
size eight so one two three four five
six seven eight
and you can imagine that if this was
rotated five times then one two three
four five four five of these numbers
will then move
to the first position
and you get this as the input
numbers and the output well
it was rotated five times so i think you
can guess that the output here should be
five
now here is a list that wasn't rotated
at all
what should be the output here
i'm sure you can guess that the output
here should be zero so i'll let you fill
this out here is a list that was rotated
just once
so let's try let's fill out this one
so this
this list rotated once would give us
seven three five
there you go
a list that was rotated n minus one
times where n is the size of the list
okay i'll let you do that
a list that was rotated n times where n
is the size of the list okay what does
that look like
so you take this list and then you first
put 10 in the first position and then
you put 9 in the first position so 9 10
comes to the beginning and 3 5 7 8 comes
after it
then you move 8 to the first position
then you move 7 then you move five then
you move three if you if you move all of
these back to the first position you end
up with the same list
so you've rotated it n times
now what should be the output in this
case there are about six numbers here
so is the output 6
i don't know i'm not so sure because
remember the question the original
question says
write a function to determine the
minimum number of times the original
sorted list was rotated to obtain the
given list so it has to be the minimum
number of times we may want to just go
back and change this
we need to find not
the number of times it was rotated but
the minimum number of times it was
rotated or it needs to be rotated right
so
coming back here
the output should be not six
but
zero
so keep that in mind
then here's an empty list i'll let you
figure out what should be the nums and
the output here
and here is a list containing just one
element
once again should be pretty
straightforward can you rotate a list
with one element
i'll let you decide
and then we're taking
all the tests and putting them into a
single list now since i have not defined
all the tests i am not going to use this
definition which contains all the tests
but i'm just going to pick the number of
tests that i have defined
so we have defined here test 0
test 1
test 3
test 5
i'm just going to put in
test 0 test 1
test 3
and test 5
and that's the full set of tests that we
have
you definitely need to fill out all the
test cases and if you can think of some
other cases that you should be testing
then you should include those test cases
here as well
okay
now to evaluate your function against
all the test cases together you can use
the evaluate test cases helper function
from jovian so there are two functions
evaluate test case works with a single
test case and evaluate test cases works
with
a list of test cases
so we have a list of test cases here i
have four but you should have about
eight at least and a few more if you
have created them
so we can import from juvenile python
dsa evaluate test cases and then invoke
evaluate test cases
with
the count rotations function
still it we don't
have any logic in the function so all
the test cases should pass and the list
of test cases we've created so you can
see test cases zero fails one fails two
fails three fails
so out of the four test cases none of
them
have passed
no problem
we have completed step two which is to
create some test cases and we'll know
once we've defined a function whether
the function definition is correct
now the next step is to come up with a
correct solution for the problem and
state it in plain english
and there's a hint here for you already
coming up with the correct solution is
quite easy and it's based on this simple
insight if a list of sorted numbers is
rotated k times so you keep rotating it
step by step moving the last number to
the
first position
then the smallest number in the list
ends up at position key
and you can verify this it's very simple
to do this
whenever you have a doubt just create a
new cell by the way you can create a new
cell by clicking on the left side of a
cell
and clicking insert cell below
or if you're in a code cell just click
here near the prompt and press the b
character
and that adds a new cell below
so let's take the list 1 3 5 7
5 6 7
and let's rotate it k times let's try
with k equals 2 so if you set k equal to
2 then you're going to take two of these
numbers from the very end
and move them to the beginning so that
means zero comes at position
six comes at position zero seven comes
at position one
and the starting element in the sorted
list now comes at position two
that's interesting let's
move the third element as well
okay so now we've moved three elements
or rotated the list three times and the
smallest element ends up at position
three
so it seems to hold true
and you can verify this now with a
larger list smaller list empty list and
all the test cases that you have but if
a list was sorted
k times sorted list was rotated k times
then the smallest number in the list
ends up at position k
counting from zero
further it is the only number in the
list which is smaller than the number
before it and you can see this once
again the smallest number is at position
3 and all of these numbers are
higher than the numbers that come before
them
except the number 1 which is smaller
than 7.
so
we simply need to check for each number
in the list whether it is smaller than
the number that comes before it if there
is a number before it then our answer is
simply which is the number of rotations
is simply the position of this number
right so if you can find the position of
the number
which is smaller than the number that
comes before it the position of the
number is also equal to the number of
times the sorted list was rotated
and if we cannot find such a number then
the list wasn't rotated at all
and that's it
you can see here in this list now
applying this logic 3 is the number
the smallest number
and not only that 3 is the only number
which is lower than the number that
precedes it the predecessor which is 29
and since 3 occurs at position 4
well actually three occurs at position
three
zero one two three
the list was rotated exactly three times
now we can use the linear search
algorithm as a first attempt to solve
this problem in the linear search simply
involves working through
this list walking through this list from
the left to the right
so now the
task for use to describe the linear
search solution in your own words and
please write it in your own words but
here's how i'm going to write it
let's say create a variable
position
with values zero
so this is the
position for tracking this is for
tracking the position
then
look at
the number
at
the given position and not only look at
it but
compare the number at the let's say the
current position
to the
number before it
now if you're starting position with the
value 0 maybe
we may not there's no number before it
so we may not be able to compare it with
something
we may even just start with the value
one that's all right
if the number is
smaller than
its
predecessor
then return position because position is
the answer we found the number that is
smaller than its predecessor there's
only one such number
otherwise
increment
position and repeat
till we exhaust
all the numbers
okay
simple
now you can add more steps if
your
description of the algorithm requires
more steps that's perfectly all right
but at this point we have a very clear
description of the solution now we're
starting with the position
1 not 0 because we also want to track
the previous position
now we import jovian here and commit our
project once again
and keep saving your work after every
step so that you can continue your work
so now we're talking about
implementing the solution and testing it
so let's implement the solution we said
that we want to start with position
we want to start with position one
and while
when should the loop be terminated well
while position
is less than the length of nums
i guess that's fair
and then what is the success criteria so
we have if position greater than zero
and
nums of position less than numbers of
position minus one okay so that's the
success criteria here now you can see
that there's a condition if position
greater than zero here so we don't
really need to start position at zero we
can start position at we don't really
need to start position at one we can
start position at zero as well and all
that will happen is this condition will
get skipped and position will get
incremented and this is
a good practice because whenever you
iterate over a list you normally just
want to start with 0 just to avoid any
confusion
later when you're reading the code that
did you intend to write 0 here a 1 etc
etc
so just put in position equal 0 here and
simply skip the check
here or simply skip this comparison if
position is not valid right so whenever
you're accessing an element from inside
a list or inside a dictionary you always
want to make sure that that
index
or that key is valid okay here we are
making sure that the
key position minus 1 is valid by
checking position greater than zero
in any case we now have the logic and
finally
[Music]
we are saying that if the number at
position is less than the number that
comes before it then we return that
and that's just going to if it's not
then it's going to increment the
position and it's going to check again
and again and again till we run out of
numbers now if you've exa exhausted the
entire list
then it follows that
there were no rotations or there were n
rotations exactly in either case the
number we returned should be zero okay
so
keep this in mind the sum
you may have the doubt should you be
returning -1 here or should you be
returning 0 here
well
the question does specify clearly that
you are given a sorted rotated list and
you have to find the number of times it
was rotated now obviously minus 1
rotations are not possible so minus 1
would not be a valid return value from
your function
and this is the reason we write test
cases too
now let's evaluate the test case
so let's call evaluate test case for a
single test case on count rotations
linear and let's see what the test case
is
this is the test case here and this is
the output
we call evaluate test case with count
rotations linear and test
and that gives us a linear search result
you can see here this was the number
the list of numbers this was the
expected output and this was the actual
output so grade our function seems to
have passed the test case
now we can evaluate all the test cases
by calling count rotations linear on all
the test cases together and give that
gives us a whole list of test results
test case 0 and 1 and 2 and 3
all of them have passed now if you had
put n minus 1 here
you would see
that
one of the test cases would fail
which is
the case where the list wasn't rotated
at all or was rotated n times
so that should tell you that the answer
here should be
zero
[Music]
so that's our linear search algorithm
and
at this point
you may face issues
you may feel stuck you may not be able
to figure out how to write the code
and that's perfectly all right that's
part of learning
you may face errors you may face
exceptions for instance if you did not
have this check here
position greater than zero or maybe you
what you had here was
some other condition
like position less than equals position
plus one
and that's okay
then you can go to the forum and post
your issue so let's open up the forum
here
this is the
forum discussion for assignment one
and you can go into the original topic
here
which is a
longer discussion so this is where
everybody is posting small issues so you
can see that there's about 321 messages
that have been posted you can start
looking through this forum you can start
reading through some of the posts you
can even search if you press ctrl f and
you can even search for questions here
now if you want to post your own
question
scroll down to the very end or you can
just click this button here
and click reply
okay and mention your question here i
have a
[Music]
an issue
should i return -1 or 0 in the case
the list
has not been rotated
okay maybe that's and
if you want if you have
code that's not working or there's an
error you can also include a screenshot
of your code or i'll show you another
trick
you can actually include
let's say you commit your notebook
so let me come up here i've committed my
notebook
and if you have a particular line of
code that you want to share
you can actually click
copy cell link
and paste it here
so that will give a link to the entire
cell
and if somebody clicks on the link then
they can view that specific cell of the
notebook directly let's see
you can see here that it brings us
directly to this specific cell
there's another option you can even
click on
embed cell
okay for embed for secret notebooks we
do not allow embedding but copying the
cell link should work
and then click reply and your question
will be posted and somebody will reply
to your
question just come back to the forum in
a few hours or maybe the next day and
you should see an answer you will also
receive an email
so that's the discussion topic you can
also go back to the topic here the
category here and create a new
question you can see that if you want to
start your own thread
if you think your question deserves a
deeper discussion where multiple people
can reply you can also create a new
thread by clicking new
topic okay so keep this in mind and do
make use of the forum what we've seen is
people who are active on the forum are
at least four to five times more likely
to complete the course and earn the
certificate of accomplishment
and continue working on these topics
after the course as well
okay so the next step is to analyze the
algorithms complexity
and the way to do this if you've seen
lesson one is to simply count the number
of iterations the number of executions
of the while loop
now if you have a list of numbers of
size n
then you can see here that this is the
key loop here
while position less than the num length
of numbers
so then there will be n loops or n
iterations and then inside each each
iteration we're performing certain
comparisons and returning things so all
of these are
in effect constant time and based on
this you can probably tell
that the complexity of linear search is
order of n so you can just put in
a big o
and in the big o notation this would be
order n
so that's the first part of the
assignment linear search
now the next step is to apply the right
technique to overcome the inefficiency
and that's where you can now
you can now read through the rest of the
assignment now the idea here is this
binary search is the technique we'll
apply
and the key question
we need to answer in binary search is
given the middle element
can you decide if it is the answer which
means if it is
let's say the smallest number in the
list
or whether the answer lies to the left
or the right of it okay so given the
middle given if the middle element is
smaller than its predecessor
then it is the answer we already know
that because there's only one number in
the list that is smaller than its
predecessor so you can see here for
example
now if the middle element was 1 which
it's not but suppose the middle element
was 1 and you can see that 1 is smaller
than 8 then we know that 1 is the answer
so the position of the middle element is
the answer
however if it isn't
then we need a way to determine whether
the answer lies to the left of the
middle element or to the right of it
and consider these examples so here you
can see that the middle element is 3
and the answer is
the position
so
in this case the answer or the smallest
element lies to the left
on the other hand in this case you can
see the middle element is 4 and the
smallest element minus 1 lies to the
right of it
so now you need to apply your mind and
think of a check that will help you
determine if the middle element
given the middle element if the answer
lies to the left or the right of it
right and we're looking for the smallest
element remember so the logic here if
you just spend a couple of minutes you
will come up with this quite easily if
the middle element of the list is
smaller than the last last element of
the list okay
or the last element of the range that we
are currently looking at that means that
all the numbers here are in increasing
order
so then the answer lies to the left of
it
on the other hand if the middle element
of the list is
larger than the
last element of the range
that means that because we know that the
list is a rotated sorted list so that
means that the numbers increase up to a
point and then there's a decrease and
then they continue increasing that's the
only way in which the final element can
be smaller
so that means the answer lies to the
right of it so that's the logic here for
binary search
and now what you have to do is describe
the binary search solution in your own
words so here once again you have these
four five
lines
it's very important that you do this
because if you cannot express it then
coding it is also going to be difficult
for you so always do this exercise of
expressing the solution in your own
words when you're practicing when you're
solving a coding challenge or something
even in an interview it's also very
important
because the first thing you need to do
is to communicate to the interviewer
your thought process and how you're
thinking about the problem so the first
thing you need to do is describe a
simple solution in your in simple words
and then they may or may not ask you to
code that solution and then the next
thing is to identify the
complexity or identify the inefficiency
then the next step for you is to
describe the optimal solution or the
binary search solution in your own words
okay now
if you don't describe the solution in
your own words and you start writing the
code they may not be able to follow your
code
so even if you've written mostly correct
code maybe with one or two edge cases
wrong
they may still have a feeling that you
don't know what you're writing but if
you explain the solution clearly to them
they will know that now you understand
the solution
and they will be able to follow the code
as you write it
and they will be able to pick up
mistakes or errors and help you with the
errors
one secret is that interviews are always
open to helping you
unless you
make them really confused
so keep that in mind and describe the
solution in your words
once you do that you can commit now the
next step is to implement the solution
now the implement the binary search
solution as described in the previous
step
let's run this again
so you run count rotations define the
function count rotations binary now you
may want to review lesson one here on
how to start it out
you'll see that low starts out at zero
and high starts out at length
nums minus 1
and i will not solve the rest of this
but there is a certain condition here
between low and high so in binary search
we are starting with the entire list as
the range then we are looking at the mid
number so we're getting the first the
mid position and we look at the number
at the mid position
then
we check if the middle position is the
answer so if the middle person is the
answer we return the middle position
then we check if the answer lies in the
left half so here's a condition where
you decide if the answer lies in the
left half and we
once if the condition holds true all we
do is we change the high so which we
change the end point of the range
to mid minus one and then we check if
the answer lies in the right half
in that case we change the starting
point of the range to mid plus one and
the while loop repeats okay so that's
the general logic of binary search and
one thing you have to keep in mind is if
none of the elements satisfy the
criteria that you have what is the
answer and this is a very important
condition this is where
it is very easy to go wrong
it is also called the edge case or the
trivial case so you should handle and
think about this carefully
and then once you've done that you can
evaluate the test case and you can a
single test case you can evaluate
multiple test cases now if your test
cases are failing you may want to enable
this print statement inside by
uncommenting it
but make sure to comment it out at the
end once again
and the print statement will help you
see what the low high and mid points
were now you may want to then take a pen
and paper look at an example that is
failing
and see if the printed numbers match
what you expect to see
debugging your function is a very
important skill
so keep that in mind
and use a debugging technique like this
by adding print statements and working
out the same problem side by side on
paper to fix your issues
otherwise you may feel lost if you're
not able to look into the internal
workings of the function
next you have to analyze the algorithms
complexity and identify inefficiencies
this should be straightforward enough
we've already looked at the complexity
of binary search but all you need to do
is make sure that what you're doing
within the algorithm matches the
analysis that we've done earlier so the
problem size reduces by half each time
and then we are doing constant work
in each step before solving a problem of
half the size
so that should roughly give you an
answer
and keep committing your work
now finally to make a submission you
have two options
now one option is to take this link so
your notebook has been committed here
and you can come to the
assignment page let's open up the
assignment page binary search practice
come down here and paste this
link here and click submit
now once you click submit the assignment
will be submitted and
it will go into automated evaluation so
in about
a couple of minutes maybe up to an hour
depending on the queue of
submissions from different participants
you will receive
a grade over email
let's just refresh the page
and it seems like
there was an issue here the issue was
that count rotations binary was not
defined
so it's possible that
this happened
contradictions binary did not get
defined because there are a bunch of
question marks here
so we may need to then fix the issue and
then come back
and make a submission once again
okay
so i have received failed grade i will
go back and i will fix the issue and
then come back okay now it's very
important for you that's why to have
good asset good set of test cases for
you to test your function
so that
when you submit it or when you get an
error you can maybe look at your
functions performance on the test cases
and fix anything that needs to be fixed
and add new test cases if you need to
now one other way you can submit
is by simply running the code by joven
dot submit assignment equals python dsa
hyphen assignment 1 the code is
mentioned here
you can see here that the submission was
made and you can verify your submission
on this page
ok
so
that's assignment1
so what should you do next
review the lecture video if you need to
and execute the jupyter notebook
you may need to keep you may want to
keep the jupyter notebook running side
by side as you're working on the
assignment then complete the assignment
and even attempt the optional questions
if you scroll down here on the
assignment notebook
you will find that there are some
optional questions for you
here's one bonus question use the
generic binary search algorithm so
inside the python dsa
module in jovian there is a function
called binary search you can use the
generic binary search example
then here's an optional bonus question
two handle repeating numbers we did say
that you can assume that
there are no
repeating numbers in the list but here's
one list with repeating numbers can you
modify your solution to handle the
special case
and then here's an optional bonus
question three
about searching in a rotated list so
you're given a rotated list now instead
of finding the number of times it was
rotated you you're trying to find the
position of a certain number for
instance the position of six
can you apply binary search and modify
your previous solution slightly
to search within the rotated list and
find the position of a given number
now here's a hint
you can simply
identify two sorted sub-arrays within
the given array
and perform a binary search on each
sub-array
using so to identify the two sorted
sub-arrays you can use the count
rotations binary function so that's one
potential solution another way is to
modify the counter rotations binary
function to solve the problem directly
so it's a very interesting problem to
solve
and if you found the assignment easy
then you should definitely solve these
bonus questions and if you can solve
this question
by yourself without taking additional
help
then you can solve pretty much any
problem related to binary search that
may be asked in an interview because
most of the questions are some
variations of something like this and
this is pretty much the hardest problem
you may get asked
you can also test your solution by
making a submission on lead code and
this is only for the final optional
question
and there's a thread
on the forum where you can discuss the
bonus questions separately as well
so do make use of the forum thread too
here it is optional bonus questions
discussion
so that was assignment one of data
structures and algorithms
this is called binary search practice
hello and welcome to data structures and
algorithms in python this is an online
certification course by jovian
my name is akash and i am the ceo and
co-founder of jovian
you can earn a certificate of
accomplishment for this course by
completing four weekly assignments and
doing a course project today we are on
lesson two of six
now if you open up pythondsa.com
you will end up on this course website
where you will be able to find all the
information for the course you can view
the previous lessons which is lesson one
and uh you can also
work on the previous assignment which is
assignment one
and you can also check out the course
community forum where
you can
get help and have discussions
so let's open up lesson two
this is a lesson page here you will be
able to see
the video for this lesson
you can watch live or you can watch a
recording here and you can also see a
version of this video lecture in hindi
and in this lesson we'll explore the use
cases of binary search trees and develop
a step-by-step implementation from
scratch solving many common interview
questions along the way
so
here is the code that we are going to
use in this lesson all the different
notebooks containing the code are listed
here and let's open up the first one
so here you can see all the explanations
and the code for this lesson this is
binary search trees traversals and
balancing in python
and this is the second notebook in the
course you can check out the first
notebook in lesson one
and if you're just joining us
this is a beginner friendly course and
you do not need a lot of background in
programming with a little bit of
understanding of python and a little bit
of high school mathematics you should be
able to follow along just fine if you do
not know these then you can follow these
tutorials to learn the prerequisites in
just about an hour or two
now the best way to learn the material
that we are covering in this course is
to actually run the code and experiment
with it yourself
so to run the code and you can see here
if we scroll down you can see that there
is some code here on this page as well
now to run the code you have two options
you can either run it using an online
programming platform or you can run it
on your computer locally
so to run this code we will scroll up
and click on the run button and then
click run on binder
and this is going to start executing the
code that we were just looking at
so once again you can go on the course
page pythondsa.com
open up lesson2
and you can watch the video there and on
lesson 2 you can open up the link to the
code where you can read the code and the
explanations here
and if you want to run the code just
click the run button and that will
execute the code for you
so once you click the run button on
binder
you should be able to
see
an interface like this this is the
jupyter notebook interface the same
explanations that we were seeing on the
lesson page you can see here the same
explanations are now available here
but the difference is you can now edit
these explanations and you can go down
and you can actually run some of the
code in this tutorial you can see here
that you have a run button and when you
click the run button that is going to
run the code in this particular cell and
this is a jupyter notebook made up of
cells now we'll do a couple of things
here the first thing we'll do is we
click on
kernel and click on restart and clear
output what this will do is this will
clear all the outputs of the code cell
so that we can execute them ourselves
and then i'm just going to zoom in here
and hide the interface so that we can
look at
the explanations and the code
so finally we have some running code
and in this notebook we will focus on
solving this specific problem and this
is a common question
a question of this sort can be asked in
interviews so this is an interview
question but along the way we will also
learn how to build binary trees and
binary search trees and how to apply
them to several other questions so
here's the question
as a senior back-end engineer at jovin
you are tasked with developing a fast
in-memory data structure to manage
profile information which is username
name and email for 100 million users it
should allow the following operations to
be performed efficiently you should be
able to insert the profile information
for a new user find the profile
information for a user given their
username and then update the profile
information of a user once again given
their username
and list all the users of the platform
sorted by username
and you can assume here that usernames
are unique
so this is a very realistic problem that
you might face if you're working at a
company where you have a lot of users
so let's see how we solve this problem
now here's a systematic strategy that
we'll apply for solving problems not
just here but throughout this course
this first step is state the problem
clearly and in abstract terms and then
identify the input and output formats
then come up with some example inputs
and outputs to test any future
implementations and try to cover all the
edge cases
and then come up with a simple correct
solution for the problem
it doesn't have to be efficient it just
has to be correct and stated in plain
english and then implement the solution
and test it using some example inputs
fix bugs if you face any
and finally analyze the algorithms
complexity and identify inefficiencies
if any
now once you identify inefficiencies
then we apply the right technique and
that's where data structures and
algorithms comes into picture so we
apply the right technique to overcome
the inefficiency and then we go back to
step three so come up with a new correct
solution which is also efficient state
it in plain english implement it and
then analyze the complexity now if you
follow this process you should be able
to solve any programming problem or
interview question
so step one we state the problem clearly
and we identify the input and output
formats now we can reduce the problem to
a very simple single line statement we
need to create a data structure which
can efficiently store 100 million
records
and
we should be able to perform insertion
search update and list operations
all of them as efficient as possible
now the input the key input to our data
structure the solution that we are
building
is going to be user profiles
which contains username name and email
of a user
now before we come up with a solution we
need a way to represent user profiles
and a python class would be a great way
to represent the information for a user
so you may have heard of the term
object-oriented programming and that is
what we're going to look at now
if you're not familiar with the class
it's very simple a class is simply a
blueprint for creating objects and
what's an object well everything in
python is an object whether you're
looking at a number a dictionary a list
anything and you can create your own
custom objects with custom properties
and custom methods
by creating your own custom classes
so here's the simplest possible class in
python with nothing inside it we're
creating a class user so this is how you
declare a class and then when putting
nothing inside it so whenever you put
nothing inside a function or a class or
anything
you can put you need to put the pass
statement because python cannot accept
empty blocks of code so here we're
creating a class which does not have
anything inside it
and we can create an object or it's
often called instantiation which is take
creating an instance of a class
instantiate an object of the class by
calling it like a function so we say
user1
is user
so this creates an object and the
variable user1 points to that object now
we can verify that the object is off the
class user by simply printing it
or by checking its type
user1 and typeuser1 are both user
now the object user one does not contain
any useful information
so let's add what's called a constructor
method so constructor method is used to
construct an object
to store some attributes and properties
so now we're defining the class user
once again but inside it we're defining
this function and you can see that this
function is inside the class because
there is some indentation here
so we define this function underscore
underscore init
and it takes four arguments now the
first argument is a special argument
called self and we'll talk about this
and then we have three arguments
username name and email
and inside in it what we're doing is
we're
setting self.username so we're setting a
property on self to username we're
setting a property on self to name and
we're setting a property on self to
email
and finally we're printing user created
so let's see let's create another user
user2
and you can see that user 2 is also
an object of the class user now here's
what happening conceptually when we do
this
the first thing that happens is
when you invoke this function when you
invoke user as a function python first
creates an empty object of the class
user
and then stores it in the variable user
too
and then
python invokes the init function
and to the init function it passes user
to the object that was just created as
self
and then the other arguments that were
passed while creating the object
as the rest of the arguments so you can
imagine that we are basically doing
we are basically calling user dot
underscore underscore init
the function with user to an empty
object
and these arguments john johndoe and
jondo.com and then inside the init
function we simply set these properties
on user two so now we get user two dot
username is
john user two dot name is john doe and
user two dot email is
johndoejohneddo.com
so that's basically how classes work in
python
and that's why you always have this
additional
extra argument in all class methods
which will refer to the object that
finally gets created
okay
so
once user two is created with the values
john john doe and john doe dot com you
can check that user two dot name
is john doe and user two dot email
is john doe dot com and user two dot
username is john
now you can also define some custom
methods in
inside a class
so obviously we had the init method but
here we are also defining another method
called introduce yourself now introduce
yourself takes again two arguments the
first argument is self which will
refer to the actual object
that gets created later
and then we have a guest name and we
basically say hi guest name i am
such and such contact me at such and
such so these blanks are filled in using
the guest name self.name and self.email
okay so that's how you define a method
in a class so here we have
another user we're creating jane and
jane doe at janetddo.com
and you can see here that when we call
introduce yourself with david
so user3
which is jane becomes self and then
david becomes guest name and that's why
we get hi david i am jane doe contact me
at geneto.com
so that's a quick refresher on classes
in python now there's a lot more to
classes but the simplest thing you need
to know is you how to define a class how
to create a constructor
which is underscore underscore init how
to set some properties like we said the
properties name email
and username and finally how to define
methods like we defined the method
introduce yourself
and that's all we will need today so we
won't need much more than that
and one final thing that we're doing
with our class is we're defining two
other special
functions
underscore underscore repr wrapper and
underscore underscore str
so now these two functions
these two functions are used to create a
string representation of the object and
you can see here once we create an
object user4
now and if we try to print user four you
can see that 4 is
now printed like this so user 3 was not
printed i mean user 3 was printed just
as a user but with user 4 we have all
this information printed here as well
so now here's an exercise for you which
also brings us to the first quiz of the
day now we are going to do three quizzes
in this video and you can answer these
quizzes on linkedin
so go to our linkedin profile if you see
the posts you will see a new post here
which will give you a question and the
question is what is the purpose of
defining the functions str and wrapper
within a class and how are these two
functions different now leave a comment
with your answer
and we will pick
the right answer one right answer and
one lucky winner will get a swag back
from us
so that was the input we have we now
have a way to represent users by
creating classes
and then the output that we want the
final output that we want to create for
our problem is a data structure
so a data structure is once again
something that we can define using a
class so we can define we can expect our
final output to be a class called user
database which has four methods insert
find update and list all and insert
takes a user and inserts it into the
database find takes a username and
returns the user
update takes a user
and updates the data for that user and
finally list all returns a list of the
users so this is what the class will
look like and we have not implemented it
yet
but we now have an interface
so now the next step is to come up with
some example inputs and outputs so let's
create some sample user profiles that we
can use to test our functions once we
implement them
so we're going to create
these seven user profiles you can see
that we're creating these seven user
profiles with a username name and an
email and storing them in these
variables
using the user class that we have just
defined earlier
and we're also going to store the list
of users
in this variable called users
and as you can see we can access
different fields within a user profile
using the dot notation so you can check
biraj dot username is bharaj and biraj
dot email is biraj example dot com and
biraj dot name is bhiraj
now you can also view a string
representation of the user as we have
seen so if we print the user you can see
some information about the user and here
is the full list of users that we have
created so it's always a good idea to
set up some input data set up some test
inputs that you can use to test with
your implementation later on
and since we haven't implemented our
data structure yet it's not possible to
list any sample outputs
but you can try to come up with some
different scenarios to test any future
implementations
so let's let's list some scenarios for
testing the methods of our user database
class so the
methods are insert find update and list
all and for inserting you may want to
test that you're inserting a user into
an empty database of users so that's
what's called an edge case and then the
general case is to insert a user
into the database assuming that the user
already does not exist
then another edge case is trying to
insert a user with a username that
already exists right so these are all
the different ways in which you can use
the insert function and there can be
some more so here's an exercise for you
try coming up with all the different
scenarios in which you would like to
test the different functions insert find
update and list
so that completes step two now we have
some sample inputs and then we have
some scenarios in which you we are going
to finally test our function
so the next step is to come up with a
simple correct solution and then state
it in plain english
now here's a simple and easy solution to
the problem
we simply store the user objects in a
list sorted by usernames
that's simple enough and suppose we do
that so inside our data structure we
have a list
which simply contains a bunch of user
objects then the various functions can
be implemented
like this
so you have the insert function the
insert function simply requires looping
through the list and then adding the new
user at a position that keeps the list
sorted
so for instance if you have the users
akash
and siddhant already and then you're
inserting the user biraj then you can
tell that bharat should go between akash
and hemanth in alphabetical order
so that's how you insert a new user and
maintain the sorted property of the list
then to find a user we simply loop
through the list and then find the user
object with the username matching the
query
so that's you if you're looking for
he-man for instance you start from the
beginning you go through akash biraj and
finally hit him and then you can
retrieve the user object
associated with hemanth
and then you have update now updating is
very simple as well it's similar to find
so you find the user object matching the
query and then update the details of
that user object
and then finally because our internal
representation is already a list of user
objects sorted by usernames so we can
simply return that list when we want to
list the users
so that's our
plain english description and it's
always a good idea to describe your
solution in plain english so
that you can clarify any doubts you have
and even during interviews it's a good
idea to have a conversation with the
interviewer before you actually
implement the solution
and now one
fact that we can use is that usernames
which are strings can be compared using
the less than greater than or equal to
operators so we can compare strings just
like numbers in python
so that will make it easy for us to
implement these functions
and that brings us to the implementation
and the code for implementing these is
also fairly straightforward so now we
have the user database class we are
actually implementing this class
and here you see that we have a
constructor and the constructor does not
take any additional arguments apart from
self and all we do is inside self we set
a property.users and that property.users
is set to an empty list
then we come to insertion so now assume
that we already have some users in our
user database
so we start out with a pointer set to
zero
and we go through all the valid
positions in the users list so which is
from 0 to n minus 1 if there are n users
and then we find the first username
greater than the new user's username so
for instance if you're inserting a
month then you go through akash and
bhiraj and then finally you realize that
the next value is probably siddhant so
you want to insert
before siddhant right so you want the
first username that's greater than the
new user's username
and you check this property and as soon
as you find the next that the next user
is
greater than the user that needs to be
inserted we break out
and then we insert that user at that
position okay so this is the insertion
you can it's a just four or five lines
of code so you can work through this
code try to read the score line by line
and see how it works
now similarly you have the find function
the update function and the list
function they're all pretty
straightforward there's really not much
here so this is an exercise for you
because this is also the brute force of
the simple implementation so this is an
exercise for you to go through each of
these functions and try it out and use
the interactive nature of jupiter to
experiment
and add print statements inside each of
the
functions if you need inside each of the
loops if you need more visibility into
what's happening okay
but what we will do is we will try and
test this implementation out and the
first thing we do is instantiating a new
database of users
using the user database class so here we
say user database and that gives us a
database of users
and now let's insert some entries into
this database so we can now insert for
instance we can insert the value hemanth
akash and siddhant
so here we have inserted three values
into the database and now we can
retrieve the data for a given user given
their username using the find method so
now we say database dot find siddhant
that returns a user and we can check the
value of user and you can see that now
we have retrieved the data for siddhant
which is username siddhant name siddhant
sinha and email siddhant example.com
now let's try
changing the information for a user so
to change the information we can call
database dot update and then simply pass
in a new user object so let's say we
want to change the information from
sadhan cena to siddhant u
so this is how we do it
we call database dot update
and now if you find the information once
again now if you can't find call
database dot find once again
we get back
a user object and this time with the
updated information
so we have created the database we have
inserted some values into it and then we
have retrieved values out of it and
we've also updated them and finally we
can retrieve a list of the users in
alphabetical order
so now if we list it out you can see
here that we have
the username akash we have the username
himant and we have siddhant these are
the three values that were inserted and
they are all in alphabetical order of
username
now if we insert a new user let's say
let we insert barrage
we can make sure that bhiraj is inserted
into the right position
okay
so that's how we use the data structure
that we just created
and you can use the empty cells
here
to try out the various scenarios when
you run the notebook
so just to recap
we created a simple class inside which
we are storing a list of users in sorted
order of usernames
and then insertion is pretty easy we
simply loop through find the right
position and insert any new values
finding values is very easy as well we
simply loop through and keep comparing
and updating values is simply a matter
of finding them and then updating that
specific value and listing is simple
because we can simply return
the internal list representation that
we're already storing in the sorted
order of usernames
so that's the simplest solution or one
of the simplest solutions there can be
even
simpler solutions
maybe so the next step now is to analyze
the algorithms complexity and identify
any inefficiencies
so typically in an interview setting you
may not want to implement the simplest
solution so you you can actually skip
step four you know when you've described
what the simplest solution is in english
in plain english which was step three
you can directly jump to analyzing its
complexity and then move on to
optimization and implementing the
optimized version but when you're
practicing or when you're learning it's
always a good idea to implement even the
brute force solutions
so let's analyze the complexity the
operations insert find update involve
iterating over a list of users and in
the worst case they may take up to n
iterations to return a result
where n is the total number of users
now the list all function
is slightly different because it simply
returns
an existing list so the list all
function does not take
linear time it takes constant time
now based on this information it's very
easy to check to guess the time
complexities of the various operations
insert find and update have a order n
first case time complexity which means
they can
take up to n iterations
however the list function has an order
one complexity which means irrespective
of how many users you have in your
database
it returns the
list in the same amount of time now if
you want to display the list or if you
want to iterate over the list that may
take you additional effort but getting
the list itself is a constant time
operation
so that was the time complexity and an
exercise for you is to verify that the
space complexity of each operation is
order one
and if you're wondering what we mean by
complexity then you can go back and
watch lesson one where we talk about
analysis of all algorithms complexities
and the big o notation
what we're calling order of n the big o
notation all of these explained in a lot
more detail so you can go back to lesson
one and check it out
now we've created a simple solution and
our first question might be
to wonder if this is good enough and to
get a sense of how long each function
might take if there are a hundred
million number users on the platform
let's create a while loop let's create a
for loop
and let's run it for let's see how many
this is one two three four five six
seven eight so let's run it for 10
million 100 million numbers so here we
are creating a range of 100 million
numbers
and we're running a for loop which
iterates over the entire range
and we're simply performing a simple
operation which we're not really using
we just we're just multiplying the
number by itself to simulate what might
happen if we have
a database of 100 million users and
we're trying to access find a user now
what is the worst case scenario here
let's run this
and you can already see that it is
taking a while
for 100 million users the loop takes
about
10 seconds to complete here it took
about 9.45
and a 10 second delay for fetching user
profiles will definitely lead to a sub
optimal user experience and that may
cause users to stop using the platform
altogether now imagine you came to
joven.ai and it took 10 or 15 seconds to
load your profile and then maybe even
longer to load the other information and
display it
you would not be happy with the
experience
and then a 10 second processing time for
each user for each request each profile
request will also significantly limit
the number of users that can access the
platform at a time because if you're
running the backend server on one
computer which has eight cores then
each core will be busy for 10 seconds
each time a user tries to access the
platform so you can only serve about 8
users in 10 seconds time
now that's pretty bad
that could significantly limit the
number of users
you will have a significant outage if a
lot of users come to the platform
or on the other hand you may have to
increase the cloud infrastructure add
more servers add bigger hardware more
cores more ram
and that could
increase the cloud infrastructure cost
for your company by millions of dollars
so as a senior back-end engineer you
must come up with a more efficient data
structure
and this is why choosing the right data
structure for the requirements at hand
is a very important skill
now
we can clearly see that using a sorted
list of users may not be the best data
structure to organize the profile
information so let's see what better we
can do here
and before we do that
let's save our work so remember that
this notebook
we were running it on an online platform
called binder and binder can shut down
at any moment because it is a free
service
so
what you want to do is run pip install
jovian
and then import
the jovian library
and you can then run jovian.commit
now when you run jovian.commit
what this does is this captures a
snapshot of your jupyter notebook
whether you're running it on binder or
you're running it on your own local
computer
and it saves the snapshot of this
jupyter notebook on your jovian profile
so here you can see now on my jovian
profile
i have this notebook
and i can go back on my profile and view
the other notebooks that i've created in
the past so your jovian profile becomes
a collection of all the jupyter
notebooks that you're working on so
always just it takes just a couple of
lines import joven and run joven.com so
always run your window commit inside
your notebooks
and if you want to resume any work that
you were doing then all you need to do
is click on the run button and then
click run on binder once again and then
you can start executing the code within
the jupyter notebook once again right so
remember that binder is a free service
so it will shut down
if
after about 10 minutes of inactivity
which is if your computer goes to sleep
or you change your tab
so keep running juvenile.com it from
time to time so now we have
a simple implementation and we have
analyzed it and determined that it is
not efficient it is inefficient
so now we need to apply the right
technique to overcome the inefficiency
and we can limit
the number of iterations required for
common operations like find insert and
update
by ditching the linear structure that we
had earlier and organizing our data in a
more tree-like structure
so this is a structure that we use for
our data and we will call this a binary
tree
now this is called a tree because it
vaguely
resembles an inverted tree trunk with
branches so you can think of this as the
root so this has the root and then you
can see each of these are like branches
and then there are nodes where branches
then split into multiple branches so
these are called nodes and finally at
the end you will have
individual nodes which do not have any
more branches and those are called
leaves
so these are some terms that are used
the tree represents the entire structure
the top node is called the root and each
each element in the tree is called a
node the top node is called a root and
then the bottom most nodes which do not
have any
sub trees or what are called children
which do not have any children are
called
leaves right so the root node has two
children and then each node there with
can have zero one or two children so
it's not necessary to have exactly two
children but
up to two children
is what determines a binary tree
so that's a binary tree
but the binary tree that we need
will have some additional properties
which was what will make it efficient
for our purposes so you can see one
thing you can observe here is that the
root node seems also seems to be the
central value if you sort the keys
in increasing order so what you will
notice is
on the left we have
keys which have which lie before jades
and on the right we have keys which lie
after jades so that's one thing
and that is actually the second property
listed here
that the left subtree of any node
consists only of nodes
which have keys that are
lexicographically smaller than the nodes
key right so the key for this node is
barrage and that is lexicographically
smaller than jades and similarly hemant
and akash are all smaller than jadish
and then this property holds at every
node so at every node if you check
sunaks you can see that siddhant is less
than sunaks and vishal which comes to
the right is a more than sunaks and then
so not siddhanta vishal all three are
greater than jadeesh right
so when a binary tree satisfies this
property it is called a binary search
tree
so that's what we're looking at here
this is a binary search tree so that's
the first property but we need the
second property is that
our nodes will have both keys and values
now sometimes you can create binary node
binary trees with just keys each node
will have a single
number or string inside it and you can
call it the key or value or element or
whatever you wish but what we want is we
want
the keys to be user names so that we can
compare the keys easily but along with
each node we also want to associate a
value which is the actual user object so
if you're looking for hemath let's say
we started the root node
we see that jadeish is the root node and
since it is a binary search tree we know
that he meant lies to the left then we
reach biraj
we know that himans will lie to the
right of biraj so we go right we reach
him
and then we access the values stored at
hemanth which is the user details for
hemath
right so we need both keys and values in
a binary tree and this is what is called
a tree map
or a map in many languages
and then finally
this tree that we will create this data
structure that we will create it will be
balanced
so here what we're looking at is each
node has
two children left and right but it is
also possible to have an unbalanced tree
where you only have one child on each on
on maybe one of the sides
so we will require it to be balanced
which means that it does not skew too
heavily in one direction
and we'll talk about what balancing
means and we'll talk about how to check
if a tree is balanced and how to keep it
rebalanced okay so we'll go over all of
these things step by step but these are
some of the properties that we want our
final data structure to have
okay
so one important property of a tree of a
binary tree
is the height of a tree in fact if you
start counting you can say this is level
zero where you have one node and this is
level two or this is level one where you
have two nodes
the left and right
the left and right child
of the root node and then this is level
three level two where you have four
nodes the left and right child of the
first node on level one and the left and
right child of the second node on level
one right so you can see that the number
of
nodes in each level in a balanced binary
tree
is double of the number of nodes of the
previous level
so if you have a tree of height k or
which which means a tree which has
exactly k levels
then here's the list of the number of
nodes at each level now level zero will
have one node the root node level one
will have two nodes its children level
two will have four nodes their children
so that's four nodes is two times two or
two to the power two
level three will have eight nodes
two nodes for each of these four nodes
so that's two to the power three and
similarly if you keep going down level k
minus 1 the final level will have 2 to
the power of k minus 1 nodes
so that if the total number of nodes in
the tree is n then it follows that n
is 1 plus 2 plus 2 square plus 2 cubed
plus so on plus 2 to k minus 1
okay
so what we're trying to determine here
is what is the relationship between the
height of the tree and the total number
of nodes in the tree and this is the
relationship and we can simplify it a
bit if we add 1 to each side you can see
here that this side we get n plus 1 and
this side we get 1 plus 1 which gets
simplified as 2 or 2 to the power 1 and
then we can add 2 to the power 1 by 2 to
the power 1 and that gets simplified as
2 to the power of 2
then we can add 2 to the power of 2 and
2 to the power of 2 and that gets
simplified to 2 to the power of 3 and we
can keep performing this reduction we
can keep adding these together till we
finally end with 2 to the power k minus
1 plus 2 to the power k minus 1 which is
simply 2 to the power of k
so what that gives us is that k the
height of the tree is log of n plus 1
which is approximately or in almost in
every case less than log n plus 1 so
that's a a bit of an approximation are
doing here but it is uh the height of
the tree is less than log n plus one
so to store n records we require a
balanced binary search tree of height no
larger than log n plus one
now this is a very useful property in
combination with the fact that nodes are
arranged in a way that it makes it easy
to find a specific key simply by
following a path down from the root the
binary search tree property
and we'll see soon by the end of this
lesson
that the insert find and update
operations in a balanced binary search
tree have complexity order of login so
in our original implementation a brute
force implementation they had order n
and this time we've reduced the
complexity to order login and that is
far better
and we will see how that happens okay
so that's a quick introduction to binary
search trees we have we've had enough
theory now let's get into some
implementation
but before that
we have the second question
now binary trees are very commonly used
as data structures
for a variety of different in a variety
of different languages for instance
java c plus plus python java and c plus
plus have this concept of a map which is
represented using a binary tree
and it is also used in file system so
binary trees are also used in file
systems to store indexes of files so
when you browse
your file system or when you search for
a specific file it is a binary tree that
is used to look up the file and find the
location of the file
now that's where that brings us to our
second question of today
now you can you can find the second
question on our linkedin profile so once
again go to linkedin.com slash
school slash jovian ai
and you will find the second question
here
the second question is which tree based
data structure is used to store the
index
in the windows file system
and who invented this data structure
so
like this question follow us and comment
with your answer
and you can stand the chance to win a
swag pack right so we repeat the
question which tree based data structure
is used to store the index in the
windows file system also known as ntfs
and who invented this data structure
okay so let's get to the implementation
of binary trees and here's a very common
interview question that you might get
implement a binary tree using python and
then show its usage with some examples
so what we'll do as we implement binary
trees and binary search trees is
to also cover many common interview
questions in fact we'll cover exactly 15
so that's a quite a few
the first one is to implement a binary
tree and to begin we'll create a very
simple binary tree so we will not have
any of the special properties like key
value pairs and binary search tree and
balancing rather and we'll also use key
numbers as keys within our nodes because
are simpler to work with so here is an
example binary tree so we have a root
node and then we have a left child in
right side
and here's a simple class representing
this representing a single node within
the tree so we're calling this class
tree node and it has a constructor
function it simply takes a key and it
sets self dot key to key it also has a
couple of other properties self.left and
self.write which are initially set to
none so each node when it's created
exists independently of other nodes
and now let's create nodes representing
each of these
nodes
so we have node 0 we're calling it
we're calling tree node with the value
three then we have node one and node two
so there you go now we've created the
nodes and we can verify that it is of
the type tree node you can see here and
if we check the key of node zero you can
see that it has a value three
and we can now connect the nodes by
setting the dot left and dot right
properties of the root node so if you go
to node zero and set dot left to node
one so now we've connected node zero to
node one
and similarly if we set node zero dot
right to node two now we've connected
node zero and node two
and that's it we're done
so now we have three nodes and then
we've connected each of those nodes
and we may also just want to track which
is the root node so we can create a new
variable called tree
and simply point it to node zero so tree
points to the root node of the
tree and then the root node is connected
to its children and the children will be
connected to their children and so on
so you can check here that if we check
tree dot key
we get three and if we check tree dot
left dot key
so three is the root node it has a value
three tree dot left is this node so it
should have the value four and tree dot
right dot key should have the value of
five
okay so pretty straightforward and
that's pretty much the answer to the
question implement a binary tree in
python
now going forward we will use the term
tree to refer the node root node
to refer to the root node and the term
node can be used to refer to any node in
a tree not necessarily just the root
okay so here's an exercise for you
try to create this binary tree so now
you have a root node here and then you
have a left child and right child and
then this left child has another left
child but does not have a right child
similarly here you have another right
child and then it has a left child which
does not have a left child but has a
right child okay so there's a slightly
more complicated tree structure and try
to use these cells these empty cells
that are given here to replicate this
tree structure
and then try to view the different
levels of that tree
manually okay
now please do that because that's a
great exercise in understanding how the
structure works and how to connect the
nodes
but it's a bit inconvenient to create a
tree by manually connecting all the
nodes in fact here you may have to make
a total of one two three four five six
seven eight nine connections right
so what we can do is we can write a
helper function which can convert
a tuple
and the tuple will have this kind of a
structure so a tuple is simply
is kind of like a list except that it is
represented with these round brackets of
parenthesis
so a tuple will have this kind of
structure it will have three elements
and then the middle element will
represent the value or the key within
the root node
the first element will itself also be
either a tuple
if the left
child is is an entire subtree
or if it is a single number then it will
be just a number
and then the right element will
represent the right subtree okay
so here's an example
here is one tree tuple now if you see
this tree tuple it has three elements
this is the first element
this is the second element and then this
is the third element so this first
element two
represents the root node
and then this
so the second element 2 represents the
root node this first element or element
at position 0 represents this subtree
so you can see here that in this sub
tree if you look at just that subtree of
that tree
3 is the root in that subtree and then
one is the left child and there is no
right child so that's what this
represent and then for this subtree
where 5 is the root node and then you
have 2 other subtrees
that's represented here so 5 is the root
node and then you have a subtree here
and a subtree here
so this is a very easy way it is a
convenient way for us to represent a
binary tree and what we can do is we can
define a function parse tuple
and this parse tuple function can take a
tuple like this and then convert it into
a tree like structure of linked nodes
using the tree node data struct using
the tree node class that we have defined
above
so we call the parse tuple function with
some data for instance this tuple
and the pass tuple first checks
if data is
of the type tuple and it has a length
three
if these two things hold true
then first we create a node we create a
node with data one so in this case we
create a node with
two as the key
and then we set the left and the right
subtrees of the node
and then we're doing something very
interesting here we are calling the pass
tuple function once again so we call
parse tuple
this time
so this is called recursion when a
function calls itself inside it
that's called recursion so we call parse
tuple
with the first element which itself is a
tuple right so once again that it calls
another invocation to pass tuple and for
a moment let's assume that that returns
the proper subtree the proper node so we
set that node which which got created to
node.left
and similarly we create the right
subtree using these values and then we
set that node to node.right okay
now
you might wonder in the function we're
calling itself so when will this stop
can't it go on forever and that's where
you have to track the actual function
calls so when we call parse tuple with
the entire
tuple
first it calls past tuple with this
and when you call past tuple with this
uh then you can see that
three is used to create a node and then
pass tuple is called with one
so when past tuple is called with one
this condition no longer holds true
and we also check the next condition
which is if the data if one is none when
one is not none so this condition does
not hold true so we fall into the else
condition and we simply create a node
right so we just create a node and this
time we are not calling parse tuple once
again right so this is called a
terminating condition of the
recursive function
and similarly once we get back the
result from one then we call patch
triple with the value none once again
this condition is not entered and this
condition matches so we set node equal
to none and then we return the node okay
so when we reach either a leaf node
which is either a single number or we
reach the value none that is when we
stop invoking the function recursively
and then the function returns and that's
how the entire tree gets con gets
converted
so this is a very powerful idea in
programming the idea of recursion the
idea of functions calling themselves
and it can seem unintuitive and
confusing at first
so one thing you can do is you can add a
print statement here inside this
function
to see how it works to see how the
different calls are going so when you
call past tuple with the entire tuple
what are the internal calls that are
made
and and study how the result comes out
maybe try it on pen and paper
but it's a very important technique for
you to learn
you will be asked or you will find
applications of recursions in many
places throughout your programming or
data science career
so do learn it
so let's now call parse tuple with this
tuple as an input
and let's see okay so that returned a
tree and then that tree is of the type
tree node that's great and now let's
examine the tree to verify that it was
constructed as expected
so now we check tree two dot key so tree
two dot key should be pointing to the
root node which has the key two
and then let's check the level one so
that was level zero let's check level
one so let's check three two dot left
dot key and tree two dot right dot key
you can see here we get the values three
and five
let's check the next level
on this level we have three two dot left
dot left and then we have three two dot
left dot right but there's no value
there
so we can't really check for a key here
then we have treated right dot left and
tree two dot right dot right
so you can see that tree two dot left
dot left dot key is one but tree two dot
left dot right is none because there is
no child here no right child
then we have left dot key and right dot
key and that gives you three and a seven
and similarly you can now
check level four level three as well
so here are all the levels of the tree
so it looks like the tree was
constructed properly and you can see the
power of recursion at play here that the
recursive function can now construct
trees of any levels now you can create
tuples within tuples within tuples and
as long as they have the right structure
as long as you have this
three element structure where the left
element represents a left subtree the
right element represents a light right
subtree in the middle element represents
the current node
you can construct a tree of any size
so now here's an exercise for you
we've defined a function to convert a
tuple into a tree
define a function now to convert a tree
back to a tuple so if you have a binary
tree
convert return a tuple representing the
same tree for instance for the tree
created above tree 2 calling tree to
tuple should return this original tuple
which is used to create the tree and
here's a hint on how to do this use
recursion
so do fill this out
and see if you can figure out how to do
this
so now we have defined a class for a
binary tree and we also have a way for
creating a binary tree from a tuple so
now let's create another helper function
to display all the keys of the tree in a
tree like structure for easier
visualization so here we'll just use
we'll call this function display keys
and we'll not get into the code for this
because it's once again it's a pretty
straightforward but there are a few
conditions we need to handle
but here's what it will give us
when we call display keys on a tree
so then we'll then we'll get this kind
of a representation of a tree and you
can see that this is not exactly the
same representation as this you will
have to take this representation and
then mentally rotate it by 90 degrees in
the clockwise direction to get a
representation like this but you can see
roughly that the root node is 2 and then
it has a left child 3 and it has a right
child 5.
then 3 again it has a left child 1 and
there is no right child
now 5 has a left child 3 and 3 has no
left child and 3 has the right child 4
and so on so the exact same structure
has been replicated here for us to view
visually now this is a very useful thing
we're spending all this time here
or talking about how to create trees and
how to
visualize trees because
the easier you make it for yourself to
create trees the more likely you are to
test the easier it is for you to test
different scenarios out so always spend
a little bit of time coming up with good
string representations for any data
structure you create something that
helps you visualize them and an easy way
to create these data structures okay
so now we have a way to visualize the
tree as well
that's great
now here's an exercise for you try to
create some more trees and visualize
them using display keys and you can use
this tool excalidraw.com and that's
where how that's how these diagrams were
created
as a digital whiteboard so you can
create some trees you can create trees
like this and then try to come up with
tuples for those trees try to create
those trees using the
parse tuple function and finally try to
display them okay so experiment with it
and see explore what are all the
different tree structures that you can
create
now the next
one of the frequently asked questions in
interviews is to traverse a binary tree
binary tree traversals are very common
so you may face one of these three
questions write a function to perform
the in order traversal of a binary tree
or write a function to perform the
pre-order traversal of a binary tree or
write a function to perform the
post-order traversal of a binary tree
what do you mean by a traversal a
traversal refers to the process of
visiting each node of a tree exactly
once
now what do you mean by visiting by
visiting it could mean any operation but
generally it refers to
either printing the key or the value at
the node or adding the nodes key
to a list
and then there are three ways to
traverse a binary tree
and return a list of visited keys
so the first one is called in-order
traversal
and the in-order traversal now traversal
is defined recursively because binary
trees have this recursive structure so
you will see that almost all the
functions that we write will have some
sort of a recursive structure
so in order traversal
involves first traversing the left
subtree
recursively in order then traversing the
current node and then traversing the
right subtree recursively in order
so what does that mean well we start out
with this tree and we we're traversing
it in doing an inorder traversal so we
try we look at the root node and then we
realize that there it has a left child
so it has a left sub tree so we do not
visit it yet which means we do not print
it or we do not add it to our list yet
rather we follow the
we follow the path on the left side and
then we come across three
and then we realize that okay three also
has a left child so we don't visit it
yet so then we go down to one
we go down to one and now it does not
have a left child or a right child so we
can visit one
then we go to three
and now we
so we've visited the left subtree of
three so now we can visit three
and then the next step is to visit the
right subtree of 3 but of course 3 does
not have a right child so there is no
right subtree to visit so we can move
back up to 2. so now we have visited the
left subtree of 2 so now we can visit 2
so we we print 1 three two
and now once we've visited two we can
now visit the right subtree of two
so to visit the right subtree we go to
five once again we realize that five has
a left subtree so we go to three now
three doesn't have a left subtree so we
can visit three then we visit four
then now since we visited the left sub
tree of five we can now visit five
and similarly we then visit six seven
and eight okay so that's the in order
traversal of the tree
and then there is another traversal
called pre-order traversal which is
slightly different where you traverse
the current node first so here we start
out at 2 and we say that okay we're
going to visit 2 first so we visit 2 or
print it or add it to a list then we
traverse the left subtree and then we
traverse the right subtree so we go we
visit three and one and then we come to
the right side we visit five and three
so you can compare these two diagrams
and see how in order and pre-order
traversal are different now these are
very important for you for you to
understand because
they are great examples of
dif different
functions which have very similar
implementations but there are just one
or two things you will need to change uh
and these are recursive as well so do
understand the subtle difference between
them and second they are very commonly
asked in interviews you will most likely
face some coding assignment or an
interview where you will be asked to
perform a traversal of a binary tree
and then finally there's another
order called another
traversal called the post order
traversal and i'll let you guess how it
works you can also look it up
and here's an implementation of in-order
traversal now it may seem a little
complicated but it's actually pretty
straightforward so let's look at it here
what we do is
given a node
we first traverse the nodes left subtree
then we create so that should return a
list a list of all the keys
and then we create a list with just the
nodes key so we get the list of keys
from the left subtree in with the
inorder traversal then we get add to it
the current nodes key and then we call
traverse in order
with the right subtree and that
recursively keeps adding these keys each
one and the end condition so the
terminating condition for the recursion
is when we hit none so when we hit a
node which does not exist so that means
we come there from a parent which does
not have a left or right child
then we return the empty array
okay
so let's try it out with this tree so
this is the tree we have and we just saw
its traversal
now if it travels the tree in order we
get the values one three two three four
five six seven eight and we can verify
here we have one three two three four
five six seven eight so that was the
in-order traversal of a tree
now the exercise for you is to print the
pre-order and post order traversal of
the binary tree and you can test your
implementations by making submissions to
these problems on
leadcode.com okay
so that was our discussion about
traversals
another thing that you may get asked
commonly is
writing functions to calculate the
height or the depth of a binary tree and
then writing a function to count the
number of nodes in a binary tree
once again these can be expressed
recursively as well now the height of a
tree
given a node
is simply
1 plus
maximum of the height of the right
subtree of the left subtree
the height of retreat is defined it is
defined as the longest path from a root
node to a leaf so you can see that the
longest path from root node of the to
the leaf
is of length four so two five three and
four
and the way to do get the longest length
of the longest path is by checking the
max of the left height right height and
then adding one to it
and of course the terminating condition
here also is if you hit a node that does
not exist you return zero
so that's how you get the height of a
tree
and you can check that the height of a
three is four then here's another
function to count the number of nodes in
a tree once again really simple all you
do is this time instead of checking the
maximum we simply get the size of the
left subtree get the size of the right
subtree add them and add one to it
so here you can see that there are nine
elements in the street three six and
nine
so we get tree size of tree as nine
now here are a few more questions
relating to the path lengths in a binary
tree so you can just check
there's a concept of maximum depth and
minimum depth and then there's also the
concept of a diameter so you can try out
both of these
now as a final step
what we can do is we can compile all the
functions we've written all the methods
as methods within the tree node class
itself and this technique is called
encapsulation where we are encapsulating
the data as well as the functionality
related with the data of the data
structure within the same class and this
is real as really good programming
practice so as you
write more code try to think about how
you can create these classes with not
just the information inside them but
also with the relevant methods inside
them
okay so we have now added the methods
height size traverse and order display
keys to tuple and we've also added these
methods str and wrapper and remember
quiz 1 or you can go on linkedin and
post an answer to what these functions
do
and finally parse tuple as well
so all of these functions are now added
within the class and you can try it out
here so for instance here we have a tree
tuple and we can call tree node dot pass
tuple
to convert this tree tuple
into a tree
so you can see that now we are also
representing the binary tree itself
using this tuple like representation but
we can also display it in this
hierarchical structure using display
keys
then we can check the height using tree
dot height we can check the size using
tree dot size and we can traverse the
tree in order using traverse in order
and we can
convert the tree to a tuple
using 3.2 tuple
so do create some more trees and try out
the operations that we've just defined
and try or you can also try adding more
operations
to the tree node class
and before continuing we can just save
our work so i'm just going to import
jovane and run juventus commit
so that concludes our discussion on
binary trees
next let's talk about binary search
trees
now a binary search tree
or a bst is a binary tree that satisfies
these two conditions
the left subtree of any node
should only contain nodes with keys less
than the current nodes key
and then the right subtree of any node
should only contain nodes with keys
greater than
the current nodes key
and we can see that this is let's just
copy this over
so we can see that this node this tree
here is actually a binary search tree
and you can verify that these two
properties hold for each of these nodes
and it should follow from these two
conditions that every soft tree of a
binary search tree must also be a binary
search tree so i can let you verify that
that if you pick up any subtree inside
so you pick up any node and you see the
tree under that node you will see that
it is a binary search tree
so here are some questions that are
often asked
relating to binary trees and binary
search trees and we've lumped them
together because we'll answer them with
a single function
so here's a function that you might be
expected to write so write a function to
check if a binary tree is a binary
search tree which means
ensure that these two conditions hold
and second write a function to find the
maximum key in a binary tree so this
could be a generic question finding the
maximum key
and here's another question that you
might face write a function to find the
minimum key in a binary tree
so what we will do is we'll answer we'll
answer all of these questions together
with a single function called is bst so
isbst takes a node
and then is bst returns three things so
if you look at the return value it
returns whether the node
and the tree
under that node
is a bst
so here so we this is going to be the
value
determining it's going to be either true
or false telling us whether the tree
under that node
with that node as root is that a bst
it also returns the minimum key from
that entire tree and it also returns the
maximum key from that entire tree now
why are these two useful we'll see in
just a moment
so the way we calculate is bst node
is by actually looking at
the left subtree and the right subtree
recursively so we call is bst on the
left subtree of the node
and we call isbst on the right subtree
of the node
so we get back three values which is is
the left subtree a binary search tree is
the right subtree binary search tree
is the minimum key in the left subtree
the minimum key in the right subtree and
then the maximum key in the left subtree
and the maximum key in the right subtree
so now what we can do is we can say is
is bst node so is the entire tree of
binary search tree well if the left sub
tree is a binary search tree and the
right subtree is a binary search tree
and then we verify these two properties
which is the maximum key
in the left subtree is either none which
means that there is no left subtree
or the current nodes key is greater than
the maximum key
and
the minimum key in the right subtree
the smallest key in the right subtree is
either none which means that there is no
right subtree or the minimum key in the
right subtree is greater than
the current nodes key so that this was
condition one and condition two and that
tells us whether
this entire tree is now a binary search
tree
and then finally we can also calculate
the minimum key and maximum key simply
by computing the minimum of the left
minimum node.key and right minimum
and the maximum can be calculated by
checking the maximum of the left maximum
node dot key and right maximum okay
so what we return from the sbst function
is whether the
node
and the tree represented
rooted at that node is a binary search
tree and then the minimum and maximum
key out of it
so if we look at this tree right here
let's verify whether this is a bst and
well before we check we can probably
tell that it's not because you can see
that 3 appears as a left sub child of 2
but 3 the key is greater than 2 and
that's a problem so this is a violation
of the property
elsewhere this property is satisfied you
can check any other node here and you
will find that the left subtree is
always
smaller than the right than the node and
the right subtree is larger than the
node
so let's check is bst tree one
it's not
so it's false
now on the other hand
this tree is a bst this is the tree that
we've been looking at all this while
so once again
we can create this using tree node.parse
tuple
and note that the keys can
the way we've implemented tree node keys
can not only be numbers but they can
also be strings so we don't need to
change anything here and that creates
tree two
and we can even display tree two so if
we do tree two dot
display keys
you can see that it has this structure
where jadeesh is at the center
and then on the left you have biraj on
the right you have sunaks biraj and
sanaksh then you have akash siddhant and
vishal
and this
is a bst so you get back true here and
the smallest value here is akash and the
highest value is vishal as you can
verify in alphabetical order
so that's pretty handy now we have a way
to check if a binary tree is a binary
search tree and this is again a very
common interview question that you might
face
next remember that we need to store not
just keys but also user objects within
each key
with each key within our bst so what we
do is we will define a new class called
bst node to represent the nodes of our
binary search tree
and bst node will not only have the key
but in the constructor it can also
accept a value and this is optional
so we will set the key and we set the
value we will also set the left and
right apart from this we also set
another property called parent and the
parent will point to the parent node so
for instance if this node
is a left sub tree of this route then
the parent of barrage will point to
jadeish and this will be useful for
upward traversal now if you're given a
pointer to a node and you have to go
back and find the root of the tree
the parent will be helpful there
so this is our bst node
and let's try to recreate this bst right
here
with usernames as keys and user objects
as values so first we create level 0. so
level 0 we create bst node now the key
is jaadesh or username which will be
just the string jadeesh and then the
value will be the jadeish user object
so we've created that and we can check
its key and value you can see that
jadish is the key and then the user
object is the value
let's create
let's create level one
now level one is
we set tree dot left
to bst node barrage dot username and
biraj now one other thing that we should
do here is once we set it we should set
tree dot left dot parent
to tree
and similarly we said tree dot write
it's not tree dot write is sunak so we
said bst node with sonar username as the
key and sonax is the value and then we
can set tree.write.parent as tree
and now can you can view these values so
now you can see that we have inserted
barrage
and the username barrage we've inserted
sonaax and the user
sonar shear as keys and values
respectively
now the exercise for you two is then try
to add the next level of keys and values
and then verify that they were inserted
properly but you can see now that we
now have a way to represent the data
the both both the usernames and the user
objects in a binary search tree so we're
getting pretty close to the data
structure that we want to create
once again we can display the keys of
the tree by calling the display keys
function
now this is also rather nice is a good
thing about python that because python
functions
are dynamic because you do not need to
specify the types of the objects while
defining the function the same display
keys function can be used both with tree
node and bst node classes
so all it requires is that the object of
your class should have a property dot
key for it to be able to display the
keys in this visual
setting
and the same is true with most of the
other functions that we've defined in
fact any function we've defined for tree
node will also work for bst node
okay so moving right along
now we have a way to construct a bst but
it it's a bit inconvenient to insert
values manually because what we're doing
so far is we are manually checking
whether we should insert a value in the
left or the right rather there should be
a way to do it automatically we should
be able to call a function insert
and here's this is a common question as
well write a function to insert a new
node into a binary search stream
so we'll use the
bst property
to perform insertion efficiently
once again let's grab a copy of this
tree here so that we can think about it
easily
okay so now we have this tree and let's
say we want to insert a new user with
the username tanya into this tree so
first we start at the root and then we
compare the key to be inserted with the
current node's t key so the current node
is the root so we compare tanya with
jades and we see that tanya is greater
than jades because t comes after j
so obviously tanya should not be
inserted into the left sub tree rather
than should be inserted into the right
subtree so if the key is smaller we
recursively insert it into the right
left subtree and if the key is larger we
subtree so then we encounter sunak tanya
is also greater than sonax t is greater
than s t comes after s so once again we
call recursively called insert on this
subtree that subtree rooted at vishal
this time we notice that tanya is
smaller than vishal so t is less than v
so then
we need to recursively insert in the
left subtree but there is no left
subtree here and this is the point at
which we can create a new node and
attach it as the left child of vishal so
you can see that the node tanya will get
added here
at this position
in the tree
so here is a recursive implementation of
insert
exactly what we just discussed
first we check if the key is less than
the current nodes key and if that is the
case then we insert it into the left
subtree then we check if the key is
greater than the current nodes key and
if that is the case we insert it into
the right subtree
and the ending condition is that if the
node is none
which means
if we've hit a position where we do not
have a left subtree and we need to go
left or we do not have a right subtrain
we need to go right then we create a new
node so we create new node node equal to
bst node and then we return the node
so we return the node and this is an
interesting thing that we're doing here
we're returning
the root node back from insert so when
we called insert with node.left
we get back the pointer to the left
subtree so we can set it back to
node.left
and we can also set the parent of the
left subtree to node okay so this is
just updating the parent
so
just study this function carefully
see how it works it does exactly what we
just talked about
and it finally returns a pointer to the
to the tree once again
so let's use this to recreate the tree
that we had here
now to create the first node we can call
the insert function with none so
initially we don't have a tree to begin
with so we just called insert with none
and remember that insert after
performing an insertion returns
the pointer to the tree
so we call insert with none
and we want to insert the value
jaadesh.username and we want to insert
the we want to insert the key short
username with the value jadesh so that
gives us a tree
and now the tree has one element you can
see tree
dot key and tree dot value
and now the remaining nodes can just be
inserted into tree so now we call insert
with tree
and call it with barrage dot user name
and biraj then we call it with sonar
username and sunaks
akashad username and akash and this way
so we are adding barrage when we are
adding sonax then we are adding akash
siddhant vishal and see that we are not
specifying exactly where these nodes
need to be inserted but you can see that
once these nodes are inserted then they
are inserted in the right places so
jadeesh you can see that the binary
search tree property is
preserved here
and also we've exactly replicated the
tree structure that we had here so the
left subchild of jadeesh is
biraj and the right child is sonak for
biraj the left child is akash and the
right child is hemanth and so on
now note however that the order of
insertion of nodes can change the
structure of the resulting tree so for
instance if we insert
all the nodes in the increasing order of
username so if your for example here we
are inserting akash biraj
siddhants vishal so this is the
lexicographic increasing order and we
try to display that tree
this is what we end up with so we end up
with an unbalanced or a very skewed tree
and you can see why it was created as a
skewed or unbalanced tree well let's
look at it so we started with akash so
we have a single node and then when we
try to insert bharaj we realized that we
need to go right so we insert barrage
here then we try to insert hamad then we
realize that we need to go
right from akash and right from biraj
and go to himant
and then we keep going this way so how
you set up the root node and how you set
up each subtree and the order in which
you insert the nodes is very important
and that can create a huge skew within
the tree
now skewed or unbalanced trees are
problematic because the
height of sub such trees is no longer
logarithmic compared to the number of
nodes in the tree right so
earlier we had deduced that in a
balanced tree if containing n nodes the
height is
log n or log n plus one
and that makes the operations like
insert update and find very efficient
but here where you have a very skewed
tree the height can actually match the
number of nodes for instance this tree
has seven nodes and it has a height
seven
and in these q trees
once again you may get back the fact
that insertion finding and update
can be order n because you may have to
traverse the entire height of the tree
which is equal to the number of nodes of
the tree
and that may once again defeat the
purpose of using a binary search tree in
the first place
so maintaining the balance of a binary
search tree is very important and we'll
see how to do that
so we've seen how to insert a node now
the next thing is to find the value
associated with a given key in a binary
search tree so once again we can follow
a recursive strategy here
similar to insertion so we check
we start from the top let's say we want
to find the key heyman we start from the
top and we compare it with the root node
now
here if it matches the root node we can
simply return this node
if it does not then we check whether we
need to go left or right since hemanth
comes before jadeish we need to go left
then we encounter bharaj and here we
realize that we need to go right and
finally we encounter haiman and we
return
another option is that we have a value
let's say tanya which does not exist
here so if we try to search that we may
go in this kind of a direction and we
end up at an empty place so in that case
we simply return none
so you either find a node and return it
or you return none
so you can see here
that if we called find tree
with hemanth we get back the details for
human
and very interestingly because it's a
balanced tree you we only had to take
two steps
and not go through the entire tree and
in the worst case you can check that any
path from the
root to any leaf in a balanced tree
will only be two steps long and that's
what makes it so convenient
now on the other hand if we try to find
the key tanya
you can see that it's not formed
try creating larger
bsts and try finding some more nodes
it's important to experiment with these
operations once they're defined because
now it's simply a matter of calling the
function we've written the code for it
so experiment with it try creating
larger trees with multiple levels and
dozens or maybe hundreds of nodes
try generating some fake data putting it
into the trees and see how trees build
up
and that will give you a feel for how
binary search trees work
next let's talk about updating a value
in a bst
now updating a value is fairly simple we
already have a way of finding a node so
if you want to update a node let's say
we want to update the node hema the key
heimat
and here we want to update it we want to
update it to this value which is the new
value of the user heman and we're
changing the name and we're changing the
email here so we first find the node and
if the node is not none
then we simply change the value at that
node it's as simple as that
and we what we're also seeing is we're
reusing the find function here and this
is a good practice to always incorporate
into your programs into your functions
whenever you find yourself copy pasting
some code and maybe changing one or two
things here and there think about
whether you can extract that piece of
code into a function and then reuse that
function so always try to make your code
more and more generic the less code you
write the less there are the chances for
errors the easier it is to understand
and the smaller your functions become so
write small reusable generic functions
whenever you can and this is a
principle called the dry principle or
the dry principle which stands for don't
repeat yourself
whenever you're writing programs
so in update we are not repeating
ourselves by using the find function to
find the right node and simply updating
it
by setting its value
so let's update hemanth here to the new
value and you can see that now we have
the updated data here so we have payment
j and human j at example.com
now the value of the node
was successfully updated and you can in
it and you can easily check that the
time complexity of update is same as
that of find
now finally we have the last
operation that was required and this was
to write a function to retrieve all the
key value pairs stored in a binary
search tree in the sorted order of keys
is a question that you might face uh
once again
and this is simply the in order
traversal it's a different way of
stating the inorder traversal now
what you will have to figure out or a
reason about is why the inorder
traversal of a binary search tree
produces a sorted array of our sorted
list of keys
think about it
so here's the list all function all we
do here is we call list all on node.left
and then we call listall on node.write
and in between them then these give us
two arrays so we assume that
listall.node.left gives us the
list of key value pairs from the left
subtree in sorted order similarly here
we get the list of key value pairs from
the right subtree in sorted order and
between them we simply insert this key
value pair from the current node and
recursively
it automatically fills out the entire
array and this is the end condition
where we encounter an empty node we
simply return the empty array
you can see now when we pass in this
tree we get back the list of users key
value pairs
arranged by the sorted order of keys
now here's an exercise for you
determine the time complexity and state
compliance space complexity of the list
all function
now you can do this for a balanced tree
or an unbalanced tree and here's a hint
it will not make a difference
but think about it
so once again let's save our work and
now we've talked about
binary trees and operations on binary
trees
now the next thing is to look at
balanced binary trees and this is once
again a very common question that gets
asked write a function to determine if a
binary tree is balanced
and here's a recursive strategy to do
this
in fact this is really the definition of
balanced binary trees the left sub tree
should be balanced the right subtree
should be balanced
and the difference between the heights
of the left and right subtree should not
be more than one okay so this is an
important thing now when we're looking
for balance we're not always looking for
perfect balance because it may not
always be possible to create a tree with
perfect balance because to have a
perfectly balanced tree where
for every node the left subtree and the
right sort you have the exact same
height
you will have to fill out all the nodes
at all the levels
and that can only have
that can only happen for certain numbers
for example you can have one node which
satisfied this property or you can have
a tree with three nodes which satisfy
this property or you can have a tree
with seven nodes which satisfies this
property but you may not be able to get
a tree with six nodes to satisfy that
property for instance if you remove
vishal here you will see that
the left subtree and right sub tree of
this node sonar will not be of equal
height that's why for balancing we relax
the criteria slightly we simply need to
ensure that the difference between the
heights of the left and the right
subtrees is not more than one
so here's the code for is balanced
once again pretty straightforward but we
will return two things here we will this
is balance will not only return whether
the tree node is balanced it will also
return the height of the
tree which is rooted at that node
so the way we implement it is first
calling is balanced on node.left and
then calling is balanced on node.right
and by the way this is exactly how we
implement recursive functions as well
sometimes we write the recursive
functions
signature
then we immediately write the return
value
and then we assume that a recursive call
is going to return these values so a
recursive call is balanced node.left is
going to return
whether the left subtree was balanced
and the height of the left sub tree and
then we assume that is balanced for
node.write is going to recall
is going to return whether the right
subtree is balanced and the height of
the right subtree because that's what we
return here
then the entire tree is balanced if the
left sub tree is balanced and the right
subtree is balanced and the absolute
value of the differences in their height
is less than one which means the height
l minus height r is either minus one
zero or one
and finally we calculate the height of
the tree itself which is simply one plus
the maximum of the height of the left
subtree and the right subtree and we
return it
so that's how you implement a recursive
function or think recursively
and there's one last thing which is the
end condition and the end condition
although it's often the last thing you
think about it's the first thing that
you have to put in the end condition is
to check whether a node is none
because as we call node.left you may not
have a left subtree so you may call is
balanced with none and if the node is
none we simply return true
because an empty tree is
balanced by default because there's no
imbalance there
and its height is zero
so that's our is balanced function it's
just
four or five lines of code
but if you are not able to reason about
recursion easily you may get stuck with
this and
you may spend an entire 45 minutes
trying to write this function and debug
it so always try to think in recursive
terms and that's why always it always
helps to write down what you want to do
in plain english so that you can
determine what should be the inputs and
outputs to your function
maybe also have some test cases ready
and then start implementing your
function and it becomes really easy
so this tree for instance is balanced
here
you can check is balanced
you get back true
but this tree here you're looking at
this is not balanced so this was tree
two and if you check is balanced here
you get back false
so here you also get the height of the
tree which is three and here you get the
height of the tree which is seven
now here's another tree
is this tree is this tree shown here
balanced why or why not now create this
tree and check if it's balanced using
the is balanced function
so there's another concept called
complete binary trees which is slightly
similar to balanced binary trees but
it's a slightly stricter criteria so you
can check out this problem here
and you simply need to modify the is
balance the code for is balanced
slightly to get the code for complete
binary so do check out this problem on
leadcode.com
all right so we've looked at binary
search trees and we've looked at
balanced binary trees now let's bring
them both together
into balanced binary search trees
and here's one question that you will
face
at some point write a function to create
a balanced binary search tree
from a sorted list of key value pairs
so you have a sorted list of key value
pairs so the keys for example could be
usernames the values could be the user
objects and they are sorted by key and
you have a list
and you have to create a balanced binary
search tree from it
and here's the basic logic which is
somewhat similar to
binary search which is something that
we've covered in lesson one do check it
out
what we can do is we look at the middle
element
for instance if you have a list of 15
elements then the element at position 7
counting from 0
the element at position 7 is the middle
element
now we can take the middle element and
then create a new
binary search tree with the middle
element as the root node
okay so you take you make the middle
element the root node
and then
you take the left half of the list
and use that to create a balanced bst
and make it the left
child
of the middle element
the root node and then you take the
right half
which both of the house will have seven
elements each so if you take the right
half and you create a balanced bst out
of it and then make it the right child
of the middle element
so that's the idea here
and
how do you make a balance bst for the
left or right child
recursion right
so once again here's a recursive
solution
make balance bst takes data which is a
list of key value pairs it takes a low
and high and it also takes a parent and
we look at those
now
low is set to zero by default and high
by default is set to the last index in
the data
so we use that to get the middle index
so for instance if low is 0 and high is
14 the middle index is 7
then we get back the key and the value
from the middle index so we calculate we
find data made and that gives us the key
and the value for exa since the username
and the user object then we create the
root node so we create the root node
using bst node
and then we call make balanced bst
on data but this time from low to mid
minus one so from the indices zero to
six
and make that the left child of the road
and we called make balance bst
on the right node
so on the right half so from mid plus 1
so which is index 8 to 14
and we make this the right subtree and
then we return the root
and that's it that's pretty much it the
only thing that we might need here is
the terminating condition when low
becomes less than high which means that
we have no more elements to create trees
out of we simply return none so the
left or right subtree for those for the
parents of those nodes get set to none
so that's your makes balance bst
function we also have this other thing
called parent going around
and this i will let you figure out what
the parent does here but this is the
basic idea
so here is a list of key value pairs you
have
a key value pair sorted in increasing in
the increasing or lexicographic order of
keys
and we're calling make balance bst with
data
and that gives us a tree and let's view
the tree here
so there you go now we have created the
tree perfectly as we wanted it jadeish
is at the center and we have viraj sunak
on each side and then the appropriate
nodes on each side as the children of
those nodes
now recall that the same list of users
when inserted one by one resulted in a
skewed tree here we are getting the list
of users username and user from data and
inserting them and you can see
calling display keys on tree three
returns a skewed tree okay so whenever
you have a sorted array and you want to
create a balanced bst the way to do it
is
to start from the middle out
now finally one other question you may
be asked is to
balance an unbalanced binary search tree
and this is
pretty simple at this point and this is
kind of a trick question because
if you were given this question directly
you may not be able to think about what
to do how do you balance an unbalanced
binary search tree
but now that we have we have a way to
create a balanced binary search tree
from a sorted array
of key value pairs
and we have a way
to get
a sorted array of key value pairs
so now it simply becomes calling the
sorted array so calling list all on the
node which is also the in-order
traversal so doing an in-order traversal
of the binary search tree which gives us
a sorted area of key value pairs and
then passing that into the make balanced
bst function okay
so that's the trick here it's a two part
question and once again we see the
benefit of reusing our functions here
now we this now balancing and unbalanced
bst now becomes a single line of code
that's very nice
so we create a tree here
with the value none and now we insert
into it the values one by one and you
can see that that creates a skewed tree
because we are inserting
the values
in increasing order
electrical graphic order so we keep
adding right children and we never add a
right left child
but then we call the balance bst
function which internally takes this
gets in order traversal so the inorder
traversal lists all the keys and key
value pairs in sorted order
and then we call the
make balance bst function which starts
from the middle and then creates a
bandwidth binary search tree out of it
so there you see
this is how you balance a binary search
tree
and what we can do now to maintain the
balance as we grow our data structure is
a simple thing that we can do is to ins
to of insert
to balance the tree after every
insertion
and that brings us to the complexities
of the various operations in a balanced
bst
so if we are doing an ins if you're
doing an insertion that takes order
login because now if a tree is balanced
its height is order login so for
insertion you may have to traverse a
path from the root down to a leaf and
that path can be of length
at maximum equal to the height which is
order login but if we are also doing a
balancing with every insertion then we
also have an order n term added here and
order n plus order log n because
log n becomes much smaller than n as n
grows so order n plus order login is
the same as order n
so that makes insertion order n
finding a node becomes order login
updating a node becomes order login and
you can verify that listing getting a
list of all the nodes is order n
so what's the real improvement between
order n and order login so let's think
about it
if you're looking at a 100 million
records
then
log to the base 2 of 100 million is
about 26 or 27
so it only takes 26 operations to find
or update a node within a balanced bst
as opposed to 100 million operations so
you can see here a 26 or
a loop of size of length 26 and we're
doing some operation inside it only
takes about 19.1 microseconds that is
one microsecond is
10 to the power minus 6 seconds on the
other hand order n
involves looping through the entire list
so looking through 100 million numbers
rather than 26
and that obviously takes far far longer
and we saw that it took about 10 seconds
right about 9.98 seconds so
to find and update
finding and updating a node in a
balanced binary search tree is 300 000
times faster than our original solution
and all we have changed here is the data
structure
and that's the importance of data
structures because now
each user will be able to view their
profile in just 19.1 microseconds at
least that part of the request will take
only this long
so the user experience will be better
and your cpu will be busy for a shorter
time so you will be able to serve not
eight
but hundreds of thousands of users
every second
and finally your
hardware cost will also be far lower
because now your cpu is busy for a
lesser time so you do not need to use a
very large machine or you do not need to
use too many machines to support
hundreds of millions of users
and that is the benefit of choosing the
right data structure
now there's one tip here how do you
speed up insertions
so what we may do is we may choose to
perform the balancing periodically
instead of at every insertion for
example we can balance for every 100th
insertion or every thousandth insertion
or every 100 000 insertion whatever you
know that and that's where we have to
balance how often do we need to insert
things versus how often do we need to
restore the balance
another idea is to do the balancing
maybe periodically at the end of every
hour
so
for a second or two there may be a
slight dip in the performance because
you may be performing the balancing but
even that there's a way to do it so you
can take a copy of the tree and then
balance it and then simply replace the
pointer
to the original tree so there are many
other tricks that you can apply
and in fact there's also an algorithmic
trick which brings
insertion and balancing together into an
order login operation which we look at
right at the very end so stay till the
end
but before we do that
let's come back and answer our original
problem statement so remember now as a
senior backend engineer you are tasked
with developing a fast in-memory data
structure to manage profile information
username name and email for 100 million
users and it should allow insertion find
update and listing the users by
username
all as efficiently as possible
and to answer this question instead of
creating a user database class we we can
create a generic class called tree map
because we have been making things more
and more generic as we have gone along
so let's define a function called tree
map
which
internally stores
a binary search tree a balanced binary
search tree inside it
so when we initialize the tree map we
set self dot root to none which means we
have not created a tree so far
and then instead of defining functions
insert
update and delete we are going to use
some special functions
in python classes so we are going to use
the function set item
we're going to use the function set item
here and set item
is just like insert except it is a
combination of both insert and update so
to set item we will pass a key and a
value and of course self will refer to
the tree map object itself
so the first thing we do is we get the
root which which is basically the binary
search tree that we are storing
internally here so we get the binary
search tree and then we find we look
for the key inside the binary search
tree so if the key is found so if we
find the node
in our tree
then we come into this else position and
then we simply update its value and if
we do not find the node so which is what
happens initially because initially our
self.root is none so when you call find
with none and pass a key you get back
none
so then we first set
self.root
by inserting the key
into the tree okay
so if a key exists within our
binary search tree
then we update it
and if the key does not exist within a
binary search tree
then we insert it into our binary search
stream okay so we've combined insert and
update into the single operation called
set item
and similarly we define another
operation called get item this is the
find operation
all we do here is we find the node
inside self.root using the find function
we had defined earlier
and if the node is
present if it is found then we return
the value of the node otherwise we
return none
so given a key we retrieve the value
and then we have we defined one last
function called iter and this is the
replacement for
our list all function so what we do is
we simply say we call listall on
self.root so that gives us a list of key
value pairs
and then
we have the special syntax we say x for
x in
this list
and we put
these round brackets around it so what
this round brackets around it does is
that this creates a generator out of it
so now this is no longer list but this
is a generator and a generator is
something that you can use within a for
loop so
the iter function will allow our class
to be used directly within a for loop
and we'll see the example in just a
second and finally we have another
function called underscore underscore
len
so remember there are double underscores
here so there's double underscore set
item double underscore double underscore
get item double underscore similarly
double underscore uh len double
underscore here we simply return the
size of the self.root so here we simply
return the size of the binary tree and
then we have this function called
display this is going to simply display
the keys
okay so now we've defined the stream app
structure and it has all of these funny
looking methods like we know in it but
what about all of these but we'll see
what these do in just a moment and we
know what the what the functionality is
but you may be wondering why we've
defined them like this so the reason is
these are special
methods
that are treated especially in python
so here's how you can use them
let's first get a list of users that
we'll later insert into a tree
let's get a tree map so we instantiate
the tree map function
the tree mac class and that gives us a
new tree map inside it there is no
binary tree you can check
if you check tree map dot root you will
see that it is none there is no value
here
and if we try to display it you can see
that this tree map is empty
then to insert instead of calling
treemap.insert or instead of calling
premap dot underscore underscore set
item we can use this
indexing notation so we open these
square brackets and we put in the key
that we want to insert so if we want to
against the key ins against the key
akash which is the string if you want to
insert the value akash then we simply
say tree of akash
is akash
and similarly tree of a certain key with
the indexing notation set to this right
so this is
going to first look for the key as we
have defined in set item if it finds the
key then it is going to update the value
for the key if it does not find the key
then it is going to insert that key
value pair as a new node into our tree
so let's check it out now
and let's see here if we now check tree
map
dot root you will see that now it is a
bst node and if you try to display it
you can see that now it has a structure
jadeish
and akash
also note that this is a balanced tree
now if you go back here to set item you
will notice that whenever we insert
right after this we also balance the
tree and now you can change the logic
here so that we do the balancing not
after every insertion but maybe after
every 100 insertions so you may need to
track somewhere what is the current
number of what is the current insertion
counter and when it gets 200 only then
do the balancing and then set the
counter back to zero so that's an
exercise for you perform the insertion
or perform the balancing it only at
certain intervals
and here's a way to retrieve an element
so the retrieving element is also now
really simple you just call tree map
with jadesh as
the index and that gives you the value
if it is found and if it is not found it
simply returns none
now because we have defined the function
underscore underscore len underscore
underscore
so you can see here that has the value 3
because that
now we can use it with the len function
which is used for lists and dictionaries
and let's add a few more things
and let's set the values and let's see
here
so you can see all this
works exactly as expected
now
we are able to set values we are able to
update values we are able to display the
tree
it is remaining balanced and remember i
mentioned that you can use this in a for
loop so you can now put the tree map
directly into a for loop and what this
will do is because we have defined the
underscore underscore iter function and
the iter function returns a generator
so now
you can use this in a for loop and you
get back the key value pairs from the
list all
function that was used inside editor you
can print the keys in the values
and in fact if you want to convert it to
a list all you need to do is pass it
into the list and once again because
this is a generator because this is an
iterable this is now an iterable class
and you have defined that the way to
iterate over this class is to get
elements out of the key value pair list
so when you call list you get back this
list of key value pairs
okay so now we've made it a very python
friendly class you know instantiating it
is very easy we simply create a new tree
map adding values is very easy we simply
use the indexing notation removing
elements is very easy well not removing
a finding elements is very easy we
simply use the indexing notation
updating elements is the same as
inserting
we can also check the size of the tree
quite easily using the len function and
then we can also use
iterate over the keys iterate over all
the users in a for loop quite easily
and we can also update values as you see
here values have been updated
now
the the purpose of doing this
is to make it easier for other people to
use this data structure now as a senior
backend engineer you may have designed
this data structure and you may have
implemented binary search trees inside
it
but it's not important for other people
on the team or other people using your
data structure to know what the internal
implementation is what's important for
them is to be able to use it easily so
that's why always think carefully about
the interface or the api of your
functions or of your modules or of your
classes
try to make them as python friendly as
possible this was something that will be
appreciate that will be appreciated in
interviews and by co-workers
so make them python friendly so that
when people want to use something you
have created it is extremely intuitive
you know and they do not need to really
understand the underlying details
for instance i could be using this class
and i could have no idea that it is a
binary search tree all i know is how to
insert and how to get a value out of it
and i know that it is super efficient
because you have designed it
and i don't don't need to worry about
the internal details
so encapsulation and good apis are very
important
skill to have to cultivate so do that as
you work on programming problems
now once again let's save our work
before committing
now i did tell you that
there is a way to create self balancing
binary
trees and a self-balancing mandatory
remains balanced after every insertion
or deletion and in fact several decades
of research has gone into creating
self-balancing binary trees and not just
binary trees but other trees as well
which are not binary in nature and many
approaches have been devised for
instance red black trees avl trees and b
trees so here's an example
this is an avl tree so here whenever a
node goes out of balance
we rotate the tree and you can see
visually what we're doing here now
whenever you see that there is an
imbalance in the tree
we rotate it and how do you do this we
do this by tracking the balance factor
which is the difference between the
height of the left subtree
and the right subtree
for each node and then rotating
unbalanced subtrees along the path of
insertion or deletion to balance them so
you can see the balance factor is zero
right now the balance factor becomes one
and the balance factor becomes two then
we rotate it to set the balance factor
back and then the balance factor here
becomes -2 so here we do a right
rotation
here the balance factor
becomes minus 2 here and minus 1 here so
here we do two rotations so there are
four cases in total
there's the left right case the right
left case the left left case in the
right right case all four cases were
demonstrated here as well
and then you may need to do this
rotation not just once but you may need
to do this multiple times along the path
of insertion so when you insert a node
and that node creates an imbalance then
you need to work backwards so you need
to keep going from parent to parent
and keep rotating nodes whenever you
need to rebalance them based on the
updated balance factor of each node
so it
seems a little complicated but it's
actually not it's just that there are
multiple cases to handle
so you will need to write a couple of
helper functions you'll need to write a
function
left rotate which rotates node left
while still preserving the binary search
tree property you will need to write a
function right rotate which rotates the
function
which rotates it to the right while
preserving the bst property and then in
the insertion you will also need to
perform the rotation at the right places
and you will need to track the balance
factor inside each node so there are few
things to work out here
and don't worry you will normally not be
asked to implement an avl tree within
within an interview or within a coding
assessment so you do not really need to
learn the implementation but it's
nevertheless a very interesting data
structure to study and here are a couple
of resources you can check out so you
can check out this
youtube video which explains it very
wonderfully and you can check out this
implementation on geeksforgeeks.org and
the important thing for us to take away
here and which is something that you
may be asked if not the implementation
but just the complexity the important
thing is that
each rotation takes constant time and at
most log n rotations may be required
because if you are starting with a
balanced tree and you are inserting a
new node
then you may traverse a path of height
at most of length at most log n so you
may need to perform at most login
rotations maybe twice of that
so what that means is in order login
time you will be able to insert and
maintain the balanced property of a
binary tree right so you do not need to
recreate the entire tree again
and that makes your tree very efficient
because now when you're working with 100
million records
inserting will also take 20 steps
and finding will also take 20 steps and
updating would also take 20 steps and
all of these will work in microseconds
so that makes your data structure very
efficient
and with that we conclude our discussion
of binary search trees
so here's a quick summary we we looked
at
this problem of creating a data
structure which allows efficient storage
retrieval and updation
also efficient
iteration in a sorted order we first
started out with a list of sorted list
of
values sorted by the keys and we
realized that that was probably not the
right idea because
we are working with really large number
of records then we created this binary
tree structure so we looked at binary
trees we looked at how to create them we
looked at easy ways to visualize them
easy ways to create them from tuples we
looked at how to calculate their heights
their sizes how to traverse them in in
order pre-order post order we then
looked at binary search trees which have
this property
that the left subtree
has keys that are smaller than the
root nodes keys and the rights of trees
keys are larger than the root nodes keys
and that property holds at every sub
tree
and that makes it really easy to find to
locate a specific element or find the
position to insert an element so we
created binary search trees we created
the operations insert update find
and list all in a binary search tree we
also
determined ways to check if a binary
tree is a binary search tree or not then
we talked about balancing and we saw how
to create balanced binary search trees
and binary search trees form the basis
of many modern programming languages
language features for instance
maps in c plus plus and java are binary
search trees and data storage systems
like file system indexes or relational
databases also use something called b
trees which is an extension of binary
search trees
so it's very important to know about
binary searches even if you may not ever
need to implement them
you may be asked about them and in many
cases you may need to pick a binary
search tree as a data structure for a
problem like we did in this case
now you may wonder if dictionaries in
python are also binary search trees well
they're not
dictionaries and python are not binary
search trees so we'll soon release an
assignment that you can find on the
lesson page and you will work on hash
tables in the assignment
and here are some
more problems that you can try out so
you can try to implement rotations and
self-balancing insertion you can try to
implement the deletion of a node in a
binary search tree that's slightly more
complicated because
what you do if you have to delete a node
that has both left and right subtree
you can try deletion with balancing if
you really are up for a challenge
here a couple more finding the lowest
common ancestor of two nodes in a tree
so the common node which
is a common parent of both nodes
here you can use the parent property
finding the next node in lexicographic
order so given a node how do you find
the next node
what's its complexity or given a number
k how do you find the kth node in a
binary search tree so to do this you
will have to employ some clever tricks
and then there are a couple more
resources here you can open up these and
find more questions the important thing
to take away is that almost all of these
will involve some form of recursion so
you will either work with
the left sub tree or the right sub tree
or both
and some of them may also require you to
store additional information within the
node for instance for
for this one
the given the number k find the kth node
this may require you to store the size
of each
balanced binary search tree
in each node
so what to do next
you should review the lecture video and
execute the jupyter notebook experiment
with the code yourself
then complete the assignment hopefully
the next lesson
is called divide and conquer and sorting
algorithms
this is data structures and algorithms
in python
and i will see you next time
thank you and goodbye
let's look at assignment 2 of data
structures and algorithms in python the
topic of the assignment is hash tables
and python
dictionaries let's get started
the first thing we'll do is go to the
course website pythondsa.com
and on the course website you can find
all the lessons
and previous assignments
we are looking at assignment two so you
may want to open that up and assignment
two is based on or inspired from some of
the topics discussed in assign lesson
two so you may also want to watch lesson
two and complete the notebook before you
work on assignment two let's open it up
now in this assignment you will apply
some of the concepts learned in the
first two lessons to implement a hash
table from scratch in python that's very
interesting
you will
and hash tables are very important data
structure they're present in pretty much
every programming language and are a
common topic
discussed and asked in coding interviews
so we'll see how to implement them from
scratch
and one of the central problems in hash
tables is called collisions so we'll see
how to handle
hashing collisions using linear probing
and we will also replicate the
functionality of python dictionary so
python dictionaries are actually
implemented using
hash tables
so we see how to replicate
the way python dictionaries are created
and used and modified and the way we
access keys and
iterate over keys and set values and
change values and so on so we'll pretty
much re-implement the python dictionary
now we have an assignment starter
notebook here so we can click on view
notebook to open up the notebook
once again this is a jupyter notebook
and as you work through the notebook you
will find
question marks in certain places to
complete the assignment you have to
replace all the question marks with
appropriate values expressions or
statements to ensure that your notebook
runs properly end to end okay so make
sure that you run all the code cells do
not change any variable names and in
some cases you may need to add code
cells or new statements and since you'll
be using a temporary online service for
code execution keep saving your work by
running jovian.commit at regular
intervals
there are some optional questions they
are not considered for evaluation but
they are for your learning okay so let's
run the code now the
recommended way to run the code is using
free online resources binder
specifically but you can also run it on
your computer locally so we're going to
click run and click run on binder
once again this may take
a few minutes sometimes depending on
the current traffic on the platform
there we have it now we have the jupyter
notebook running
the first thing i like to do is click
kernel and restart and clear output so
that we can execute all the code cells
and see their outputs from scratch
i'm also going to hide the header and
the toolbar and zoom in here a little
bit
so we can see things a little better
the first thing we will do is set a
project name import the jovian library
and run jovian.commit this will allow
you to save a snapshot of your work to
your trovian profile so now you have a
copy of the assignment starter notebook
any modifications that you make every
time you run joven.com it will get saved
to your personal copy and it is this
personal copy that you will submit at
the very end
so let's talk about
the problem statement
in this assignment you will recreate
python dictionaries from scratch using a
data structure called hash tables
and dictionaries in python are used to
store key value pairs so keys are store
used to store and retain values
and here's an example here's a
dictionary for storing and retrieving
phone numbers using people's names so we
have a dictionary called phone numbers
and the way you create a dictionary is
using this special character the brace
or the curly bracket as it's called
and then in a dictionary you have these
key value pairs so this is one key value
pair where you have a key
the key in this case is a string akash
and here you have a colon
and then here you have a value the value
in this case is a phone number
so that's how you create a key value
pair
and comma separated key value pairs is
what you need to create a dictionary you
can see once the dictionary is created
it is displayed in the exact same way
and then you can access a person's phone
number using their name so if we have
the variable phone numbers and we use
the indexing notation so this is the
square bracket and we pass in a key here
we get back their name
and you may wonder what happens if the
key is not present the great thing about
jupiter is you can insert a new cell
like you can just click
insert cell below or you can use the
keyboard shortcut b as i just did
and check maybe
let's check the key vishal
okay and you get back a key error
and you may also wonder what happens if
is it case sensitive does that matter
you can check it very easily
so a lot of the questions that you might
get a lot of the questions that you may
want to even ask on the forum or look up
online can be resolved simply by
creating a new cell and typing out some
code right what happens if
questions
can all be answered by writing some code
so now let's add some new phone numbers
so this is how you create an initial set
of phone numbers this is how you access
a phone number and this is how you add
new values so adding new values is like
accessing them but instead of accessing
it you put an equal to and then you
actually set the value here
so we can add a new value here the phone
number for vishal and we can also update
an existing value in a dictionary simply
by accessing that value and putting an
equal to
and putting in new value there
you can see now that the dictionary is
updated to contain the new phone number
7878 and not the original phone number
you can also view all the names and
phone numbers stored in the phone number
dictionary using a loop so you can say
for for name and phone numbers so when
you put a dictionary into a for loop you
get back a key within each loop
you can see here that
the name and the phone number here is
displayed for you
using the print statement
so those are some things that you can do
within a dictionary
and dictionaries in python are
implemented using a data structure
called a hash table and a hash table
uses a list
or an array to store key value pairs
and
uses a hashing function to determine the
index for storing or retrieving the data
associated with a given key
so here's what it looks like here you
have
the key john smith
and you have a function called hash and
the function hash takes any key and it
returns an index within the list
so why do we use a hashing function well
one approach as we've discussed in
lesson two
is we can store our key value pairs in a
list and we can simply search through
the list each time we want to look up
the value for a key but that is
inefficient because that requires
looking through potentially all the keys
before we get to the key that we want or
maybe half of the keys so that makes it
an order n operation
if n is the size of the list
that's pretty inefficient we want
something faster and a hash function
actually operates in constant time so
hash simply takes the key
and it converts the key into a number so
in that sense it gives you the index of
the specific key value pair
in constant time rather than ordering
and that is what makes hash table so
efficient right so hash function
does not require looping through the
list it simply takes a key gives you the
index and you can simply then get
the key value pair or the value from
that index
now your objective in this assignment is
to implement a hash table class which
supports these operations an insert
operation a way to insert a new key
value pair a find operation to find the
value associated with a given key an
update operation to update the value
associated with the given key and then
list operation to list all the keys
stored in the hash table
and here's where we are going to use
python classes
and there's a
brief introduction to python classes in
lesson two
of this course so do check out lesson2
if you want a refreshing on python
classes
you have the class hash table
and inside the class hash table you have
a bunch of
methods now the insert method apart from
taking the self argument and remember
that the self argument is
refers to the object of the
class that will be created so this is
equivalent to this
variable in java or c plus
but these are the actual arguments of
the method
the actual arguments are key and value
so the
insert function or the insert method
will take key and value
then the find method will take a key
the update method will take a key and
value once again so the find method
takes a key and your job is to return
the value the insert method takes a key
and value and you insert the key value
pair into the hash table
then you have the list all method which
is used to list all the keys from the
table
so before we begin our implementation
let's just save and commit our work so
we're running joven.comit here
let's just run that once again
there we go the notebook has now been
committed
so what you can do is
you can come back to this particular
page and you can find this from your
profile and then you can click run to
continue your work
based on the modifications that you've
already made
okay so we build a hash table class step
by step
and the first step is to create a python
list which will hold all the key value
pairs now remember that a hash table
internally uses a list to store the key
value pairs
and we will create a list of a fixed
size so we'll set this variable max hash
table size of size 4096
initially
and we're going to create a python list
of this size how do you create a python
list of the size and we want all the
values to be set to none
so this is the way to do it you can of
course you can start typing
none and that would take a long time
or you can use a simple
technique just put in none times 4096
and that's one of the great things about
python it is such an expressive language
that creating a list of 4000 elements
simply requires this single
expression here
you can check that here you can even
check the length of
the data list
now if the list was created successfully
here are some test cases
here is one check that the length of the
list is 4096 here's another check and
we're simply picking a random value from
the list 99 and just checking if that is
equal to none but if you really want to
have a
sure shot test here what you should be
doing is you should be checking for
item in data list
item equals none
okay and here's a trick you can do you
can
write a word called assert and what
assert does is if this comparison
is true then it does nothing it lets
your code proceed as usual but if at any
point this comparison becomes false
then it throws an error so let's see
here you can see here there was no error
so that means it worked fine but if this
comparison was wrong so let's say if
item
if we had here
we wanted the items to be equal to
seven if you put it and and the telus
does not contain the item seven at a
certain position then you will get an
assertion error here okay
this is how you can create your own test
cases by putting in assert
but the idea here is that whatever you
try to do make sure that you're adding
some more test cases and not just
depending on the test cases that are
given here
these are simply to guide you in the
right direction
okay so next up we have a list now we
need a way to store or insert key value
pairs into a list
that's where the hashing function comes
into picture the hashing function is
used to convert strings and other
non-numeric data types into numbers
which can then be used as list indices
for example if a hashing function
converts the string akash into the
number 4 then the key value pair akash
and the phone number seven eight seven
eight seven eight seven eight
seven eight will be stored at the
position four within the data list and
here's a simple algorithm for hashing
which can convert strings into numeric
list indices and
a hashing algorithm does not have a
single definition
you can come up with a hashing algorithm
and in fact coming up with a good
hashing algorithm is
an area of research in itself now of
course python dictionaries use hashing
that is inbuilt into python and that's a
fairly optimized
hashing algorithm that's
probably the result of several years of
research
but here's one very simple technique we
iterate over the string character by
character and then we convert each
character into a number using python's
built-in ord function
and you can see here that if you call
ord
on the character x
you get back a number
it already gives you a way of converting
characters into numbers but not
entire strings that's why we need to
iterate over the string character by
character then we simply add the numbers
for each character to obtain the hash
for the entire string it's a very simple
technique we just keep
if you have the number hello we take the
odd for hello the odd for e the odd for
l the odd for l and the odd for o and
add them together
and since we want that number the final
result to be an index
or a position within the list
so we take the remainder of the result
with the size of the data list right so
it's possible that once you add the
numbers together you may end up with a
pretty big number but if you take the
remainder
with
or the max hash
table size
variable
you get back
a number that is smaller than 4096 so
you can use just that remain as the
index
so let's first define a function called
get index
all it does is it takes the data list
and it takes a string
and it returns it applies this hashing
algorithm to return an index
for that string for that key
so for a character in a string we need
to convert the character to a number so
we convert the character from the string
into a number
by calling od
on a character
great then we update the result by
adding the number so we say result plus
equals a number
pretty straightforward
and that
repeats for all the characters in the
string and then we get back the final
result now that result may be longer
than the actual size of the list
and this is where we then we may then
want to check the size of the list okay
now remember there's one no i could also
have probably written max
hash table size here
but that would be wrong
isn't it because we are passing in a
data list here we are passing in a data
list and
although we have so far created a data
list of size 4096
your function should ideally be you
looking at the size of the data list
that you have here and not any global
variables
so keep that in mind and the right thing
you should check here is lend data list
and what this will allow is now this
will allow your function to work with
data lists of different sizes and not
just the standard size 4096 that we have
defined above okay very important thing
always make sure that your functions
use the arguments
that are passed into them that they are
generic that they can work with any
input and not just a particular input
that have been
that has been defined earlier okay
so
there you go now you have
this is a function get index that has
been defined
and here are some tests now if you pass
in the data list and you pass in the
empty string because there are no
characters the result is likely to be
zero it's great
here's another one
the result here is 585 here's another
one result here is 941 great now
this is where you should be testing your
function with some custom test cases i'm
going to create a new
data list 2 and this is going to have
the size none times 48 so this is only
going to have the size 48
and i should be testing get index
with this data list as well
so let's say
we're looking at
the key akash
now we know that
let's see
we can actually test this out here what
happens if you add ord of a
plus or d of a
plus k
a
s
and h
that number is 585 but since the
size of the list is 48
what we should be getting back as the
result is 48 divided by 585
so we should be getting oh sorry
585 and its remainder with 48.
we should be getting back the number
nine
this should be equal to nine
okay
so let's check that if this is equal to
nine
and indeed this is equal to nine
on the other hand if we had
max
hash table size
you will see here that
since we are not taking into
consideration the actual size of the
list that was passed into the function
we are getting back the value 585
because we are taking the remainder with
4096 okay so remember to take the result
remainder with the size of the data list
that was passed in
so this is one of the several gotchas in
this assignment and they're there for a
reason because
this is something that you need to keep
in mind
a function which only uses its arguments
and does not
depend on any external global variables
or
constants and things like that
is called a pure function
of course a plot function also does not
modify any external global variables so
it simply takes some arguments and
returns a result
irrespective of
anything else
outside
so now we can
to insert a key value pair into a hash
table we can simply get a hash of the
key so here we have a key value pair and
we simply get a hash of the key by
calling get index for data list and key
and we get back the index 585 and then
inside the data list at the given index
we can simply set the key value pair as
the
element stored at that index
and the same operation can be expressed
in a single line of code so here we're
calling get index
for data list and he month
and that's going to give us an index
and we're going to then invoke
a set
at that particular index within data
list
the the element
hemanth comma hemans phone number
now to retrieve or find the element
associated with a pair
we can simply get a hash of
the element the value associated with
the key we can simply get a hash of the
key and look up that index within the
data list so here we have the kiakash
and we have the data list and we call
get index
so we get the index of the kiakash
and that gives us the index here
and we can then call datalist
and pass in the position idx and that
should give us a key value pair remember
that we stored a key value pair at the
given index so we should get back that
value here
so now we know how to store a value you
get its hash for the key and you store
the key value pair how to retrieve a
value so you get a hash for the key and
then you retrieve the
key value pair and from there you can
get the value
you can also list the keys to list the
keys here is some special code we are
using
so let's see this is called list
comprehension and let's take a quick
look at list comprehension
so list compression works like this
if you create a list y from a list x
uh let's say let's call this list one
and list two
go to variable names always help so if
you have a
list one and you write this x for x in
list one
what does that do
that for x in list one
patches
elements one by one from the list
and then here you can specify what to do
with the numbers that were fetched so
right now i'm not doing anything i'm
simply returning that number and then
i'm putting the entire thing into a list
what this does is this creates a new
list so you can see this is a copy of
the original list what i could do is i
could write x times two for x in list
one
and now i would end up with a list which
in which each element is the double of
that particular element
i could also do x times x if i wanted
i could also call a function on it
let's see what function we can call here
let's maybe put in some numbers here 1.3
2.4
3.2
so we could put maybe the function math
dot round
x
oh sorry math dot seal
this is going to give us the ceiling the
1.3 becomes 2 2.4 becomes 3 so you can
do any operation with each element of
the list and once you put that in a
bracket and you have this 4 here
that's going to apply that same
operation to the entire
list and this is called list
comprehension in python it's a very
powerful way to express complex
operations on lists and dictionaries
and there's one final thing in list
operations which is the if condition so
for x in list 1 can be followed by an if
condition and the if condition can once
again apply on x
so if
x is greater than
3 let's say we put this condition
then what happens is we choose only
those numbers from list one which
satisfy this condition x greater than
three so that means we would skip one
point three we would skip two point four
we would get three point two we would
get six we would get seven and we would
apply math.cl to them and that's how we
get back 467
so that's list comprehension in a
nutshell
so to get a list of keys all we can do
is for key value pairs in data list
if the key value pair is not none
remember that we have a lot of non
values and it's a huge list
if the key value pair is not none then
we simply return kv0 so remember if you
have a key value pair
if you have like a key value pair that's
akash and a phone
number and you can also put because
these are tuples
you can also put a
round bracket here if you want but even
without it it's the same thing
that's a key value pair
kv 0
is going to give you the key and kv 1 is
going to give you the value
so we simply get the key for those key
value pairs in data list where the
element at that position of the key
value pair is not none
and that should not be called pairs that
should probably be called keys
you can see that the keys are akash and
hemath
so that's how we can now use the get
index function
and the next step for you is to complete
the hash table implementation
here
by following the instructions given in
the comments
so now you have this basic hash table
class and in this class you have a
constructor
now the constructor takes
the object self or this and the self is
going to point to the actual object or
the actual hash table that gets created
using the class
and then it takes a maximum size
now what are we doing here we want to
make our hash table configurable we
don't
always want to have 4096
elements
in our internal list
we may need a hash table that can store
more values or we may need a hash table
that can only store fewer values so we
are going to set a
a default value for it which is the max
hash table size so if you do not provide
this argument by default it will create
a list of size 4096
but
we also want the option to specify a
maximum size now you need to create a
list of size max size with all the
values set to none
now you may be tempted to do this
but that would be wrong remember that
always use the arguments to a function
try not to depend on an external value
or external constant so this would be
wrong
you may also be tempted to do this data
list set dot data list equals data list
that we've already created this would
also be wrong
not just because you're not using the
max size but also because
now you are tying this class
implementation to a global variable
and that global variable
is a list which can be modified so if
you all the objects of this class any
number of hash tables that you create
using this class
we'll all use the same data list and
that's not what you want each hash table
that you create maybe you have a hash
table for phone numbers you have a hash
table for addresses you have a hash
table for something else each of them
should have their own internal data list
and this is not going to create a copy
of that original this is simply going to
point to the original list so what you
want to do is you want to do
none
and you want to multiply it with max
size
there you go this is the correct way to
do this
now we're looking at insert here now to
insert
we did see that to get the index all you
need to do is you need to pass the key
and remember here you need to pass not
data list but self.datalist right
because now we want to use the
data list that is stored inside this
specific object of the class we do not
want to use the global data list and
this is something that is
an mistake that we often make initially
i've still make this mistake where i
have certain global variables defined
and i'm using those global variables
inside my class
avoid doing that anything that you want
to put inside a class object you need to
put inside self like we've done here and
then to access it you need to use self
dot to access that specific
property or
element or even method
so now we have self.datalist and we pass
in the key and the data list into get
index
and that gives us the index
now the get index function was defined
earlier we've seen it already
now we want to store the index inside
the list so we call
self.datalist idx and we want to store
the key value pair there so we can
simply put in key comma value here
if you wish you can also put in the
brackets but they are not necessary
and that's going to insert the key value
pair now how do we
find the value associated with the given
p key
first
we get the index for the key so we call
get index
on self.datalist and key
then we retrieve the data stored at the
index so this would be
simply
self dot data list
of idx
and then if the key value pair is not
none
if the key value pair is none well
there's nothing in that index we can
return none another option would be to
also maybe raise an index error
and with a message
etc etc but
return on is good enough for now
then if not
from the key value pair we get back the
key and the value and then we return the
value
keep those in mind if you simply return
this you would get an error you would
get an exception that may go unexplained
so whenever you are destructuring or
you're trying to get two values out of a
tuple make sure that the tuple is not
none especially in this case because
we're starting with a list of nones
in a place where we're supposed to be
storing key value pairs
so that's fine
now update is
going to be
pretty much identical to insert i don't
see any difference here so we can simply
say
get index for self dot
data list and key
and then now we simply store the key
value pair inside it so we can simply
store oops the key comma value
inside self.datalist idx
then for list all
again straightforward
self dot
fkb is not none so get all the
key value pairs that are not empty and
then we simply get
kb 0 is going to give us the key from kv
so that there it is
here you can see already that we are
creating a basic hash table
of max size one zero two four
so the first thing that we can verify is
that the length of the basic of the data
list is one zero two four
there you go
then you insert some values here so we
insert
the value akash we insert the key value
pairs so we insert the value 9999 for
akash so this is one key value pair we
are inserting hemanth and 8088 and what
this will do is when you call basic
table dot insert
it will call this insert function
and self will now point to the basic
table that we have just created because
we're calling insert on that specific
basic table so self will point to the
basic table
so self.datalist will become basic
table.datalist and then the remaining
arguments are cached in 9999 will get
passed in as the key and the value
so this code will execute we will get
the index
within self.datalist for the kiakash and
then within self.datalist or basic
table.datalist in this case add the
given index that we just computed we
will store the key value pair which is
akash and the phone number
and that's how it'll work
so we're inserting some values and then
we're finding a value
so when once we insert the two values
and then we find a value that should
give us the
value 888 you may want to then maybe
modify this test case to also include
the test for the other value that we
inserted so feel free to modify the test
cases
or add new test cases
so that we're checking not just one
value but both the values
next let's see how we if we can update a
value so we call basic table dot update
and we said seven seven seven seven
now suppose you're not implemented
update here that's for a moment
return
suppose you've not implemented update
here
then
if you called update
you would get false here because the
value did not get updated and you can
check that by
simply checking
basic table dot find akash you can see
that it still has a value 9999
that's how test cases are helpful
let's remove the return
okay so now the value seems to have been
updated just fine
then let's get a list of all the keys
and the list of keys should match true
once again if we did not have this kv is
not none then we would get back not just
this key value pair but we would get
back all the nuns and we don't want that
so these were some test cases but you
need to now create more test cases
and test them out to make sure that your
implementation is correct
now once you've done that
you would want to run jobin.comit
now the next step and this is something
that you may have thought about while
working through the assignment is that
how do you ensure that
different keys
do not point to the same index because
we are doing all these things where
we are
converting each character into a number
and then adding up the characters now
obviously if you have
words which have the same characters but
in different orders now obviously there
are different keys
but
they do not have they have the same hash
listen
and silent
have exactly the same
keys
exactly the same hash so for instance
instance you can check get index
listen
and get index
silent
okay we also need a data list let's put
in a data list here
both of them have the hash 655
that means if you insert a value
at with the key listen and then you
insert a value with the key silent
the data at this position will get
overwritten so when you try basic table
dot find listen you will get the value
associated with silent and that's bad
and this is called collisions
this is called a collision because here
the
two keys are colliding in some sense
because they're leading to the same hash
and any hash table that you implement is
ultimately going to have collisions
because the number of strings or the
number of keys is possibly infinite but
you have a
limited number of positions or indices
in your table
so our hash table implementation is
incomplete because there can be data
loss and it does not handle collisions
and there are multiple techniques to
handle collisions and we the technique
we will use in this
assignment is called linear probing and
here's how it works
while inserting a new key value pair if
the target index for a key is occupied
by another key then we simply try the
next index and if the next index is also
occupied by another key we try the next
and then if we try the next and then we
try the next till we find the closest
empty location
and then while finding a key value pair
we apply the same strategy but it's
searching for an empty location this
time we search for a location which
contains the key value pair with the
matching key
we get the hash of the key that we want
to find and then we check if that
position is occupied by another key not
the same key
then we try the next index and then we
try the next index and then we try the
next index till we find a position which
is occupied by a key value pair for the
same key
and if we find an empty position that
means
the key does not exist because if it did
exist then it should have been somewhere
in that
string of searches that we just come
that we just did
now by updating the key value pair again
we apply the same strategy but instead
of searching for an empty location we
look for a location which contains a key
value pair with the matching key and
update its value
so that's how you handle collisions in a
hash table
and to handle collisions we will define
a function called getvalidindex which
first gets the hash using get index
and then start searching the data list
and returns the first index which is
either empty
or contains a key value pair matching
the given key so we are now
addressing two
requirements in one shot with the get
valid index function
for insertion we are looking for an
empty position
for
find an update we are looking for a
position which is occupied by a by the
given k value by the given key value
pair
okay or the given key specifically so
here's the get valid index function
and
i will let you work through this
so you will start with the index
returned by get index
then
while true
because we don't know how long we may
need to iterate get the key value paired
stored at the index
this is where you may have to
it's simply a question of putting the
index into data list getting the key
value pair now if the key value pair is
none which means that there is nothing
at that index it is empty
that's great we are done we can simply
return the index
on the other hand if it does have values
so then we get the key and value out of
it if the key
matches
the key that we want to store
great then we can return the index once
again
if neither of these hold true we move
the index to the next position
but as we move
to the next position it's possible that
we may run out of indices so the index
may become equal to the length of the
data list so then we wrap around and go
back to the zeroth position so this is
an important part where we go around so
now our list is in some sense circular
where we can keep looping around it so
that if we have something that needs to
be stored at the last position
but the last position is occupied then
we move back to the zeroth position and
so on
and then you can check if get valid
index was defined correctly and if it
was then these cells should output true
once again these are just some sample
test cases so you should include some
more of your own test cases here
and finally once you're done just save
your work
now the next step is to incorporate
linear probing into your hash table so
here's a new class called probing hash
table
here you need to use not get index but
get valid index
it has pretty similar code so i'll let
you work this out
be
aware not to simply copy paste code and
you will run into issues if you copy
paste code
so always make sure that you are
writing the code yourself and carefully
writing each word or each variable in
each method and each argument of the
code
then there are some test cases here for
you to test the probing hash table
once again you can try it out with some
examples and
see if it works fine
specifically here we are taking the same
example listen and silent
both of which in basic hash table would
have the same key but in probing hash
table would have different
will have the same position but in
probing hash table will have
different positions
and that's it you at this point you're
done with the assignment so you can make
a submission
if you have run jobian.commit
you can take this link
and make a submission on the assignment
page
or the other option for you is to simply
run jobin dot submit python dsa
assignment 2 and once you make a
submission it will be evaluated
automatically so let's click through
here
so it will be evaluated automatically
and if you scroll down here you will see
that you will get a grade and not just
grade but you will also get comments for
each question so if you see here there
are question numbers here
you can see that there's question five
question four and so on so it seems like
we since we implemented the get index
function since we implemented the data
list correctly question 1 was a pass
let's see what question 1 was
very quickly
question 1 create a python list of size
max table hash size question 2 was a
pass so question 2 was the get index
function
question 3 was a pass so question 3 was
complete the hash table implementation
question 4 was a field get valid index
we've not defined it yet and question 5
led to an exception obviously because we
have some code which will not execute
because we have some blanks that need to
be filled in
so keep that
use this as feedback you will know
exactly what to fix and if you are stuck
at any point
you know what to do
you can go to the forum
so let's see the forum here
so this is the forum
sub category for assignment two you can
create a new topic here if you want to
have a longer discussion or you can
simply go to the main topic assignment
to hash tables and python dictionaries
and you can ask a question here there
are already a lot of discussions going
on here
so it's possible that your question may
already have been answered
and after this there are also some
optional questions now here the optional
question is for you to implement a
python friendly interface for the hash
table so instead of defining functions
insert update and find you will define
the functions get item
set item
and instead of list all you will define
the function eter
and also instead of using the hash
function
instead of using the custom hash
function that we have defined
you will define you will use a function
that's inbuilt into python called hash
and it takes any string or any object
and it returns a number for it
now since hash does not accept a list so
you will have to take the remainder
manually so in this case for example
we've taken the remainder and gotten
back the number three five six nine
so you define a hash table here and once
you have done that you will be able to
use it just like a python dictionary you
will be able to use it exactly like this
you create a hash table and then to
insert a value you use the indexing
notation and insert the value to
retrieve a value you use the indexing
notation to get the value back and here
you can compare it to the number to
update a value you simply use the
induction notation again
and to get a list of values you simply
call the list function or you can also
use it within a for loop
and we've also defined a
function called wrapper and str what
that will do is that will let python
print a representation like this when
you simply run a cell which just
contains the name of this variable
that's one
and then there are a bunch of
improvements that you can try to hash
tables this is a great exercise if you
want to improve your python programming
skills and also understand how hash
tables work if you can complete these
four exercises there's pretty much no
question related to hash tables that you
cannot answer you will know everything
about them and each of these exercises
may take another
30 minutes to 45 minutes but it's
completely worth the time maybe spend
set aside a few hours on the weekend to
work on these optional exercises now
here's one how to track the size of the
hash table instead of having to look
through the entire table to get the
number of key value pairs
can you
store the length somewhere so that you
can
track it in
size order one here's one to implement
deletion so to implement deletion you
have a topic called technique called
tombstones that are used
so you can use this tombstone technique
and implement it just a little more code
can you implement dynamic resizing so
instead of starting out with a hash
table of a given size or requiring the
user to specify a size
can you or maybe start with a hash table
of let's say 128 elements and then
double it as soon as you reach 128
elements or maybe even before to avoid
collisions you may want to double it as
soon as you reach 64 elements
like 50 of the capacity
so dynamic resizing is the technique
that allows you to automatically grow
and shrink the data list internally and
then here's another technique for
collision resolution this is called
separate chaining so instead of going to
the next index what you do is you
maintain a linked list
at each position
and for all the key for all the keys you
still use that position but you look
through the linked list while looking
for a key or you add a new element to
the linked list
for that position
if you're adding a new key there
so here's separate chaining explained in
a youtube video
you can look through that and try to
explain it on your own
and one final thing here is also the
complexity analysis and here's where you
talk about
average case time complexity because on
average if you have a good hashing
function and you've implemented some
improvements like dynamic resizing
then the average time complexity for
insert update find and delete
are order one and list of course is
still order n on the other hand the
worst case time complexity because there
can be collisions are still order in
so here's something for you to ponder
upon what is average case complexity and
how does it differ from worst case
complexity this is also something that
is discussed in lesson three of the
course where we talk about quicksort
and you see why insert find and update
have an average case complexity of order
one and a worst case complexity of order
n
if not it is something that you can look
up online
try to see if you can search a tutorial
and learn
why this happens
then how is the complexity of hash
tables different from that of binary
search trees we've discussed binary
search trees in a lot of detail in
lesson two
so now the question becomes when should
you prefer using hash tables and when
should you prefer using binary search
trees or vice versa so
all these very interesting questions and
you may get asked some of these
questions and interviews as well
it will help you especially to ponder
upon some of these questions even if you
do not end up
solving all of these optional questions
do look at the complexity analysis and
think about it
and there's a forum thread where you can
discuss your
thoughts so what you do next
review the lecture video review the
assignment walkthrough video and execute
the jupyter notebook
complete the assignment and attempt the
optional questions as well
and do participate in forum discussions
so this was a walkthrough of assignment
2 of data structures and algorithms in
python hello and welcome to data
structures and algorithms in python this
is an online certification course
conducted by jovian and today we're on
lesson three
my name is akash i'm the ceo of jovian
and i'm your instructor for the course
if you follow along with this course and
complete four weekly assignments and a
course project
you can earn a certificate of
accomplishment for this course
so let's get started
the first thing we do is visit the
course website
pythondsa.com
so when you visit pythondsa.com
this will bring you to the course
website here you can find all the
information and material for the course
you can check out lessons 1 and 2 and
assignments 1 and 2
both of which are still open for
submission
and let's open up lesson 3.
so the topic today is sorting algorithms
and divide and conquer
and you can watch a video recording of
the lesson here
you can also catch a version in hindi
now the code
used for the lesson
is provided here so let's open up this
link sorting and divide and conquer this
is where all the code is present
so here we have it
now we are looking at
the tutorial and the code for this
lesson if you scroll down you can see
that there is some code here
now to execute this code you have two
options you can either execute this code
online using free online resources which
is what we recommend or you can download
it and run it on your computer locally
and the instructions for both of these
are given here
we are going to use the first one
which is to click the run button at the
top of this page and select run on
binder
so let us scroll up here and let us
click the run button and then click run
on binder
now once you do this it will open up an
interface like this
and what you're looking at here is a
jupiter notebook so a jupiter notebook
is an interactive programming
environment where you can write code
look at the results and you can also
write explanations
and we've provided you with a
cloud-based jupyter notebook setup so
you don't have to install anything all
the code that you execute here will be
running on our cloud
but you can also download it and run it
on your own computer by following the
instructions
so the first thing we'll do is click on
the kernel menu and click restart and
clear output
to remove any of the outputs from
previous executions of the code
so that we can execute the code and see
the outputs fresh for ourselves
now i'm also going to
zoom in a little bit here
so we can look at the code
and let's get started
so this is a coding focus and practical
course
and we're talking about different data
structures and algorithms the topic
today is sorting algorithms and divide
and conquer algorithms in python
so in every lecture we focus on a
specific problem
so in this notebook in this tutorial we
will focus on this problem which you're
looking at here
so let's read the question
you're working on a new feature on
jovian called top notebooks of the week
write a function to sort a list of
notebooks in decreasing order of likes
keep in mind that up to millions of
notebooks can be created every week so
your function needs to be as efficient
as possible
that is the key point here
now this is a classical problem in
computing
the problem of sorting a list of objects
and it comes up over and over in
computer science and software
development
and it's important to understand common
approaches for sorting
how they work what the trade-offs are
between them
and how to use them
so before we solve this problem we solve
a simplified version of the problem it's
quite simple to state write a program to
sort a list of numbers
and sorting usually refers to sorting in
ascending order unless specified
otherwise
so that's a question
for today write a program to sort a list
of numbers and we'll expand upon it to
answer this original question as well
now this is the method that we've been
following throughout the course and we
will continue to follow a systematic
strategy for solving programming
problems step one state the problem
clearly identify the input and output
formats
step two come up with some example
inputs and outputs and try to cover all
the edge cases and step three come up
with a correct solution for the problem
stated in plain english
step four implement the solution and
test it using example inputs so this is
very important that you implement the
simple solution so you just need a
correct solution first not the efficient
one and then you implement it and test
it then you analyze its complexity
identify inefficiencies and then you
apply the right techniques to overcome
the inefficiency and that is where the
knowledge of the right data structures
and algorithms comes into picture and
once you apply the new technique then
you once again state the
solution implement it and analyze its
complexity and repeat if necessary so
this is the strategy we'll follow here
today as well
so step one state the problem clearly
and identify input and output formats
now the problem is stated clearly enough
for us we need to write a function to
sort a list of numbers in ascending or
increasing order now here's the input
the input is a single argument called
nums
and that is a list of numbers so for
instance here's a list of numbers you
can see that they're not in any specific
order
and then the output is the sorted
version of the input so here is the same
list of numbers in sorted order
and based on these two we can now write
a signature of our function so a
function will be called sort or
something else but it will accept just
one input and right now we've not
written any code here so we just put in
pass
now i'm running this code here using the
shift plus enter shortcut but you can
also use the run button on the toolbar
so either run or shift plus enter
and the great thing about jupyter
notebooks is that you can add more code
cells anywhere and test
anything that you want for instance if
you want to insert a code cell below
just click the insert cell below menu
option or click outside a cell on the
left
and press the b button
and now you can write some code here
and run it
so please feel free to experiment with
this notebook
as you go along
so step two come up with some example
inputs and outputs now this is very
important you need to think about all
the different scenarios in which you may
want to test out your function before
you put it into production so that you
catch errors early on and thinking about
scenarios will help you identify what
are the special cases you need to handle
in code and it's easier to do it right
now than while writing your code because
that may lead to bugs
so here are some scenarios that i was
able to come up with and there may be
more so you can continue and increase
this list so the first one is some list
of numbers in random order for some
numbers in any random order and you can
try
slightly smaller lists and larger lists
and so on
second is a list that's already sorted
we need to ensure that an already sorted
list does not become unsorted
a third is a list that's sorted in
descending order we may want to check
that
see if
we need to handle that case separately
somehow
then a list containing repeating
elements this is something you may not
have thought of but the question never
said that the number should be unique so
there could be repeating elements here
an empty list
interesting input the output is also an
empty list or a list containing just one
element or a list containing one element
repeated many many times
or even a really long list this is
something that we may want to test
because we want our algorithm to be
efficient at the very end so a long list
may help us just evaluate the efficiency
empirically so these are the scenarios
and what we now need to do is create
some test cases for these scenarios so
test cases
involve creating an input and an output
for instance here is an input
num0
and this could be
the list 431 and here's the expected
output
so let me call it output 0
and this would be 134
now this is a good way to put create a
test case and you can use it later for
testing but we will put our tests into
this particular structure we'll create a
dictionary and creating a dictionary
like this will help us automate the
testing of all our test cases with a
single helper function
so what we're gonna do is for each test
case create a dictionary and
then
it'll have two keys first key is called
input and the second key is called
output
and in the inputs for each of the
arguments that go into the function and
remember there's just one argument here
we will have one key so we will have the
key nums and the key numbers will have
the input value for the test case and
the output will simply contain the
output returned by the function
so that's how we'll set up our test
cases
so does our test 0 a list of numbers in
random order
then we have test one this is also
another list of numbers in random order
you can see here no specific order
now we have a list that's already sorted
and of the output obviously is the same
now for the random ordered list the
output is the same numbers in sorted
order
now we have a list that's sorted in
descending order
and the output is the same list in
increasing order
then we have a list containing repeating
elements
you can see that the numbers 1
2 6 and 7 and even minus 12 repeat here
here we have the empty list
here we have a list containing just one
element and here we have a list
containing one element repeated many
many times
and then the final test case which was
to create a really long list
that's where we can start with a sorted
list
created using the range function and
then shuffle it to create
the input
otherwise you may spend a lot of time
just creating a list and then writing
the sorted version of it that's too much
work
so always use a computer always use
helper functions whenever you can even
to create test cases
so we'll use the range function now the
range function
takes either a single number or two
numbers so you can have something like
this range 2 to 10
or just range 10
and if you just look at it this way it
just prints range 0 to 10. now if you
actually want to see what's in it there
are a couple of ways you can do list
range 10 and that gets converted into a
list
or you can use it in a for loop
so you can put for x in range 10
print x so you can see that it contains
the numbers zero to nine
and that's important that the range does
not include the end element of the range
okay so just keep that in mind
now what's the difference between a
range in a list
a list contains all the 10 numbers
together at once but a range internally
simply maintains a counter so when you
use a range in a for loop it simply
starts the counter from 0 and increments
it up to the starts the counter from the
starting value so if it's two to ten
then it starts a counter from two and
increases it up to the end value minus
one so it does not use as much space as
a list
it simply uses a one single variable
internally and that's why it's more
efficient
in any case right now we need lists so
what we'll do is we will create
a list of ten thousand numbers so zero
to nine nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety nine that is our in list and then
our out list is also going to be 0 to
999 that's our outlist both of them are
sorted now what we do is we shuffle the
inner list so we import the random
module from python and then we call
random.shuffle
and we call random dot shuffle on in
list and that
shuffles the
the first list the n list
so now we have that as the input
nums and then the out list the sorted
list is the output
now once again we can even check
that in list is actually shuffled maybe
by looking at the first 10 elements you
can see here that these are all shuffled
numbers on the other hand if you check
the out list
you can see that these are all
in order
so those are our test cases and it's
very important to create good test cases
even in interviews
before you start coding or before you
even suggest a solution you should try
and list out your test cases either
verbally to an interviewer in a coding
assessment you may create a block of
comments at the top and start listing
some test cases at the top or you can
create proper test case dictionaries
like this
it takes a few minutes but it's totally
worth it because you can then test your
algorithms very easily
and finally we'll take all our test
cases test 0 to test 8 and put them into
a single list called tests
great so we've made some good progress
so far
next let's come up with a simple correct
solution and stated in plain english
and coming up with the correct solution
is pretty straightforward
we have a list of numbers
so we iterate over the list
let's grab a list of numbers so that we
have something to look at
here you go
so we have a list of numbers so we
iterate over the list of numbers
starting from the left so we start from
the very left
and then we compare each number with the
number that follows it so we compare 99
with 10.
and if 99 is greater than 10
then we can say for sure that 99 should
appear after 10 in the final sorted
array and the sorted array
by default it means the increasing order
of numbers right so that's what we're
solving first
so
what we can do is we can simply swap 99
and 10 because we know that 10 should
appear before 99 and 99 should appear
after 10.
now once we continue the swap we move to
the next position
and then we compare 99 with the next
element nine
that turns out to be
higher as well
so we swap it and then we keep going so
we iterate over the list and for each
element compare the number with the
number that follows it and if the number
is greater than the one that follows it
swap the two elements
now you do that once
and that alone is probably not enough to
compile the entire list because the
entire sorted list because 99 in this
way will end up at the end
if you follow
the process but the rest of the list is
still not sorted
so we repeat these steps one two three
so once again we start from the left and
then we start comparing ten with nine
and then ten with eight and so on
and keep swapping elements as we go
forward
now
i have a claim here that you may you
will need to repeat the steps one two
three at most n minus one times to
ensure that the array is sorted
can you guess why and here's a hint
after one iteration of the process the
largest number in the list will reach
the very end
so that means that each time you're
putting one of the largest numbers at
the very end
so you need around n steps so here's an
animation showing the same thing here we
compare six and five and then we switch
them
then we compare six and three
and we switch them
then we compare six and one
now we compare six and eight
and we don't switch them because they're
in order next we compare eight and seven
and we switch them
next we compare eight and two and we
switch them
and finally we can compare eight and
four and we switch them
and in this way the largest number eight
has reached the very end so now we can
froze freeze its position
and we can start again from the
beginning and you can see that this time
the next number seven will end up here
and then the next time the number six
will end up here and then next time the
number five will end up here and so on
so in
n
repetitions of this process of
comparison left to right
we will have sorted the array
and this approach is called bubble sort
because it causes the smaller elements
to bubble to the top or to the beginning
you can see that the numbers 1 3 slowly
bubble up to the top and it causes the
larger numbers like 8 and 7 to sink to
the bottom
and you can watch this entire animation
to get a full sense of how bubble sort
works what will also really help is if
you can take an example on paper and
work it out on your own step by step
especially with sorting algorithms this
really helps
okay so now we've come up with a correct
solution
let's implement it and let's test it
using an example
now the implementation itself is also
pretty straightforward
so we have the bubble sort function here
def bubble sort it takes a list of
numbers
now
we may not want to modify the list of
numbers in place because then our test
cases will not be reusable
so just to avoid modifying our test
inputs
we are going to create a copy of the
list to avoid changing it and the way to
create a copy simply call the list
function
with the list as input so now we are set
replacing nums with a copy of nums
now depending on your particular use
case this may not be necessary so this
is something that you can actually check
while you're in a coding assessment or
in an interviewer or talking to an
interviewer just check with them do do
they want an edit to be sorted in place
or do they want a new array to be
created if they want if they're okay
with sorting it in place then you
probably don't need this but you may
still just want to keep it in because
otherwise you may end up modifying some
of your test cases unintentionally
and that may lead to problems
it's always good to create a copy of the
input
rather than modifying it in place
okay so then let's come to steps one two
and three
and then we'll see step four which is
the outermost step really so we iterate
over the array so we go from
we take i
and we check the range
len
nums minus 1 so the number of elements
in the array is n
and n can be obtained using len nums
then we want to go from indices 0
to n minus 2
so the total number of indices is 0 to n
minus 1 but if you go to the n minus 1
or the last element there is no
further element to compare it with okay
so keep that in mind that you only want
to run this iteration till your pointer
comes to this point not till the last
element and that is why
we check if we put i in the range 0 to
len nums minus 1.
so the highest value that it can take is
len nums minus 2.
next we compare nums i with nums i plus
1. so we compare the number with the
element that comes after it
and if it is greater so that means these
two are out of order
so then we simply swap them so we set
nums i
comma nums i plus 1 equal to num i plus
1 comma num psi now this is a very
interesting way of sorting in c or c
plus plus or java you would have to
write three or four steps to swap
numbers but in python it's really simple
first you say x y is let's say we're
saying x comma y are two comma three so
you can see they have the values two and
three and then we simply write x y
equals y x so what happens is the value
of y gets placed into x and the value of
x gets placed into y it's a single step
for swapping two numbers there you go
so we swap the two elements
exactly what we're showing here swapping
the two elements
next
we repeat this so now we're doing this
from left
to the
penultimate element
and in this way we have pushed the
largest element to the end
now we need to repeat this process n
minus one times so that each time we are
pushing one of the largest elements to
the very end and in n minus one
repetitions of these three steps we will
end up with a sorted list
and finally we return the sorted list
and that's it
so let's test it out with an example
and by the way if some of this doesn't
make sense so a simple way
to debug it
is to
add print statements here so you can add
a print statement and maybe just print
this value so we've used underscore here
because we don't actually use this value
but let's say we wanted to use this
value then we can print that this is
iteration
j
and then inside it you can print that
the value of i is i
and you can also print the value of nums
i and you can also print the value of
nums
i plus 1
and at the very top you can also print
nums now if you add all of these print
statements
and then execute your algorithm now you
will be able to see exactly what is
happening inside each iteration
so that's a great way to debug your code
if you're facing any issues and also
understand what the code does
but in any case we won't need these
so i'm just going to comment these
so let's test it out so we get from test
0 we get the
nums
as input and then we get the output
and we can print the input and the
expected output and then finally
calculate the result by passing num0
into bubble sort
and then
printing the actual output and finally
whether the two match
so you can see here now
that the input was this unsorted list
and then the expected output was the
sorted version and that's what we got so
in fact there was a perfect match
and that's it so we've implemented our
first sorting algorithm it was pretty
straightforward a few lines of code
as an exercise you can try to implement
it once again from your memory
just write it in plain english first and
then try to implement it it's a good
coding practice
and we can also evaluate all the test
cases that we have remember we created
about nine test cases
and to help you evaluate the test cases
we've given you a helper function called
evaluate test cases which is part of the
jovian library so we installed the jobin
library here pip install jovian and then
from joven.python dsa so python dsa is
the name of the course and that's also
the module where we have helper
functions for this course
import evaluate test cases
and evaluate test cases simply goes over
the list of test cases that you have and
it pulls out the inputs and passes them
as arguments to the function provided
here which is bubble sort and then gets
the outputs and compares the outputs and
also prints the information with like
what was the input what was the expected
output and the actual output and whether
they match
so
let's check it out
so you can see here this was test case 0
and that work which we just tested out
here's a larger list
including some negative numbers this
worked as well you can see the test
result is passed
then you have another list here
this seems to work fine too this is
already sorted
here you have one which is sorted in
decreasing order that works here you
have one with repeating numbers that
works too
the empty list works the
single element works
and this works too this is the same
element repeated over and over and
finally here is our final test case this
had 10 000 elements remember so you can
see that this was the expected output
and this was the actual output so we
have successfully sorted 10 000 elements
and that's really the power of
programming that
without having to look at any of the
numbers we've just written four or five
lines of code and we've sorted 10 000
elements
so all our test cases passed
although do look here that it took about
15 seconds
for the sorting of 10 000 elements
now maybe that's not maybe that's not
that bad but we we are looking at
probably millions of notebooks every
week at jovin so
we want there to be a faster sorting
algorithm
okay so
to before we improve the algorithm we
need to understand the algorithms
complexity
and identify any inefficiencies now the
core operation in bubble sort if you
look at the code here once again
is this operation of comparison so we're
comparing a number with the next number
and swapping now comparison almost
always happens and swapping doesn't
happen nearly as often
so if you want to find the time
complexity
and we want an upper bound or the worst
case time complexity we can assume that
roughly every comparison also leads to a
swap
in the worst case so if we just count
the number of comparisons
as a function of the input size the size
of the list that was given as an input
that should give us an idea of the time
complexity
okay
so here we can see that there are two
loops and the length of each loop is n
minus 1 and inside the
inner loop there is a comparison so the
total number of comparisons is n minus 1
times n minus 1 which is n minus 1
square or n square minus 2 n plus 1.
now expressing this in the big o
notation which is to get a rough idea of
how the number of comparisons or the
number of operations in the algorithm
grows with time
we can ignore the lower order terms like
2 n plus 1
so we can now conclude that the time
complexity of bubble sort
is
order of n square and this is also known
as quadratic complexity
so we can now verify that bubble sort
requires order one
additional space
that this is an exercise for you but
here's a quick hint you can see that we
are not allocating any new lists we did
create a copy of the list but we didn't
have to
so let's not count that but apart from
that there is no additional space that
was required here we're not allocating
any new variables we are creating this
range but remember i mentioned that a
range simple simply contains a single
variable inside it
which it
keeps incrementing for a for loop so we
have these two ranges so maybe we have
two variables assigned
so it's
constant irrespective of the size of the
input and that's how bubble sort
requires order one additional space
now you may be asked about space
complexity and this is where it's a
slightly tricky thing because sometimes
strictly speaking space complexity
also includes the size of the input
because to store n numbers or
n elements you need
n spaces in memory so the space
complexity of bubble sort in that sense
is order n
and this is something you can check with
the interviewer if they're asking you
what is the space complexity and you can
ask them if they just want to know what
is the additional space required so the
overall space complexity is order n
because we need to store the actual
input list somewhere
but on the other hand the amount of
additional space required is order one
which is a constant factor
independent of the size of the list
so that's
that's how bubble sort works
now analyzing this order n square
complexity
and keeping in mind that
a list of 10 000 numbers takes about 12
seconds
so if n is 10 000 and n square is
multiplied by some constant is about 12
seconds then
if you had a list that was
of hundred thousand elements so that
would be 10 n whole square or 100 times
the same amount of time
that it would take to sort it so that
means it would take about 20 minutes to
sort 100 000 numbers
which is i would say is a bit
inefficient now
and a list of a million numbers would
take close to two days to be sorted in
python now if you do it in c plus plus
maybe it might be uh four or five times
faster
but again the moment you go from a
million to ten million well that will
actually end up taking a year or so
and that's bad and that is why n square
or quadratic complexity is
something that we would like to do away
with because it grows very fast as soon
as you hit maybe
a ten thousand or a hundred thousand
elements then it starts taking longer
than a few seconds or a few minutes or a
few days and at that point you can no
longer use that particular algorithm
so we need to optimize bubble sort
and the inefficiency in bubble sort
comes from the fact that we are shifting
elements by at most one position at a
time so each time we go through the list
we
capture some information about the list
but we are simply moving one element
from left to right so to speak
and each time we're just moving it one
at a time by doing swaps
rather it would be nice to just place
elements
directly
maybe a few positions ahead
and that's where we will look at some
optimized algorithms
now another common algorithm that is
used is called insertion sort
and this is here is the code for
insertion sort so you can look through
the code for insertion sort here
and here is
an example you can see how it works
and we will not look into insertion sort
in a lot of detail but roughly this is
how you arrange cards in your hand which
is by
starting to move cards around so that
at the
maybe on the left edge you have
sorted cards on the right edge you have
the unsorted cards and you keep moving
the new cards into sorted positions
that's how it works so here's an
exercise for you go through this
function
read the source code and then describe
the algorithm in plain english now
reading source code is an essential
skill for software development this is
something that you'll have to do in your
work whether you're doing software
development or data science maybe
because there are no comments in the
code there is no documentation or the
person who has written the code is not
available or has left the company or
this is some open source library so in
all these cases you will have to read
and understand code so read it and then
describe insertion sort the algorithm in
plain english then look it up online and
see if it matches what you've written
and then second is to also determine the
time and space complexity of insertion
sort
and see if it is any better than bubble
and explain why or why not so these are
a couple of exercises for you
so that's bubble sort and insertion
sword
now before we continue
i just want to recall you that this is a
jupiter notebook running on an online
platform hub.binder.joven.ml
and since this is free it will shut down
after some time so you want to capture
snapshot of your work
at regular intervals and that's where
you can use the jovian library
so you install the joven library using
pip install jovian import jovian and
then run jovian.commit now when you run
jovi.com it captures a snapshot of this
jupyter notebook and puts it on your
jovian profile so now this will be your
profile when you run juvenile commit
and you will be able to resume your work
by clicking the run button on this page
anytime and this notebook will go to
your profile so you can just click on
your jovian profile or just click home
here
and if you check either the overview or
the notebooks tab you should be able to
find your
notebook here
like here you go okay coming back now
we're at step 6 where we want to apply
the right technique to overcome the
inefficiency in the algorithm
now to perform sorting more efficiently
we will apply a strategy called divide
and conquer and divide and conquer is a
very common strategy
used across the board for many different
kinds of algorithms and it has this
general steps that is applied in
different different ways across
different problems
so step one is to divide the inputs into
two roughly equal parts okay they don't
have to be exactly equal but two roughly
equal parts
and the idea here is that
those two
parts can themselves be used as inputs
as sub problems
so then we use recursion so we
recursively solve the problem
individually for each of the two parts
so here you have a problem you have
created two sub problems out of it and
then you call recursion so the recursive
solution itself will use divide and
conquer and then keep going and so on uh
but once it gives you the solution
combine the results to solve the problem
for the init for the original inputs
okay so you have now results of the sub
problems and you combine them you get
back the final result
and then
the only last thing you need to know is
because you're going to
keep calling this keep doing this
division recursively so if you have an
input of size 100 you will
call the same function on inputs of size
50 and 50 then you will call the same
function for each of those 50 you will
call the same function on inputs of size
25 and 25 so each half and as you keep
going you will eventually end up with
small or indivisible inputs
and that is where you can solve the
problem directly and include terminating
conditions so that's where the recursion
stops
okay so you include terminating
conditions for small or indivisible
inputs
so that's divide and conquer you take
the problem divided into two sub
problems recursively solve the sub
problems get the solutions of the sub
problems and then combine them so you
can also call it divide conquer combine
in some sense
and
merge sort is the algorithm that is the
classic application of divide and
conquer to the sorting problem
so let's take a look at merge sort
by looking at an example visually so
here we have a list
that needs to be sorted in increasing
order
so remember
step one
divide the problem into two sub problems
so here we have half the list a little
more than half here we have another half
so we have split it into four elements
and three elements
then
we take we call recursively we call the
same sorting problem
the same algorithm on these two so we
split 38 and 27 into one half and 43 and
three into another here 982 becomes one
half and 10 becomes the other
again we can split 38 in 27
we can split 43 and 3 980 to 10. so now
we've ended up with single elements so
with recursion we've ended up at this
terminating condition we can no longer
split the list so now we start combining
the problems now if you're looking to
sort a list with just one element 38
well that list is already sorted so you
can return that
and 27 is already sorted the single
element so you return that now we have
these two sub lists and we need to
combine them each has one element so we
can simply compare these two elements
and we can tell that 27 comes first and
38 comes
second so that's how you combine these
two results to get 2738 then similarly
with 43 3 you combine them to get 343
and you get 982 and 10.
next you can combine these two results
so this is where now the combination is
important okay we need to look through
and we can probably tell that 3 should
come first
and then 27 and then 38 and then 43 so
we've combined them here
and similarly here we've combined 9 10
and 82 and then we take the final
results these two final lists and then
we combine them back to get the fully
sorted list okay and we'll talk about
this combination or what is called the
merge operation in a lot more detail
soon but this is roughly the idea here
you keep splitting it into half and then
you combine the halves
so let's now state it in plain english
so first the terminating condition if
the input list is empty or contains just
one element then it is already sorted
return it
if it is not divide the list of numbers
into two roughly equal parts
then
sort each part recursively using the
merge sort
algorithm and
by the power of recursion you will get
back two sorted lists
then merge the two sorted lists to get a
single sorted list and this is the key
operation here and this is why it's
called a merge sort because we are
always merging sorted list and making
bigger and bigger sorted lists out of
them
and the merge operation is something
that you may be asked to write in an
interview or a coding challenge apart
from the whole merge sort operation
itself
so this is something that you can try to
explain yourself so try to think about
how the merge operation might work and
explain it in your own words
here is some space for you
but let's jump into the implementation
of merge sort then
now we will implement merge sort
assuming that we already have a helper
function called merge
and this is a very useful trick
where your program may need some
complicated
piece of logic or some logic which you
have not figured out yet so all you do
is assume that you already have the
function
and write
uh use it first and then implement it
later so here's a merge sort algorithm
so now we have the merge sort algorithm
and we have numbers here given as an
input to merge sort now here's the
terminating condition if the length of
numbers is less than equal to one which
means if the list is empty or has just
one element return the numbers
then
if not then get the midpoint so return
length of numbers divided by two and
remember using the double slash here
because
a single slash would return a decimal
and we cannot use a decimal as an index
or a position in the list so that's why
we're using the double slash here
so we take the length of numbers divided
by 2. so if the size of the list is 10
so we get back
five here
then we split the list into two halves
and here's some interesting syntax for
you and let's look into what the syntax
actually means so let's say you have a
list
so this is the list we have and let's
say mid
has the value
well we can check it here one two three
four five six so
six elements by two mid has a value
three
now let's check
x
of mid what does that give us
well that gives us one three five well
actually
x
of colon mid means x of zero to mid
and x of zero to mid means all the
elements from position zero
till before the position mid so that's
very important once again it's like a
range so you get the
indices at position zero one and two not
at position three okay so that gives us
these three elements
then let's check the other thing x
of mid colon
now what this gives you is this gives
you
the elements starting from the position
mid
all the way to the end so you can also
write here minus 1 or we can also write
here len of
x minus 1
but or we can just skip it and python
will automatically interpret that you
want all the elements starting from mid
to the end
that is twelve five and one so positions
three four and five
and hence to split the
list all we need is
to invoke this
one three five and twelve 1251
we get back two parts of the list
so this is a nice thing about jupiter
whenever you don't understand a line of
code just create a cell above or below
and try out a simple example so now we
have
the the left half
num
zero to mid and then the right half so
numbs mid colon now here's where the
magic happens we call the function
recursively so we call the merge sort
function itself
so because we call merge sort on left
and that gives us back a list a sorted
list for the left half called left
sorted and then we call merge sort
function right and that will give us
back a sorted list called write sorted
and then we combine the results of the
two halves by calling the merge
operation so we now we are now saying
that we want to merge left sorted and
right sorted
to get back the final sorted numbers and
then we return the sorted numbers
so that's merge sort
so
yeah it's almost seems like magic but
it's pretty small pretty straightforward
only about four or five lines of code if
you combine some of these lines
so then let's come to the merge
operation
because that seems to be the meat here
right this is the only missing piece
so to merge two sorted arrays
what we can do is we can repeatedly
compare the two least elements of each
array and copy over the smaller one into
a new array so here's what that process
might look like let's say you have these
two parts one four seven and zero two
three and we want to get this sorted
list and notice that these are both
already sorted because these are the
results of the recursive calls to merge
sort so we keep a pointer on the left
on each one so here we have the pointer
at one here we have the pointer at zero
we compare the two
we take the smaller one and put it in
the list how do we know we can put it
because if this is smaller than this
all these numbers are also greater than
0 and then since 1 is greater than 0 and
all these numbers are greater than 0 are
greater than 1 so that follows that all
the other numbers to the right of 1 and
to the right of 0 are greater than 0 and
hence 0 should come in the first
position
so we put it there and advance the
pointer now you can see here now we can
compare one and two and this time one is
smaller
and you know that all the numbers here
are greater than two so they're also
greater than one and then all the
numbers here are also greater than one
hence we know that one is now the next
largest number so we can now put in one
and advance the pointer
and keep going this time now you compare
two and four so now you can put in two
and advance the pointer now you put in
three and then advance the pointer and
at some point you will exhaust one of
the lists and when you exhaust one of
the list then you can stop comparing and
you can simply copy over the remaining
elements so we can now copy over four
and seven and we've exhausted this list
and we get back the sorted merged array
zero one two three four seven so it's
really simple it involves each step
involves one comparison
and incrementing one
pointer so you're either incrementing
this pointer or you're incrementing this
pointer
okay so let's now define the merge
operation and you can see the benefit
now of assuming that the function
already existed now we do not have to
worry about the actual
sorting and recursion etc we simply have
to worry about merging two sorted arrays
so first we will create a list to store
the results and we have nums 1 and num2
the two left and right list that we are
going to combine then we are going to
set up two indices or two numbers for
iteration the two pointers on the two
lists
and we set up each of them at position
zero
so each of them are currently at
position zero here
and we loop over the two lists so we say
while i less than len of nums one and
while j less than len of nums 2. so
if you have four elements in the left
list then i can go from zero to three
all four positions and if you have five
elements in the right list j can grow
from zero to five zero to four all five
positions
then
we check and and we remember we want to
make sure that both of these indices are
valid if any of those have reached the
end then you want to skip and we can
simply copy over the remaining list
right so as you see here as soon as we
reach this point there's no more
comparisons to be made so we can exit
the loop
so now we check
which one is smaller so if we if norm's
one i so the left list current element
is smaller than nums to j
then we append to the merged list num1i
as we did here and we increment i so
this is exactly what we've done here so
we put in
well let's say here so we put in 1 here
and we increment the left pointer
on the other hand if that's not true
we append the element from the right so
nums 2j and we increment the right
pointer so in each case in each while
loop we are incrementing one of the
pointers
and then
when the while loop ends one of the
lists would have been exhausted that's
when the while loop ends so we can get
the remaining parts of both the lists so
we can get numbs1 i colon will get the
remaining elements from the first list
the left list nouns 2 j colon will get
the remaining elements from the right
list but remember since one of them is
exhausted so one of these two is going
to be empty
right now we we can check which one is
empty and simply add the
remaining one but here's a simpler
solution we just add both of them to the
merged array
so we append both the lists at the end
and this automatically takes care of the
empty case if the left side becomes
empty then this adds nothing to the
merged array and this adds the remaining
numbers from the right side if the right
side becomes empty then this adds the
remaining numbers from the left and left
side and this adds nothing so that's a
small trick
so that's the merge operation again not
very difficult
if you have any questions is take this
out into specific
cells and try it out with examples and
you should see it working
let's try out the merge operation now so
here we have two sorted lists you can
see here
and there you go you can see that this
is now arranged
all these numbers are now arranged in a
sorted order
so now we have the merge operation and
we have the merge sort operation so we
can now test out the merge sort function
so we get the first set of inputs and
outputs
from test 0
and you can see here
that this is the input and this is the
expected output and this was the actual
output as well
now let's test all the cases using the
evaluate test cases function from jovian
so here we're simply going to call
evaluate test cases on the entire list
of test cases and you can see all the
test cases seem to be passing
now if one of these test cases had
failed what you should go do is you
should go back and add some print
statements inside your merge function or
add some print statements inside your
merge sort function the right places to
add the print statements is right after
the function definition
right after
in the body of the function it can be
the first statement and then inside each
loop so inside each loop whatever are
the changing parameters you should print
them inside the loop and then finally
you can also print the return value of
the function so in this way you can
build a full picture of what the
what your function is doing and that
makes it much easier to solve issues
so test cases and print functions make
it easy to fix errors in code and don't
worry if there are there are always
errors in code
what's important is you should be able
to find a way to fix them easily and
without
test cases or without printing you may
get stuck
and you may just keep staring at the
code and trying to figure out what
exactly went wrong so please do that
now one last thing i want you to notice
is here the execution took only about 50
milliseconds
on the other hand remember bubble sort
took about 15 seconds
to sort ten thousand numbers so that's
mer sword is much much faster right a
millisecond is point zero zero zero one
ten to the power minus three seconds so
in a second you can probably sort
two hundred of two hundred list of size
ten 10000
and that's what makes merge sort so much
more powerful and because it is so much
more efficient and as we analyze the
complexity you will learn
that merge sort is in fact more
efficient in terms of the
bigger notation as well so let's analyze
the algorithms complexity and identify
if there are any inefficiencies
now analyzing recursive algorithms can
get tricky and that's where it helps to
track and follow the chain of recursive
calls so what we'll do is we will add
some print statements to our merge sort
function
and our merge function so we'll simply
see what the merge sort function was
invoked with
okay so we'll add a print statement
inside merge and we'll add a print
statement inside merge sort both of them
and we are also tracking something
called a depth to
track the chain or the depth of each
recursive call
and you'll see what i mean in just a
second
okay so this is what it looks like we
called merge sort on this big list
of elements unsorted and that merge sort
internally led to two calls of merge
sort so you can see this one here and
this one here so you have two calls to
merge sort one with the left half of the
list and one with the right half of the
list and they're unequal
and these two merge sorts finally
returned
merged lists and we finally called a
merge operation on the two of them you
can see that this is the merge operation
the final merge operation called here
on the two merge sort lists and this
merge operation is working with these
two sorted lists okay
so we can see that each merge sort
invokes the
itself invokes merge sort twice but this
time with an area of half the size you
can see merge sort was invoked with
arrays of or lists of half the size
and it also invokes the merge function
once to merge the two resulting arrays
the two sorted arrays
now the two calls to merge or if you
observe closely they themselves make two
more calls to merge sort
and one more call to merge
and then those internal calls make two
more calls to merge sort and one more
call to merge and so on
till we end up with single elements at
which point merge sort simply returns
that single element
so
the merge sort algorithm ultimately
points down to a series of merge
operations you can see here that each
merge sort all it's doing is calling
merge sort internally and then calling a
merge operation so ultimately what we
are doing is we are first merging 5 and
-12
and then we are merging 2 and 6
and then we're merging minus 12 5 and 2
comma 6
and then we're merging 123 and we're
merging
7 minus 12 and then we're merging
7 minus 12 7 and finally we're merging
123-1277 and then finally we are merging
the big list right so it's ultimately
just a whole bunch of merge operations
and if you look inside the
merge operation this is where a
comparison is happening and this is
where this append step is happening so
we are comparing and appending so those
are the two key operations here and with
every comparison there is append so if
we simply count the comparisons once
again
that's happening
that should be enough to get the time
complexity
and what is the number of comparisons
that's happening
well that's straightforward too if you
have two lists nums one and nums two
each and the total length of the two
list is n
so because the size the number of
iterations is equal to
in the in the worst case it would be
equal to the lengths of the two lists
combined so you may have to first maybe
increment i by one then increment j by
one then once again increment i by one
and j by one so the total number of
iterations here is len of numbers 1 plus
len of norms 2
right but remember the merge was called
if merge sort was called with a list of
size n then merge was called with a list
of size n by two and n by two roughly so
the total list the total length of nums
one plus nums two is actually the
overall length n
so that's the real trick here that merge
the merge operation is an order n
operation where n is the number of
elements the total number of elements
okay so
this merge operation
takes four plus five nine comparisons
and this merge operation
takes five comparisons and this merge
operation takes three comparisons and so
on
now this way now if we visualize a
problem now as a tree where we're
calling merge sort with nl with n
elements and that ends up calling merge
sort with n by two elements and that
ends up calling merge sort with n by
four elements all the way down and then
we start merging so here when we get to
individual elements we are calling
merge with literally single elements and
as we come up here we are calling
merge at this point we are calling merge
with elements of size n by eight and n
by eight
but we are calling merge
eight times
so
now each of these sub problems makes a
call to merge
and each of these sub problems has the
list size n by eight
so you have eight calls to merge of size
n by eight so the total number of
comparisons done is n
and at every stage you can check this at
the top level
uh you are calling merge with n total
elements so the total number of
comparisons is n
at the second level you're calling merge
here once with n by two elements and
you're calling merge here once with n by
two elements so the total number of
comparisons is two times n by two that's
n
and here you're calling merge with n by
four elements four times so that's n
so if the height of the tree is h
then the total number of comparisons is
n times h right so
on each level you'd require n
comparisons for the merge and you call
merges at every level for each of these
sub problems so the height of the tree
is so the total number of comparisons is
n times h
now how do we get the height of the tree
if the height of the tree is h and you
can see here that as we go down
this is level zero and it has
one element this is level one and it has
two elements this is level two and it
has
four sub problems and this is level
three and it has eight sub problems so
level k has two to the power k sub
problems so if you keep going down this
is level h minus one
so level h minus one should have two to
the h minus one sub problems but
remember at the last level we simply we
simply have sub problems or merge merge
calls with single elements so that means
we have a total of
n elements here or n leaf nodes here
so it follows that 2 to the power of h
minus 1 is n
okay so i'll i'll let you think about
that in reason with that now this is
something that you may have to work out
on pen and paper to get correctly that
if the height of the tree is h then 2 to
the power h minus 1 is equal to n
because at the bottom most layer you
have n leaves in the tree
so it follows that h is log n plus one
so since we said that there are n times
h comparisons and h is log n plus one
so it follows that the complexity of
merge sort is n log n
and that's a big improvement from n
square it may not seem like much but it
is so n square for ten thousand is ten
thousand times ten thousand
but n log n for ten thousand is ten
thousand times
12 or 13
log to the base two
so that's about
a few hundred times faster
now even for an array of a million
elements it will only take a few seconds
to be sorted and you can verify this by
actually creating a list of a million
elements okay so the complexity of merge
sort is n log n and you get it by
drawing this sub problem tree and
realizing that there are you get a sub
problem tree of height log n or log n
plus one and at each step you perform a
merge operation
or multiple merge operations totaling to
n comparisons so so n times log n is the
complexity of merge sort
now here's also
discussion about space complexity and
this is something that i believe is an
exercise for you so do read through this
and see if you can reason why the space
complexity of merge sort is
order n
okay so time complexity is order n log n
and the space complexity is order n
but here's a hint why it's order n you
can see that inside the merge operation
we are creating a new list and then we
are copying over elements from each of
the two lists into the new lists
so we are allocating a new list inside
merge
and now it's so now that's no longer
constant that list will have the same
size as the size of the problem itself
and hence roughly that's why the space
complexity is order n
okay
so with that we conclude our discussion
of merge sort it's a divide and conquer
algorithm you split the list into half
recursively sort both of them then merge
the two sorted lists and the initial
condition is one or zero elements
now there are several extensions and
variations
of merge sort
called the k way merge sort where we
split not into two parts but into k
parts then we have the counting
inversions problem
where
we modify merge sort a little bit to
also find some other info information
about the list
and finally we have
hybrid algorithms which combine merge
sort and insertion sort so what they do
is for smaller lists they use insertion
sort because that's more efficient and
then for bigger lists they use merge
sort so
as they're splitting the list when you
get to a small
enough problem let's say 10 or less
elements they use insertion sort
and that brings us
to our next question
where we
make one level of optimization and then
we stop
but here we will go one step further
what we do is we will apply
an another technique to overcome the
inefficiency in merge sort now
the time complexity is pretty good you
can actually sort millions or even tens
of millions of elements with merge sort
quite reliably
but it's a space complexity that
causes a problem now because merge sort
requires allocating additional space and
that is additional space is as large as
the input itself
that makes it somewhat slow in practice
because memory allocation is more
expensive than
computations so doing a comparison is
very easy you just tell the cpu to
compare two things in the memory or
swapping them is also easy because
you're still working with memory that
you already have but when you have to
allocate new memory you often have to
then request the operating system
uh to allocate the new memory and then
you have to get its address and do a
whole bunch of operations so it's
let's say an order of magnitude more
expensive than simply doing some
computations so you should try and avoid
memory allocations as far as possible
now one or two variables is fine but if
you're dealing with a million elements
so you're probably going to need maybe a
few mb of additional space and that is
what may slow down
your
algorithm a little bit it would still be
n log n but the constant factor now the
cost of each operation will be higher
because it involves an allocation
now to overcome the inefficiencies the
space efficiency of merge sort we will
study another divide and conquer based
algorithm
sorting algorithm and this is called
quick sort
and quick sort
the array in place which means it does
not create a copy of the array
internally for sorting inside each
operation inside each combination
operation so let's see how it works it's
a pretty interesting a pretty smart
trick
so here's how it works if the list is
empty or has just one element return it
it's already sorted straight forward
then pick a random element if not
pick a random element from the list
now this element is called a pivot now
there are many strategies for picking a
pivot one is to pick a random element
one is to maybe pick the first element
the last element
what we'll do is we will pick the last
element but you can
easily
augment our implementation to pick a
random element
and then
reorder the list and this is the key
operation here reorder the list so that
all the elements with values less than
or equal to the pivot come before the
pivot element while all the elements
with values greater than the pivot come
after the pivot element
and this element is called partitioning
you're partitioning the array around the
pivot
so here's an example
you
let's say we take three as the pivot
element the final element now what we
want to do is we want to reorder the
elements and the way we reorder is by
doing swapping and comparison in
whatever way we can and that's what we
will really focus on the partitioning
algorithm
and you reorder it in such a way that
all the numbers to the left of the pivot
are smaller than it and all the numbers
to the right of the pivot are larger
than it
now here's the key observation here once
you do that
you can tell that
all these
all these numbers can now be sorted
independently and none of the numbers
from here will move to the right of
pivot and similarly all these numbers
can also be sorted independently and
none of the numbers here will move to
the left of the pivot so the pivot is in
the correct position in the final sorted
array so it's now in its correct final
position
and you can simply call quick sort on
this half or less than half this portion
of the array and this portion of the
array
and there's no real combination required
anymore right so because we're doing it
all in place we simply call quick sort
on each
side of the array
and once this gets sorted and this gets
sorted recursively
then you will have end up with the
entire sorted list right and that's what
that's how we then continue doing the
process recursively now on the left half
you once again pick a pivot and then you
arrange the elements around the pivot on
the right half you once again pick a
pivot and arrange the elements around
the pivot
and so on and so on okay
so as i said the key observation here is
that after the partition the pivot
element is at its right place in the
sorted array the two parts of the array
can be sorted independently in place
now maybe once again take pen and paper
and try to work it out yourself again
all of this makes a lot more sense when
you
actually put it down and solve a real
problem as a real
example so here's an implementation of
quick sort and
once again we will assume that we
already have a helper function called
partition which can pick a pivot
partition the array and return the
position of the pivot element
for the next quick sort step okay
so this entire process going from here
to here this is where we'll assume that
we have a function and write the quick
sort algorithm and then implement the
partition function
so here's what quick sort might look
like now quicksort takes a bunch of
numbers
and apart from the numbers it also takes
a start index and an end index now why
are we doing this
remember we want to avoid creating
copies of the list that's the whole pro
that's the whole thinking here the line
of thinking so
we will call quick sort not with a sub
list which is
which is a copy of a portion but we will
call quick sort simply by changing the
by passing the same original list but by
changing the start and end index okay
now there is some code here if end is
none then we are sent setting end to the
length of the list minus one
and here's one more thing that we're
doing so
the final invocation to quicksort that
we'll make will be something like this
we may call quicksort
let's say there are a few numbers here
so we may call quick sort
on a list something like this and in
this case automatically start will have
the value 0 and end will have the value
none
now remember the quick sort is going to
sort the array in place but we also said
that we don't want to modify our test
cases so here's one assumption we are
making that if end is none which means
if quicksort is called just with the
just with the list then we'll create a
copy of the list right so we'll just
create one copy at the very beginning
right when the list is passed for the
first time and then we will not create
any more copies and you can even skip
this line entirely
but the only trouble is that we'll start
changing our test case input so that's
why let's keep it and let's keep a copy
but this is only done at the very top
level right so only when we start we
create a copy so that we're not
modifying the input list but never again
so that's what we're doing here creating
a copy if uh quick sort what was called
with the list and setting end to len
nums minus 1 which is the final valid
index in the list anyway putting this
aside this is the real
condition here
so if start is less than end which means
let's say here you have start and here
you have end now if start is less than
end that means you have two or more
elements right if start and end are
equal that means you have just one
element
and if start is greater than n that
means you have zero elements really so
if start is less than n that means if
you have at least two elements
then we call the partition function
we call the partition function on nums
and we say that we want to partition the
region start to end so let's say this is
the region start to end
we want to partition it
so we want to pick a pivot and then
partition it in such a way that
elements to the left of the pivot are
smaller than it and elements to the
right of the pivot are larger than it
for example if you want 4 to be the
partition element 4 to be the pivot
element then we will partition the array
as 3 comma 4 comma 5 comma 23
so that 3 is smaller than 4 and 523 are
bigger than 4 and we will return the
position of the pivot element
okay
so now you partition the array and
return the position of the pivot element
so this is the position we get back and
then we can call quick sort on this
region and on this region
so we can now call quick sort on start
to pivot minus one and we can call quick
sort on pivot plus one
to end okay so now we are passing
actually explicitly passing in values
for start and end so this will not kick
in the next time so no more copies of
the list will be created so all the
recursive calls will keep modifying in
place so all the even the partition call
will modify in place and we'll see how
partition works in just a moment so
partition gets the
slice of the original list
and it returns the position of the pivot
element then we call quick sort on the
left slice which is before the partition
the element smaller than the partition
and then we call quick sort on the right
slice which
is elements that come after the
partition
okay now here is how the partition
operation works
it's pretty straightforward too not that
difficult
so
what we'll do is we will pick the final
element as the pivot element but if you
don't want to pick the final element you
want to pick a randomized element well
just pick a random position and move
that element to the final position and
that's as good as picking the final
element now so
random pivot simply involves picking an
element moving it to the final position
but assuming the pivot is in the final
position
we then keep two pointers left and right
now remember we want to
create we want to push all the numbers
smaller than the pivot to the left
and we want to push all the numbers
larger than the pivot to the right
okay and what we'll do ultimately is we
will arrange them in such a way that
some of these are smaller than the pivot
and some of these are larger than the
pivot and then we'll move the pivot
between them
so we'll see how to do that so you have
the left pointer and the right pointer
now here's what we do inside partition
while these two pointers are far away
from each other
first we check if the element at the
left pointer is smaller than the pivot
well if the element at the left pointer
is smaller than the pivot which it is
you simply advance the left pointer
forward so this goes to 5
and then we
go back to the next loop
now this time once again we check if the
element that the left pointer points to
is smaller than the pivot
5 is not smaller than 3 5 is greater
than 3. so if that is the case then we
check
if the right pointer
is greater than the pivot
now if the right pointer is greater than
the pivot that means this number is in
its right position
it's greater than the pivot so we move
the right pointer back
one space
okay
so that's the operation we just did now
once again we check is the left pointer
smaller than the pivot no it's not
is the right pointer greater than a
pivot no it's not so that means these
two numbers are out of place right we
ideally would want this to be smaller
than the pivot and this to be larger
than the pivot so we swap these two
elements so now zero comes here and phi
comes here
now once again we can check is 0
the left pointer smaller than the pivot
yes so move the left pointer forward
then we is the left pointer smaller than
the pivot no 6 is now greater than 3 so
we check is the right pointer larger
than the pivot
yes so we move the right pointer forward
because five is still in its correct
position it's you know on the on the
right edge and
everything is greater than three so now
once again we end up in this position
that the left element is smaller than
the is larger than the pivot
so we check the right element the right
element is smaller than the pivot
we want it to be larger so we
swap these two because these two are
once again out of order and now you can
see that one zero two are all smaller
than the pivot and six five eleven are
all larger than the pivot so we do one
final check is two
smaller than the pivot yes so we advance
the left pointer
and now both of the pointers are at the
same position so now we can tell at this
point that
here
or from this point position onwards all
of these numbers are larger than the
pivot so we simply simply swap this
element with the pivot so there you go
so you end up with one zero two three
five eleven and six
okay so that's the partition operation
so again to understand it yourself
do it on pen and paper write out write
down write out this array
create the pivot
create the left pointer right pointer
and keep creating copies of the array
for each step of the loop okay and
that's how you understand these things
it's not that difficult it's just
it involves two pointers so it's a
little tricky
now this is the code for partition
and i will let you follow this code
we'll go over this briefly but at by
this point since we are halfway into the
course now you should be able to read
the code and then there are also
comments here and understand what we
have just discussed in plain english
understand that in terms of code okay so
one exercise for you is to explain this
visual approach in plain english
step by step and then the second
exercise for you is to read the code
and understand it
or maybe even try to write it from
memory so just take the english
description and try to write the
partition function from your memory not
memorize the code itself but
convert the english
text into code
okay
so once again here you know we have the
nums the numbers that need to be
partitioned the start and the end
and if end is none we simply set end to
the last index which is len nums minus
one
then we initialize the start and end
pointers so we initialize the left and
right pointers
remember we want to use the end element
so this is the end element so we want to
use the end element as the pivot so the
left point
the left pointer is start and the right
pointer is n minus 1
that's what we that's what we've set
here and then white while the right
pointer is greater than the left pointer
we increment the left pointer if the
number at the left pointer is less or
equal to the pivot we decrement
otherwise
we decrement the right pointer if the
number
on the right pointer is greater than the
pivot otherwise the two of them are out
of place and they can be swapped so we
swap them here
and finally we place the pivot
in place between the two parts and
that's it
that's exactly what's happening here
so let's see here let's see this
partition we are taking this list and we
are calling partition on it
and 3 is the number that was used as a
pivot so now 3 ends up here in between
so you have 1 0 2
and 5 11 6.
and the partition function returns the
position of the pivot so now you can see
how it is used in quick sort
the partition function returns the
position of the pivot and then we call
quick sort on the left partition
before the pivot and on the right
partition after the pivot
so now we can test out quick sort okay
and here's another exercise for you add
print statements inside the partition
function so there are already some print
statements you can simply uncomment them
uncomment the print statements to
display the list the left pointer and
the right pointer and the beginning at
end of every loop to study how
partitioning works and similarly you can
also add print statements inside the
quick sort function to study how the
recursive calls are going on
so study what we've done in merge and
merge sort and add the same print
statements in quick and quick sort
and look at these recursive calls
now what you want is to have a
completely clear and perfect idea of
what your code is doing you don't want
to be lost about it and that's why
adding print statements and looking at
small examples and making sure that it's
working perfectly really helps
so let's look at quicksort in action so
here's an input
and here's the expected output and
here's the actual output and they match
great
and we can now evaluate all the test
cases using the evaluate test cases
functions for function from jovian
so
we import from juvenile python dsa
evaluate test cases
and call evaluate test cases here
and you can see that it passes
all the test cases
and not only that you will also notice
that it is marginally faster than merge
sort for sorted lists
sometimes you may not
see that but yeah you can see here that
it's
you will see that in most cases
quicksort is marginally faster than
merge sort for larger list and that's
because it is not allocating
new space okay so now coming to the time
complexity for
quick sort
now assuming that we are able to have a
good partition each time so each time we
are dividing the list into roughly equal
halves
roughly equal parts
like you start with a list of size n and
you partition it
into n by two and n by two so this is
what the sub problem tree looks like so
you call quick sort with two lists of n
by two n by two then you call quick sort
with four lists of size n by two n by
four n by four and so on
now what is the activity that we're
doing inside quick sort in each quick
sort the core operation is partition
right and that's what puts one element
the pivot element into its right place
and then the
element smaller than it to the left of
it the elements larger than it to the
right of it
so the partition is where
the actual work the comparison and
swapping happens and how many
comparisons do we perform in the
partition
i would say that the number of
comparisons is equal to the size of the
actual list and you can see that here
you can see that we are going on
comparing
numbers like this we are comparing each
number to the pivot so each number gets
compared to the pivot exactly once
roughly
and that means
that there are a total of
n comparisons if n is the size of the
list
okay
so we have n comparison and partition so
partition performs n operations or
partition is an order n function
and what is the height of the tree once
again the height of the tree is log n
because
to go from n to one
it takes log n steps you keep going n by
two n by four and by eight and so on n
by two to the power log n becomes n by n
one
and so the time complexity of quick sort
is n login
if you're able to partition the array
into roughly equal parts
and that is what happens on average if
you're picking random pivots each time
then you do end up with roughly equal
parts maybe it's 75 35 75 25
but that's still more or less in the
same range
so the quick sort complexity is about n
log in
and this is called the average case
complexity on the other hand if you have
a really bad partition and a really bad
partition is maybe you picked the
smallest element as the pivot now if you
pick the smallest element as the pivot
then all the elements will go to the
right of the pivot and you will end up
calling quick sort
on a problem of size n minus one and
then maybe once again if you pick the
smallest element as pivot
all the elements will go to the right of
the pivot once again and you will end up
calling quicksort with a problem size of
n minus two now this is an unbalanced t
or a skewed tree and what happens in a
skewed tree is that the height this time
is the same as n you can see n n minus
one n minus two n minus three so going
up to one
the height of three is n
but the amount of work involved in
partitioning is the same because you
have to run through the entire list to
partition the list right so
that in this case the time complexity is
roughly n times n minus 1 by 2.
so the time complexity is about
order n square
and that's bad because that's as bad as
bubble sort
but despite the quadratic worst case
time complexity quicksort is still
preferred in many situations now it
really depends on
what kind of algorithm you need to use
and what kind of memory constraints you
have because
quicksort's complexity is closer to end
login in practice especially with a good
strategy for picking a pivot and a good
strategy is picking a random pivot but
there's another one called picking
median of medians you can check that out
as well
so that's n log n is the average time
complexity of quick sort and then
n square is the worst case time
complexity of quick sort
now here's an exercise for you verify
that quicksort requires order one
additional space which means that it
does not really need to copy the array
we did create a copy
because we did not want to affect our
test cases but we could have removed
that line and quick sort would work just
fine so because you do not need to
create a copy of the list or the array
it requires order one additional space
but because space complexity also
includes
often the size of the space required to
store the input so you can say that
quicksort has the space complexity of
order n okay so if you get the question
about space complexity you may want to
ask are you talking about the additional
space or do you also want to include the
input in the space complexity
so that's quick sort
and those are the two sorting algorithms
we've looked at so we've looked at
we've looked at bubble sort and we've
looked at insertion sort and then we
optimized it
using
divide and conquer and
got to merge sort which is order n log n
but it also has a space complexity of or
the additional space requirement of
order n which can be avoided using quick
sort
which uses order one additional space
but can have order n square
complexity in the worst case time
complexity
but with the right choice of a pivot it
is closer to n log n
so that's sorting and you can see that
python is such an expressive language
that all these sorting algorithms which
are often quite confusing to implement
in c plus or java are actually pretty
straight forward to implement in python
all you need to do is follow the method
which is to state it first in plain
english have some test cases ready to
test your function and then write your
code carefully
checking each line for errors and create
small functions wherever you need to so
try not to have too much logic in one
function a good rule of thumb is about
seven to eight lines of code per
function no bigger than that
and that's not just for toy problems but
that's also even as a software developer
something that you can
try to
follow just have seven eight lines of
code in any function if you have more
than that try to split it into two
functions
okay and and this way it's very
difficult for you to go wrong
so now let's return to our original
problem statement and let's read it once
again you're working on a new feature on
jovian called top notebook of the week
or top notebooks of the week and write a
function to sort a list of notebooks in
decreasing order of likes now keep in
mind that up to millions of notebooks
can be created every week you want to
build this for scale so your function
needs to be as efficient as possible
so first we need to sort objects this
time and not just numbers
and second we also want to sort them in
the decreasing order of likes for each
notebook okay
so all we need to do
is to use our merge sorter quick sort
techniques that we've already
discussed
is to define a com custom comparison
function to compare two notebooks okay
but before we do that we let's create a
class that can capture some basic
information about notebooks so here we
have the class
so we're still following the method so
to speak right the step one was to come
up with the input and the output format
so here is the input format our input
format would be using this class so we
create creating a class notebook which
is titled username and likes
so you create the class and that gets
stored as properties titles username and
likes and then we also have a string
representation here then
create some test cases so now we are
creating some test cases here so we are
creating some test cases in nb0 to nb9
and let's put them all into a list and
you can see here that
we now have a list of notebooks
nb 0 to nb9
and you can see that because we have a
string representation we can see that
the first notebook is this our caution
slash pytorch basics and it has 373
likes
and the second one is this and it has
532 likes and these are clearly out of
order in terms of likes
next we will define a custom comparison
function for comparing the two notebooks
what it will do is it will return the
strings lesser equal or greater to
establish the output order between the
two objects okay so it should return
lesser
when
nb1
should come at a position or a index
lesser than the position of nb2
in a sorted
list
okay so in in in case of our problem
what that means is we want to sort
things in the decreasing order of likes
so the first notebook should have the
highest number of likes and then maybe
the second notebook should have the
second highest number of likes and the
third notebook will have a lower number
of likes and so on so if you have two
notebooks nb1 and nb2 and if nb1.likes
is greater than nb2.likes so then nb1
should come at a lesser index okay so we
will return lesser because it should
come at a
lower position
in the sorted list so we return lesser
because we want a decreasing order
and if nb1 dot likes is equal to nv two
dot likes then we return equal and if nb
one dot likes is
less than nb two dot likes so that means
this is not uh is nb two is the more
like notebook and bit one is the less
like notebook
then nv1 should actually come at a
greater position so we will return
greater okay
so this is
this comparison function should
return whether the first input to it
should come up should show up at a
lesser position in the sorted list
compared to the
second input
now in
languages like c plus plus and java
normally the convention is to return a
negative number zero or positive number
but i find that python allows you to
return strings strings are first-class
citizens in python and it's a lot
clearer when you are debugging things
when you face issues to look at actual
strings and it's also easier to write
write code
so i prefer using strings but you can
also use
you can also use
numbers like negative zero or positive
that's totally up to you
so now here is an implementation of
merge sort which accepts a custom
comparison function so let's see the
merge sort function
so the merge sort function uses
it takes a list of objects this time not
a list of numbers
and it also takes a compare function
which by default we also provide a
default comparison so that we can still
use it with numbers now with numbers
and default assumption is if you want
sorting you want sorting in increasing
order so this is what the default
sorting looks like for numbers so that's
pretty straightforward but
you can also pass a custom comparison
function so here we have the terminating
condition if the length is less than 2
then we simply return the list then we
get the mid index and then we call merge
sort
on the left half with the custom
comparison function we call merge sort
on the right half with the custom
comparison function and we call merge
with the custom comparison function
now what happens inside merge inside
merge earlier you know once again we
have these two halves left and right and
then we have a custom comparison
function so we create pointers for the
two of them and then we also create the
final result list which is merged
and then we iterate over the left list
and the right list
so while we are going through these
we compare
the left element and the right element
so now we're calling compare now we're
not doing the greater than less than
comparison calling compare and if the
result if the element on the left is
lesser or equal to the element on the
right then we append it to the result
array and we increment the left counter
otherwise
so lesser or equal means that the
element on the left the first element on
the left
should show up at a lower position in
the sorted final sorted list so that's
why we append it first otherwise we
append the right child to the right
element
and we increment the right pointer and
finally we attach any remaining elements
here so this is something that you can
review something we've covered in a lot
of detail so now let's see let's call
merge sort on our notebooks and let's
check if the notebooks are sorted by
likes and indeed they are you can see
that at position 0 you have the notebook
with the highest number of likes and
then you have the next one and the next
one and so on
now since we have written a generic
merge sort function that works with any
compare function we can now very quickly
use it to sort the notebooks by title as
well or if we had maybe the number of
views per notebook or the number of
versions in each notebook or the number
of
comments on each notebook we could do
that sorting as well so we could even
use a hybrid of those
so here the example we're taking is
comparing by titles so here we have nb1
and nb2
and simple comparison strings can also
be compared using the comparison
operators so if nb1 dot title is less
than nb2.title then we return lesser
otherwise we return equal or greater
and with this we should be able to sort
them in the
ascending order of titles you can see a
n c i c i f e l i l o
p y p y okay p y t
h p y t h p y t o by torch okay so this
is an order sorted in the order of
titles
an exercise for you is to sort in the
order of username slash title which
means you first compare the username and
if the usernames are equal
then compare the titles so you can
compare you can
probably write another comparison
function compare username and titles
and use that to do that two-level
comparison and use that for sorting
okay now another exercise for you going
forward is to implement and test the
generic versions of
bubble sort insertion sort and quick
sort
using these empty cells that are given
here right so at this point in the
course you should start writing code you
should be writing maybe solving one
problem every day
to really practice the concepts and
internalize them
and while you're doing that you can also
any problem that you work on any
notebook that you create you can save it
to joven.commit and i'll show you also
how to create new notebooks so one way
to create new notebooks is to go to
jovian joven.ei click the new button and
click blank notebook
and you can give it a title let's say
you are doing quick sort
generic
and you can set up privacy and create a
notebook
and that creates a notebook for you and
then you can click the run button and
run it so that's one way to do it
another way you can do it
is we've given you a problem solving
template so if you come back to the
lesson page you will find a problem
solving template here
now you can click on the problem solving
template and click duplicate to create a
copy of this notebook in your profile
so let's do that
and now this is on your profile so you
can now click run and then run it on
binder or you can even run it locally on
your computer
and make some changes to it and come
back and run jovian.commit
and you will end up with a
link that you can share so now you can
now go on twitter and you can just share
this link so
write out a tweet
and tag us and also use the hashtag 60
days of python
okay and maybe say this is your quick
sort
algorithm
for generic objects
and tweet it out
and we will retweet your tweet so we
want to support everybody who's taking
part in this course on the course page
you will find a link to the course
community forum which is where you can
go and ask questions where if you have
questions about any of these and you can
even discuss some of the ideas that are
discussed here some of the exercises
that are shared so you can go into
lesson three for instance and create a
new topic maybe you want to talk about
the generic implementation of quick sort
so maybe you can create a new topic and
post a query there if you're not able to
make it work post your notebook there
and ask a question have a discussion
and
if you are helping other people out if
you are answering other people's
questions and you've written some really
great posts there are links to some more
problems that have been shared here so
you can check out these links
on each of these links you can try out
problems you can make submissions you
can solve these
problems some of these are interview
questions as well
you can check if your results are
correct
and you can use the solving problem
solving template as a starting point as
we've just shared
so there is a starter notebook with each
assignment and in the assignment all you
need to do is run the notebook so you
can run it on binder for instance
and then there is a question mark in a
bunch of places you will find like
question marks here in the text and you
will find question marks
here in the code
so you simply need to put in your code
your answers into the question marks so
replace that with your code you can see
here there are some question marks here
so you replace that and step by step
there are instructions to guide you
there is
there are comments to guide you so step
by step you can solve it and then
finally you can also make a submission
so right at the very end when you run
the code you will also be able to submit
directly
and when you make a submission then the
assignment will get automated will get
evaluated in an automated fashion
instantly and you will get a pass or a
fail grade now if you get a pass grade
that's great but if you get a fail grade
then you will also get some comments
about what went wrong in your solution
so you can use those comments to fix the
issues
so it's a great way to get quick
feedback and keep fixing your issues uh
especially watch out for edge cases so
that's assignment one and then
assignment two is called hash tables and
python dictionaries a very interesting
assignment where you are going to
implement
hash tables which power python
dictionaries from scratch in python and
you will also replicate the interface of
python dictionaries so do check it out a
very interesting assignment
again very similar format
you will find question marks in certain
places you need to replace them with
appropriate values expressions or
statements
and
in this way by working through each of
these step by step
you can see here by working through each
of these you will
implement hash functions and hash tables
which again are very commonly asked in
interviews as well so this is an
important assignment for from an
interview preparation or coding
assessment preparation as well
and it also teaches you a lot of really
good practices in python programming
in particular
so do check out assignment 2 as well and
we will send you an email as soon as
assignment 3 is ready but you can check
back in a couple of days and you should
see it on the same page
pythondsa.com
so what you do next review the lecture
video and execute the jupyter notebook
use the interactive nature of jupiter to
experiment with the code
complete the assignment and attempt the
optional questions as well so each
assignment has some required questions
and you can make a submission as soon as
you're done with the required questions
but there are some optional questions
which are slightly harder but i highly
recommend doing that because
they will improve your understanding
give you more practice help you
internalize the concepts better
and then participate in forum
discussions
and join or start a study group so this
is a great way to learn get together
with some friends maybe watch the
lecture together over a zoom call pause
the video
have discussions wherever you have
doubts discussion is a great way to
solve the specific doubts that you may
have
and it will also help you to articulate
your understanding better because you
when you explain to others you also
answer a lot of your own questions so
please do that
this is data structures and algorithms
in python
thank you and good day or good night
hello and welcome to data structures and
algorithms in python this is a live
online certification course being
organized by
jovian
today we are on lesson four recursion
memoization and dynamic programming
my name is akash and i am your
instructor
you can find me on twitter
on at akashness
if you follow along with this course and
complete the weekly assignments
you can also earn a certificate of
accomplishment
which you can add to your linkedin
profile and you will find hosted on your
jovian profile as well
so let's get started
now to the data structures and
algorithms course this is
pythondsa.com is the course website and
on the course website you will be able
to find
all the information about the course
so you can view the previous lessons
lessons one two and three and you can
also view the previous assignments
assignments one and two
today we're on lesson four so let's open
up lesson four the topic is recursion
and dynamic programming
now you can find a recording of the
lesson here and you can also watch a
version in hindi if you would prefer
that
in this lecture we will cover recursion
memoization and dynamic programming by
looking at two common problems in
dynamic programming the longest common
subsequence problem and then knapsack
problem
and we'll do this by coding these
problems live using the problem solving
template that we have
been using
one in one way or another since lesson
one so let's open up the problem solving
template
this is a template that you can use to
solve any coding problem and we will
illustrate this by solving two problems
using this template today
so
the first thing we need to do is to run
this
template you can see that there is some
explanation and then there is some code
here as well now to run this code you
have two options you can run it using
free online resources or you can run it
on your computer
the simplest way to run it is click the
run button here and select run on binder
and with just one click this will
set up a machine on the cloud for you
start
a jupyter notebook server
and you will be able to then
execute the code and modify the notebook
and save a version of it to your own
profile so that you can continue working
on it
so there we have it now we have a
running jupiter hub server
i'm just going to zoom in here a bit so
that you can see things clearly
okay so this is the problem solving
template and i said we're working on two
problems so i have some problem
statements listed out here
you can see the first problem longest
common subsequence is listed here
and this is a part
of the
lesson notebook lesson page as well so
you will find link to this problem
statement on the lesson page too
so let's first
modify the title of this notebook
problem solving template let's change
this title
to
dynamic programming
longest
common
subsequence
let's get rid of this
i don't think we need this
then i'm going to keep the section on
how to run your code so that
if
i share this notebook with somebody else
they have a way to run it
and then before we start
the assignment or the
problem
let's just save this to our own profile
so i'm just going to give it a name
longest
common
subsequence
this is an appropriate name for it so
i'm going to give it this a project name
install the jovian python library
and just run jovian.commit now what this
will do is we started out with a
template and now we are editing the
template by running joven.com we've
saved a copy of the template to our own
profile you can see this is the link
where you will be able to access this
notebook and you can run it and continue
your work
if this jupyter notebook shuts down if
you want to continue tomorrow for
instance
okay so now let's look at the problem
statement
now i'll just copy over the problem
statement here as well so that we can
see it directly within the notebook
there we have it
now you can paste the problem statement
and if you are getting this problem
statement from some other source then
it's always a good idea to include the
link to the original source as well
okay now we have a problem statement in
front of us
so the question is write a function to
find the length of the longest common
subsequence
so that's a new term we'll unpack that
between two sequences
now let's first learn what we mean by a
sequence now a sequence is a group of
items with a deterministic ordering for
instance a list
a tuple a range or even a string these
are some common sequence types in python
so here i have the string serendipitous
this is a group of items and this also
contains an order you can see that e
comes after s and r comes after e and so
on so this is a sequence a list would
also be a sequence so that would be a
list of numbers
so that's a sequence then we're looking
at subsequence what is the subsequence
now a subsequence is a sequence that is
obtained by
deleting or removing zero or more
elements from another sequence for
instance if you look at serendipitous
and if we remove the characters s
r e n
i
i o u s then you will be left with e d p
t so e d p t is a subsequence of
serendipitous now two things to note
here edpt does not have to occur
continuously
so these elements can occur anywhere
within the sequence but the order should
be the same so e d p t occur in this
particular order here and e d p t should
occur in the same order here so d should
occur after e
and p should occur after d and t should
occur after p
so those are the two requirements for
edpt to be a subsequence of
serendipitous and visually speaking what
we can see is if you take a
sequence and then you draw boxes around
some of these
characters or some of these elements of
the sequence and if you just take the
elements in the boxes then in the same
order then you end up with a subsequence
so now we understand what a sequence is
and what are subsequences
and once again if this is this question
is asked in an interview and you're not
sure what you mean by a longest common
subsequence and or even what a sequence
is then you should ask the interviewer
what do you mean by a subsequence or
what do you mean by a sequence and
they'll be more than happy to tell you
it's very important to communicate
whatever you're thinking whatever
questions you have
contrary to what
you might think asking questions is
actually a good thing the more questions
you ask the more it is appreciated
okay so now we've talked about a
sequence
and a subsequence now what's a common
subsequence so look at these two strings
serendipitous and precipitation now if
we pick just these elements that are in
the boxes r e i p i t o
now you can see that
rei pito is a subsequence of
serendipitous
and
r-e-i-p-i-t-o is also a subsequence of
precipitation
so a sub-sequence
which is common which is a subsequence
of both sequences
is called a common subsequence so rei
p-i-t-o is a common subsequence between
serendipitous and precipitation
now you can have many common
subsequences for instance we could just
look at re and re here and re would be a
common subsequence too
or you could just look at
i t and i t and that would be a common
subsequence as well or we've not picked
n here but you could also pick r e n and
r e n and that would also be a common
subsequence between the two
now the longest common subsequence as
the name suggests is the subsequence
which between the the common subsequence
between the two sequences which has the
maximum possible length
and you can verify this you can try
different subsequences and see that rei
p i t o is the longest common
subsequence between these two strings
these two sequences
and its length is seven
one two three four five six seven
so you have to write a function to find
the length of the longest common
subsequence between two sequences
so that's a question
and
this is a visual example that tells you
the answer okay
so now that we have the question we've
understood the question
we can start applying the method that we
have been learning throughout so this is
the systematic strategy that we will
apply and nothing about this method has
changed since the first lesson even
though we've covered a whole variety of
topics like binary search and binary
search trees and then sorting algorithms
and divide and conquer
this method has remained the same the
first step is to state the problem
clearly and identify the input and
output formats
then the second step is to come up with
some example inputs and outputs and
these will be used to
test our solutions so we should try and
cover all the edge cases and that will
help us write code that is correct
anticipating all the errors that we
might face
then we come up with a correct solution
to the problem as stated in plain
english
very important for you to state the
problem in plain english before you
start coding so that you communicate
your ideas and you also make it clear
once you express yourself
then you implement the solution and test
it using example inputs
and you fix bugs if you find any of them
and you will be able to find bugs if you
have written good test cases
then you analyze the algorithms
complexity and identify inefficiencies
if you have any
and most likely the first solution that
you come up with it doesn't have to be
optimal it just has to be correct so
there will be some inefficiency but it's
important to go through that process of
first finding a brute force solution and
then
finding the inefficiency
and then apply the right technique to
overcome the inefficiency and repeat
steps to three to six so you identify
what's the right technique and in this
case we will learn a couple of
techniques called memoization and
dynamic programming and then we go back
and state the correct solution again
then we implement the solution and test
it and then we analyze it again and if
there's further scope for improvement we
do that otherwise we say that we've
arrived at a
optimal or good enough optimal enough
solution
okay
i hope by this point
this you've started to memorize this
process and that's why we keep repeating
it over and over that it should become
second nature every time you see a
problem
so the first thing is to state the
problem clearly and to identify the
input and output formats now the problem
is already stated clearly enough but
let's just state it slightly more
clearly so let's say
we are given and just write it in your
own words that's more important whatever
is clear to you so we are given two
sequences
and we need to find
the length of the
longest common
subsequence between them
simple enough
then we have two inputs now we decide
the input and output formats
we have sequence one
a sequence
example
serendipitous
sequence two
another sequence
example
precipitation
great
and this these are the only two inputs
that we require and the output would be
the
length of the
longest common subsequence let's just
abbreviate that as lcs
which in this case
is seven
and we know what that subsequence looks
like we've just seen it above
so now based on this we can now create
and you can see the problem is now
created
and before i talk about the next thing
you if you double click on a text cell
you can start editing it and here we are
using a language called markdown so you
can see this creates a block code this
creates a bold font and
this creates a
code like font so let's see here no and
the way to go back into the display mode
is to press shift plus enter
so now you can see here that now we have
the problem we have the block code and
then we have all the styling so markdown
is a really useful and easy to learn
language for formatting your text
especially in jupyter notebook so do
learn it
but now based on this
we can now create a signature of our
function
so our function len lcs
will accept a sequence sequence 1
and sequence two
and it will return something okay so
that's the basic signature of our
function
and even though it's not doing much just
establishing what the arguments are is
the first step towards solving a problem
and let's just save our work from time
to time it's very important to keep
saving your work on jovian because this
is running on
a free online service so this will shut
down after some
minutes of inactivity so just run
jovian.commit and that will save the
notebook to your profile and you can
rerun it
okay so now the next step is to come up
with some example inputs and outputs and
here we need to try and cover all the
edge cases
so
i have written out a few test cases here
already
now the most common case is a general
case of a string like we had
serendipitous and precipitation that's a
common case there is one of them
both of them have some common elements
and there's a subsequence common
subsequence of length 7
but we may also want to test out another
type of data and this is one of the nice
things about python where you can write
functions that operate not just on a
particular class and its subclasses but
on any kind of data as long as it
satisfies certain criteria for instance
strings and lists both allow indexing
into them and picking out the ith
element or the nth element from the
sequence so they're both sequences so
our function should be able to work with
both strings and with lists
then
here is another case where we have two
sequences and they have no common
subsequence a function should not throw
an error here it should gracefully
return the number 0 because the empty
sequence is a subsequence of every other
sequence does that make sense
think about it so in that case if you if
there's no common subsequence then the
empty sequence is the common subsequence
so the answer is zero and here's one
other extreme case where one is a
subsequence of the other
here's another case where one sequence
is empty there's another case where both
sequences are empty all of these are
important otherwise you might miss out
certain special cases and you will face
an error when you code your solution
finally you can also have this case
where you have multiple subsequences
with the same length for instance if you
have a b c d e f and b a d c f e an a c
e
a c e is one long subsequence of length
three and that's the longest you can
verify and bdf is another subsequence
which is common to the two and also has
the same length
those are some test cases now let's copy
over these test cases here
in an interview or a coding assessment
what you might want to do is just write
these as comments if you have just a
single coding screen and try to list at
least four or five if but
go as far as you can because this will
also help you streamline your own
solution
and it's always something that is
appreciated
by interviewers
let's do that let's get
let's copy over these test cases here
and you can think of more so
if you have some more ideas of things
you should test
come up with them there's no right
number of tests
whatever it takes for you to feel
confident
is what you need to do
okay
so now what we've done is we've taken
these test cases and converted them into
dictionaries so you can see here we have
this first sequence sequence one and
remember that's why we've written out
that's why we've written out here the
names of the inputs and the signature of
the function now we can create test
cases
as dictionary so that we can test them
all easily all at once so we have the
sequence one and sequence two in the
input
sub dictionary inside the main test case
dictionary and then we have the output
which is the output of the function
which should be seven and this you can
verify so this is a general case then we
have another case in this case we have
two sequences these are both
lists
of numbers and in this case the output
that we expect is 5
and we have another general case longest
and stone in this case you can verify
that o n e is the common subsequence
it has the output three then here we
have two sequences which do not have any
common elements all these
come from the left half of the keyboard
all these come from the right half of
the keyboard so that was a quick way to
generate these two sequences
then here we have
dense and condensed and you can see that
dense is actually a piece inside
condensed so this is a special case
where dense is a continuous
sub string of the string
but it even if we had d e s e
that would still be a subsequence
because d e s e occur in this order so
that's one example and in this case the
sequence one is itself the longest
common subsequence and it has length
five
then we have this case where one of the
sequences is empty
and you can see in that case the output
should be zero and both sequences are
empty and here is the case where you can
have multiple longest common
subsequences and even in this case
your function should be able to figure
out the answer correctly
so let's take this
and let us copy over these test cases
here so we have t 0
to
p 7 so that's 8 test cases
and
you can add more test cases here
please feel free
coming up with good test cases is a
skill that you should develop
and what we'll do is we'll also put all
these test cases
into
this function called lcs or longest
common subsequent tests
so that we have all of them easily
available for testing at once
okay
now next step is to come up with a
correct solution for the problem now
we've seen the problem we have
identified some scenarios
now we need to come up with a simple
correct solution stated in plain english
it doesn't have to be efficient
it just has to be correct
so here's one idea
here's one idea here you can see we have
a couple of
sequences
let's create two counters idx1 and idx2
both starting at 0. so idx 1 will be a
pointer which will
start tracking
elements on in the first sequence and
idx 2 will be a pointer which will start
tracking elements in the second sequence
and what we'll do is we will write a
recursive
function so we'll write a recursive
function
which will compute the lcs of sequence
one
from idx to the idx1 to the end and
sequence 2 from idx 2 to the end
so what does that mean
let's say idx 1 has the value 3
and idx 2 has the value
1.
so you can see 0 one two three so
sequence one idx one onwards is logy
and sequence two idx uh idx2 onwards is
lch m e m y
so we are looking at this portion of the
problem and this portion of the problem
and our recursive function when invoked
with idx 1 and idx2
should return
the length of the longest common
subsequence between these two portions
so l o g y and l c h e m y now why are
we doing this we need this longest
common subsequence for the entire string
don't we
now
here's the logic why why we're writing
this recursive function which which can
theoretically compute this subsequence
for from any position onwards
so here's how we do this
if
sequence 1 of idx1 so if idx1 was
pointing to l and idx2 was pointing to
l here as well if sequence 1 of idx 1
and sequence 2 of idx2 are equal
then this character l
belongs to the lcs of
this portion
and this portion
okay why
think about it it makes sense because
these
these elements are equal so if you pick
the longest common subsequence of this
and you pick the longest common
subsequence of the remaining
then you can always add l to bo to that
subsequence and that will make the
subsequence longer right and that way it
follows that l will always occur in the
longest common subsequence between l o g
y and l c h e m y
okay
so we know now that this will occur l
will occur in the longest common
subsequence further
the length of this
longest the length of this longest
common subsequence will be
the length of the longest common
subsequence between ogy and ch emy
plus one
okay and now you can see why a recursion
is required because what we can now do
is we can say that if
sequence one of idx 1 and sequence 2 of
idx 2 are equal
then we simply call the recursive
function on sequence 1 of idx 1 plus 1.
so ogy and sequence 2 of idx 2 plus 1 ch
emy
and
assume that recursion will give us the
solution there
and simply add 1 to it because this is
equal okay so that's one case if
sequence 1 of idx 1 and sequence 1 of
idx 2 are equal great
but if they're not equal right so for
ins in this case for instance you can
see that
if i dx1 and idx 2 are both 0 so idx 1
points to a and idx 2 points to b so if
they are not equal
then one of the two things should hold
either
a does not occur in the longest common
sub sequence
between the two strings or b does not
occur in the longest common subsequence
between the two strings now we don't
know which one but that's the
power of recursion that we can just try
both so we can simply ignore a and we
can get the longest common subsequence
between b s e and t and b est
and check its length and then we or we
can simply ignore b and we can get the
longest common subsequence between absc
and est and check the length now
whichever is longer in length that
becomes the solution for the two strings
okay
so this is what it looks like
we start out with analogy and alchemy
we compare a and a
these two are equal so we know that the
longest common subsequence is one
the length is one plus
lcs of analogy and alchemy okay now we
compare n and l and now we see that they
are not equal
so either n does not come in the longest
common subsequence or l does not come in
the longest common subsequence so we try
both we remove n here you see a l o g y
and we remove l here we see c h e m
now once again a and l are unequal so
either a does not occur in the lcs of
these two strings or l does not occur in
the lcs of these two strings so if a
doesn't occur in the lcs we can remove a
and try again if l does not occur in the
lcs we can remove l and try again
and here once again we get a match
so in this case we know that l occurs in
the longest common subsequence of these
two elements
so now we can get the lcs of ogy and ch
emy okay and then you know as these
recursive calls complete
you can see that this entire tree pans
out you can see that each time you
either get one
child or you get two children and if you
go all the way down and then you
go back up and simply count the number
of matches for each path you will kee
and you take keep taking the maximum so
here you get back an answer let's say
you get back an answer of size two here
you get back an answer of size one
so the answer for this is simply the
maximum of two and one which is two and
then the answer for this is simply the
maximum of two and
let's say this is three then three and
the answer for this is simply one plus
three four okay so this is the way that
we will build up the solution
so we've now looked at the recursive
solution expressed
in text and we've looked at the
recursive solution expressed as a tree
now it's possible that it still may not
make sense to you how exactly this is
working and that is where you should
start trying to
create this tree yourself so pick up a
pen and paper and then start drawing on
pen and paper take an example and try to
read each step here and try to work it
out like a computer okay and just
thinking about it that way will help you
understand
this algorithm
now one last thing is that if either of
the
sequence one from idx onwards or
sequence two from idx onwards is empty
which means the index has reached the
end point
in after doing some recursion then their
lcs is empty so the length is zero okay
so that is the
recursive solution here i will just copy
over this recursive solution too
along with the entire tree
now obviously in an interview you do not
need to write all of this
in
in a lot of detail or you do not need to
so it helps to show a diagram sometimes
but you don't really need to do all of
this all you need to do is express
yourself clearly that we will create two
counters
and
the condition to check is whether these
two elements at those counter positions
are equal what do we do if they are
equal what do we do if they are in equal
and why are we using recursion here so
we are using recursion we can because we
can use reuse some of the sub problems
to compute the final problem
okay
and
understanding recursion is really
important for solving data structures
and algorithms problems because it's
like a superpower pretty much
pretty much every problem that you see
one way or another can
does boil down to recursion in one way
okay so now let's
save our work once again and now we're
ready to implement the solution so we
have the recursive solution in front of
us and if you remember the four steps
let's go let's go ahead and implement it
so we see
let's just call it lcs recursive
and this will accept a sequence one
and a sequence two
and let's also initialize
idx1 and idx2 because we will be calling
this function recursively so we'll
simply
use these two counters idx 1 and idx 2
and set them to 0.
now the first thing we need is if idx 1
is equal to the length of sequence 1
or idx2
is equal to the length of sequence 2.
then we return zero
again this is a common thing
that happens that the base case or the
end scenario is something when you're
describing the algorithm you will
describe at the very end as you're
drawing the tree you will notice what
the end case and scenario is but when
you're coding the algorithm the end
scenario or the base case comes at the
very top because otherwise we'll try and
access idx 1
from sequence 1 and that will throw an
error so that's why you need to handle
the base case at the very beginning
okay
next moving ahead
if sequence one
of idx one
equals
sequence 2
of idx2
great we found a match
we simply return 1 plus
now we can call
lcs recursive
on sequence
one sequence two
and we increment idx
one by one
and we also increment idx two by one
both of these need to be incremented
because
we are going to use this element this
common element
as an element in the subsequence okay
so there's just one recursive call here
that was nice
otherwise
we have to either ignore the first
element of or the current element from
sequence 1 or the current element from
sequence 2.
so we have two options so we have option
one
which is
we ignore the current element of
sequence one so this becomes lcs
recursive sequence one
sequence two
idx one plus one
and idx2
and then we have option two
this is
lcs recursive
once again with sequence one
and sequence two
and this time we increment
idx2
okay so make sure you understand this
piece because this is really the key
here
and then the length of the longest
common subsequence is simply the maximum
of option one
and option two okay
and that's it
what may
have seemed like a fairly tricky problem
once you start thinking about it
recursively okay
what happens if we simply compare the
first two and they're equal and they're
unequal okay now we need to solve the
problem for the remaining um either we
add one or we take or we ignore one of
the elements right once you get that
thought the recursive thought then the
solution and the code simply presents
itself to you it's just about
seven lines of code
okay
that's our lcs recursive solution
now let's test it out let's look at a
test case t0
okay so here we have serendipitous and
precipitation as the inputs let's call
lcs
let's keep that around so that we can
view it later
let's cost call lcs recursive
on
t0
but of course we need to fetch from t0
the input
and
get sequence 1 out of the input
and similarly we need to get the input
and get sequence 2 out of the input
you can see it it
takes
it returns the value 7
which is equal to the output by the way
so if we simply put in here t0
output
and i'm also going to put in this
special command called percentage
percentage time this is going to tell us
how long the cell takes to execute
yeah so now you can see here that we get
back true and the cell takes 495 seconds
or half a second to execute
and that's it so now we have tested this
test case one small thing i can tell you
how to
improve this slightly is because
in t 0 of input is a dictionary and
because the names of the elements of the
dictionary are sequence 1 and sequence 2
which also match the argument names of
lcs recursive you can see here we have
sequence 1 and sequence 2. what you can
do is you can simply say star star t0
input
and python will automatically grab each
key so sequence one will be passed as
the argument sequence one and sequence
two will be passed as the argument
sequence two
that's this is a small trick here that
helps us speed up
the reduce the amount of code we need to
write
okay now we've tested one test case but
that's not enough we should be testing
all the test cases
so to test all the cases we can write a
for loop for
t in tests etc
but we can do something else too
we can use the evaluate
test cases function from jovian so from
jovian.python dsa the module
we will import evaluate test cases
it's a helper function that we've
created for you but it's really simple
to write you can just use a for loop as
well
and we call evaluate
test cases
on the function that we want to test
which is lcs recursive
and the test that we have which is lcs
tests
and when we do this it is going to try
out each test case you can see it strike
test k0 that was a pass it tried test
case 1 and it's also printing out the
input the expected output in the actual
output
the test case 1 was
lists
and
lists work too because all we have used
here is indexing and length and these
are both things that are available in
both strings and lists and this is
something that's very nice about python
the dynamic nature of the functions
uh once again this worked perfectly fine
then here we have another one longest in
stone the expected output was three and
the actual output was three as well here
we have ads f e w ad and another string
they have nothing in common so the
expected and actual output are both zero
here's one where one is the
is already a subsequence of another so
the smaller one becomes the longest
common subsequence and then we have an
empty string and then we have two empty
strings and finally we have multiple
longest common subsequences we still get
back the right output now if any of
these failed you would know exactly what
went wrong for instance if you had an
issue in
this case where the two of these were
empty then that would tell you that
you've probably not handled that empty
case properly and that is why having
great test cases is very important
okay and we can see the timings for
these as well each of these took about
well
480 milliseconds was the highest now
that's still a bit high i would say 480
milliseconds because we are just looking
at sequences serendipitous and
precipitation which are of very short
length if you're looking at a really
long sequence for instance this
technique is used for dna sequencing and
we were looking at two dna strands or
two in two dna strings and trying to get
the common subsequence out of them and
these can go into thousands or sometimes
millions of
elements
that would make it rather slow
okay so we do want to improve this
algorithm further
so let's do that
and before that we can just commit our
work once again
but the first thing before we improve
the algorithm is to analyze its
complexity how long does it really take
okay and identify any inefficiencies
now to analyze the complexity
let's look at an example and let's
consider the worst case now when does
the worst case occur here we've seen
that if two
elements match then we simply have one
sub problem or one recursive call but if
the two elements or two elements of the
sequences don't match then we have two
recursive calls
so if you have two completely distinct
sequences
where none of the sequences none of the
elements match
then each time we will end up with two
sub problems so that becomes the worst
case so the worst case occurs each time
we have two sub problems where the
sequences have no common elements and
here's an example this is a sequence of
length six
here's a sequence of length eight
and this is what the tree will look like
so now we have no longer put the actual
sequences we've simply put what is the
length of the string that we started
with so here we start out with strings
of length six and eight and then we say
that we either ignore the first
character of the first string or the
first sequence or we ignore the first
element of the second sequence and that
gives us two sub problems and this time
this
the sequences have length five and eight
in this case and six and seven in this
case okay so we either reduce one from
the left or we reduce one from the right
and once again here we either reduce one
from the left or we reduce one from the
right so this way we create a tree and
you can also see that a lot of common
trees get created and that really is
what is the inefficiency and we'll talk
about that
but what will happen here is five seven
will then call four seven five six and
five seven here will once again call
four seven and five six
and four seven and four seven will get
repeated here and five six and five six
will get repeated three times here so
there's a lot of repeated calls that are
going to occur and you can even see this
here at the top you can see that alogy
the problem was
called repeatedly
so that's really a source of
inefficiency but
now the question becomes
that we know that all the leaf nodes
will end at zero zero that's when the
entire tree ends
so can you count the number of leaf
nodes
okay can you count the num if you keep
expanding this tree completely expand
each of these don't skip any of them can
you count the number of leaf nodes now
if you count the number of leaf nodes we
know that in a binary tree
the number of leaf nodes if the number
of leap nodes is
l um then the height of the tree is
if the number of leaf nodes is n then
height of three is log n
and based on that we can actually
determine the actual size of the tree as
well
so we know
that
to count the number of unique paths from
root to leaf will give us the number of
leaves right so each time
we have two choices we either reduce
from the left or we reduce from the
right so to get to 0 0 we would have to
reduce all the elements from the left
and we would have to reduce all the
elements from the right that means if
you have
strings or
if you have strings of length or
sequences of length m and n then you
would have to make m plus n choices
in total
and you so each time you have m you have
to make m plus n choices and each time
you have to choose whether you want to
reduce from the left or from the right
you have two choices and you have to
make those two choices m plus n times
that's the right way to put it really
so that means each time you com you do
two choices so you have two multiplied
by two multiplied by two multiplied by
two
and you keep multiplying that and you
will end up with two to the power of m
plus n leaf nodes okay
so here is an exercise for you draw this
tree on a piece of paper
mark out
how
the number of leaf nodes how the length
of each part is m plus n figure that out
and based on that can you conclude that
it takes 2 to the power of m plus n
leaves
to complete this tree and if 2 to the
power m of m plus n is the number of
leaves then the total number of elements
is in the tree simply double of that
once again this is something that is
very easy to verify you can check it
here for instance if you just consider
these two levels
the
if you have two leaves then the total
number of elements in the tree is two
plus one three actually it's double
minus one so two into two four minus one
three
if you have three levels you can see
here that if you have four leaves then
the total number of elements in the tree
is four into two eight minus one seven
and you can see that here
so it follows essentially that we have
an exponential number of sub problems we
have we are calling the
recursive function an exponential number
of times and inside the recursive
function we are doing
inside the recursive function we are
doing a constant time work so you can
see here that there's no there's no
special work that we're doing all we're
doing is some comparison and we're doing
an addition both of them are constant
time so we make 2 to the power of m plus
n recursive calls inside each we do
constant work so the time complexity is
order of 2 to the power of m plus n okay
that's a rough explanation we've not
gone into a lot of depth because we've
covered this over and over in three
lessons but the exercise for you to is
to verify how exactly it is 2 to the
power of m plus n okay
so that's our
recursive solution
and we know we now know that the time
complexity is 2 to the power of m plus n
let's just copy that over here
and the inefficiency as we said in this
algorithm is that we are calling the
same problem
we're calling the exact same problem the
lcs recursive function is called with
idx equal idx 1 equal to 5 and idx 2
equal to 7 and at x 1 equal to 5 and at
x 2 equal to 7 the same time twice so
each of these sub problems will be
called twice and then each of the sub
problems within them will be called
twice and of course some of these sub
problems will once again get shared so
there's a lot of repetition now there's
a simple solution here which is simply
to
remember some of these results okay and
this technique is called memoization
and you may also just call it
memorization because you're just
remembering some of these things but
memoization is a technical term for it
and we remember these solutions in our
dictionary called memo so what we are
going to do is we are going to follow
the same recursive strategy but this
time we are going to maintain a
dictionary
called memo and we're going to track
intermediate results within the
dictionary and if we find an
intermediate result already exists in
the dictionary then we will not compute
it again okay so let's see
so now we write lcs memoized or let's
just say lcs memo for short it takes a
sequence one and it takes a sequence two
and this time
we
create this dictionary called memo
and then we write a function inside it
so we will write a helper function a
recursive helper function inside the lcs
memo function so that it has access to
sequence 1 and sequence 2 and we will
simply started out with idx 1
as 0
and idx 2 as 0 as well right x1 will
track the position in sequence one idx2
will track the position in sequence two
now the first thing we do is create
using the two indices create a key so we
are going to create the key idx one
comma idx2
and if the key is
present in the memo so this is the way
to check if a key exists in a dictionary
then we simply return memo of key
simple the problem is solved we don't
have to solve this problem because it's
already it's already something that
we've solved if it isn't then we need to
solve the problem and save it in the
memo
now here we know that we can now write
our same three recursive cases now if
the base case if idx 1
is equal to the length of sequence 1
or idx 2 is equal to the length of
sequence 2
then we simply set
memo of
key as
0 because by this point we have reached
the end of the strings there's nothing
left for us to compare
lf idx sequence 1
of idx 1
equals
sequence 2
of idx 2. so in this case
this is the case where the current
characters are equal so this is if we go
go up here and look at the tree once
again
this is a case like this where the
current characters that we are pointing
at are equal so in that case we simply
return
we simply get the result as one plus
the result for the remaining
with the first character removed
so in this case we simply set memo of
key
to
1 plus
we call the recursive function again
recurs
idx one plus one and idx two plus one
great
else so this is the case where the two
elements are not equal so and this is
where we have two options i'm not going
to write the two options separately
let's just do a max directly here
max
and we say
recurs with idx 1 plus 1
comma
idx2 and recurse with
idx 1 comma idx 2
plus 1
okay
and finally from the recurse function we
return memo of key so we have whichever
case it is we have computed the result
and saved it in the memo
so this time
these computations will not get repeated
again and again
and let us now return
recurs of zero comma zero
because zero comma zero is the entire
string
and that's it
and this is the common strategy that you
should apply
whenever you come up with a recursive
solution and you see the inefficiency
coming because of the same problem being
called again and again and again
this is where you need to apply this
technique called memoization right and
in this technique you will then be able
to
simply store intermediate results so
it's really simple you just create a
dictionary and then you add one or two
lines of code here and you make sure to
save the result in that dictionary
whenever you compute a result the next
time you don't have to compute it okay
and we can test it out we can test it
out with all the test cases
evaluate the test cases
so lcs
memo and lcs tests
and you can see that all the test cases
pass
now not only do all the test cases pass
you can see that the
time taken is now lower
okay so
that's nice the time taken is now lower
now we went from 450 milliseconds if we
just go up here you can see that it took
480 milliseconds
for the
for finding the longest common
subsequence between
precipitation and serendipitous but in
this case it only took about 0.234
which is 0.2 milliseconds so it is 2 000
times faster even for strings of length
7 or 8
and that's a huge boost
let's analyze the complexity here
let's uh look at the complexity now a
quick and easy way to find the
complexity of the solution
is to see where the computation how many
times the computation can occur now this
is where the bulk of the computation is
occurring in a recursive call
and this computation is avoided
if we already have
something in the memo okay
so that means that the only number of
computations that we need to do
is equal to the maximum number of
elements that can end up in the memo now
what are the keys in the memo look like
the keys in the memo look like idx 1 and
idx 2
great and what values can these take idx
1 can take
0 to
m values if m is the length of sequence
1 let's say and idx2 can take
0 to n values if n is a sequence a
length of sequence 2. so in total the
possible number of keys is
m times n
the possible number of keys is m times n
the possible number of things that you
need to store in the memo is m times n
and for each of them you do constant
work and then the next time you try to
access this you do not need to do the
work you do not need to call any
recursion you can simply access the
memoization right
so what that tells us is the complexity
of this case and in any memoization case
in general
is
equal to the number of keys which in
this case is m times n so the time
complexity here is order of m times n so
we've gone from 2 to the power of m plus
n
which if you if m plus n was equal to 30
would be 1 billion
to
m time order of m times n so let's say
both strings were 15 and 15 so that
would just be 225 operations so we've
gone from 1 billion operations to
225 operations simply by storing
intermediate results and it's a very
powerful technique
that we apply all the time so now you
can see here that the first time five
seven is computed
the next time phi 7 does not need to be
computed again and that's why this tree
here is actually marked out so this is
the tree for memoization this the first
time 4 7 is computed it never needs to
be computed again so this entire tree of
computation gets eliminated and
similarly this entire tree of
computation gets eliminated we are
eliminating
from
1 billion computations almost
all except 225 computations so we are
left with practically nothing and that
speeds up your algorithm by a huge huge
factor
so that's memoization
and
as i said it's really easy to compute
the
time complexity of memorization just
simply count the number of keys
and then just track how much work do you
need to compute each key
assuming that you already have the
recursive solutions for the remaining
okay so how much work do you need to
compute each key using some other
existing solutions now in this case that
was constant because all we needed to do
was
compare and add
okay and i'll let you write here a
simple optimized so a
plain english explanation of
memorization it's worth a it's a good
exercise to try out but what we will
also look at is another technique called
dynamic programming now the downside
with memoization is that it requires
recursive calls
and while it's not a problem for small
cases when you have really large
problems
recursion has an overhead and the
overhead for recursion
if you see this way is that for this
function execution to complete you need
this function execution to complete and
this to complete and for this to
complete you need this to complete and
this to complete right so the idea here
is that for
each new recursive call
takes more space in the memory and it
also takes longer because now we have to
allocate some memory and then set up
that function stack
the function stack for the execution of
that function
so if you have a large tree
then you're creating hundreds thousands
or possibly millions of open functions
all of which have their own memory and
that can eat up a lot of memory and
sometimes that can also take up
a take longer time
so the solution to replace recursion
is iteration
and how do we do that we do that using a
technique called dynamic programming
so we'll do almost the same thing there
are a few changes here
instead of using a dictionary to track
intermediate results we will create a
matrix because we know that
sequence one uh the idx one can go from
zero to n uh where or zero to n one
let's say where n one is the length of
sequence one and sequence idx2 can go
from 0 to n2 where see
n2 is the length of sequence 2 and what
we can do is we can use a for loop or a
couple of for loops to fill out all
these sub problems
without having to
require a recursion okay and this is how
we'll do it
so let's say these are the two strings
that we're working with this is string
one t a c g t and this is string two and
these this is what
dna sequences look like
so what we'll do is we will create a
table of size n plus one plus one
and
n one plus one and n two plus one so you
can see that
there are
n one plus one rows so if if this is of
length n one these are n one rows and
then there's an additional row
and similarly there is there are n2 plus
one rows here so if this is of length n2
there are there are n2 plus one columns
so you can see these are n2 columns and
there is an additional column here
and
table of inj so let's say table of uh if
i and j are 0 so i is a pointer for
the first sequence and j is a pointer
for the second sequence so i
selects a row and j selects the column
so table of i and j represents the
longest common subsequence
of
sequence 1 up to i
which means sequence 1
so here if let's say i was 1 and j was
1.
so this represents the longest
subsequence of sequence 1 up to i
so
all the positions before 1 which means
only the 0th position just t
and sequence two up to j which means all
the positions up to the first position
of up to up to one so which means only
the zeroth position
so which means a okay so table one and
uh table i j represents the longest
common subsequence of
these two of just a and t which is zero
on the other hand if we skip ahead a
little bit
if we skip ahead to let's say this
position you can count here i goes zero
one two three four five six
so this is 6 here
and here we have
0 1
0 1 2 3
so this is so this is table of 6 comma 3
the table of 6 comma 3
takes the first
six elements
which is ta gtca
and the first three elements aga of
sequence 2
and it stores the result of the longest
common subsequence between these two
okay
so i'll just let you look at the table
and maybe even draw the table on a piece
of paper and verify that the length
three is right you can see here a g a
a g a occurs here so a g a is a
subsequence of t a g t c a so the
longest common subsequence between them
is three
now
what we'll do is we will now compare the
next elements
of
we will now compare sequence 1 of i in
sequence 2 of j so let's say we are
looking at
let's pick an example let's say sequence
let's say i has the value
i has the value 0 1 2 3 4 i has another
value 0 1 2 i has the value 2 and let's
say j has the value
1 so 0 1 so if we compare sequence 1 of
i
so which is g
and sequence 2 of a
sequence 2 of j which is also g and if
they're equal so if they're equal
then
table of i plus 1 on j plus 1 which is
this value
right so remember i is 2 and j is 1
so table 1 of
i plus 1 so table 1 of 3 is 0 1 2 3
and table and table 1 of i plus 1 j plus
1 is table 1 of
three
and
a table a table of i plus one and j plus
one
i being two and j being one
is table one of
three and 2 and table 1 of 3 and 2 is
the value 2.
so this value is obtained by adding 1
to table 1 of i comma j so because these
two elements are equal
we we can then
say that if we take the longest common
subsequence of t a
and a
and add one to it that will give us the
longest common subsequence of
tag and a g so the exact same logic as
recursion
we have simply
now reversed it so we now now looking at
the last element so that we can keep
filling out the last value using some
previous values okay so this is one case
similarly here's one other case where a
and a are equal
so the longest common subsequence
between t a g t c a and the longest
common subsequence between a g a
is one plus the longest common
subsequence between t a g t c
and a g
okay one plus this value
so that's one case the other case is if
they're not equal so let's look at
this value for example over here
so we have ta gt on this side and then
we have
okay let's let's look at this one uh we
have ta gt on this side and we have a g
ac on this side
now t
is the element here and c is the element
here
they are not equal
so that means
the longest common subsequence between
these two either does not contain t
or it does not contain c it cannot
contain both obviously because
one of the strings has to end
so if it does not contain t then it is
this result and if it does not contain t
or if it does not contain c then it is
this result so we simply take the
maximum of these two maximum of these
two to get the result for this if these
two elements are not equal
and that is how you fill out the table
you start from the top the first row is
zeros because we are we have empty
strings and the first column is also
zeros because we have empty strings to
fill out an element you compare if the
two elements are equal and if they are
equal we simply add one to the
diagonally left
top left element if they're unequal then
we take the maximum of the element above
it and the element to the left of it and
that way we fill out the entire table
okay so that's the dynamic programming
solution and i know this can seem a
little bit complicated honestly i still
get
confused with dynamic programming a lot
of times and that's why i like to just
draw tables and
write things out carefully
okay
and and especially you have to be
specially careful with indices because
here we are saying that if sequence i
one i and sequence to j are equal then
table one of i plus one and j plus one
is one plus table i j so b just watch
the indices carefully here but let's
implement the solution
let's implement the dynamic programming
solution
so let's say
lcs
dynamic programming so we'll just say dp
here
and we have sequence one
and we have sequence two
and the first thing we need is we need a
table of results
now this table
for it let's just grab n1 and n2 so
length of sequence one
and
length of sequence two
and now we need to create a table with
all zeros how do you create a table with
all zeros the way to do it a way to
create a list of zeros is this
zero for underscore in let's say n1
let's give n1 and n to some values
now if you want to create a list of
zeros of length and one use you simply
say
zero for underscore or zero for x you're
simply ignoring whatever value you're
getting from a range
arrange n one and that's going to give
you a list of zeros but we don't want a
list of
n one zeros we want
these one these want to be rows so we
want each of these to itself be a list
of zeros of length n2
so zero for
x in
range n2
and now we have you can see that we have
five rows one two three four five then
we have seven columns
one two three four five six seven
so this is the table that we want to
create initially okay now this is a
table that we've created this is going
to be this exact same table
and we're just simply going to start
each string from position 1 this time
not from position 0 because we want to
have this additional row where we don't
consider either of these that just makes
computations a little easier
now we say for idx one in len
at x1 and range n1
so that's that's going to iterate over
the rows and then for idx true
in range n2
and that's going to iterate over the
columns
and first we compare
if sequence one of idx 1
is equal to
sequence 2
of idx2
if they're equal
then we can fill out table of i plus 1
and j plus 1
as 1 plus
table of i j
okay and we can see this
we can see this here suppose the first
elements were equal so suppose this was
suppose idx 1 was 0 and idx 2 was also 0
suppose they were equal
then this value should be 1 so this
value should be 1 plus the diagonally
top element and that holds true anywhere
within the list so wherever you have two
elements equal like g and g are equal
here so this value is one plus this
value
else
we have table
i plus 1
and j plus 1
is max of
table
i comma j plus one so you stay in the
same row
or you you go to the previous row or you
go to the previous column which is table
of
i plus 1
comma j and this is the previous column
okay so
this is this case where g and a are not
equal so if g and a are not equal then
we take the maximum of these two values
and that's it that is going to fill up
the table for us and then we simply say
return
table we simply want the bottom right
element
we can simply say return table minus one
minus one so this is going to get that
last row last column and that's our
dynamic programming solution
let's do evaluate test cases here
okay turns on there's no i okay let's
just call this i
and j
turns out idx 1 is not defined
let's just make these i and j
now that we're doing this coding live
you can see that even after a decade of
coding i still make all of these
issues says the list a list index is out
of range it seems like i plus 1 and j
plus 1.
ah that's because remember we need an
additional row and an additional column
to track the case where either of the
strings is empty so we need to get range
n two plus one here
and we need to get range n one plus one
here okay that's why it helps to have
test cases so that you can fix all of
these issues now you have test k0 it
passes and test case 1 2 3 all of them
pass you can see that all test cases
have passed and you can also verify that
the amount of time it took is now lower
than the amount of time it took for
memoization
okay
and
so that's the dynamic programming
approach you simply create a table and
you fill out the table
sometimes just
working with indices within the table
can get confusing so it helps to work
with it on paper
and make it clear to yourself and then
write it in english that's why we've
written it in plain english here
and now an exercise for you is to verify
that the complexity of this dynamic
programming approach is order of n1
times n2 so which is the same as
memoization
and it's actually more straightforward
to see here because you have two for
loops
and then each of these for loops
you're simply doing a comparison and an
addition
and there's not even any recursion to
very
there's not even any recursion for you
to worry about
so you just do a comparison and you do
an addition or you take a maximum pretty
straightforward
so order of n1 times n2 and it does not
even
invoke an another function so it does
not take up too much memory it does not
take up too much time it's very very
efficient
and this is how you solve pretty much
every dynamic dynamic programming
problem
you write a recursive solution you come
up with the brute force solution and
keep in mind that recursion is
almost always
the way to go about creating a brute
force solution so you come up with a
recursive solution
and then you identify you draw the
recursion tree
and if you see that the same sub problem
is being called again and again
that is a point where you can introduce
memoization so you introduce memoization
and sometimes you can just write the
memoized solution and that's enough
because it's easy to reason about you
just put in a memo and you're done with
it um even the interviewer or
the coding assessment will accept that
solution
but in some cases you will be asked to
then remove the recursion and write it
as a in an iterative fashion and that is
when then you have to start drawing a
table and think about what are the rows
and columns in that table need to
represent so here
the i j element of the table represented
the first the first i elements of
sequence one and the first rj elements
of sequence two what is the longest
subsequence between them and we used
that to build the next row and the next
next column
and we then filled out the entire table
and we simply used the last value
now
again this is not very straightforward
uh how to come up with this and the way
you do that is by solving problems so if
you solve five to ten dynamic
programming problems you will get some
intuition about how to build the tables
and it's always very helpful to solve it
on pen and paper first especially with
dynamic programming so that it's clear
to you
what each element of the table
represents otherwise you may make a lot
of off by one errors like missing the
plus one here or missing the plus one
here
and get confused just like i did pretty
much
and that's the time the time complexity
is pretty straightforward in most cases
it is simply the size of the table but
sometimes you may have to do more than
constant work here so keep that in mind
see what it is that you're doing inside
your loop now inside of inside your loop
if you have to go back and check the
entire length of the string so that will
introduce another factor into the
equation so keep that in mind but in
most cases counting the iteration should
be good enough to give you an idea of
the time complexity
okay so that's the first problem and let
us just
commit this
and now it's saved
to my profile
if i just open this up here
you can see that now i have this
notebook called longest common
subsequences and i can share it online
whenever you work on a notebook it's
always a good idea to make it public put
it up on jovian all you need to do is
run jobin.com and share it online just
press the
share button and then you can share it
on twitter linkedin facebook or wherever
you like
so that's the first problem that we
looked at
now let's come back to lesson four
and uh by the way the problems that
we're talking about all the
problem statements the graphs the images
you can see them in the second link here
but we will once again open up the
problem solving template
and now we'll use it for the second
problem let me run this once again
and we're going to look at the second
problem which is the knapsack problem
so let's read the knapsack problem it's
also called the zero one knapsack
problem here's there are many variations
of this problem but here's one way to
state it
that you might come across
or something similar you are in charge
of selecting a football or a soccer team
from a large pool of players
and each player has a cost
and a rating so
there's a selection going on you have to
come up with a team for this year
and you have a large pool of players
each player has a cost and each player
has a rating
now you have a limited budget
so you need to build a team within the
budget so what is the highest total
rating of a team
that you can create
which fits within your budget okay so
this is the question here you have to
maximize the total rating
but fit it fit the total cost within
your budget so we have two variables
here rating and variables rating needs
to be maximized cost needs to be
simply optimized to the extent that it
fits in the budget and just a
simplifying assumption here is that you
can assume that there is no minimum or
maximum team size
this is simplification and later you can
introduce a criteria there as well that
you want to build a team of exactly 10
people and see if you can also solve
that problem in a way
so that's the knapsack problem let's
copy it over
and
here's a jupiter notebook a fresh
problem solving template
let's simply
change the title here
it is also called the zero one knapsack
problem because each item can either be
chosen
or not chosen
and let's give it a project name here
too
let's commit it
and let's paste the problem statement
here
okay
so that's the problem statement and this
is a specific or a special form
of
a more general problem statement and we
look at the general problem statement in
a second
we'll when we try to state the problem
clearly but here's once again the
systematic strategy will apply we will
state the problem clearly identify the
input and output formats come up with
some example inputs and outputs and try
to cover all the edge cases
then we will come up with a correct
solution for the problem and state the
solution in plain english it just has to
be simple correct solution not too
complex
then we apply the right technique to
overcome the inefficiency and then we
so we analyze the algorithm and identify
any inefficiencies after implementing
the solution and finally we apply the
right technique to overcome the
inefficiency and then repeat the process
of stating the solution implementing it
and analyzing it
so to state the problem clearly
what we can do is we can abstract out
the problem in more general terms and
that is what is stated here
and let's just grab that and we'll take
a look
so here we have we are given n elements
and each of which has a weight and a
profit
so you have n elements and here's the
profit of each element and here's the
weight you can of each element so you
need to determine the maximum profit
that can be obtained by selecting a
subset of the elements weighing no more
than a given weight w
so
you have a capacity a maximum capacity
let's say the maximum capacity is 15
and you have to select certain elements
so that you fill out
the total weight is no more than the
capacity and the total profit is
maximized
that's and this is why it's called the
knapsack problem it's assuming here you
have a bag or a knapsack with a capacity
of 15 kilograms and these are the
weights of the items and these are the
profits
now in this case you can see in this
example the optimal selection is
these four elements which have the
weights five
three two and five so that you fill up
the total capacity of 16 or 15
and
the of the solution on the maximum
profit that you can obtain is 7 plus 4
11 plus 5 16 plus 3 19. now you can try
other combinations and verify that this
is actually the best solution
do give it a shot
so what are the inputs here so we have
it's pretty clear we have an input
weights
so these are the weights of
the this is a list of
numbers
containing weights
and then you have profits
a list of numbers
containing profits
and this should have the same length as
weights
and then finally you have a capacity
the maximum
weight allowed
and there you go
and now we have outputs so now
the output would simply be the max
profit
so this is the
maximum profit
that can be obtained
by selecting elements
of total weight
no more than w or no more than capacity
okay
great so that gives us
a
pretty good starting point now we can
write a function signature here so we
write max let's say def max profit
and we can give it weights and we can
give it
profits and we can give it a capacity
and we pass
so now we have defined the problem we
have stated we have identified input and
output formats now we need to come up
with some example inputs and test cases
once again we have listed out a few test
cases here so we will have a few generic
test cases
where you have just a random set of
weights and profits and you identify the
knapsack the optimal solution then
here's one option where all of the
elements can be included
you can take everything here's another
option where none of the elements can be
included
you have to think about all these
scenarios
here's one where only one of the
elements can be included then you may
also think about areas where
you do not use the complete capacity
okay you do not use the complete
capacity
because the optimal solution is actually
taking a lower capacity so there may be
a way to fill out to capacity but that
may have a lower profit
than another option which takes less
than the complete capacity but has a
higher profit so think about some cases
here
think about some good test cases here
and
i will just copy over these for now
and then what we'll do is we will
express these test cases once again as
dictionaries so you have test 0 test 1
s2 all of these expressed are
dictionaries and these are covering all
the test cases that are mentioned here
you can see here are some weights and
some profits and the capacity is 165 and
then the optimal solution is 309 now we
are simply asking here for the optimal
solution the maximum
profit that can be obtained but an
extension of this problem is to identify
which are the elements that should be
chosen
and it's a simple extension it's a good
exercise for you to try out and you can
discuss it in the forums
we have test zero test one test two
test three and four and five so we have
a total of six six test cases let's copy
over these test cases here
and let's put them here into a single
string and that gives us the test cases
okay
now
coming up with the solution
so once again the first step is to try
and come up with a recursive solution
and a recursive solution is again quite
straightforward we'll write a recursive
function
max profit
that given an index so this time we have
just one sequence so given an index
within the sequence so let's say our
index idx
it computes
the maximum profit that can be obtained
using the elements from idx onwards so
31547 using all of these elements idx
onwards
the maximum profit that can be obtained
right and
using a given capacity
so it will take an index
so it will take an index and a capacity
so if let's say the idx is one so it
will then look at just these elements
and if the capacity is 10 so it will try
to fill the capacity of 10
and that's a recursive function and why
are we creating a recursive function
like this
there's a simple reason now suppose idx
has the value 1 and the capacity is 10
or let's say the capacity is 3
then the weight of this element is
greater than the capacity so that means
it cannot show up
it cannot be selected because it cannot
fit inside the bag the knapsack that we
have so then
the solution for
this sub problem with idx equal to 1 and
capacity equal to 3
is same as the solution for this sub
problem with this element removed
because you cannot include this element
within the knapsack right so if you
remove this element and simply consider
these elements
the remaining elements which essentially
means idx plus one
so max profit of idx plus one
profit uh of weights idx 1 profits idx 1
and capacity
is the answer for max profit of weights
idx profits idx and capacity because the
current weight 5 is greater than the
capacity 3 which is which the recursive
function has been invoked with so that's
one option but the more general case is
that you have enough capacity so let's
say you have a capacity of 10 recursion
was called with a capacity of 10 and you
are at idx 1 so then you have two
choices
either you include this element in your
knapsack or you do not include this
element in your option because you don't
know whether the optimal solution will
have this element or not so you try both
so there are two possibilities we either
pick weights idx this element or we
don't
and what we can do is we can simply
compute the result in both cases and
pick the maximum
so if we don't pick weights idx
then once again
if we don't pick this element so the
capacity remains the same let's say the
capacity was 10 so we simply try out to
fill out the capacity of 10 using the
remaining elements so we simply call max
profit with weights idx plus 1
profits idx plus 1 onwards and the
remaining capacity which is 10
but if we do pick the element
if we pick the element and we had a
capacity of 10
then the optimal then the
solution the best solution in this case
will have a profit 3 more than the
solution for this case
and since we also used of some capacity
so we need to
add 3 in the profit and we need to
subtract 5 from the capacity right
so if we pick weights idx then the
maximum profit for this case is profits
of idx plus
max profit of weights idx plus 1 onwards
profits idx plus on onwards but because
we've used up some capacity we reduce
the capacity in the recursive call okay
and that is why a recursive call takes
both an index and a capacity
okay i hope that makes sense
so here's a recursive tree that tells
you the same thing we started the first
index and we we have the capacity and if
we don't pick the first element then we
sim the answer is simply
the
to the best solution for second index
onwards with the same capacity if we do
pick the first element then the answer
is the second solution onwards
with the reduced capacity with the
profit added okay
and then we simply take the maximum of
these two cases so we call these two
recursive calls and then we simply take
the maximum of these two cases to get
back
the final result or the final best
answer
and the final end case is that if we've
reached the end if weights idx onwards
is empty if the index that we're
tracking has reached the very end then
irrespective of what the capacity is the
maximum profit is in that case is zero
so let's try and implement this now
let's copy this over
as the explanation
and let's try and implement the solution
let's say let's call it max profit
recursive
and this is going to take a set of
weights it is going to take a set of
profits and it is going to take a
capacity and is also going to take an
index which the index will start out at
zero
so now if the index is we start with the
base case so if i dx
equals the length of weights
in this case there's nothing left to do
we simply return 0 because we don't have
any more elements
then we check
if the weights idx
is so the current element is greater in
weight than the capacity
then it's a pretty straightforward
solution we simply return
max profit
recursive
of
weights
profits
capacity plus one
sorry capacity and idx 1.
so we simply ignore this element because
we cannot fit it in the capacity that we
have
else we have two options
we have option one option one is even
though it can fit within the bag
we don't take it we every because the
optimal solution may still not have it
just because it fits does not mean we
should take it so we look at the option
one which is once again the same as this
where we ignore this element and then we
have we look at option two
in option 2 we actually put this element
into the bag so since we are putting
this element into the bag then we get we
get profit from it so we get profits of
idx
and then we call max
profits recursive
and this time we call it with weights
and profits
and now the capacity has reduced a
little bit
because we have taken this element so
now we can now we need to fill the
remaining
we fill the need to fill the bag with
the remaining elements from idx plus one
onwards with a limited capacity of
capacity minus weights of idx
and then finally we just put in idx 1 so
that we can start calculating the
solution from the next element onwards
so that's max profit recursive
again not very difficult it is just
about
six seven lines of code
and let's try it out here's test zero
let's try max profit recursive
with test zero
input
and we need to get weights capacity and
profit all of these out of it the simple
way to do that is simply to put in star
star and we'll get back all of these
will get passed in
capacity will get passed as a capacity
parameter in weights will get passed
against the weights parameter and
profits as the profits parameter
okay so we've encountered an error and
that's completely fine
completely fine to encounter an error
i see so what we've done here is uh we
have not really taken the maximum of
these two we've just defined the two
options so we do need to take max of
option one
and option two okay once again this is
why helping test having test cases helps
and you can see that now we call max
profit
and we can also add a timer here so max
profit it takes 210 micro seconds but it
result it returns a result 309
great we get back the result 309 here
which is what we expected
so our function is working correctly we
can even evaluate it on all the test
cases so
from joven dot python dsa
we import
evaluate
test cases
and then we simply call evaluate test
cases
on all the inputs so we pass in
max profit
recursive
and then we pass in all the test cases
as tests
now you can see that we have these test
cases and each test case seems to be
passing just fine all six x test cases
have passed and these are the times they
took
so that's your recursive solution pretty
straightforward once you reason it out
once you
maybe just
look at an example draw a tree of
recursion yourself work it out on paper
the code is in fact in most cases fairly
simple
and this is what the recursion tree
looks like each time we make a choice to
either include the element or not
include the element and now you can
reason the complexity very easily
because now we have n elements for each
one we keep making this choice so that
means we end up with 2 to the power n
leaves
and from there it follows that
the complexity of the recursive
algorithm is order of 2 to the power n
right so it could be 2 times or c times
2 to the power n but
and in the bigger notation it's order of
2 to the power of n so it is exponential
and complexity and why is it exponential
complexity once again there are it's a
possibility here that we may be
computing a lot of things repeatedly
because we are creating so many of these
sub problems
so it's possible that we may be creating
we may be
recomputing a lot of data here so now
the
task for you or the an exercise for you
is to write the memoized version of this
so what is it that you need to memoize
now the trick here is to look at what is
changing within the recursive calls so
now in max profit recursive
you can see that weights and profits
remains the same but it's the capacity
and the idx that change so you can take
the capacity comma the index the idx as
the key in your memoization dictionary
and each time you compute so each time
let's say you compute this or you
compute this or you compute this
store the result in the dictionary
before returning it and then at the
beginning of the recursive function
check within the dictionary
if this value is already present okay so
remember what we did for longest common
subsequence we defined a recursive
function internally we defined a memo a
dictionary internally
and the recursive function kept either
checking the dictionary or filling the
dictionary if it could not find a value
and that could eliminate a lot of the
repeated work
in your problem okay so that's the
challenge for you to try out implement
the memoize solution
and what we'll do is we will go ahead
and we will
implement the dynamic programming
solution so let's just commit our work
once again and we've analyzed the
algorithms complexity in recursion it's
order 2 to the power of n
in memoization now that's an exercise
for you what do you think the complexity
will be
well let's apply dynamic programming so
let's look at a dynamic programming
solution
now once again for dynamic programming
you have to create a table you always
almost always have to create a table for
dynamic programming and in this case
we can see that there are n elements so
there are n rows within the table
because we have n elements to choose
from
and we we have a number of columns going
from zero to capacity plus one going
from zero to capacity and that's why
there are total of capacity plus one
columns
and in fact what we can do is we can
also include another column at the top
here another row at the top here
which we have not which is not shown
here
but what n represents
n is the number of elements so what n
represents or or what the a particular
element in the table represents so table
of i comma c what it represents is
the maximum profit that can be obtained
using the first i elements if the
maximum capacity is c
so if your maximum capacity is c
let's say your maximum capacity is three
what is the maximum profit that you can
obtain using the first
two elements so um here let's say we are
at this position so using the first two
elements
of the list
within this capacity okay so the first
two elements have weights one and two
and the capacity is three
so you can
you can actually pick uh sorry the first
two elements are weights two and three
and the capacity is three so you either
pick this element or pick this element
now if you pick this element the profit
is one and if if you pick this element
the profit is two so the solution is to
pick this element and you get
uh
you fill the capacity three and you get
a profit of two you cannot pick both
because your capacity is three okay so
that's the logic here
a very simple visual representation now
remember that there will also be a zero
throw here which we have not shown
but this is something that should be
here another zeroth row so the zeroth
row represents that you've not picked
any of the elements and if you don't
pick any of the elements it is simply
going to contain all zeros and that's
why it's not shown here the first row
assumes that you have picked you can
pick only the first element so you can
you you can't pick the first element
till a capacity of two and then from a
capacity of two onwards you pick the
first element and that has a maximum
capacity
of one
the maximum profit of one the second row
or the row number two
with row with index two represents the
fact that you can pick both of these
elements
and if you can pick both of these
elements once again at capacity 0 none
of them can be picked at capacity 1 none
of them can be picked at capacity 2 this
element can be picked which has a weight
2 and it gives you a maximum profit of
one at capacity three
this element can also be picked so now
you have a choice to pick between the
two of these so you might as well better
pick this one
because this is going to give you higher
profit and then finally when the
capacity becomes 5 you can pick both of
these elements
and you can pick both of these elements
and that is going to give you a profit
of 2 plus 1 3 and so on so you keep
filling out this table for each
step here or for each
set of first i elements you fill out the
capacity table and then you use the
information to fill out the next row and
the next column and so on
okay and finally your what we need is
using all the elements
and using the maximum capacity that we
have what is the maximum profit that we
can obtain so the last element of the
table will give you the result okay
so what does the logic look like we will
fill the table row by row and column by
column now if table of i comma c
table of i comma c
let's say this is a certain position
here table of i comma c
can be filled using some values in the
row above it okay now if you look at the
table of i comma c you you look at
look at this element for example
yeah let's look at this element here
so in here c has the value 3
and then i has the value 0 which is a
row that is not shown 1 2 3 4. so i has
the value 4
and c has the value 3.
so if
yeah so if weights of i
is greater than c
so zero one two three four uh if though
if this if this weight so this weight
the weight of this element is greater
than the capacity so the weight of this
element is 4 it is greater than the
capacity
then
this element cannot show up
in this maximum profit
why because its weight is greater than
the capacity so obviously it cannot show
up in the maximum profit now if it
cannot show up in the maximum profit
then the then this cell can be filled
using the value above it because in any
case you cannot put in this element so
you might as well get the result by
using the first three elements and in
that case the
value of this cell is obtained from the
value of the cell above it
that's one case now on the other hand
let's come here you come to this case
into this cell in
to fill this cell because you have a
capacity of 4
you have the option of either choosing
this element or of not choosing this
element
now if you do choose this element let's
say you choose this element with a
capacity of 4
with a capacity of 4 you get back a
profit of 9
and now you have no more capacity left
to create more to fill more elements
on the other hand if you do not choose
this element
then that's the same as this value
because if you do not choose this
element then you have to fill the
capacity of 4 using the value of
using the first three elements
and that simply gives you
the same highest profit as the previous
cell right so you just consider these
two cases whether we choose the element
or we do not choose the element now if
if you do not choose the element the
value comes from above if you choose the
element then the value comes from
where let's see
if you choose the element the profit of
9 comes and you fill out the capacity 4
so you have no remaining capacity but on
the other hand if the capacity was 6 and
you choose the element
then you have chosen the element and
you've used up the capacity 4 so you can
still use the previous three elements to
fill the remaining capacity which is
six minus four so which is your capacity
of two so you can go back to the
previous row and check the capacity two
and see how much was the maximum profit
that you can obtain with capacity 2
and it turns out that with capacity 2
using the first 3 elements you can
obtain a maximum profit of 1. so the
maximum profit here when you choose the
element is 9 plus 1 n
similarly here a maximum profit that can
be obtained if you choose the element is
plus 7 minus plus from the previous row
you pick the element with a capacity 7
minus 4 which is 3 so 9 plus 5 14
okay so that's the logic here
sometimes you choose the element
sometimes you don't choose the element
and in fact the solute the result of
this cell is simply the maximum of
either not choosing the elements the
maximum of this cell or choosing the
element and subtracting the weight which
is
six minus four two
so
maximum of this and that okay
so let's implement this same dynamic
programming solution
once again do work this out on paper it
really helps to work it out in paper but
let's say
we have
max profit
dp the dynamic programming solution we
have weights we have profits and we have
a capacity
and then let's say n is len weights
so we need to create a
table
so this is our table
our table contains
n rows so we have len n and then in for
each of the rows
we contain we have
capacity plus one
oh we contain n plus one rows remember
we also want to consider the case where
we don't consider where we don't take
any of the elements
and it is filled with zeros and the
number of columns is capacity plus one
to check the values from zero to
capacity so that's our table right now
you can check what this capacity looks
like let's say n has n capacity
i have the values here n in this case is
5 and capacity is 10.
we don't need a len here
you don't need a len here as well
it's all perfectly natural
to make these mistakes
this should be range not len
this should be a range and
this should be arranged too
yeah now you can see that we have
created n rows
or n plus one rows so one for each of
these and then one more row above
containing all which will contain all
zeros this is in the case where we don't
pick any of the elements and then we've
created 11 columns so this is for
capacity zero so again the first column
will also contain all zeros and this is
something that you will often see in
dynamic programming you will have an
additional row at the beginning or at
the end containing all zeros and that is
simply to
make your calculations or computations
easier but what that will lead to is off
by one error so you need to be very
careful while doing this
and now we'll fill out this value using
either this value
or by subtracting the weight of the
element that's here
and getting a value from the previous
row
so now we start iterating so when now we
say for
i in
range
n
and for j in range c
let's just say for c in range capacity
it should be capacity
table of i comma c
and it's actually going to be i plus 1
and c plus 1 because we have these
additional rows and columns
table of i plus 1 comma c plus 1 is
there are two cases here if
weights of i
is greater than c the current capacity
then we can simply
look at the previous row so which is
this case
let's say
the weight 3 is greater than the current
capacity 2.
so then we simply
copy over the value from the previous
row
the same column so we just say table of
i
comma c plus one we see
so our capacity should go from the value
of 1 because we don't want to affect the
first column so the capacity goes from
the value of 1 to a value of 10.
so capacity c goes from the range of 1
to capacity
and if the weights i is greater than the
capacity then we cannot fill the table
on the other hand
if it is
if it fits within the capacity then we
have two options
the table of i plus one comma c has two
options
so one is we
don't use the current element we don't
use the current element and that gives
us stable ic once again the other option
is we use the current element so we get
profit from the current element so
profits i
but we do not get profits
but
that reduces the capacity so we then
have to pick
table of
i
but now we have to pick c minus
weight
weights of i
okay
and that should fill out the entire
table pretty much
that's a nice thing about dynamic
programming you simply just have to
write this one solution or this one
recurrence and be careful about it and
everything else is taken care of by this
loop here
now we simply return table of
minus one
and minus one
and let's see if that works
it's likely that there are some issues
here but let's see we have test cases
max profit dp
with the tests that we have
great so we are seeing an issue already
i see here that
this should be range
and this should be range
okay one thing that we haven't done here
is
well it seems like our solution is
always zero
ah this should be capacity plus one so
that we this takes all the values from
zero to capacity right so c the iterator
should take the values from one two
three four all the way up to the maximum
capacity and the range does not end so
the range does not include the end value
so you need to put capacity plus one
here
okay now with that out of the way
you see once again these off by one
errors are always going to bug you with
dynamic programming
i've probably solved
50 or 100 problems in dynamic
programming but i still make these
errors
but with that out of the way you can see
now that each of the test cases seems to
pass
now there may be other cases which you
have not accounted for but overall we've
covered all the test cases here and
we've ended up with now a dynamic
programming solution
and i'll let you figure out the
complexity here but once again it's
pretty straightforward
because we are filling up this table and
filling up this table simply requires
this constant amount of work which is a
comparison and then potentially
another comparison and an
addition and a subtraction so like four
or five operations
so you have this n times and uh you have
this n times
capacit n times capacity
where n is the length of weights and
capacitor or w is a total capacity so n
times w is the
number of iterations and that really
also is the
complexity the time complexity of the
algorithm
so that's the knapsack problem
and now what you can do is try and
figure out not just what is the maximum
value but also figure out what are the
actual elements that were chosen now you
can do this for the knapsack problem and
you can do this for the longest
subsequence problem figure out the
actual longest subsequence and it should
be possible to do that with just a small
modification now use the forum
if you have any questions
about the contents of this lecture go
back to
the lesson page and open up the course
community forum here
you can see here that
this is the lesson for recursion and
dynamic programming lesson you can post
your question here and you can also
discuss ideas on how to figure out what
the longest common subsequence is and
what the best selection for the knapsack
problem is so what do you do next well
you can review the lecture video and
execute the jupyter notebook the next
step is also to complete the assignment
now
we have released assignments one and two
so far
if you go back on the lesson page
you will find lessons you will find
assignments one and two and you can work
on them there is sufficient time
and also work on optional questions and
do participate in forum discussions and
or if possible join or start a study
group too
that's a great way to stay motivated
this was lesson 4 of data structures and
algorithms in python
thanks and talk to you soon
hello and welcome to data structures and
algorithms in python this is an online
certification course being conducted by
jovian
today we are on lesson five graph
algorithms like bfs dfs and shortest
paths
my name is akash and i am your
instructor
you can find me on twitter on akashens
if you follow along with this course and
complete all the assignments and build a
course project you can earn a verified
certificate of accomplishment for this
course
so with that let's get started the first
thing we'll do is go to the course
website pythondsa.com
now you can point your browser to
pythondsa.com to open up the course page
and on the course page you can enroll
for the course and you can view all the
previous lessons and assignments
so do check it out and do check out the
course project as well but for now we'll
open up lesson 5 graph algorithms
now on this page you can watch a video
for the lesson later the same video that
you're watching right now
and you can also catch a hindi version
if you wish
and here is the code that we are going
to use today the
first notebook under the heading
notebooks
so let's open it up
and this is a jupiter notebook hosted on
jovian
you should be familiar with it by now
but
here you can see that there are some
explanations and then there are some
code cells where we can write some code
you can see that there's some code here
now to actually execute and edit this
code we will need to run this notebook
you can find the instructions to run the
notebook right here but the simplest way
to do it is to click run
and select run on
binder now this will take a second or
two but this will take your jupiter
notebook and create a new machine in the
cloud and send your jupyter notebook to
that machine for execution this is a
free service
that you can access via jovian
you can also run this notebook on your
own computer directly if you wish so for
that you can check the run locally
option here
okay
so our jupyter notebook server is now
ready so we can now start editing and
writing some code
let's just go full screen here
okay so the topic today is graph
algorithms bfs dfs and shortest paths
using python
now before we talk about graph
algorithms let's just
try to understand intuitively what
graphs are now here's an example of a
graph in the real world
so this is the railway map of india you
can see here all the train stations that
you have in india
they're represented using these black
dots
points they're also labeled so each
train station points to a city or a
village
so all these are also labeled
and then you can see connections between
these stations so these are as you might
guess railway lines and you see that
there are
three or four colors involved so these
colors could represent different types
of railway lines like different gauge
meter gauge broad gauge etc or these
could represent different zones
so there's some information contained in
the connections as well now another
important thing is that each railway
line between two cities will also have a
certain length
so that's what a graph is roughly and
the kind of questions that you may want
to ask here is for example
is there a path from new delhi
to
hyderabad
so
given this information first of all the
question is how do you even represent
all this information how because you
have so many railway lines connections
between different cities so many
hundreds of cities how do you even
represent this so that you can start
writing algorithms to answer these
questions right so if you're building a
search
a trained search website
then you would have to answer given new
delhi and hyderabad is there is there a
way to get from new delhi to hyderabad
okay that's the first question that you
might ask now if there is a way then the
next question might be that what is the
path
with the shortest number of stops
so
do you go this way for the shortest
number of stops or do you go this way or
do you go this way another question
could be what is the path with the
shortest distance right so sometimes
if you measure the distance and if you
measure the number of stations the
number of stops they may be different
along different paths and one may be
greater than the other
in in certain cases
so those are the kind of questions that
we want to ask and answer today
or another question could be what are
all the stations reachable from new
delhi within one stop or two stops or
three stops or ten stops
so those are the kind of questions we'll
try and answer and for that we need a
way to represent graphs
in a more abstract fashion because this
same question can be asked in a
different context for instance here we
are looking at flight routes
international flight routes now once
again you can ask the exact same thing
here is there a way to get from
new delhi to
vancouver
now if there is then how many stops will
that require
what is the minimum number of stops we
can take to get from new delhi to
vancouver or what is the minimum time it
might take maybe if you you're okay with
taking multiple stops but you want to
minimize the
the the time taken or the distance
traveled because you're concerned with
the miles or for some reason
another thing you could ask is what is
the minimum cost if there is a cost
along each route okay
now here's one more example from a very
different domain this is hyperlinks or
the internet essentially so you can see
here here you have a whole bunch of
websites
and you have links on websites now links
on websites point to other websites and
in this case it is a one-way connection
you can see that from this particular
course website we have a link to ibm but
from ibm you may not have a link to this
course website now that's an interesting
thing that's a slight variation here and
this is called a directed graph because
each
connection here
is
has a particular direction
now this is again interesting to ask
is there a way to navigate from
cs.umass.edu
to ithaca weather
if there is what is the shortest way
what do what does that path look like so
those are the kind of questions that we
want to answer today
and to do that we will need a more
abstract representation of graphs and we
start with the simplest possible
representation where you have certain
points or what we will call nodes or
vertices so these are two terms that are
used for these points so nodes or
vertices
a graph has certain nodes or vertices
and just to make things easy
these could be cities or these could be
web pages or these could be something
else but just to make things easy what
we'll do is we will number the nodes so
in our graph if we have
10 nodes then we will number the nodes
from 0 to 9. okay this is and they can
be numbered completely arbitrarily
there's no reason to name number the 0
number this one what's more important is
that we should use up all the
all the numbers from 0 to n minus 1 if
we're dealing with n nodes
now why do we do that we'll see in a
moment when we try to represent graphs
using certain data structures like
adjacence adjacency list etc but we want
to number our nodes from 0 to n minus 1
and this number is arbitrary this 1
doesn't represent anything in the sense
that 1 being greater than 0 or so on
okay
so these nodes have labels
and then
you have edges between nodes so an edge
is simply a pair
an edge is simply something
like
1 comma 2. so a pair 1 comma 2 tells you
that there is an edge between the node
one and node two okay now
as we move forward we will also store
some information within an edge and we
will call that weight of an edge and we
will also later look at directed edges
and those will get us directed graphs
but let's start with this
and let's see how we can now represent
with this basic structure how we can
represent
a graph so we can represent a graph
using two
variables so one is called a number of
nodes and the number of nodes is in this
case
and then we can represent
the edges using a list of pairs
so in this case the pairs are
zero comma one
in this case the pairs are zero comma
one that's an edge then zero comma four
that's an edge too
then we have
1 comma 2 so 1 is connected to 2 and the
edge in this case is bi-directional so
when we are saying 0 comma 1 we're
saying it automatically says that 1 and
0 are also connected
right
so 1 comma 2 and then we have 2 comma 3
and which order we write these in
doesn't matter we could have just
written 3 comma 2 here as well
or we also have 1 comma 3
and then we have one comma four
great
and then finally
we have
three comma four okay so this is how we
represent this data structure which what
we've drawn here is now represented in
code using these two variables and we
can check here
if we simply print the number of nodes
and the length of edges
we can verify if this
is roughly correct so you see we have
five nodes and we have one two three
four five six seven edges okay seems
right to me we could there may be a
mistake here but roughly
uh we have set things up correctly okay
now the question becomes
is this question is this representation
good enough now this representation is
good enough if you want to convey the
structure of a graph to someone i could
give you these two variables and then
without showing you this image and you
could use this information to draw the
graph on a piece of paper so this
representation is complete it provides
all the information about the graph but
it may not be efficient for example if
you want to find out which nodes
the node 1 is connected to we would have
to iterate over the entire list of edges
we would have to go through this one and
then check if either of these is one and
check if either of these is one and so
on
so that makes it very tricky to
access any information efficiently
rather it'll be much nicer to just look
at a list of nodes that one is connected
to in some way and go from there now if
you want to find the shortest path we
would first have to find all the nodes
that one is connected to and then for
each of those we would have to find
their neighbors and then for each of
those we would find have to find their
neighbors and so on so it would get
pretty
tedious to go through the list so many
times
that's why and by the way
by a neighbor we represent we mean two
nodes that are connected by an edge so
zero and one are neighbors but zero and
two are not neighbors okay so that's a
very simple nomenclature that we can use
and
what we can say is if we track the path
we say 0 1 2 and then if there is an
edge between both of them we say that 0
1 2 is a path
so 0 1 2 in this case is a path
but 3
zero one is not a path because there is
no path but there's no edge between
three and zero okay and we'll see what
what we mean by paths and neighbors and
so on in some time
but
to
work with graphs more efficiently we
will represent them using what's called
an adjacency list now
the name it explains what it contains
so the adjacency list contains a list
for each node
and it contains a list of all the nodes
that are adjacent to that node now again
adjacency is the same as an adjacent is
same as neighbor so if for each node so
for example for the node 0 we we
maintain a list and that list contains
the numbers one and four indicating that
zero is adjacent to or zero is a
neighbor of or zero is connected via a
direct edge to one and four so that's
why you have one and four here and then
one is connected to zero two three and
four you can see that one is connected
to zero two three and four
similarly two is connected to one and
three three is connected to one two four
and four is connected to 0 1 3. now this
is more convenient for sure one because
since this is an uh this is a list
if you want to find
let's say which nodes 2 is connected to
we can directly access the index 2
within the list
and this is why we number the vertices
or the number of the nodes from 0 to n
minus 1 so that we can access them
directly
in an adjacency list right so we
directly access the number stored next
to 2 and so we have one and three here
so that's what makes it convenient and
one important thing to notice here is
that edges each edge goes twice so the
edge zero one shows up in the list for
zero so you can see here in the list for
zero we have one
and similarly in the list for one we
have zero
so each edge shows up in two adjacency
list
of each of the nodes
that it connects okay
so now
the obvious next question might be to
create a class to represent a graph as
an adjacency list in python okay
this is again a question that you might
get asked a step or this might be part
of another question that you may get
asked where you're asked to perform a
breadth first search or depth first
search or find the shortest path but the
first step you will have to do is define
a class for a graph
to maintain the information about the
graph as the adjacency list okay so here
we're creating a class graph and the
first thing we'll need inside the graph
is
a constructor function
so we need to put something inside the
constructor function and we know that
the first argument to any graph any
class method in python is self which
represents the object that will get
created ultimately when we
create an object of the class
but apart from this what information do
you need to create a graph
now it's
pretty straightforward we can simply
work with this information because these
two variables together
specify the graph completely
so let's simply accept num nodes and a
list of edges
as the information
the first thing we can do is simply
store num nodes in self.num nodes so
that once we create a graph we can
access the number of nodes very easily
then we need to create the adjacency
list
so we need to create the adjacency list
we'll call it
self.data and
initially we will create a list
containing empty lists because
and then we will fill out the empty list
step by step so what we need is
something like this in this case because
there are
five
because there are five nodes
so this is what we need to create
the five empty lists now in general
the way to create
repeated elements is this you can
say
if you want to create a repeated element
like this 0 times
you type 0 times 10 and that gives you
this list
0 0 or containing all zeros
on the other hand if you create empty
list times 10 and let's call this l1
and let's see what l1 is
it looks like you've gotten an empty
list you've got in a list containing 10
empty lists but let's just go into the
first element so the first element is
this first empty list and inside the
first element let us add the value one
okay and then let's look at the let's
look at the list l1 once again
and you see what happens
this one gets inserted into all of these
lists now what's the problem here now
the problem here is that when we do this
when we create a list containing an
empty list or containing any object then
the same object gets replicated 10 times
but python does not create copies
now when you're working with numbers
it's fine because when you're working
with let's say the number zero
that's fine because
there's no internal structure inside
zero right so there's nothing you can
change inside the zero it's a fixed
value fixed immutable value
so what so you can you can't really say
l one of zero and change its value
internally what you can do is you can
set l one of zero to another value let's
say you can set l1 of zero to one
so instead of getting all zeros you get
all ones but you cannot take this take
the zero and change something inside it
on the other hand when you have an empty
list here
so this is the same list that is showing
up in 10 different showing up 10
different times each of the each of the
elements in the list
outer list is simply a pointer to this
same empty list so what we can do is we
can go inside this empty list and append
something to it so since this is the
same object that we are seeing over and
over
the one gets appended to the first list
and because the rest of them are the
same object we get back all once inside
here okay so this is a com the reason
we're spending time here is because
there's a common
common bug that you may unintentionally
execute whenever you want to create an
list of empty lists do not use this
method so what's the method you should
use then
so here's one method you can use let's
say you want to create a list
of empty list of size 10
so you may be familiar with this
object this
this object called range this function
called range what this does
is if you view it as a list you can see
that it contains all the elements from 0
to 9. okay now if you view the range
itself it simply shows you 0 to 10 but
when you convert it into a list you can
see that internally it contains the
value zero to nine
okay so you can take this range
and you can do something like this put
this range or put anything which is
iterable inside these brackets
the list brackets and then say for x in
range
and simply put x
so what did that do that did practically
nothing we simply took x from the range
of 0 to 10
and returned x itself so we created a
new list
like this but suppose we multiplied it
by two here x by two so for each element
in the range we are multiplying it by
two so we get back a new list which is
zero two four six eight so this is each
element is the double of the elements
that we have in the range
now what we need is we need
just empty lists right so we can simply
put an empty list here and we can ignore
this value x that we get here so now we
get back a whole bunch of empty lists so
let's call this l2
and what we are now doing is for each
element in the range we are creating a
new empty list so this is important so
now when you do
l2 0
dot append 1
and then check l2
you can see that one was only inserted
inside the first list
so keep keep out watch out for this
this is something that you will
probably go wrong with at some point
i've gone wrong many times
and one last change we can make here is
whenever you're not using a variable in
python it's always a good idea to just
call it underscore you can still call it
x but your sometimes
somebody reading your code may not
understand
why you have declared a variable and not
used it and assume that maybe you've
made a mistake so just to make things
very clear it's always a good idea to
make something underscore it's also a
variable name a valid name and mark
something is underscore if it is not
being used
okay
so with that whole discussion about
lists we now know how to create a list
of empty lists
so here you have a list of empty lists
or underscore in
range num nodes so now we have created a
list of empty lists then
for each edge
in edges
we need to do something so we need to
insert it
into the right lists
okay
now what does for edge and edges look
like so let's see for edge in edges
print
edge okay each edge is a pair we already
know that and when you have pairs or
tuples here
you can get them get the values out so
let's say let's call them n1 and n2 node
1 and node 2. you can get the values n 1
and n 2 out like this so now we can say
print n 1 and print n 2.
you can see that we are able to get
values n1 and 2 out directly within the
for loop so let's call this n1 and n2
and now this is a much more pythonic way
of writing code so one of the things
that we are also learning is how to
write code which is more pythonic or
which is idiomatic in python and this is
again something that will
impress people when you use it in an
interview or a coding challenge
so for n1 and n2 in edges
what we need to do is
first we get self data of n1 so this
gives us the adjacency list for n1 the
first node
and here we append the value n2
and similarly we do the same for n2
and we append n1 to it and that's it now
we've set up the graph
let's create a graph g1
let's call this graph 1 maybe
and
we simply invoke the graph function
and then we give it a number of nodes
and the edges right so remember self
will be passed in by python
automatically as the object that is
getting created
so the graph one object essentially so
now the number of nodes is five and we
have a list of edges
and let's see what graph1.data looks
like
so there you go you can see that zero is
connected to one and four
and one is connected to zero two three
four and so on now while this is okay it
would be nicer to print it
like this
so maybe let's see if we can print it
and the way to do that
is to define a wrapper function so we
define a function called underscore
underscore repr
and it contains
it simply takes self as the input
and what we are going to do is
we are going to
go over
we're going to call
enumerate
on self.data now what does that give us
let's just check what enumerate on
self.data give us gives us
well maybe before we do that let's see
what enumerate on a list gives us
enumerate on a list
gives us this object but let's just get
the value out of it in a for loop
because you can use an enumerate in a
for loop and just print x
so what enumerate gives us is
it gives us the values from the list but
apart from those values it also gives us
indices okay so you can get an index
i
and a value v out of enumerate so then
you can see that you can print both i
and v here
and you will get back the same
output
so what we can say is we can do
enumerate self.data now because
self.data contains these elements so
what we'll get back is we'll get back
pairs
let's see here
we'll get back pairs 0 comma 1 4 1 comma
0 2 3 4 2 comma 2 1 3 now this is
starting to look a lot like what we want
okay so we'll just take enumerate self
data and these we'll take these pairs so
the pairs will be
a node so node n
and its
neighbors
the so we have the node n so the node n
will first be 0 and its neighbors will
be 1 and 4 node n will be 1 and its
neighbor will be 1 and 2 and so on
and then
so for n comma neighbors in enumerate
what we'll do is we simply create a
simple string
and here we are using string formatting
we are simply creating this string
where
we put this
here we place a placeholder where we put
n and then here we put a placeholder
where we put neighbors
again let's just see what that looks
like
and this is the best thing about jupiter
while you're writing code you can test
your code right then and there simply by
creating putting data into a new into a
new cell so let's see graph1.data
so you can see here that now we have now
we have converted that enumerated list
into a list of strings so we have a
string here this is the string 0
pointing to one comma four this is a
string one
point this one pointing to zero two
three four and so on but this is still a
list of strings what we need to return
from the wrapper function
is a single string
so the way to join them together
whenever you have a list of strings and
you want to join them together all you
need to do is
you say what you want to join them with
so we want to join them with a new line
and then call the join function on that
string
and return that right so that is our
wrapper function and we'll see its users
in just a moment and similarly we have
another function called str
now wrapper is used when we simply type
graph one
so when we type graph one this is the
output of the default wrapper function
now this will get replaced by the
wrapper function that we are defining
but when we do str of graph one or when
we do print of graph one or when we
insert graph1 into string that is when
the str function is used
now we will simply use the wrapper
representation so let's just put self
dot underscore underscore rdpr
and that's it
okay so let's see now let's put let's
type graph one here and you can see that
now we have this representation printed
using this wrapper function that we've
defined
so we have zero one four one zero two
three four two connected to one three
three connected to one two four and four
connected to zero one and three
okay so now we have a graph data
structure that we've implemented using a
class so the adjacency list and we have
a nice way to print it out
and this is just good programming
practice now you don't have to do this
in a coding competition or you don't
have to do this it's good if you do it
in an interview if let's say you're able
to type this out quickly but when you
are working
when you are working on your own
problems or on your own code or on a
project always make sure that any
classes you define have a good string
representation so that when you type the
name of a variable you understand what
it represents and you don't have to
spend time thinking about it make it
clear to yourself okay
so that's the adjacency list and we'll
see how that is useful in just a few
moments
but here are a couple of questions for
you try writing a function to add an
edge to a graph that is represented as
an adjacency list okay so here we've
specified all the edges right in the
beginning but can you write a function
add edge which takes
a couple of nodes and it inserts an edge
between those two nodes and here's a
hint this code might be useful
so do try that out
now here's another one can you write a
function to remove an edge from a graph
which is represented as an adjacency
list
here you may have to use the list remove
functions to remove a particular element
from a list but these are two good
exercises to
complete here okay
now before we continue let's just save
our work
and
we know that this notebook is running on
binder which is a free service
so we'll just save our work by running
jovian.commit and what that will do is
that will capture a snapshot of this
notebook all the changes that you've
made and put this on your jovian profile
now this will go on your jovian profile
from where you can continue running it
continue executing it from where you
have left off okay
now another common representation for
graphs is called the adjacency matrix
which is slightly different from
adjacency lists in this case for example
the same graph here is represented using
this matrix so what we do is we create a
matrix of size n by n if n is the number
of
if n is the number of nodes in the graph
and then for each node
for instance since we have
zero and since we have a edge between
one and two
so
if you take the first row row number one
and column number two you put a one
there
otherwise if there's no edge for example
there's no edge between zero and two you
take the zero throw and column number
two
the you put a zero there okay so you put
a one wherever there is an edge between
the two nodes and you put a zero
wherever there isn't you can see that
there is this reflection reflexive
property here because
one two is one and two one is also one
because these are undirected edges now
of course if this is a directed graph
this would be different
okay
so an exercise for you once again is to
represent a graph as an adjacency matrix
in python
shouldn't be too hard all you have to do
is instead of so in adjacency list we
initialized a list of empty lists here
you may want to initialize a list of
zeros a list containing lists of zeros
okay and then you may simply just want
to fill in the zero once in the right
places now adjacency matrices have their
own benefits sometimes they are
more useful for example
when you want to immediately check if
there is an edge between two vertices or
two nodes you can quickly look up look
it up in the adjacency matrix but in the
adjacency list you will have to get the
list for one of them and then search
through that list
which is fine for most cases but in some
cases you may just want an adjacency
matrix as well
so that's one other way you can
represent a graph
and that's an exercise for you
okay
so now we know we've represented graphs
and
now we can start looking at some graph
algorithms and probably the most common
graph algorithm something that you will
ultimately get asked in one interview or
the other if you're interviewing with a
bunch of companies is breadth first
search
and breadth first search well this is
what it looks like so suppose you have
this
this is a real world graph that we're
looking at so these are cities in
germany
and you can see that there are roads
between these cities and we have lengths
of each road now we can ignore the lens
for now
what's important is that these cities
are connected to each other but not all
cities are connected to all of them all
of the others
so starting from frankfurt you may want
to find out
which are the cities that are
that you can reach from frankfurt
without stopping so
which are the cities that are one edge
away from frankfurt and if you look at
it this way it turns out that mannheim
castle and
wurzburg
are the three cities that are one edge
away from frankfurt right so if you
start drawing this tree of sorts
so
you will find that mannheim wurzburg and
castle are one edge away okay then you
might ask which are the cities which are
two edges away from frankfurt
so now the cities that are manheim is
connected to
karlsruhe and wurzburg is connected to
these two cities and then castle is
connected to this city okay
so here you have these other cities and
then you might ask which are the cities
that are three steps away from the from
frankfurt and that would be the
remaining two cities
augsburg and stuttgart okay
now i'll let you think about this but
what you will find in this way
as you go step by step by step like
first you're finding all the cities that
are one step away so all the nodes that
are one step away from a source node
then you're finding all the nodes that
are two steps away from a source node
what this will give you is ultimately
you will end up
for each node you will find out
how far away it is from the source
and that will be the length of the
shortest path between the two okay and
you can verify that i'll let you think
about it for instance if you see
you can go to
castle by going this way from wurzburg
to nurenberg to mission to castle
but that would not be the shortest path
but binary search the this is called
breadth first search brett first search
will always discover the shortest path
because we're first finding all the
nodes at distance one and then we're
finding all the nodes at distance two
and then we're finding all the nodes at
distance three and if a node at distance
three has a shorter path then it would
have been already found
when we are finding nodes of length one
or two or distance one or two okay
so that's brett first search
so here's one problem that you might
face in an interview
implement breadth first search
given a source node in a graph
using python
and here is some pseudo code this is so
it's always a good idea to write or
explain your approach in plain english
before you implement it so that you do
not make mistakes while coding
so here for here is the pseudo code so
if you have to write a function bfs
which takes a graph and a root or a
source node
so first we say create a queue so we're
creating and this is taken by from
wikipedia
so first we create a queue and what's a
queue
well a queue is a very simple data
structure a queue is simply a list
and it follows a first in first out
of policy
so when you have a list and you want to
add something into a queue it's also
called enqueue the enqueue operation so
when you want to add something into a
queue you add it at the end okay so you
have a list and then you simply keep
adding things at the end you just append
things at the end of a list
but when you want to access something
from a queue you do not access any value
directly no
you always access
the first available value okay you
access the first available value in this
case
what what is called the value in front
and when you access a value it gets
removed
okay so it's so in this way you can see
that it implements the
the first gen first out policy like if
first we enqueue one and then we enqueue
three and then we on q4 and then we want
to dq and when we want to dq we simply
get the first value that was inserted
which is 1. then maybe we enqueue a few
more numbers 5 2 7 then we dq and then
we get back the first value that we had
inserted which is not yet dequeued so
then we get back
four or whatever was the was the second
value inserted initially right so that's
a queue
and we let's see how a queue is useful
so we create a queue
and then we
mark the label
we mark
root
we label the root node as discovered
okay so we need
to somehow
track which nodes have been discovered
or visited
and first what we'll do is we will mark
the root node so let's say we're
starting from the node three we will
mark three as discovered so three is now
discovered
and as soon as we mark something as
discovered we will enqueue it
okay
then while the queue is not empty which
is why we have not
accessed all the elements in the queue
or well we have not
dequeued all the elements from the queue
we dequeue an element so we dequeue the
first element which has not yet been
removed from the queue
and if we are looking for a particular
goal node then we can simply end there
like we found that node but we are not
looking for a goal node so let's remove
this code
yeah so we get we get the first element
or the first node from the queue which
is not yet dequeued and then so for
example initially we just have three in
the queue so then we get back three we
get three back from the queue then we
check all the edges for three so we
check that three is connected to one and
three is connected to two and three is
connected to four so we see all the
edges for three
and if
the other end of the edge
we check for each node let's say
the other end of this edge is 2 we check
if 2 is not yet discovered or not yet
visited
then we enqueued 2 into the queue
similarly we check for 1 and if one is
not yet already discovered we enqueue
one into the list similarly for four we
enqueue four into the list okay so we
have dequeued three so three is no
longer in the queue
or
we've moved forward are we no longer
going to get q a three out of the cube
but now we've enqueued two one and four
and two one and four we now understand
they are at distance one
so when we pick the next element of the
queue we dequeue the next element the
first in first and first out we get back
and then
we mark 2 as visited great now we
visited 2.
oh no we we mark
as soon as we are adding something to a
queue we also mark them as visited
because we've identified that 2 1 and 4
are all at distance 1 from 3 and we've
added them to a queue so we mark them as
visited
now
when we get 2 out of the queue in the
next iteration we check
if there are any nodes which 2 is
connected to those are not yet visited
so 2 is connected to 1 but 1 is already
visited so there's no need to enqueue it
again and then 2 is connected to 3 but 3
is already visited so there's no need to
encue it again
and so we just move forward then we go
to 1 and when we go to 1 we realize that
0 is
not yet visited so we enqueue 0
4 is visited so we don't enqueue four
okay and that's how we proceed so now
what you should do is you should draw
this on a piece of paper and work it out
just write on a piece of paper what
would be the first element that gets
inserted and what will be the elements
that we will insert into the queue etc
etc
but
this is the algorithm here
exactly what we what we just discovered
so we dequeue in a vertex for all the
edges that start from the vertex v or
the node v
if the other end of the edge is not
labeled as discovered
then mark it as discovered and enqueue
it into the queue
let's implement this let's see if we can
implement this live
so we are implementing bfs where we will
get a graph and a source node
the first thing we need to set up is a
queue
so the queue is empty then we set up
discovered
and discovered will be false initially
and it will have the length
so we want to mark it false for all the
elements okay and remember now we can
use this notation here because false is
an immutable value so it doesn't matter
so so we don't really need to use the
range or the list comprehension notation
here
then
here let's come here so we mark the
label root as discovered
so discovered of
source
let's just call it root so that we don't
get confused with the terminology
so we mark discovered of root as true
great
then we insert
or we enqueue the root so we we
type q dot append now enqueue simply
means adding something to the end and
you know how to do that in a list you
simply call q dot append
so q dot append root
great
now
python list by default do not support a
dq operation so what we will do is we
will set up an index which will track
the first
available element in the queue okay so
whenever we dequeue an element we will
increase the index so that we move
forward
so here we have the index idx equal to
zero so now while there are elements in
the queue which means while the next
available index is less than the length
of the queue
first we will get the current we will dq
so dequeuing simply means
getting the getting the first in element
the element that was most recently
inserted and has not been dequeued so we
get current
is
q of idx and then we can also
increase idx so as soon as we dequeue
something we update the index so you can
imagine that the index starts out here
and when we dequeue this or delete this
then we get that value out and then we
update the index to the next position
okay so now we have the current
this is the dq operation
then what do we have next
now we want to check all the edges
of current right so we are going to say
for
so remember we have the adjacency list
representation so we will get
for node in self.data
current so self.datacurrent contains a
list of all the nodes that are connected
with the current node
so for node in self.datacurrent
if
not
discovered
node so if you have not yet discovered
the node
then
we first mark it at this as discovered
and then we add it to the queue so we do
q dot append
node
okay
so what you end up with this way is
first you have the source that got added
to queue
and then we inserted all the
inserted all the nodes which were at a
distance one from source and then we
insert then if you follow the trajectory
you'll see that we we will insert all
the nodes that are at a distance to from
q and so on right so ultimately when we
end up with this entire process
we will have the q and the queue will
contain
the list of nodes as they would be
visited
in a binary in a breadth first search
okay so we can simply return the queue
here
so let's try it out so we have graph one
and let's call bfs
and graph1 is this graph so let's grab
this image as well
so let's simply copy the code for the
image and come down here
let's come down here
and put the image here
okay let's call bfs on graph one
starting at the node three
okay of course this should be called
graph.data
so because graph is the graph that we're
working with so we need to check graph
or data here
okay so we start out with the note 3 and
you can see that three first causes one
two and four to get inserted and then
one causes two to get inserted okay
now that's bfs for you it's pretty much
done at this point but what would also
be helpful is maybe to keep track of
what is the distance of each node right
so we can also track
we can also keep track of a distance so
let's say we have a distance which we
initially set to none
or yeah which we initially set to none
and we will track a distance for from
each for each node so we have the
distance here
and initially we are going to set the
distance for
the root to zero of course because the
root is at zero distance from itself
and the distance here means the number
of edges right
then when something is discovered
so when we are discovering a node and
that node was not already previously
discovered that means that the distance
for that node
is one more
than the distance for the current node
which caused it to be discovered right
so the distance for
so for example if you're starting with
three the distance for one is one more
than three which caused one to be
discovered and the distance for zero is
going to be 1 more than 1 which caused 0
to be discovered
so that's the distance
great we've now also tracked the
distance one other thing that would be
nice to have is
what is called the parent
if you see if you go back here you can
see that
it would be nice to know
what led to carl's room being discovered
was it mannheim wurzburg or castle so
that we can work our way backwards and
find a path
from frankfurt to carl's room okay
so for that what we can do is we can
keep track of a dictionary of a
list called parent once again we will
have no parents uh by default so
parent none
and whenever
we find a node and that node was not
already discovered
then we can set the parent of that node
to the current node which caused it to
be discovered okay and now we can return
from the queue the distance
and the parent
so let's see if that works
okay so it seems like now we have
these are this is the this is the order
in which the nodes are being visited you
can see that 3
is the first node to be visited
and
3 has and if you want to check the
distance of 3 you can see that the
distance of three is zero so this is
distance is given in the order of the
nodes in the order of the original
numbering of the node so you can see
that three is at a distance zero from
itself obviously then you have one two
and four now if you want to check the
distance of one just check the index
number one here so
one is at a distance one if you want to
check the distance of two now that is at
a distance of
one as well you can check here and then
you want to check the distance of four 4
is also at a distance of 1 right so all
of these 1 2 and 4 are at a distance of
1 from the root node 3
and also you can see here that the
parent of 1
remember these are 0 1 2 3 4. these are
the indices of the nodes so the parent
of one is three and the parent of two is
three as well and the parent of four is
three three itself does not have a
parent that's why this is none and
finally the last node we visit is zero
and it is at a distance two you can see
it is the this distance here is indeed
the highest
and
the parent for
zero is one right so because one was the
first node that caused zero to be
visited it could have been four two but
in this case just how we implemented it
one was the first node which caused it
to be visited so
one is the parent of zero so if you now
want to find the path from three to zero
you can look at the parent of zero that
would be one
and then you can look at the parent of
one
that would be three
and we are done so we can work backwards
from the target we can keep checking the
parent after parent of the target and
that will give us the entire path so now
we have the path we have the distance
and we have the order in which these
nodes will be visited so you may get
asked bret first search in all these
different variations but roughly this is
what the code looks like and you can see
here that the code is not too long now
we have created all these additional
additional lists but you don't really
need them so the code is about 15 lines
of code 10 to 15 12 to 15 lines of code
not more than that
so that's bfs again if you're working on
a bfs problem it always helps to first
state it in simple words
and work it out with an example and then
start coding so that you do not make
mistakes while coding
now
one question that you can
work on is to check if all the nodes in
a graph are connected this may not
always be the case so for example here
you can see that all the nodes in the
graph are connected but sometimes you
may have a situation where some nodes
are not connected for instance if these
edges 1 1 2 and 3 2 weren't present then
2 would not be connected to 0 and maybe
2 is connected to 5 and 6 etc so here is
one graph where not all the nodes are
connected to each other you can see that
there are nine nodes but there are only
eight edges and
if you look carefully you will see that
0 1 2 3 0 1
2 3 are connected
but there is no connection from these
nodes to 4 so 4 5 6 are then connected
separately and then seven eight are
connected to each other but not to one
another right so can you use breadth
first search
to determine if all the nodes in a graph
are connected
i would reckon yes
look at this q
now this queue gives you
all the nodes
that starting from the source node are
connected to the source node by zero one
two three or so many steps
if something is not connected it will
not show up in the queue so you can
simply check the length of the queue and
see if that is less than the total
number of nodes
and then use that to
determine if all the nodes are connected
or not
now another related question that you
may get asked is to find the number of
connected components in the graph now
what's a connected component if you take
a set of nodes that's connected that's
one component and if you remove that
then you look at the next set of nodes
that's connected that's two components
if you remove that then you take the
next set of nodes that connected
that are connected
that and that gives you the
third connected component and so on so
in this case for example you have this
is one connected component you can check
by drawing the graph and then this would
be one connected component and then
these would form one connected component
so zero one two three would be one
connected component four five six would
be another and seven eight would be
another
can you find the number of connected
components or even can you list all the
connected components of a graph using
bfs
yes you can
again a very simple way to do it is just
pick the first node perform bfs from the
first node that gives you the connected
component that contains the first node
then find the first index which is the
first node which is not yet visited
start bfs from that node now that will
give you the connected component for the
second node and then find and then keep
doing keep repeating this till all the
nodes have been visited
okay
that's another question that you might
get find the number of connected
components or find a list all the
connected components in a graph the bfs
is a very versatile algorithm that can
be applied to solve
pretty much
most graph problems that you may get
asked in an interview
so do do work on a few bfs problems
and get some practice with it
now another way to work through a graph
to
look through a graph is what is called
dfs and this is the way in which you
would normally explore a maze where you
start out in one direction and then keep
going so for example we started out here
and then we kept going till we hit an
end right so you can see here that we
kept going until we hit an end and then
we turned back and then we tried the
next path and then we turned back and
tried the next path and so on so we go
like this then we turn back we try 5 go
like this turn back we try 8 then we
turn back try 9
10. that's another way to go about it
and
it's some cases in some cases bfs makes
more sense in some cases dfs makes more
sense and
you can in most cases both of them work
just fine for most problems so you can
implement either one when you are faced
with a graph problem
so let's implement
dfs or depth first search okay now here
is a depth first search it's pretty
straightforward you have you pick a node
and then you pursue the the node and the
next node then the next node and so on
among the edges you pick one node and
then once once you've exhausted the path
along one edge you come back and try the
next edge and then you come back and try
the next edge so there are two ways to
write it there is a way to write it
recursively and then there is a way to
write it without recursion
and i'll leave it as an exercise for you
to write it recursively but what we'll
do is we will write it without recursion
and you write without recursion we will
use
something called a stack we will use a
stack and a stack is another data
structure very simple list like data
structure but it's
just like a queue but it's different
instead of being first in first out
which is what we do in a queue in a
stack we perform
last in first out
so here's how it works you start with an
empty stack
so you can think of it like this
container or a cookie jar and you start
putting in things into that jar you put
in one and you put in two and you put in
three so now when you have to remove an
element from the stack or you want to
access an element from the stack the
only element that you can access is
the element that was inserted most
recently
so last in
first out that's a stack
how is that going to be useful
it's pretty straightforward if you think
about it
because this node when you start from
this as the source you will add all
these three into the let's say you add
these three into the stack
now if you add these three uh let's add
them in this order so you start with
this node then you add this this and
this so you add these three into the
stack
then the last in value was two okay so
then what you do is you
extract two out and then you insert
everything that two is connected to into
the stack so you insert three into the
stack
and then you the last in value was three
so you insert you take out three and
then you insert four into the stack then
the last in value was four then you take
out four and you have nothing left to
insert so now this entire path has been
exhausted so then you end up with this
five now when you end up with five you
can insert its name neighbors eight and
six into the stack
and once six gets inserted into the
stack uh then you take out six and you
put seven into the stack and so on right
so you can see how depth first search is
working using a stack and roughly this
is what the procedure the
process looks like you start a stack
it's empty
push push the
current
source let's say the root node which you
are starting with put the root into the
stack now while the stack is not empty
pop the stack so get the last 10 value
from the stack and that gets removed as
soon as we call pop
then if that node is not already
discovered
then we mark it as discovered and then
for all the edges from v to w
so for all of its neighbors
we simply push them into the stack right
so that's it that's all we are doing all
of its neighbors which are not already
visited we can simply push push them
into the stack okay
so let's do that let's implement dfs
and once again we will keep this picture
in mind so let me just grab this picture
here as well
this is one of the nice things about
jupiter that you can take these images
and
simply include them within your jupyter
notebook while coding so that you don't
make any mistakes so let's say we're
writing define dfs
and once again let's assume that we are
going to start from 3
and this picture is graph one
so let's say we are starting from three
so define dfs graph and we have a
root node that we want to start with
and the first thing we want to do is we
want to create a stack and you can use a
list as a stack
adding
you can simply add things to the end and
then pop them from the end
so
we create the stack and then we find
discovered we mark discovered as false
for every node
len graft or data
then we say stack dot
insert so stack dot append so we simply
add the number three to the end or the
root number to the end so stack dot
append root and then we don't mark it as
discovered yet now this is the
interesting thing in dfs because
remember when you start out with three
you want you don't want to mark four one
and two all of them as discovered you
want to put them into the stack but only
when they come out you want to mark it
as discovered because you want to
discover four and then you want to
discover zero before you discover one so
that's why we put these into the stack
but we don't really
mark them as discovered just yet so
that's why we are not marking
the root as discovered then while
lens stack is greater than zero
we get the current value so the current
value would be stack dot pop
so interestingly python lists two
support a pop operation so if you have a
list
and then you do l1 dot pop
you can see that
the value v that you get from l one dot
pop is the value two and l one now has
the value five comma six okay so you can
use a dictionary or you can use a python
list like a stack in fact we can even
try append here to see the entire
process let's say we are appending three
and then we are popping three
so we get back three and five six two
remains
so we pop the current node and then we
mark it as discovered
so we mark it as discovered here
discovered of current is true
and
we may also just want to store that this
is the result that we have so we may
also just want to create a result list
where every time we pop something we are
also going to add it to the result list
so let's say result
dot append current
and then we are finally going to return
the result
okay but here's the main logic
so for
all the nodes in
graph dot data current
we are simply going to push those nodes
into the stack so
we are simply going to say
stack dot append
node okay so what we do is we start with
three and we then pop three
and add it to the result and then we
put one two and four into the stack we
don't mark them as
discovered yet
then we pop one
and then we put
all of these zero two three four into
the stack
we don't mark them as discovered yet we
mark one is discovered now
then we pop zero because sorry then we
pop four not one because we insert one
to four so four is the last inserted
value so then we pop for four we mark it
as discovered and then we insert zero
one and three now you can see that there
is some repetition here we're also
inserting three once again so just to
avoid that what we can do is we can say
if
not
discovered node
only then add it to the stack right
there's no point in adding something to
a stack if it is not all if it is
already discovered so now with that in
mind let's see we start with three and
then we insert one
two
and four great four is the last value
inserted so three is discovered now four
is the last value inserted so we pop
four
and then we insert 0 1 but we don't
insert 3 because it's visited
so now 1 is the last value inserted then
we pop 1
and we try to insert some of these other
values it seems like everything is
already inserted so nothing will get
inserted
then the only thing that remains is zero
so we pop zero
then we pop once we have popped zero we
are going to pop four so the order in
which we expect to see things is three
four
one
zero two i believe
let's see
dfs
graph one
starting at the node three
okay so it looks like we have
zero one so it looks like we made a
mistake because we got some repeated
values here
and that's because we may want to just
check
if not
discovered current
we may want to just add this check and
put everything inside this check
so that
any older values that have been inserted
into the stack which are already visited
later
sometime through another value in the
stack that gets ignored so we end up
with three one three four one two zero
right so it goes like this first we go
from
three to four to one
to 2 and then we go from 3 to 4 to 0.
so that's how it goes
now
a challenge for you is to also implement
distance now in this case the distance
will not really make sense because this
is not the shortest distance anymore so
when you want to get shortest distance
from one node to another then you want
to use bfs not dfs because if you track
distance here you may end up going by
dfs three to four to one to two
and that is going to give you a distance
of
or a distance of three to getting to two
although the shorter distance is one so
maybe distance doesn't make sense here
but what you may want to put in is the
parent you may want to track the parent
for each node
should be simple enough to do whenever
you are
popping something you may just want to
track its parent
okay
that's an exercise for you
another exercise that you can try is to
write a function to detect a cycle in a
graph now when you're performing dfs
let's say you are going about performing
dfs starting at one
and you do this and then you end up here
back at one right because you go to from
one to two two to zero and when you
notice that zero points to one which is
already visited that gives you an
indication that there is a cycle in the
graph a cycle is simply a path which
leads from a node to itself so 1 2 0 1
is a path and a path is something a path
is a sequence of edges so 1 2 is an edge
2 0 is an edge and 0 1 is the edge so
this is a path but 1 2 and 2 4 is not an
edge so 1 to 4 is not a valid path right
so cycle is simply a path that leads
a node leads from a node to itself so
the challenge for you is to write a
function to detect a cycle in a graph
another challenge for you is to
detect maybe the number of cycles in a
graph
okay so that's another thing that you
can try out
but we will move on to another problem
now we will talk about
weighted graphs and get closer to that
example of
the railway map that we looked at
initially so here you have nodes so you
have nodes numbered from 0 to
8 so you have a total of 9 nodes
and you have edges too now these edges
also have weights and this could be
distances for example the railway line
or
this could represent
any other information which is of value
to you right so you decide what edge
weights are what they mean
in the abstract representation we simply
call them weights so this is a weighted
graph and here is an example of how we
can convey the information about a
weighted graph i can give you the number
of nodes and then i can give you a list
of edges so the first two elements of
each edge tell you which nodes are
connected like the nodes 0 and 1 are
connected here
and then the last element of the list or
the third element of the list tells you
if it is weighted if there is a weight
associated with the edge
okay
so you have 0 1 3 and then you have 0 3
2 so 0 is connected to
3 and it has a weight 2 and so on and
you can verify that there are 10 edges
here and these are the 10 edges with the
10 weights
so that's one variation that we see in
graphs
here is another variation this is called
a directed graph in this case
edges have a certain direction so this
corresponds to the example of hyperlinks
where we have pages web pages on the
internet and one page can link to the
other but the other page may not
necessarily link back they may in which
case you may have a bidirectional edge
but in most cases there you would have a
single unidirectional edge so you have 0
1 1 2 and 2 3.
now directed graphs can be represented
just the same way as undirected graphs
all we need to do is we need to provide
some information that this is a directed
graph right so you can simply say uh
directed equals true
and that will simply and once you
provide all these all this information
that can then specify to the person who
is going through this data that this is
a directed graph right uh so here's how
it's exactly the same as a normal
undirected graph but
when we create the adjacency list
we can
have a graph we can have a node from 0
to 1 but we should not put 0 into the
adjacency list for one because there's
no way from uh to there's no direct h
from one to zero there's only a direct
edge from zero to one so keep that in
mind and similarly in the adjacency list
now you will not set both the values
zero one and one zero two one you will
only set one of them corresponding to
the one direction unless of course there
is a bi-directional edge
and what we can do is we can even
combine directed graphs and weighted
graphs
so here's the here's what we'll do we
will define a class which can represent
weighted and directed graphs in python
so we'll use it to represent undirected
graphs directed graphs and weighted
graphs all of these
and we will take some information in the
constructor to capture this
detail
so let's say let's create a class graph
once again we will create a constructor
now this has the self which is the
object that gets created always the
first
argument to any
method in a class in python
then we take the num nodes
then we take the edges
and then we take a couple more arguments
we take a argument directed which has a
default value false and we take the
argument weighted which has a default
value false okay
and we're going to store the information
self dot directed let's store self dot
num nodes
as num nodes
self dot directed as directed
self dot
weighted is
weighted
okay so now we come to the edges
so for edge
in edges
what do we do now an edge can either
have two values or three values if it is
weighted if it is unweighted then it
will have two values if it is weighted
then it will have three values
so we need an if condition here if
self dot
weighted
then
include weights
else
work without weights
okay now we may want to also because we
need to create an adjacency list so we
will create self.data just as we have
been doing so far
and in self.data
we will
create a list of empty lists as we have
done
for underscore in
range
num edges
now what we'll do along with self.data
we will also create something called
self.weight
and self.weight will store
for each corresponding value in the
adjacency list it will store the weight
of the edge between the two elements so
for
under and you will see how it works in
just a moment
num edges
okay so we have self.data and self.wait
and this will make it easier
another way you can do it is instead of
storing single values you can store
tuples inside self.data which will
correspond to the node and which will
also contain the weight right so that
both these are both ways to do it i'm
just doing it this way
but you can do it the other way as well
where you can store tuples directly
inside self.data
suppose
it is weighted
then first we get the values out of the
edge so node 1 node 2
and weight
from the edge remember the edge is a
tuple
if and then
first we set self.data
node1
and append to it
node2
and then we also set self.wait node1
so at the exact same location where we
have node 2 at the exact same index
we store the
weight
between the of the edge between node 1
and node 2 which is weight okay
so now we've stored one direction which
is node one to node two
we may also need to store the second
direction so if not directed so if if
the graph is not directed only then we
need to store the second direction so we
just say self.data node two dot append
node one
and then self dot data
node two dot append
wait
okay
and that's the case when it is weighted
if it is not weighted well
the code is actually simpler
so we simply get node 1 and node 2 from
the edge
and we say self.data node 1.
dot append
node 2
and then if not directed so there's no
wait here so we simply check if the
graph is not directed self.data
node2
dot append
node one
okay
so there's a bit of code here but the
code is again fairly straightforward
it's just a couple of things that we
have to take care of whether it's
weighted or not whether it's directed or
not but now that we've done this we have
a fairly generic representation for a
graph right so now we can take this
graph
and
remember graph one
the graph one had this information
so similarly we can we can create this
graph we can use this graph class to
represent graph one but we can also use
it to represent one of these which is a
directed graph a graph with weights or a
graph with directed edges or a graph
with both a graph with both weights and
directed edges which we'll see in just a
moment
now one thing that we'll also do here is
create a nice representation so let's
just create a representation here
now i'm not going to get into the code
of this but roughly what we want is we
want while showing the graph if there is
a weight we also want to show the weight
we'll show the weight alongside the
other node
so let's see we create a result the
result will be
this
the empty string and then we'll return
that result
then we are going to say for i comma
nodes comma weights
in
enumerate
self.data and self.weight
so now this is an exercise for you to
figure out what exactly this is doing
and you can apply the exact same
technique take create a new
create a new cell and put this data into
a cell put the zip into a cell
and then see what that represents if if
you're not able to if it doesn't show
something then try converting it into a
list or using it in a for loop and then
put enumerate around it and see what
that represents so that you understand
what i nodes and weights represent
but i am simply going to write it here
so that you see the final result
okay
so let's take
nom nodes one once again
and edges one it was called num nodes
and edges so this was the initial data
that we were working with let's create
graph one
and of course we want to do this only if
it is weighted so if
self dot weighted
if it is not weighted then we have a
different case where
for i common nodes in
enumerate
self.data
result
plus equals
okay let's see so graph one we are going
to use
the graph
and we're going to pass num nodes edges
and by default weighted and directed are
both false so we don't need to specify
them and let's see graph one
this should be
num nodes
so you can see with live coding we
always make mistakes and it's almost
always bound to happen that's where
jupyter notebooks are very helpful and
it's always helpful to just test your
function
while you're writing it
okay so now we've created graph one and
graph one you can see is an undirected
graph you can see that zero points to
one and one points to zero
then let's look at graph two so we're
going to grab this
data
this contains
let's call this num nodes two and edges
two
this is a graph with weights
so now let's create a graph too
graph and here we pass in num
nodes to
edges too
and weighted equals true
and let's say graph two
okay there's a small change here
yeah so now you can see for graph 2 this
was the graph we were looking at here
this graph let's grab this image as well
yeah this is the graph that we were
looking at and you can see that zero is
connected to one and three
and so zero is connected to one three
and eight one three and eight and there
are also weights associated so zero one
has the weight three
0 3 has the weight 2 and 0 8 has the
weight 4
and so on
there seems to be something off here
because 0 1 only seems to be connected
to 0. i think we may have made a mistake
somewhere in the code
okay so we may just have to debug this
code it seems like we may have made a
made a small mistake somewhere because
zero one uh one seems to be connected
only to zero but one should also be
connected to seven
i don't see why that did not show up
here
this is the curse of life coding and
that's why i have created
a working
i have some working code here i'm simply
going to grab the working code right now
and we'll just replace that
but see if you can detect the bug in the
code okay we don't the version i have
does not require you to specify weighted
so we can simply skip weighted here it
detects automatically if the graph is
weighted still something wrong here
let's just quickly verify what's going
wrong
so we are going through the list of
edges here
and we are appending
maybe let's just print
graph two dot
graph2.data
maybe the issue is in the representation
and not in the
code graph two dot
edges
ah there seems to be some issue in the
weight here
so we may not have inserted the weights
correctly
ic so this should be called weight
this should be called weight
and so should this be called wait
oh there was a syntax error here
okay
i think we fixed it finally let's see
this should be called weight
so we have an edge here we have too many
values to unpack ah we simply
pass
weighted equals true finally
and we need to make this a list
it's finally done
some
good hardcore live debugging but we have
this finally and again you get to see
that when you're coding you will you
will make issues you just need to
but if you have a clear idea of how
you've written the code it's easier to
narrow down the issues by looking at the
errors
but let's see this graph here so we have
zero connected to one three and eight
and that's you can see that here one
three and eight are zero connected to
one three eight with the weights three
two and four
then we have three connected to zero
so we have three connected to zero two
and four and we have six connected to
five and eight you can see six connected
to five with the value eight
so great we have now represented our
graph properly and this is why a
representation is really useful because
now we can check if our implementation
is correct before we go on and implement
any graph algorithms we can check if our
representation is correct let's try one
more let us also try this directed graph
so we're going to grab this code
and put it here let's call this
num nodes three
edges three and directed three
let me grab this
graph code here as well
we are working with
this graph
and
let's create graph three
so for graph three we have
graph and we pass in num
nodes three
we pass in edges three and you can
verify that the edges are set up
correctly and we just specify directed
equals true so we don't really need this
at this point we can just say directed
true and weighted by default is
automatically false so we have graph 3
here
you can see that 0 is connected to 1
and 1 is connected to 2 but not to 0 so
now we haven't inserted the opposite
edge and then 2 is connected to 3 and 4
then 3 is connected to 0 and 4 is
connected to 2. great so we've
implemented we've now set up another
graph
and now here similarly you can check
that if you have a weighted directed
graph the code is still going to work
fine
that's an exercise for you
and at this point let us just save our
notebook using joven.com
so the next question that we are going
to look at is called the shortest path
question
and this is really what we started out
with
let's say you have a bunch of nodes and
this is we have taken a directed graph
here but
you need not have a directed graph you
can do this with an undirected graph too
and that will be an exercise for you but
you do need weights here now whenever
you're talking about shortest paths in
terms of weights
that is when this algorithm makes sense
now if you do not have weights in the
graph then the shortest path can be
found simply by performing breadth first
search okay so whenever you're asked to
find the shortest path the first
question you should be answer asking is
is there a weight involved or are there
no weights now if there are way no
weights involved then we're simply
concerned with the length of the path
the number of nodes in each path and in
that case you can simply perform a
breadth first
a breadth first search
but if you have weights whether it's
directed or undirected then breadth
first search alone may not be enough
right because
it may turn out that certain parts
for instance you go from zero to three
so you you go if you go via zero two
four and three the length of the path is
two plus three five plus four nine but
if you sorry the
yeah the total size the total size of
the length of the path is two plus three
five plus four nine but the number of
nodes is four zero two three four
on the other hand
if you go via 0 1 3 in this case the
number of nodes is smaller so there's
just one in between so 0 1 3 there's
just three nodes total but the length of
the path is 14 which is far higher right
so this could represent that you go to a
far off place
of via a train and then take a train to
something that was actually closer even
though there were more stops in a
different route
okay this is what we're going to
implement now we're going to implement
an algorithm to
identify the shortest path from a given
node to a given target okay so now this
time we're going to focus
our
search between
a node and a target so what is the
shortest path
in terms of the total weight of the path
not in terms of the number of nodes in
the path keep in mind what is the
shortest path in terms of the total
weight
that we
can find from
a starting node to an end node
and roughly the strategy goes like this
and the strategy is called the distraus
algorithm roughly the strategy goes like
this you have the source node and the
source node is at a distance 0 from
itself so there's nothing there really
but
the first thing that we know the first
and the only thing that we know is
that
for one of the siblings for one of the
neighbors of the source node
the direct edge will be the shortest
path so
for example we have one
and we have two
now you have directed
you have direct edges from
zero to two and you have a direct edge
from zero to 1.
0 to 2 has the weight 2 and 0 to 1 has
the weight 4.
now in this case suppose we had an edge
from 2 to 1 and that edge had the weight
one
then you could go from zero to two with
a weight two and then go from zero two
to one by a weight one and the total
weight you would incur to get to one
would simply be three and that would be
smaller than the
shorter smaller than the direct edge
right so even if we are looking at
direct
connections of the root we can't say
that the direct edge is the shortest
path
except for one of the nodes right so if
we just look at the node
where the
edge weight is the smallest so you start
at the root and you look at the edge
with the smallest weight
then we can say for sure
that
the shortest path from the root to the
next node to the node to
is the direct edge why because this
direct edge is smaller than or smaller
than equal to any other direct edge so
any other path that comes to two
indirectly
will contain an another direct edge and
then some other edges right so it will
have a length greater than or equal to
this direct edge right so that's the key
inside here that at every point you
maintain a group of visited nodes so in
this case initially just two zero is
visited and then you find the first node
which is
at the closest distance from any node
within the visited group okay so for
example if we start out at zero and then
we look at 1
and we look at 2
we see the smallest edges 2
so we
add 2 into our visited group because we
we know that this is the shortest path
from 0 to 2 and at this point now
we take all of the siblings or all of
the neighbors of two and update their
weights now because we know that zero to
two is a direct shortest path so we can
update the distance for four that four
could be at a potential distance of
two plus three five or there could be a
shorter path so we've not yet added it
we'll just update four and similarly if
there was a edge to one we can update
the distance of one and we can say that
the distance of one is
either 4 which was a direct edge or it
can be 2 plus 1 if there was a direct
edge from 1 so now we will get to know
that
1 is at a distance of 3 which is smaller
right in this case it's not but suppose
there was a direct edge from 2 to 1 of
weight 1 we would get to know that
1 is at a distance 3 so each time you
add a new node as you mark a node as
visited you you update the weights of or
update the distances of all its
neighbors and then you simply
find the next node with the smallest
distance right so you will find that the
next node with the smallest distance in
this case is four
and then you update the numbers of four
there's only one neighbor the next node
with the smallest distance is three you
update the weights of three and so on so
that was shortest path in a directed
graph but here let's see a shortest path
in an undirected graph where we have
more such cases
let's just watch this
from the beginning let's wait for the
animation to start again
so we start at zero
then we check two okay we mark two as
updated then we check nine then we mark
three as updated then we update the
distance of 14
but now we can see here that we have
another path to go to 2 or we go to 3
that's why we
track that
and finally we get 2 we mark 2 as
visited now we are considering 3 and
using 3 we are updating the weights of
all the other
graph all the other nodes and then we
are marking 3 as visited then we are
using 3 to mark 6 as visited and so on
right so at each point you have a group
of visited nodes and you have distances
for all the nodes that are connected
with the visited nodes
and then you pick the first unvisited
node with the smallest distance okay now
let's read the algorithm
you first mark all nodes as unvisited
and then you create a set of all the
unvisited nodes and you call it the
universal set so a set of all the
unvisited nodes is called the universe
call it the unvisited set
assign to every node a tentative
distance value
now set it to zero for the initial node
because the initial node is at a
distance 0 and set it to infinity for
all the other nodes
so we now set the distance to infinity
because we've not yet visited the nodes
we don't know their distance
then you set the initial node as the
current node so there is a always a
current node that we're looking at in
this case we'll start with the initial
node
now for the current node consider all of
its unvisited neighbors
and then calculate their tentative
distances through the current node right
so you have the current node and the
current node is connected to a lot of
unvisited nodes
and if we look at each unvisited node we
know the distance up to the current node
because the current node is visited and
using that we can calculate distances
for the unvisited nodes
now if the unvisited nodes have
distances set to infinity then we know
that the distance from the current node
distance y for going wire the current
node is going to small is going to be
smaller than the distance infinity that
has been set but on the other hand if
the
if a distance has already been set for
an unvisited node through some other
node then we can simply compare whether
it is better to go through the current
node or whether it is better to retain
the retain the distance that was
obtained by some other node
and just maintain that right so in this
way we simply update the distances of
all the unvisited nodes that are
neighbors of the current node okay so
for example if the current node is a and
it is marked with a distance of six
and then there is an edge connecting it
with a neighbor
b and then that edge has the weight or
the length two
then the distance to go to b through a
from the source will be six plus two
eight right so from the source to a is
six a to b is two so the distance if you
want to go to b through a will be six
plus two eight
on the other hand if b was already
previously marked with a distance right
so it was not visited but it was just
marked with a distance
greater than eight
then we know that we have found a
shorter path via a so we update its
distance to 8.
on the other hand if we have a value
let's say the value of for visiting b by
an another node d was seven so we keep
the distance as seven right so we're
simply updating the distance we are not
yet marking
these new we are not yet marking b as
visited
now when we are done updating all the
distances for the current node
then we mark the current node as visited
and of course we remove it from the
unvisited set right so we mark the
current node as visited
then
a visited node will never be checked
again because once you have visited a
node you have found the shortest paths
to it and you have used it to update the
distances of all its neighbors you never
need to visit it again
so then
find the first unvisited node
find the first unvisited node that is
marked with the smallest distance right
so now we have a bunch of visited nodes
and then we have a bunch of unvisited
nodes many of those unvisited nodes have
been marked with a distance so you
simply get the first unvisited node with
the smallest distance
and make it the current node and then
repeat the process okay
so you start out with zero you see that
you can mark two as you can mark the
distances of four one and two so one
gets the distance four and two gets the
distance two
now
then you mark zero as visited
now you see that the
node with the least the unvisited node
with the least distance is two
so you get two and then you mark the
mark the edges from two so you mark the
distance for 4 as 2 plus 3 5 and suppose
2 had an edge to 1 then you would mark
the distance for 1 as 2 plus 1 if 1 was
the weight of the edge let's say you
would mark the distance for 1 as the
minimum of 4 and 2 plus 1 so which will
be 3
so you can mark the distance for a 1s3
and that's it and then you
remove 2 from the unvisited set next you
find the
next unvisited node the which has the
lowest distance so if this edge existed
that would be one but if since this says
if this h does not exist that would be
four so you get four and then you mark
the
distances for the neighbors of four and
so on okay
so what we'll do is we will
create this
we create this graph here
which contains
okay there should be a graph here that
we can look at
yeah so we'll create this graph here
which contains uh
0 to 6 which contains 6 nodes 0 to 5.
this is the graph we are creating
let's just put it here this graph
yeah so this is a graph that we'll work
with
and
let's start writing our shortest path
algorithm
so def shortest path
and we have a graph
and that's it we have a we have a start
node
so let's call it source and then we have
a target node that node that we want to
get to so we want to go from zero to
five
and as soon as we have the as soon as we
mark the target node as visited our
algorithm is done right so first we
mark everything as unvisited by setting
visited false
times lan graph.data so here we have
marked visited then we have distance so
we take we take the distance as infinity
so here's a way to create infinity in
python you just say float in
and once again we set all distances to
infinity
then we are going to maintain a queue
so because we have this first in first
out kind of structure so we're going to
maintain a queue
the first thing we'll do is
we will
mark
the distance
for
the source node
as zero
then we can insert the source node into
q so q dot insert
or q dot append
source and then we'll set an index to
keep track of
what is the next element that we need to
dequeue so the first element is what we
need to dequeue so while index is less
than
zero
and
not visited
target so while index is less than the
length of the queue
and the target is not visited
so what do we need to do we need to get
the current element from the queue so we
simply get
q of idx
and then we increment increment idx by 1
so we increment idx by 1 here
then we need to take all the neighbors
of
queue
all the neighbor we also need to finally
mark it as visited so let's just put in
visited current equals true here
but in between what we need to do is we
need to update the distances
of all the neighbors
and then we also need to
find the next
node with the
find the first
unvisited node
with the smallest
distance okay
so to update the distance of all the
neighbors we have written a function
called update distance
so we'll call this function update
distance
or update distances
where we will pass in the graph and we
will pass in the current node and we
will pass in the distance matrix or the
distance array
and we pass it in this way
and what update distances does let's
look let's look at it here and again
it's always a good idea to extract out
specific pieces of logic into separate
functions
so here you we're calling update
distances where we have a current node
and then we have the graph and then we
have the distance so we get the
neighbors of the current node using
graph dot data
draft or data current will give us the
neighbors of the current nodes
then we get the weights of of the
neighbors of the edges connecting the
current node to its neighbors so we get
the weights as well
now we go through each list of neighbors
so for i common node in enumerate
neighbors
and then we check
we get the weight so we now we have the
node and we have the weight so we have
for each edge
the node that
it is connected to
and the weight of the edge
and then we check the distance for the
node if the distance for the node
let's say hasn't already been said then
it is infinity so in that case distance
to the current node from the source plus
the weight of the edge from the current
node to the
next node will be less than the distance
so if the distance flow of current plus
weight is less than the distance we
simply update the distance of the node
on the other hand if the distance of the
node has already been set via some other
node and that is less than the distance
via the current node then we do not
update the distance
okay so that's all we are doing here
and we can ignore this for now we'll
come back to it but this is performing
exactly that update distances function
that we talked about
then next we want to find the next
unvisited node so here we have a
function called pick next node which has
a list of distances and it has visited
so
we want to track the minimum distance so
we first set a variable called minimum
distance
to the value infinity and then we set a
variable min node so this is the node
with the minimum distance to the value
none
then we iterate over
the
all the lists all the nodes in the
that we have in the graph so from 0 to n
minus 1 and we check that if the node is
not visited
and the distance of the node is less
than the minimum distance we've obtained
so far
then we set that node to the minimum
node and we set the minimum distance to
that value
okay so we track the minimum distance
the running minimum distance by going
over all the nodes in the
graph and we keep track of which node
has the minimum which unvisited node has
the minimum distance so finally what
pick next node gives us is the first
next unvisited node
okay so here we can get next node
is
pick next node
and we give it the distance and we give
it visited
okay
so now
if there was a next node it's possible
that there is no next node because we've
probably already visited everything that
we can visit
so if there is a next node
then we enqueue it so we say q dot
append
next node
and that's it
that's pretty much it so that is our
shortest path algorithm
we
create a visited list we create a
distance list we create a queue where we
will add things so this this will be all
the
all the nodes that we have visited will
go through it or go through this one by
one
and the q in order will give us
a list of all the nodes in their order
of distance from
the source node
now what we need to return here
is we simply need to return distance of
the target and since that was what was
asked here
let's also mark current as visited
through here soon enough so that we
don't end up
visiting current again and again
all right so let's run the shortest path
algorithm then
here we have a graph
this is the same graph that we see here
now we can create a graph graph 7
and this is
weighted and directed so we will pass in
graph we will pass num nodes
seven
we will pass edges seven
and then we will
pass weighted equals true and directed
equals true
and this is graph seven
okay this seems like it was it worked
out right zero is connected to one and
two with the weights four and two
respectively
and 5 is connected to nothing
4 is connected 3 is connected to 5 4 is
connected to 3 okay this looks fine
so now we can say
shortest path
in the graph
from let's say from 0
to 5
in graph 7
and it says that the length of the
shortest path is 20. so you have 2 3
four eleven so two plus three five
five plus four nine nine plus eleven
twenty so that seems to be right
what would also be nice to get is just
to see
what that path is and for this we can
introduce something called a parent
so here we can simply have another thing
called a parent
which is set to none for each element
so visited
let's call this parent
and let's set it to none by default and
all we need to do is whenever we are
enqueuing a node we need to track why it
got enqueued right so if an if a node is
getting enqueued then it is probably
getting enqueued so sorry not whenever
we are enqueuing whenever we are
updating the distance of a node we need
to track why
why its distance got updated so inside
update distances whenever we update the
distance of a node
we also set the node the parent of the
node to that current node
from which the distance got updated
right and that's all we need to do when
we update the distance of a node we need
to track why did we update this distance
by which node we did we come to update
this distance so this way we have now
tracked the parent
and let's return not just the distance
of the target but let's also return the
queue
and let's return
let's just return the parent for now
i think this should be
fine
okay so now you have the parent for each
one so if you look at the fifth element
0 1 2 3 4 5 you can see that the parent
of 5 is 3
so it seemed like we arrived at 5 from 3
and then if you look at the parent of 3
so zero one two three the parent of
three was four it seemed like we arrived
at three from four then you look at the
parent of two it seems like we arrived
at
from at four from two then you look at
the parent of
two and it looks like we arrived there
from 0
and 0 was our source so the path
is if simply going reverse 0 2 4 3 5
okay and that's how you get the shortest
path and not just the shortest path
distance now notice that 0 itself does
not have a parent because that was the
source
now you can repeat this with another
graph let's say we take this other graph
that we had
this was
graph two so let's grab this image here
so let's get graph two and let's say
shortest path
graph two
and let's get the shortest path maybe
from
zero to seven so it seems like there are
two parts one goes by one and one goes
by a six
two three
three two and seven so let's get the
shortest path from zero to seven
okay so we started out with zero and we
end up at 7 so 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7. it seems
like the parent for 7 was 1
and then the parent for 1 was 0.
so it's clear that it picked the path 0
1 7 and the total length of the path was
seven
sounds good
we can try another one we can try
two and eight so there are a couple of
ways to go from two to eight
one is to go wire three
so you can go to six to other three ways
actually but six two uh six z uh you can
go at three zero and eight or you can go
at three four and eight let's see which
one it picks
okay so now zero one two three four five
six seven eight so the parent for eight
is five
oh sorry zero one two three four five
six seven eight so the parent for eight
is four so we came to eight wire four
and then the parent for four zero one
two three four apparent four four is
three so we came to four wire three
and then the parent for three zero one
two three the parent for three is two so
we came to three y six wire two so two
three four is the path and the length
should be
eight plus one nine plus six fifteen
great it seems like we've figured out
the shortest path once again and this
time this was an undirected graph okay
so as long as you have weights you can
apply this algorithm and this algorithm
is called the dystra's algorithm
and that's it so that's all we're going
to cover today
now one thing that we have not looked at
very closely is the running time
complexities so let's do a quick
look at that let's do a quick look at
let's say bfs
and see if we can identify and get or
guess the running time complexity and
the full proof is left to you as an
exercise but roughly it looks like this
this is the main
this is the main loop here so where we
are going through the queue
so the number of times this may happen
is n
which is the number of n which is the
number of
nodes
and the number of times this might
happen now inside each for each node
inside bfs remember that we check a full
list of nodes inside each node for bfs
so the number of times this may happen
is equal to the number of
for each node we may perform an
additional number of steps equal to the
number of nodes it is connected to right
so if we have n nodes
so we have n while loops and then if we
have a total of m edges and let's say
those m edges are split across if i
count the number of edges for each node
the number of edges is e1 e2 e3 e4 and
so on and then we so the num the num the
size of this loop for the node
n1 is e1 the size of this loop for the
node n2 is e2 the size of this loop for
node n3 is e3 so if you add up the list
of all the edges e1 plus e2 plus e3 plus
e4 so the total number of iterations
inside this for loop turns out to be
you can see here
the total number of iterations inside
the for loop will turn out to be the
total the sum of all the
adjacency lists okay and this total sum
of all the adjacency list is equal to
twice the number of edges you can see
here the number of edges is one two
three four five six seven and you can
verify that the number of elements of
all the adjacency lists put together is
14 because each edge is represented
twice right so we end up if we have
n
so if you have n
f n vertices and
m edges we end up with n plus two m
operations right so each of the n
operations to start the while loop and
then each of the two m operations
those are to iterate over each adjacency
list right and now when we are talking
about
complexities we can ignore the m if m is
the number of edges we can ignore the
factor 2 associated with it so what we
end up with with is order of n plus m
so order of n plus m is the complexity
of
breadth first search
and now by this by this point
you should be able to just work it out
by looking at the code so do try it out
and if you if it's not clear do ask on
the forum but order of n plus m is the
complexity of brett first search and you
will find a similar complexity for depth
first search as well
order of n plus m
for the shortest path algorithm however
the complexity will be different
because in the shortest path algorithm
let's see it here
in the shortest path algorithm what we
do is
we go over all the vertices so that's we
insert each vertex or each node into the
queue once and then we take it out once
so this contributes a factor n
then when we are saying update distances
then it also contributes the factor m
but when we are picking the next node we
may we visit all the vertices once again
right so
here we are performing n operations
inside when we are picking the next node
so that gives us
order of
n square
plus nm
n square plus m
yeah something like that so order of n
square plus m or n plus m into n so
that's you those are some complexities
that you will see reported for shortest
path
and a way to improve this a way to
improve the picking of the next node is
to use what is called a min heap so that
you don't have to look through the
entire list of nodes each time
to pick the next node but you can simply
pick the next node in a very short time
so there's a data structure called a min
heap that you can look at the min heap
allows
is used to keep track of a bunch of
numbers and easily track the minimum so
you can keep a bunch of numbers around
in a binary tree like this and the root
will always be the minimum and the
numbers on the left and right will
always be larger than the root and then
the same will be true for each subtree
as well
an insertion into this heap is of order
login and deletion into this heap is of
order login as well and then the min max
in this case
fetching the min or the maximum value is
of order one so instead of mainta
instead of looping through the entire
list of nodes each time what you can do
is you can simply insert nodes into this
min heap and delete nodes from the min
heap when they become visited and
getting the next node is as simple as
fetching the minimum value
okay so
check this out this is not something
that will generally get asked this is a
more advanced concept in fact even the
distraught shortest path algorithm it's
very unlikely that you will get asked
but do review it and do try as an
exercise if you want to go further try
implementing and improving the distress
algorithm
using a binary heap
so that will take the complexity for
from m plus n times n to m plus n times
log n
okay and that may be better so do check
that out that's obviously going to be
better for larger graphs
so do try to implement it in fact inside
python there is a built-in heap called
the heap queue data structure
and that will that will optimize the
pick next node
operation
in the distress algorithm
so that concludes our discussion of
graphs here there's a lot more in graphs
graph theory is an entire course in
itself but since this
course is particularly concentrated on
data structures and algorithms from the
perspective of coding interviews and
coding assessments this is as far as we
need to go so what you should do is you
should practice more graph problems
related to breadth first search and
depth first search that is really
something
that you need to become very familiar
with breadth first and depth first
search and shortest path may be in
sometimes
some some really hard interviews you may
get asked the shortest path as well so
do familiarize yourself with that but
apart from that you don't really need a
lot more
but there are other algorithms you can
look at minimum spanning trees you can
look at topological sorting you can look
at connected components that's another
path you can look at detection of cycles
and there's something called disjoint
sets so there's a huge huge number of
topics that we can cover in graphs but
we'll stop our discussion here so what
do you do next review the lecture video
and execute the jupiter notebook
complete the assignment and attempt the
optional questions and finally
participate in forum discussions very
important if you're stuck at any point
just go on the forum ask a question
you can also share your code as long as
it's not working to get help
and you can also join or start a study
group to learn together with friends
and you can also find us on twitter at
chopin ml and akash in s
and the next lesson is data structures
and algorithms
in in data structures and algorithms is
python interview tips tricks and
practical advice
thank you
hello and welcome to data structures and
algorithms in python
this is an online certification course
being conducted by jovian
today we're on lesson six python
interview tips tricks and practical
advice
this is the final lesson of this course
so i hope you're excited
my name is akash and
i'm your instructor
you can find me on at akashenist
if you've been following along with this
course
and you have been working on the
assignments
and if you complete a course project as
well then you can earn a certificate of
accomplishment for the course
which you can find on your jovian
profile and also add to linkedin or
download as pdf
so let's get started first thing we'll
do is go to the course website
pythondsa.com
so this is the course website
pythondsa.com this is where you'll find
all the information about the course
you can watch all the previous lessons
lessons one through five and you can
also check out the previous assignments
assignment one two three and you have
the course project as well
let's open up lesson six
now on lesson six you will be able to
find a video recording
of the video you're watching right now
and here is the code that we will look
at today
so today we will do something different
we will
simulate the experience of being in an
interview
so while we have given you a problem
solving template and we recommend that
you follow this template for any project
or any notebook that you work on any
coding problem that you work on
and here on the problem solving template
we also have a method something that
we have been applying throughout this
course
to different kinds of problems different
kinds of data structures and algorithms
but in an interview obviously you will
not have this template
so we'll see how to apply this method
during an interview
and before we do that let's revise the
method so that we can recall it from
memory when we are working on the
interview problem
so here is the systematic strategy that
we have been applying so far for solving
problems and do check out the previous
lessons if you haven't seen them for
examples of how to apply it in detail
so the step one is to
state the problem clearly in your own
words
and identify the input in output format
and then the second step is to come up
with some example inputs and outputs and
try to cover all the edge cases that you
can think of you want to think of all
the possible scenarios and that will
help you
write your code properly then step three
is to come up with a correct solution
for the problem and state that solution
in plain english
and then step 4 is to implement the
solution and test it using some example
input this is important
while you're practicing but initially
when you come up with a correct solution
it will be a simple solution what is
often called a brute force solution and
in an interview setting you may not have
the time to implement it from scratch so
you may skip if the brute force solution
is too straightforward
then step five is to analyze the
algorithm's complexity and identify any
inefficiencies in the algorithm
so what you can do in an interview is
come up with the correct solution and
describe it to the interviewer and then
analyze its complexity directly and
start identifying inefficiencies and
then move on to apply the right
technique to overcome the inefficiency
so this is where you need to identify
what
which one of the techniques that you've
learnt in this course do you need to
apply
is this a binary search problem is this
a divide and conquer problem is this
related to binary search trees is this
something that you can solve in a
similar way you'd solve sorting is it
important to look at the worst case or
average case complexity
is this a graph problem or is this a
recursion or
is this a dynamic programming or a
memoization problem so all of these
things are something that you have to
think about and as you practice more and
for more problems so for each of the
lessons if you try and practice about
five to ten problems then you will start
to recognize these patterns and when
you're on step six when you're trying to
come up with the right technique to
overcome the inefficiency the ideas will
automatically come to you so practice is
very important to succeed in step six
and once we have determined how to
overcome the inefficiency through the
right data structural algorithm then we
state that solution implement it analyze
the complexity right so this is how
your
a coding assessment or an interview
should proceed for you
and let's see let's pick up a coding
problem and let's go from there
so here we have a coding problem python
sub array with the given sum and we read
the problem but before that you can see
that here this
notebook is fairly empty
and we what we're trying to do is we're
trying to simulate the situation where
you are on a call with somebody and they
are interviewing you and typically they
would be using some platform like
a collab edit or maybe a platform where
you can also run the code
or a platform where
the question is somewhere let's say on
the right it's already printed it's from
a pre-selected database on on the right
on the left and on the right you can
type your code and you can experiment
with it now we're not using any third
platform here what we'll do is we'll
simply simulate that in our jupyter
notebook
okay so now we have this notebook
running we've clicked the run button on
the jobin notebook and here we are
now the question is
and this is a question that was asked
during a coding interview for amazon of
course a lot of other companies may ask
similar questions too
you are given an array of numbers and
these numbers are all non-negative
you need to find a continuous sub array
of the list which adds up to a given sum
this is how interviewer might state the
problem to you
and then they may also tell you an
example sometimes they don't and if they
don't it's always a good idea to ask for
example now
you might sometimes feel that maybe if
you ask too many questions the
interviewer might think that that you
don't know this or you're dumb in some
way but that's not true it's actually
the opposite the more questions you ask
the better the interview
the better the interviewer is able to
convey what they want right now they're
busy they're doing five interviews a day
and they have their entire day's work
sometimes they may just fail to state
the question in its entirety and if you
don't ask for clarifications you may
assume the wrong thing and go ahead and
implement something that's completely
wrong and
that completely deals your interview and
trust me it happens more often than you
might think
okay
so
we here is one example so let's say if
the interviewer did not provide an
example you can ask them can you please
give me an example for this problem and
then they come back to you and they say
suppose we have this array one seven
four two one three eleven and five these
are these are all numbers and they're
all non-negative some of these could be
0 as well but suppose we have this array
and i give you the number 10 that i want
you to find the large
i want you to find a continuous sub
array of the list which adds up to the
given sum which is 10.
so
then they might also tell you that in
this case the solution is this sub array
starting from position 4
starting from the number 4 and going all
the way up to 3 and you can check that
there are no other ways to create 10
like if we took 1 7 that would be 8 and
1 7 4 would be 12. on the other hand 7 4
would be 12 again but 4 2 1 3 turns out
to be 10 and once again on the right you
will not be able to create the total of
10.
so this sub-array is what you have to
return now what does it mean to return a
sub-array to return a sub-array means to
return the indices which is the
index of the starting term or and the
index of the ending term and sometimes
we know in python when we're working
with ranges typically the end index is
outside of the actual data so you could
return the index of 4 in the index of 11
so that we so the index of 4 is 0 one
two so two is the index of four three
four five six index of eleven six so if
you return two and six and then i try to
access
the two to six two colon six range of
the list then you will get get this list
four two one three in fact that's
something that we can very quickly
verify here
let's say l1 so you have one
seven
four two one three
now if i say that the start index is the
start index i
and the end index j are 2 and 6
respectively
and you can see l 1 of 2 to 6
is 4 2 1 3 right so although j is
outside so that doesn't get included
when we put it as a range
and then we put in 4 2 1 3
and you can also verify that the sum
is 10.
all right so that's the problem now i've
explained it to you in a lot more detail
than an interviewer would
but this is the process that you have to
apply in your own mind what and
sometimes what you can also do is you
can repeat the problem back to the
interviewer that's a great idea you you
they've stated the problem to you
they've maybe given you an example now
you state the problem yourself in simple
words remember that was step one so in
the same way that i just have you can
state the problem and then you have to
figure out what are the inputs and the
outputs so the input you have an array
or array is also a list in python so
let's say arr
zero let's create let's make this the
first an example first input and that
would be one seven four two one three
and then the target so your target sum
is ten
that's the input here and then the
output that we want to want is
so this is the
output 0 that would be
2 comma 6 as we've just verified
so this is the input and output format
always makes sense to just create some
variables for that before you start
coding
the next step is to think of what are
all the cases that a function
should be able to handle but actually
before we do that we should also write a
function signature because we know what
the input looks like we know what the
output is going to look like and we know
what so we know what the function should
look like so we can just say def
and let's call this sub array sum
and it's going to take an array it's
going to take a target and there's going
to be some
logic inside it okay all right so that
was step one sorry i forgot about the
function signature but it always helps
to just write the function signature
because if you've misunderstood the
problem still the interviewer can
immediately correct you and tell you hey
but you haven't taken a certain input or
you've assumed an input which i have not
provided okay all right so now we have
the function signature now step two
remember step two was come up with an
exhaustive list of test cases to test
the problem so you can do this in
comments
you can just create some comments and
you can say i'm thinking about the
problem and i'm just trying to think
what are all the cases we need to handle
and this is a great quality this is not
something people do often but they
should because this indicates that you
are doing what is called test driven
development which means you are thinking
about all the ways in which your code
code might be used and accounting for
those before writing the code so kind of
working backwards and it's a very useful
way to avoid errors so now the first one
could be a generic
array
where the
sub array
is in the center somewhere in the center
right so which is what we have already
seen here
now
the sub eric would be in the center or
the sub array
would be
at the start
or the sub array
could be at the
end
or it's possible that the sub array
there is no such sub array so there's no
sub array which adds up to 10.
you may also have the situation where
you have a few zeros so you have
a few
zeros in the list that's one option
here's one thing that can happen this
could be that
there are multiple sub arrays with the
same sum
now this is where you might want to just
clarify with the interviewer hey what
happens if we get two sub arrays which
add up to the same
number the target
and the interviewer might say find the
shortest one or find the first one or
find any one but it's always good to
clarify that
one option could be that
or you could also ask them what is what
happens if there is no sub array that
adds up to 10 and then they may tell you
you can return none none or you can
return -1 or whatever it is
or assume that there is always a
sub-array so that will help you write
your code
and then you can obviously you may have
to work with the empty array you may
also have to work with the sub-array is
a single element
and whenever we say arrayed we also mean
list in python they're
practically speaking the same thing for
our purposes
okay we've listed quite a few test cases
and
in that process we've come across a few
more questions which we've clarified so
now we're ready to start solving the
problem
now at this point what you may want to
do
is maybe just ask for a couple of
minutes and keep a pen and paper close
to you i'm going to use this tool
instead
so i'm going to use this tool instead so
keep a pen and paper close to you so
that you can work on this problem
now let's come up with the simplest
possible solution right so we have about
two three minutes to come up with the
solution
and often the simplest solution is
pretty obvious so in this case one
simple solution could be if i could
simply try every sub array
then
i will find at least one if
that adds up to 10 if there is one so
all i need to do now each subarray is
defined by a start index that is where
the first element of the array is and
then and n index the end index is just
next the next index the first index
which is not in the array right so
that's how we define the sub array
remember so all we need to do is try all
such values so all such values i i comma
j where i goes from 0 to n minus 1 and
where j goes from
remember you could start out with the
empty sub array so which means j also
has the value i
so here we are saying
i and j both have the value 2 so l1 of 2
to 2 becomes the empty array so j grows
from i
to
all the way beyond the last element
which means if the last elements index
is n minus 1 so j can go
all the way up to n all right so i goes
from 0 to n minus 1 and j goes from i to
n and each time we start at an i and we
check e j so we check j equals 0 and j
equals 1 equals 2 j equals 3 4 5 and so
on then we move i again and then we
start over again and then we say we
start with j equal to 0 j equal to 1 j
equal to 2 3 4
okay and and we keep doing this to we
find an array and we have exhaust this
way we'll test all the sub-arrays so the
problem is solved
so that's the brute force solution and
what you should do first of all is
explain that brute force solution it may
seem that this is an obvious solution
what's the point of explaining it but to
mention it because at this point the
interviewer knows nothing about you so
they don't know if you can even
come up with a solution to the problem
right they're trying to assess can you
think about problems and they're trying
to assess can you write code now
if you don't tell them the brute force
solution then they don't even know if
you figured out the brute force solution
so do tell them the brute force solution
and generally you do not have to
code it you can do the analysis in your
memory
in your mind and
you can sort of write the code in your
mind picture the code and based on that
come up with the
complexity analysis and directly say
that the brute force algorithm will have
such and such complexity
okay now
we will just write the code right now
just to
be very clear about it in case you have
not you are not yet clear on how to
write the code but in an interview this
is the part which you can skip in the
interest of time
so f
sub array
i think it was called
sub array sum
sub array sum and let's call this server
sm1 the first approach that we're taking
here we have array1 and that's it we
have array and then we have our target
and we're saying remember that start i
from
i goes from
0 to n minus 1
that was the first thing so for i in
range
0 to
n minus 1 and what's n well n is simply
the length of the array length of the
array
then
j goes from
i to n
oops so i made a small error here this
should say 0 to n because even in a
range the last value is not taken so j
goes from 0 to i to n so for j in the
range
i 2 this should be n plus 1 then because
we want j to go
all the way up to n
and now
we simply check if
the sum
of array
i to j and then we've seen this array i
to j is going to give us all the indices
starting at i but ending just before j
so if the sum of array i to j
equals target
then we found the answer return i comma
j
that's it so
check if
sub array sum
equals target
and if not let's just return none none
maybe this is what we agreed but let's
return none
and
that's it so that's your
that's your code
it's about one two three four five lines
of code maybe six
but that's a brute force solution
if it's really short it doesn't hurt to
write it because it then it's going to
sit there and at least as a reference
you have it but
it's something you can discuss with the
interviewer should i i mean
if you if you are clear about the brute
force solution and you can tell its
complexity then you don't have to write
one other tip is whenever you're coding
it's always helpful to simply add a
small comment above
so that even if the interviewer is not
able to follow your code
they can just follow your comments and
they can tell if your general strategy
is correct right once again reading code
is hard and especially when
you
are not familiar with the coding best
practices in the industry the code that
you write is
sometimes difficult to read so while you
learn how to write good code in the
meantime it always helps to just mention
comments makes it makes their job easier
makes them easier it makes it easier for
them to evaluate you otherwise you may
spend five to ten minutes talking about
something in your code which either they
misunderstood or you made a typo etc
okay
so we have here the sub array sum one
we've implemented the brute force
solution
maybe let's also check out some
cases in
and see if this root 4 solution works
correctly
so in an interview if you have the
ability to run the code you can just run
a few
samples so let's say i simply take array
and target 0
and you get the value 2 6
and remember output
0 also has the value 2 6.
so
great it seems like our
our technique work
let's test a few more cases just to be
sure sub-array at the end subway at the
start let's see if we can fix that so
here is array 0.
now if i take this remember 4 to 1 3
oops i think i didn't complete it let me
also put in 11 comma 5 here
yeah so remember 4 to 1 3 is the
solution now if we simply take 4 to 1 3
11 5
and call sub array sum
and put in
this number here and put in once again
the target zero was 10
oh this should be subway some one okay
yeah so now you can see four two one
three is zero one two three which is the
range zero to four so it seems to have
worked correctly let's do the same thing
now list this time let's
put this at the end so one seven
four two one three eleven five
this works fine two two six
let's try another one let's try maybe
17 and that probably cannot be found oh
it can
one two
let's see one zero one two three four
five probably the sum of all of these
four let's do six plus four ten
okay
now maybe there's a problem here because
it seems like 17 is not the right sum so
you have 1 plus 7 8
and 8 plus 4 12
12 plus two fourteen
fourteen plus four eighteen
okay so this seems like a mistake then
and we can even check this out
so we have l1
that's that
let's call that l2
and 2 oh it says one to six i think i
misread it so we are ignoring the 0th
element so this does add up to 17 okay
so 17 does show up
let's try 18 which takes up the entire
array works fine
let's try maybe 4 which should just take
the single number so that works fine too
let's try 19 that should be none none
okay
we've tested this extensively and
overall our solution seems correct this
is the process whenever you write any
code you should also test it out and it
also gives
more confidence to the interviewer
but if you do not have the option to
test it out if you do if you are not
able to run the code right now
then simply walk them through an example
yourself like look at this example and
then walk them through the exam
okay so now we have the brute force
solution the next step is to analyze the
brute force solution now let's analyze
it so you have here one for loop
and we know that counting for loops
helps us count the number of operations
then we have another for loop so one for
loop can go from zero to n so this may
run n times then we have another for
loop which goes from i to n plus one
let's approximate here and say that it
can
run at most n minus 1 times or n times
so
n
and inside each of these up at most n
and then inside the second for loop you
have the sum so this is very important
now always carefully observe the
operation inside your for loop so you
have a sum which can be on an array of i
to j now remember i can be 0 and j can
have the value n that means in the the
largest area that you can work with will
have approximately the size
n as well right so you have
n and inside each of those you do n
other loops and inside each loop you do
work
you do n additions right up at most n
addition so that roughly gives you that
this is going to be n times n times n so
this is going to be an order n cube
solution
so
if you are able to arrive at the order n
cube solution
at the order n cube complexity without
implementing the solution great you have
learned it but if you're not able to
arrive
um at the order n cube solu at the order
and cube complexity for the brute force
solution
then you probably need a little more
practice because this should become
second nature to you just looking at a
problem identifying the simplest
solution and then finding the complexity
of the simplest solution
all right so now we have implemented it
tested it and we've identified the
complexity remember the next step
find the inefficiency and
overcome that inefficiency by applying
the right technique
so
let's find the inefficiency then
here we have
let's say we are at this position so
let's say you are looking at
seven four two let's say
i has the value
1 so
you start out with i equal to 1 and j
equal to 1 in the inner loop then what
we do is we increment j by 1 and then we
calculate the sum and this sum is 7.
then what we do is we increment j by one
more and we calculate this loop and this
sum and this sum is seven plus four
eleven
then we increment this window once again
and then we
calculate this sum and that is seven
plus four plus two so seven plus four
eleven plus two
13 and then we move this and then we
check it again so we are doing this over
and over and over many many times right
each time we are doing 7 plus 4 plus 2
plus 1 and 7 plus 4 4 plus 2 plus 1 plus
3 that seems like a lot of additional
work maybe we can just avoid that what
we can do is we can when we start out
with a j we can keep a running sum and
each time simply before incrementing j
add this
upcoming element which is the jth
element into that running sum right and
that way we don't have to do that entire
sum inside each of the inner loops
so that's one optimization and this is
how you should explain it that's one
optimization that i have come up with
the second optimization that we can come
up with is that the moment the sum the
running sum that we're calculating the
moment the sum becomes greater than the
target value
we can skip all of these right so we
know that 7 plus 4 is greater than 10
and we know that the array only contains
non negative number so what that means
is 7 plus 4 plus any of these numbers is
always going to be greater than 10 right
you can obviously you can see this the
number is not going to decrease if we
keep adding positive numbers
and so as soon as the running sum
crosses
this value we can break out of the inner
loop we do not need to continue and look
for higher values of g
two optimizations
helps to just write them down
maintain a running sum
so that you don't forget it and
find it and second optimization is
when some
exceeds target
break inner loop
okay
so
now we have applied an optimization
simply by just looking at the data in a
lot of cases it's very straightforward
you don't even have to apply any special
technique
and in this case we found these couple
of optimizations so let's apply them
so what we'll do is we'll define
def subarray
sum2
and here once again we have the array
and we have target
and this time we get the length of the
array
now once again i goes from the same
value so i goes from
0 to n minus 1.
nothing changes
here so for i
in range
0 to n minus 1.
now here is where we want to start a
running sum so s equals 0 this is our
running sum
then for
j
in range
remember we start out with i
and we'll go all the way oh this i
keep making these mistakes all the time
and by the way these are called off by
one errors here what we did was i wanted
to go to at the address n minus 1 but
because ranges
do not include the final value i put in
what i put in n minus 1 was wrong i
should be putting in n and i make these
mistakes all the time even after many
years of coding so always watch out for
off by one errors
anyway so j can j can take the range of
zero of i to
n so here we should put in n plus one
and now
first we want to check
if the running sum
is equal to
the target right so so assume that we've
been calculating the running sum step by
step
and we'll write and and at this current
point the sum has become equal to target
now if the sum has become equal to
target then we simply return i comma j
because
this sum
includes the sum from
index i all the way up to just before j
so initially the j also has the value i
so the sum is 0 which makes sense
but if that is not the case
we check if it is greater than the
target
so is it possible that our sum has
already exceeded the target in that case
we don't need to continue this inner
loop we can break out of this inner loop
and the way to do that is by simply
typing break
and then
if neither of these held true if neither
of these was true so which is that the
sum was not equal to the target it was
not greater that means it is still less
than the target
so that means we need to then add
array of j
into the sum so we can say sum plus
equal to
oops sum plus equals area of j which is
the same as sum equal to sum plus array
of j
in any case array of sum plus equal to
array of j
so we have added the jth element now
remember
if this is the pointer j we added the
jth element and then we we will set j to
j plus one that will happen
automatically when we come into the next
iteration
and the next iteration will once again
check if the sum is equal to the target
if it is equal we return i comma j
otherwise we check if it is greater than
the target if it is so we break if it is
still less we increment we
move j once again so we add one and then
we move j once again and then we check
again right so that's our running sum
looks good now once again
if we were if it was found it would have
been returned somewhere here
since it seems like it was probably not
found so
if we come to the very end so here we
return none none okay
and once again let's test it out so
let's try subway sum two
it gives you two six subway sum two of
none
okay seems like there is an issue here
yes
so this is why you need test cases so it
seems
that
array j took up an invalid value
so why is that well that was because j
can go to the point of n so the maximum
value j can take is n
so which means that you have already
arrived at
this position
so now you can no longer increase the
sum further right so if you've arrived
at this position but you've still not
reached the total of 10 then that means
you may need to increase it further but
you can't increase further so there's no
number here to add so what we should do
is we should here add a check if j less
than n
since j can go all the way up to n
and that's it so we had a small bug and
we fixed it
now again this is something that you
should work out for yourself on pen and
paper so even while doing the
optimization you can ask for a couple of
minutes
play around with it on pen and paper
write a few examples
relax you can even take up to four five
minutes and if you
if you're not getting any ideas you can
simply talk to the interviewer you can
speak out loud explain your thought
process and in a lot of cases they will
give you a hint because they want to see
you succeeding
okay
so now this is the second implementation
let's see okay this time it worked
none none four two one three let's put
in 10 here this should give you the
value two comma six
let's put in
this so that's zero comma three
let's test this out two so that's zero
comma four
yeah 0 comma 4. so it seems like it's
working just fine
yeah so seems like this is working
pretty well so now we have the second
optimized solution so let's look at the
optimized solution and analyze it
so we have one loop and then we have a
second loop these two are the same but
inside the second loop we are simply
doing a constant operation we are just
doing some comparisons and one addition
not up to n additions so the complexity
goes from
order of n cube to order of n square by
maintaining a running sum
great
now
this at this point when you've described
the solution to the interviewer and
maybe also coded it
you might ask them is this good enough
and
they can see that you've ex you've
thought about it you've found the
solution and you have tested it and it
tests well and at this point they may
just say i'm happy with the solution
this is good enough or they may say can
you do better now when they say can you
do better most of the time it suggests
that there is a better solution
so let's see let's think about it a
little more and let's see if there is a
better solution
now you can to can you do better
we apply the exact same technique we
have analyzed the complexity and now we
need to look for inefficiency okay now
we have removed the inefficiency on this
side which is as we move j
that is when
we reuse the previous sum to compute the
next sum so we've removed the
inefficiency on this side
and we've also added
this also added this condition so that j
only goes up to a certain point now of
course in the worst case j may always go
up all the way to the end but at least
in a lot of cases j will not j will not
not go beyond a point where the sum
becomes larger than the target
so these are good optimizations but what
about i what about the left
window now look at this here when you
have seven
four or let's start out all the way at
one
so we have one
that's so first we started with the
empty
empty sub array that has the sum zero
then we increment j so now the sum
becomes one then we increment j now the
sum becomes
eight then we increment j once again and
now the sum becomes 12.
okay the sum has become 12 now that's a
problem so what do we do what we are
saying is we will take i and set it to
the next value and then we will bring j
back to zero or back to the value i so
that we start with the empty sub array
once again so now when we do seven and
when we so that's that just has a value
seven and when we do this we have to add
up seven plus four
now here's something that we could have
done instead
now as soon as the value became larger
than the target value we could have
simply moved
this here
does that make sense
let's think about it so
till this point
this total was less than 10.
as soon as we added this number on the
right this total became more than 10.
now we know that this product became
more than 10 that means that
if we slide this
window if we slide the left window
forward one step then the total may
become less than 10 right it may still
become stay larger in this case it stays
larger or it may become less than 10.
so if the total now becomes less than 10
then we can once again move this
but the total has not become less than
10 so we will move this instead
so now the total again is less than 10
so we can once again move this
and now the total is still less than 10
so we move this now the total is still
less than 10 we move this and we
encounter 10 here but suppose we had not
encountered 10 suppose this number was 4
instead then what we would have to do is
move this right
and now now the number becomes less than
so we always go
we always try to maintain a window of
size less than 10. the moment the window
becomes greater than 10
we keep trying to reduce its size
further
to less than 10 right or exactly 10 as
well it's possible that the size may
become exactly 10 and then the problem
is solved but we keep trying to reduce
its size to a value till it becomes less
than 10.
so
to revise the algorithm we start out
with both i and j at zero
then we increment j while the running
now we have a single running loop and a
single loop essentially
so we increment j while
the
sum is less than 10.
the moment it becomes greater than 10 we
start incrementing i
the moment the sum becomes less than 10
or less than target we start
incrementing j
and if we encounter the point where the
sum equals 10 we have found the answer
so that's the algorithm so let's write
it
sub array sum three
now this is the array target
now we have
we have i we have j and we have sum all
of them let's call it s because sum is a
reserved word in python
an existing function so all of these
have the value 0
then we say while i is less than
len array
let's call that n so let's create n
equal to len a r r
i is less than n
and j is
less than n plus 1 remember because j
can take the value n as well it is the
exclusive end index
now at this point you want to
check first so if the sum s the current
sum running sum
is equal to the target
then we simply return i comma j
l if
some is le less than the target
then we
simply increment j
okay so now we can move the window
forward so we we are incrementing j if
the sum is less than the target
so we increment j but before we
increment j we should add the jth
element to maintain the running sum
so here we say s plus equals
j
or array of j
and remember j can take the value n as
well
so that's where we do this
only if
j is less than n
if there is indeed an element for us to
add
this is an error we faced last time and
you will discover this when you write
the test anyway
and then we say l if s is greater than
target and we can also just say else
here but just for clarity let's say alif
in this case
what we want to do is we want to move i
forward so suppose we end up in a
situation like this and we want to move
this forward for that we need to
subtract s array of i first so we s we
say s minus equals which is equal to s
minus
which is the same as s equals s minus
array of i
and then we increment i
so we move the left window forward as
well
so we then repeat this so we first move
j to a point then we
as soon as we cross the target we start
increasing i and then we keep doing that
till we match the target
and then finally we return none comma
none if we have not found it
so that's r sub array sum three
this is seems like the most optimized
solution and let's test it out
so here we have sub array sum three
and let's test sub-array sum three here
as well
seems like it worked let's see
so if you put in ten here you get two
comma six
let's say this is four two one three
zero comma four
let's put in 12 here that doesn't show
up
let's put in 17 here zero comma five
thirteen one comma five
let's try 19 that's three comma six
let's see one plus three
plus 7 plus 9 yeah that has the value
19. let's throw in a zero there and see
if it works with zeros
that's three comma seven works fine
and let's see if it doesn't work out
yeah
okay
great so this solution is correct too
again if you don't have
the option to run the code you can
simply pick one example and walk through
the working of the example
now we have sub array sum
three
and once again we are ready to analyze
the complexity and in this case the
complexity would be this somewhat tricky
is a little bit unusual because there is
a while loop with two variables
but remember that in each while loop
either we exit which is the best case so
we can ignore that or we either
increment j
or we increment i right so we increment
j or we increment i
and
if we increment
uh so
j can go from the value 0 to n and i can
go from the values 0 to n minus 1. so
the total number of increments can we
and we can do is the
sum of the number of possible values of
i and the number of possible values of j
right remember this is not a product
this time because this you do not have a
nested loop so for each value of i
you're not doing this rather
you are incrementing each one
and i only one of them each time
so the sum of total number of values i
can take is n the total number of values
j can take is n plus one so the total
becomes
this number of iterations becomes two n
plus one
now of course
there's the you can verify that a
constant amount of work is being done
here
so
we finally end up with the conclusion
that this is an order n algorithm
so this is finally an order n algorithm
this is a good example of a problem
where the step-by-step
solution coming up with a simple
solution and then thinking about the
inefficiency in the problem and then
applying
in this case just common sense to solve
the inefficiency step by step
leads to the perfect solution and a very
good solution in fact so you start out
with the order n cube solution the order
n cube is going to be pretty slow when
you start hitting let's say even a
thousand
even a thousand elements if you have ten
thousand elements it will take forever
it will take maybe an hour or so if you
have
a million elements it will take
hundreds of years on the other hand
order n can work fine all the way up to
a billion elements right so there's a
huge difference between
the
sub array sum one two and three
so where some three can work instantly
for a billion elements so where is some
one will take
forever even for
a hundred thousand elements
and sub-array two is in between and you
can do the math
and this technique where
you can almost certainly tell
what the next strat what the next step
is so this was not
really
related to any of the algorithms or data
structures that we have talked about
this is what is called a greedy approach
where you know some optimal strategy
about the problem in this case you know
that we can calculate the sums by
maintaining a running sum so we just do
that and then you also know that as soon
as it becomes greater than a target we
need to break out and then you know the
next thing that when it becomes greater
than target rather you can simply up
update i
so this is what what is called a greedy
approach where you
somehow know that just doing this will
fix it right there's no real technique
to be applied and
these problems are somewhat tricky but
you get the hang of these problems as
well if you search for greedy problems
online you get the hang of these by
solving a few practice exercises
so that's our first
interview problem
and we've solved it in about 45 minutes
and this is approximately how long you
will have for an interview a typical 45
minute to one hour interview we'll have
about
a couple of minutes of introduction
maybe a few minutes just you talking
about a project and the interviewer
asking you questions but then the next
30 to 40 minutes will be dedicated
towards solving a problem
and this is what roughly the process
will look like
let's do one more example let's pick
another interview question
and let's see if we can solve this one
so this is slightly different
so this gives us one more variation to
study
by the way to run these you simply click
the run button and select run on binder
okay so this is an interview question
that was asked during a coding interview
at google
and the question is given two strings a
and b
find the minimum number of steps
required to convert a
into b so what you can do is you can
perform operations and each operation is
counted as one step
and the operations you can perform on a
word are these you can either insert a
character into the word
or you can delete a character from the
word so
for instance here
you can see that
we are trying to convert intention into
execution so either you can insert a
character for example you could insert c
here or you can delete a character for
example you can delete i here or you can
replace a character
that is you can take n and replace it
with e you can take t and replace it
with x and e does not need to be
replaced
and here we've inserted c and then here
we substituted n for u right so we have
taken the word intention and by
performing a few changes character by
character by either inserting deleting
or replacing a character we have
converted it into the
string execution
so the number of steps required here is
one two three four five now here's a
challenge for you try and work this out
on paper and prove that this is the best
solution so because we need to find the
minimum number of steps required to
convert a to b
okay
so that's the problem
and
this is a moderately hard problem
and variations of this show up as well
so let's start applying the method now
when you hear the problem
a solution may not strike you up front
that's perfectly all right don't panic
sometimes when you're not able to
immediately come up with a solution or
identify how to solve this problem you
enter a sort of panic and then you are
unable to think don't do that remember
have faith in the method and we will
apply the method and come up with a
solution step by step
so the first thing
is to state the problem in your own
words
so given two strings
we need to perform operations a series
of operations on the first string the
operations could be deletion of a
character
substitution of a character with another
character or insertion of a character
and through these operations we need to
convert it into a second string okay we
have understood the problem if the
interviewer had not given an example
either you can state the example or you
can just ask for an example
whatever makes works for you
so we've stated the problem now what are
the inputs to the problem so the inputs
are two strings so the inputs are
strings like intention and execution so
let's see
maybe
let's call them str1
this is intention
str2
this is
execution
now one thing you have to be careful
about here is you do not want to
capitalize
because sometimes what might happen is
this i may match up with an i here in
the in the proper solution but
python obviously treats small and
capital letters differently python
doesn't know what's that the i which is
lowercase and the i which is uppercase
is the same so you will not be able to
compare them so just to keep things
simple either make everything uppercase
or make everything lowercase
but yeah this is what the input looks
like
and the output is going to be a single
number
so the output is simply going to be the
edit distance so let's just call it
output one and it is going to be the
number five
and here is something that you can
verify so that's the input that's the
output
and function signature
so
of course this term edit distance is how
this problem is described but
here there is no
edit there's no concept of edit distance
that's mentioned so you can give a
function name that makes sense
for this problem
so find the minimum number of steps
required to convert a to b okay
so
let's just call it min steps
for now
so the function definition would be min
steps and this would take an str1 and
this would take an str2
and it would return
an output for now we'll just put in pass
here
all right so now we have already
clarified the problem if you had any
questions this is this would have been a
good time to ask the interviewer and
make sure that you have a clear
understanding now you have stated the
input output and function signature
the problem has been communicated back
and forth properly the first step is
done
the next step is to list out some test
cases right once again a very good
quality listing out some test cases so
you can say that now i'm just going to
list out a few cases that i want my
function to cover
so that
they will help me it will help me while
writing the code
now one is
the general case
which is
listed above
so this would be
intention execution and we can take a
few more examples like this
now one example could be where
no change is required
so you are given the same strings one
case could be that
all the
characters
need to be changed
so these are the two extreme cases one
is no change is required and second is
all characters need to be changed maybe
added remove deleted
lots of such things then you can
check
both strings of equal length so in this
case they are in fact of equal length
unequal length you can check both
strings of unequal length
one of the strings
is empty
your function should be able to handle
that too
then you may check things like it will
if something only requires deletion
if something only requires
addition or if something only requires
swapping
right such things
i guess this is pretty good at this
point so now we can probably move
forward so we have stated some test
cases now you don't need to create all
the test cases right now in an interview
it can
take a little take a bit of time so
let's just move ahead and the next step
is to come up with the simplest solution
to the problem
which is also called the brute force
solution so now we have a lot more
information about the problem in this
mean time probably it has sunk into you
and you may have been able to think of a
brute force solution but if not don't
worry there is a simple trick i'll tell
you which you can apply whenever you are
stuck and you can't think of a brute
force solution so we're looking at
you're looking at it in tension
execution what am i going to do am i
going to start from the left and right
how do i check which one is
how do i know if this is going supposed
to be inserted or executed or
replaced or substituted
or deleted
so the simple trick is whenever you're
in doubt
think about recursion see if there is a
way to solve this problem recursively
and what do you mean by solving a
problem recursively can you reduce the
overall problem
to
a combination of one or more
sub problems so if you take a portion of
the input
and can you solve the same problem on
the portion of the input and then use
that to solve the overall problem okay
so let's see let's see if there is a
recursive solution possible here
so here i have the same thing
intention and execution now with
recursive solutions normally you either
start by looking at the first character
or the last character
so let's look at the first character
character of each string right so we
given these two strings and we need to
find
the number of operations to change this
string into this string let's look at
the first character
now suppose the first characters were in
fact equal suppose this was not
intention but it this was n tension and
this was execution so now we compare the
first characters and we know that the
first characters are equal okay so
if the first characters are equal then
obviously neither of them needs to be
deleted or
removed or obviously this character does
not need to be deleted or removed or
switched it's already matching so what
we can do is we can just ignore the
first characters
and we can simply look at the remaining
string
so intention and execution because the
first characters are already equal let's
write that down so that we don't forget
it
and this is the
recursive solution
now this is where you can take a moment
to work this out on pen and paper and
that's perfectly all right what helps us
to just talk keep talking about what
you're doing but for recursion now first
thing we know is if the
first character is equal
then ignore from both
so just ignore the character first
character of both strings and simply
recursively solve the problem for the
sub list or the sub string without the
first characters in each of the strings
right so you exclude e and exclude e
from this and solve the problem for
these two
perfect
now suppose the first character isn't
equal so that's another case now right
so that is the case where you have
intention and execution
so if the sub if the first character is
not equal then
either the first character has to be
deleted
or the first character has to be swapped
so you may you may have to swap i with e
or the first character or maybe
something needs to be added before the
first character okay now let's see one
by one
so if
the
first character is not equal
either it has to be deleted
or swapped
or a character inserted before it
there are only three possibilities right
of course it's possible that we may do
some other things insert characters
after after it and so on but
at that position
after applying an operation either the
first character will get deleted
or the first character will get swapped
and will be changed to e or the first
character will now change to something
else and the first original first
character will become the second
character
now let's look at each case the first
cases it has if it is deleted now the
power of the beauty of recursion is that
we don't need to guess which solution it
is we can try all three recursively and
then simply pick the best one so suppose
we choose to delete the first character
so suppose we say that we are deleting
the first character
now what that means is we've performed
one operation
and we've deleted the first character so
now what we are left with is this
so now
what we end up is
the second the string has remained the
same only the first string has changed
where we have lost the first character
now what we end up with is with a sub
problem where we need to find the
minimum number of steps to change n
tension nte and tion into execution okay
so in this case if it has to be deleted
then
recursively find
then recursively solve
after ignoring
first character of str1 okay
that's one possibility
and the you get the recursive solution
and you simply add one to it that tells
you the solution if you
delete the first character the next
option is that we change the first
character i to e
now if we change the first character i
to e
so one operation has been performed and
then now these two have become equal now
that these two have become equal we can
move this forward
and we can move this forward
so now we can simply recursively solve
the problem for n tension and execution
find the minimum edit distance between
the two and simply add one to it to get
the number of steps required to change
intention to
execution
by
swapping the first character right from
i to e
so in this case
you recursively solve
after ignoring
the first
character of each
right so it is one plus
in both cases it is one plus the
recursive solution after ignoring the
first character of each
because the one operation is something
that has been performed
okay now the final case
the final case is you have intention and
execution now we decide that
we are going to shift the string forward
and we are going to include we are going
to introduce an e here so we are going
to introduce e
here
so now what happens is the e is matching
the e
now i has gone on to the first position
i has gone on to the next position here
so effectively what has happened is that
we need to recursively solve the problem
for the original string in tension
and the second string with the first
character removed because we have
inserted something before the first
character in the first string so that is
going to match with the first character
of the second string and hence we simply
need to recursively solve the problem
for these two
in this case what we are doing is the
solution is one plus
recursively
solve after
ignoring the first character
of
str2
okay sounds good looks like we've done
that now what's the end solution going
to look like the end case remember in
recursion this is all well and good but
at some point we are going to hit some
kind of an end so let's see let's see if
we can define such an end scenario so
maybe let's say we have been performing
recursion and then we ended up at a
situation like this
where
there is nothing left in the second
string but you still have some
characters left in the first string
right so you are at this position now
and here this is gone there's nothing
left
in the second string
so in this case
to change recursive to change tion into
the empty string all we need to do is
delete all four
so
if you have a few character if you if
the second string becomes empty then you
simply find the number of remaining
characters in the first string and
delete them so that is the number of
operations or
the other possibility is that
the second string
still has some characters but you've run
out of characters on the first string
if you run out of characters on the
first string but the second string still
has some characters
then in that case what you need to do
obviously is you have the empty string
and you need to
take this
convert this empty string into t i o n
that is a recursive problem we are
solving so you that you can do by adding
t i o n
great so you add t i o n and that is
again going to be
four steps which is the number of
characters remaining in the second
string okay so these are the two end
cases now of course if both of them are
empty then
the answer is zero but if either of them
is empty the answer is the number of
remaining elements in the other one
let's write the solution now we figured
out the solution it took some time but
again this is not a very straightforward
problem so
there are a few cases to figure out
and while you are doing this while you
are identifying each
case
either you can say it out loud to the
instructor or you can write it as a
comment
whatever you feel more convenient with
because
the interviewer cannot see the work that
you're doing on paper so it's very
important for you to be able to convey
it and that is why all this while in
this course we have been saying that you
need to express the solution in simple
words because you need to tell the other
person that you know the solution
and they should be able to understand
what you're saying without looking at
your work without looking at the images
that you've drawn
and a great way to do it is either by
writing or by speaking
let's define it then def
what's it called min steps
and min steps is it takes str1 and str2
great now
we are doing recursion and in recursion
what we're tracking is the
which character we are currently at so
we could be at
the zeroth character or the first
character or the second character in
string one
and we could be at the zeroth character
second first character second character
in string two right so
the the starting point of this window
determines the sub string that we are
solving the problem for so ideally
we when we want to solve this problem
for
these two sub strings
we can simply pass those sub strings but
creating sub sub list or sub strings as
a cost because you have to copy those
characters out and then allocate some
memory and put them into a new place so
an easier way is to simply keep a
pointer so we will keep two pointers i1
and i2
and these will signify
that we should be skipping while
computing min steps we should be
skipping the first i1 characters or we
should be starting from the i want index
and we should be starting from the i
tooth index for str2 okay
so
in your window if the i1 index if the
starting
if the starting index
is equal to the length of string one so
this is the end case and remember the
end case while coding is always written
first so if this is equal to length of
str1 then we have known we have seen
here that
we need to perform these many additions
so we simply return in this case
str
len of str2
minus
i2 right and you can verify that this is
the amount number of additions required
alif on the other hand i2 is equal to
len of str
so which means that
you have exhausted the second string but
the first string still has some values
left so in this case you need to remove
the delete the return remaining values
in the first string so you just type len
of str1
minus i1
right so these we have now solved the
trivial cases
now let's see lf
str1 of i1
and str2 of i2 which means the first
characters of each sub string that we
are working with right remember we are
just using arrays as a we're just using
indices as a optimization what we really
want to work with the substring so the
first character of each substring str1
of i1 and str2 of i2 is equal
now the first character is equal e and i
are equal then we simply ignore both and
solve the problem for the remaining
string so we simply say return
main steps
and
we pass an str1 we pass in str2 and then
we simply pass in i1 plus 1 here and we
pass in i 2 plus 1 here so what this is
saying is that now we want to
recursively solve the problem
or a substring starting at i plus i 1
plus 1 so we have ignored the first
string of the current substring and
similarly we have ignored the first
character of the current substring or of
the second string okay so we ignore the
first characters and that's it and there
are no steps required here no operations
required here right now because the
first characters are equal
now finally this is the final case else
here
we want to return one so we have to
perform one operation either it is an
insertion deletion or swap
and
what we can do is we can recursively
check the
cost or the number of minimum steps
required for each case of insertion
deletion and
swapping
and simply pick the minimum one and if
to do it we add one then we get the
total minimum number of steps we need to
perform for the
entire list right so
again recursion is very useful because
you can simply assume that you have the
function which solves the problem
and you simply need to take the result
of the sub problem and combine them so
we take the minimum off the first option
is if the first
character of str1 has to be deleted
so which is let's say we choose to
delete i if we choose to delete i then
that means we have to solve the problem
for these two
so we say 1 plus recursively solve the
problem after ignoring the first
character of str1
so we solve min steps
for str1 str2 now since we have deleted
the first character of str1 we can skip
ahead into the next
because we are solving the problem now
for the from starting from the next
index
and i2 remains the same right so
remember here we have not affected i2 so
we need to solve this problem
recursively
so this was the case of deletion
next we have the option where
you have swapped the first character so
we have taken e and we have converted
the it in we have taken i converted it
into an e if we did that so then we can
say that okay now these two characters
are matching so now we can simply
recursively solve the problem
or the next character onwards after
ignoring the current character
so this becomes str1 plus str2 plus i1
plus
plus 1 plus i2 plus 1
great so this is
swap or replace
and you might notice that this is this
turns out to be the same recursive call
as this except that we will add one to
it because we have done the swap
and finally if you are adding so if
you're ad inserting
so finally if you're inserting here
something so if you are inserting e here
let's say
so in this case
what we'll do is now we'll recursively
solve the problem for intention
and
execution without the e in front so we
skip the first character of the second
string
so we have main steps str1
str2
i1
and i2 plus 1.
so this is rather nice and symmetric
and that's it so this should be it let's
run this
okay there is a syntax error here that's
perfectly fine
there needs to be a comma here that's
fine too
i make a lot of syntax errors all the
time and of course off by one errors i'm
sure there are a few
but yeah this is
the
minimum number of steps and this is a
recursive function not too bad
two four six around eight lines of code
and let's test out some of the test
cases here
i'm just going to copy the test cases
out here below
and let's try as a general case which is
intention and exception
so let's see main steps
intention
and exception
it says 5 4
okay why does it say 4
maybe let's test
let's test a more simpler case first
which is one of the strings being empty
let's say we have intention and
one of the strings is empty so we will
need to delete
uh let's just say int and one of the
strings is empty
this looks fine we will need to delete
all three of these
and that in some way tests out this case
where
or sorry tests out the second case where
the second string is empty
now we can
test this case
in this case also
the
in this case also the solution is three
great looks fine
let's test this case where str1 i1 and
str2 i2 are equal
so if you have
integer and let's say you have india
so i n i n would be the same
so these would get skipped and here is
where the recursion would kick in so t
would have to be changed to d and then
you would have to add i and e okay that
looks fine too
and let's check in tension and exception
once again i don't know what's
wrong here
let's see
so
is it possible to do it with four i
don't know it's maybe possible to do it
with just four changes
if you change i
you delete i and then you delete n
and then you delete t
delete i substitute these
two i don't think it is possible with
just four changes
so there's probably an issue
[Music]
i don't know what's wrong here it's
possible i may have made a mistake here
let me try another
saturday and sunday
okay
so
saturday
satur needs to be changed to sunday s u
n
now s is the same so a t u r needs to be
changed to
u n so u remains the same
now if we can what we can do is we can
probably delete a delete t
and take replace r with n so this seems
to be fine
all right so we'll probably unless i'm
not seeing this so you have in
tension and you have
exception
unless i'm not seeing something it seems
like we may have made a mistake
one one thing we could do is we can
simply print out the strings that we are
checking
so let's see str1 is
i1 onwards and str
2 is i2 onwards
we are first checking intention and
exception then we check
let's also print the
result here
okay so at this point i would probably
look through the loop here and see if
the see if it is correct coming properly
so you have intention and exception
first we delete i then we delete n then
we delete n then we delete t then we
delete okay then we compare e and e so
then we come back to n and exception
and so on i think we'll have this might
take some time to fix
we'll come back to intention and
exception but supposing we've solved the
yeah supposing we've written the
recursive solution correctly and i do
have the recursive solution here
so let me just
grab that and put that in here
let's see what's different
okay probably the answer is 4 because
i'm still getting 4 but supposing we
have the recursive solution here so we
have min edit distance
this is the recursive solution
and now
what you need to do is you need to find
out the complexity of the recursive
solution now to find the complexity of
the recursive solution what we can do is
simply look at the recursive calls in
the worst case
so how you start out is you start out
with a string of length n1 let's say and
a string of length n2
we have one string of length n1 and one
string of length n2
then
you call either you call this min edit
distance with i1 plus 1 and i 2 plus 1
so str1 and str2 you call them with i 1
plus 1 and i 2 plus 1 so that's one
possibility
or
you call three recursive calls now one
recursive call is the good case where
these two match up so we want to look at
the worst case where these two things
don't match up so in that case you make
three recursive calls right so you make
three recursive calls and in each
recursive call
you are then going to reduce the problem
size by one so you're either going to
decrease i2 or you're
either going to decrease the size of the
first string or you're going to decrease
the size of the second string or you're
going to decrease the sizes of
both strings right so
just to keep things simple let's assume
that in all three we are decreasing the
size of either one of the strings by one
so we are decreasing the total problem
size which is n1 plus n2
by one right so the number of levels of
recursion is going to be the total
number of total length of each of the
two strings so let's maybe just draw
that graph here as well
so let's take
this so here you have
n1 comma n two so let's assume these are
the lengths of the two strings
now
n1 plus n2 what happens to it
is that this
n1 plus n2 calls three recursive
functions
so there are three recursive functions
so let's just draw those three recursive
functions
so we have those three recursive
functions here let's take this two
and then those in those three recursive
functions
what we have is
either you reduce either you reduce the
size of the first string
or you reduce the size of the second
string or you reduce the size of both
strings
so either you end up with
n1 minus 1 and n2
and let's reduce the size of that
or we end up with
n1
and n2 minus 1
or we end up with
n1 minus 1
and n2 minus 1
okay so these are the three recursive
calls that we're doing and then each of
these will once again make three more
recursive calls
and so on
now what is the depth overall depth of
this recursive call
now because we can see that each time
the size of the problem reduces by 1 so
if the size of problem is n1 by plus n2
in this case it reduces by 1 in this
case it reduces by 1 and in this case it
reduces by 2 but for simplification
let's say it reduces by 1 here so the
total size of the problem the total
number of levels in this tree is going
to be
n1 plus n2
so you have three problems in the first
layer the second layer will have three
square problems the third layer will
have three cube problems three times
three times three and similarly you can
go ahead and you will find that at the
last layer you will have three to the
power n plus n two minus one layers
right and if you then add together all
the layers what you end up with is that
total
total number of
sub problems is 3 to the power n 1 plus
n 2 right so you have a total of 3 to
the power n 1 plus n 2 sub problems that
you end up creating
and because of that
you have the complexity 3 to the power
of n1 plus n2 in this case
so that's
that's the complexity so here we have a
recursive solution and then we have the
complexity of the recursive solution
which is exponential 3 3 to the power of
n1 plus n2 now at this point it will
make sense to add memoization so
whenever you see recursive solutions and
you see repeated problems for example
here itself you can see a repeated
problem
and then you can see that this problem
will get repeated inside this problem
and inside this problem too so there are
a lot of repetitions and all we need to
do is remove some of those repetitions
and to remove those repetitions we can
use memoization
so what happens in the memoize solution
it is exactly the same as the recursive
solution but before doing any
computation we check a memo we check a
dictionary if we already have the
solution for the changing variables
which is i1 and i2
and if we have those
if we have those solutions
what we need to do is
just return them directly if we do not
have those solutions we need to compute
the solutions put them in the memo and
then
return the value from the memo
so let's write the memoize version so we
have min
edit distance
with str1 and str2
and this we are calling memo
okay this we are calling memo so now we
have
a memo
the memo is going to be a dictionary
and the dictionary is empty
and then we define a function recurs
so instead in memoization normally you
have to write a recursive helper
function now you can either write this
outside or inside
i like writing this inside
because
well it will have access to str2 and
they do not need to be passed in so here
we have i1 and i2
and first thing we do is we create a key
so the key is i1 comma i2
now if key in memo which means if we
have already computed the solution then
we simply return
memo of key
if not then we have all the other cases
so now we have alif
now we can check if i1
equals len of str1
in that case
don't return set the memo of key
to
len of str2
minus i2
lf
i2 equals len of str2
then we return
memo of key is
len of str1
minus i1
lf
okay in this case then we check if the
first elements are equal so we have the
exact same logic you can see the same
cases coming up here so if you have str1
of i1 equals str2 of i2
in this case we have memo of e equals we
simply ignore the first character so we
increment i1 and i2 so exactly what we
have done here so we simply call recurse
this time with i 1 plus 1
and i 2 plus 1 right so we always call
the recursive function but inside the
recursive function if it has already
been computed it will return from the
memo
and finally if we have
and this is the final case which is
where they are not equal so here memo of
key becomes
1 plus
min of
let's see here
so we have recurse so the insertion
cases
we will ignore the first element sorry
the deletion cases we will ignore the
first element of the current range from
the first string so we recall recurs
with i 1 plus 1 and i 2
otherwise we call recurse with i 1
plus 1 and i 1 plus i 2 plus 1 this is
the case where we swap the first element
of the first string so
we can just recursively check
after ignoring the first element of each
and then we have recurse with
i1
comma i2 plus 1
i2 plus 1
and there we go and that's it so now we
have stored it in the memo and then we
simply return memo of e at the very end
and finally we call
recurse
0 0 and that is our solution
and there is a syntax error you can fix
these syntaxes they're easy to fix
and i've just realized that the solution
in this case might actually be 4 because
what we can do is
we can change
n to p
so that's one step we can replace i n t
with e x c so we replace i and t with
exe that's three changes we don't change
e and we replace n with p the solution
is four so our solution was correct
there was no issue there
in fact this is not the best solution
this is a sub optimal solution
so this output should be four
and that's okay this is something that
happens all the time where
you miss something
and
you just assume that you just say that
you're going to come back to it at the
end and then you move forward assuming
that that code was right and then you
realize that either you were correct or
what your mistake was
it's probably going to happen in one of
five interviews anyway
okay so now we've written a memoi
solution
great and we can start checking the
memoi solution now so minimum edit
distance memo
let's call main edit distance memo and
we get back the value 4 looks fine let's
try saturday
and sunday as we have
so that's three so what you will do is
you will leave a as it is change a t u r
to u n by
removing a t and changing r to n
that seems fine let's test out some
cases like this okay this is three six
eight characters so that seems right we
simply delete all the characters
let's check out this
here also eight characters we have to
add eight characters let's say we have
abc and
xyz so this should be three if it is x y
z
k
then maybe that will be four
what if it's x y z a in this case also
it's four
so this seems to be working fine
we have now taken the recursive solution
identified the inefficiency calculated
the complexity which was exponential
identified the inefficiency and the
which was repeated sub problems and then
fixed the inefficiency by calling min
edit dist by using memoization
and now how do you compute the
time complexity of memoization well the
argument is if you only need to compute
the solution for a key once and the
computation apart from the recursive
calls simply involves some comparison
and a fixed number of comparison and an
addition so the time required to compute
assuming you have the recursive
solutions is constant so that means if
you simply count the number of
memoizations that can possibly occur
that gives you an upper bound on the
total num number of operations it will
be some multiple of that some constant
multiple
so i1 can take the value 0 to n 1 where
n 1 is the straight length of string 1
and i 2 can take the value 0 to n 2
where n 2 is the length of string 2. so
memo
the keys in memo can be i 1 comma i 2 so
you have n while n 1 values for i1 and 2
values for i2 so that makes it n1 times
n2
that's the number of keys and that
because there's a constant amount of
time additional time required to compute
the solution for a key that is also the
complexity so the complexity is order n1
plus n2 so we've gone from 3 to the
power of n1 plus n2 which grows very
quickly even for
3 to the power of
10 is pretty high we can check it out
here 3 to the power of 10 is something
like 59 000 3 to the power of 100 so if
you have n one plus and 2 then that's e
to the 47 that's going to be a lot of
operations on the other hand
if or in with memoization it is only
going to take let's say 100 is split as
two strings of length 50 and 50.
only going to take 2500 operation so
where it was taking 10 to the 47
operations now it takes only 2 500
operations which is pretty small so you
can still work with lists of size up to
10 000 or 100 000 very easily using the
memoi solution
so that covers this problem and keep
talking through your solution even as
you're stuck even as you're confused
just as i was
it's helpful to just keep spend maybe
two or three minutes trying to solve the
issue and if you're not able to solve
the issue just say that this is
something i'll fix later and then move
on assuming that you've
fixed it and then keep talking and keep
continue keep working on the solution
and at some point later it's possible
that the solution might like you
now at this point
you may be asked sometimes to
implement a dynamic programming or an
iterative solution like the
when you talk to the interviewer and
you're telling them that this is how i'm
thinking i'm doing i'll do a recursive
solution first and i can see that maybe
there are going to be some sub problems
there then i'm going to then apply
dynamic programming
so you can just check with them and in
most cases they will accept a
memoization solution because the dynamic
programming solutions can take a little
bit of time to solve to
implement and they're always off by off
by one errors and it's also difficult to
explain the solution so you can most
most cases get away with memoization but
if they do ask you to do it with
iteratively with dynamic programming
then you'll have to go ahead and
implement the dynamic programming
solution so once again take a couple of
minutes now and work it out on a piece
of paper and then go back to them now
for dynamic programming remember you
have to create a table essentially
so what the table will look like
in this case
is let's see if we can simulate a table
what the table will look like is
let's create a new sheet
and in this sheet let us put the two
words which is
intention
okay and let's put the word exception as
well
move this down too and let's
also put in
the indices
ultimately this is what a dynamic
programming looks like programming
problem looks like
you are ultimately going to create a
table here
and how we'll start filling the table is
the ijth element so let's say this
element
int int e e x c e
so this element represents
the edit distance or the number of
operations required to convert i n t e
into e x c e
and how do you check what the solution
is now you know that e
and e
are equal so the final elements are
equal so what that means is we look at
this value then this value should tell
us what is the minimum edit distance
between exc and exc now since we can
simply add e to each string and get this
solution that means this solution is
equal this value should is equal to this
value all right so
in the case where the corresponding
elements are equal we simply copy over
the value diagonally left top left value
onto the current cell
the other option is
if they are not equal so let's say if we
are here where here you have n and here
you have p now there are three
possibilities you you want to find
the
minimum edit distance between i and t e
n and e x c e p
now
n is not equal to p
and this is the original string so
either we delete n now if we delete n
then we need to find
the solution for i n t e and e x c e p
so if we delete n then this value will
become one plus this value that's one
possibility
or another possibility is that we swap n
so we swap n for p
so now you get this becomes p and this
becomes p so this value will becomes
will become 1 plus this value because
now we can ignore the p and simply get
this previous solution for e x c e and i
and t e so this value becomes one plus
this value
or the final option is that you can
insert something
just before n so if you insert something
just before n
which is going to be p so if you insert
p just before n
so you insert p just after n naught
before if you insert p just after n then
you have p after it already so you can
just look at this value
and
this value is going to be one more than
this value in the case that you insert
something insert p after n right so
there are three ways to come to this
value either by
deleting n
or by inserting p
or by
changing n to p and what you can do is
you can take the minimum of three values
three or these three values and add one
to obtain this value so that's the logic
roughly speaking and you start from the
left so you see okay e and i they are
unequal so you need one operation to
change them and there's nothing else
to consider so that's done then e and n
they are unequal now
you need
what you can do is
you can either delete n
if you delete n then you simply need to
check e and i
and you know that the solution for e and
i is one so this would be two
another another option is that you could
possibly insert something but if you
insert something the length of i n is
going to increase so that's going to
cause a problem so you can't insert
anything another option is you change n
with e but if you change n with e
then you will no longer be able to
if you change n with e
then you will no longer be able to use
this solution
right because now you will have to match
i
with the empty list
so that's going to be one as well so
overall you end up with two and this is
how you start filling the list so you
start filling up from left to right
and left to right and keep going top to
bottom and as you fill out this list
finally you will fill out this final
value exception and intention and that
will be your solution so that's the
dynamic programming solution and you can
see that it's getting tricky to convey
the entire solution because there are so
many cases involved here so typically
you will not find dynamic programming
solutions to requested in interviews and
it will help you to just stick to the
memoization solutions
all right so with that
we have covered
two common interview questions and you
can keep going so the idea here
is to just apply the method
remember the remember the method the
problem solving template that we've
covered state the problem
identify input and output formats write
a function signature come up with some
example inputs and outputs or at least
the scenarios come up with the correct
solution stated in plain english
implement the solution test it using
example inputs and fix bugs if you face
any then analyze the algorithms
complexity and identify inefficiencies
and finally apply the right technique to
overcome the inefficiency and you repeat
the process
going back and stating the solution
implementing analyzing and
repeating now you in some cases you do
not need to implement the root force
solution if you don't have the time but
when you're working with recursive
solutions it always helps to implement
brute force first before you do
memoization or dynamic programming
and some tips
ask questions
as many questions as you can as many as
you need to clarify the problem show an
example
follow the method don't panic
if you get stuck at a certain point
give it a couple of minutes sometimes
you can even ask the interviewer and
they may be able to tell you that
maybe what your error is or
maybe you're not stuck at all what
you're
simply assuming something incorrectly
but beyond a few minutes what you want
to say is that
let i'll fix this later assuming this is
correct let's move on and then talk
about complexity and optimization and
such and such
very important is to state the brute
force solution to the interviewer and if
you are unable to figure out a more
optimal solution
then the best thing you can do is to
offer to implement the brute force
solution so that you can at least
demonstrate that you are able to write
code and it's all right in a lot of
cases you will not be able to
figure out the optimal solution and in
some cases there may not be an optimal
way so there are some there are certain
problems where there is just one way and
that is the hard way or the brute force
way and this is typically
very true with a
family of problems called backtracking
something we've not really covered
in a lot of detail
but it is also another form of recursion
so
what do you do next so the next step for
you ish is to review this lecture video
and solve these problems yourself
or take more problems ideally what you
want to do is you want to take all the
five
different techniques that we've covered
and let's quickly review what those five
techniques were
the first one was binary search so we
looked at linear search and binary
search which is a form of divide and
conquer
and along with that we also understood
the complexity and big o notation and
then you had some homework on linked
lists and python classes but binary
search is something that comes up often
and the hint to detect binary search is
simply to look for order whenever you
see something being something being
mentioned mentioned as sorted now that
is an indication for you that this may
be binary search sometimes what you may
have to do is you may have to
get things into a sorted form maybe by
taking
replacing elements by
sum of values till that element or so on
and once you get things into a sorted
form maybe then you can do binary search
that's one way to go about it and once
again just do five to ten problems on
binary search and you will be able to
identify pretty much any binary search
question in an interview
then the next topic that we looked at
was binary search trees traversals
and
here is something
that is generally asked very directly so
you will be given a question like binary
search tree do something with the binary
search tree and you can answer that
question directly we've covered a lot of
different things here so do check out
lesson two for all the different things
you can do with binary search trees
traversals balancing
and most of these are recursive
solutions so it's also a good exercise
on recursion and we've also looked at
balanced binary trees and how can we
optimize them further
then you had an assignment on hash
tables so hashing is a again a common
question that is often asked so we built
hash tables from scratch in python and
we also handled collisions using a
technique called linear probing and so
this is something you can check out in
assignment two so you may get asked just
to implement a hash table in python or
implement
collision
resolution in a hash table in which case
you can use linear probing
then you have the sorting algorithms
where we looked at bubble sort and
insertion sort merge sort using divide
and conquer and quick sort where we had
a quadratic worst case complexity but
a logarithmic average complexity and
that's a good thing because merge sort
although it is logarithmic in the
worst case it still takes up a lot of
space and space allocation is slow and
you may also not have the memory
that's why we sometimes use prefer quick
sort over merge sort when we are
constrained for space
then
assignment 3 is pretty interesting where
you will implement
an optimal algorithm for polynomial
multiplication using divide and conquer
so do check out assignment 3 as well
then we looked at dynamic programming we
looked at recursion memoization
subsequence and abstract problems and
then we finally also didn't cover
backtracking and pruning but we there
are some questions there in the lesson
notebook which you can try out which use
backtracking and pruning as well then we
looked at graph algorithms the last time
which was
graphs and adjacency list and adjacency
matrices we looked at the depth first
and breadth first search and how to
implement them and we also looked at
shortest paths and directed and weighted
graphs
this is a very important topic breadth
first in depth first search you will get
many questions related to these so do
solve maybe five questions on each of
these topics
and you should be good with most graph
problems asked in interviews now this
project for you the course project if
you haven't seen it already
is to pick a coding problem so you can
pick a coding problem from an online
source like lead code hacker rank geeks
for geeks etc and then use the problem
solving template that we've shared with
you
this problem solving template as a
starting point so just give it a name
and then write the problem statement and
implement the solution step by step to
use the problem solving template to
solve the problem using the method
you've learned in the course then
document your solution add explanations
wherever required perform the complexity
analysis
all of this you should add in the
jupyter notebook and then publish your
notebook to your jovian profile
and finally you can submit the link to
your jovian notebook
here
do submit the link to your jovi notebook
and you can check out
the discussion where
you can
change
where you can post what you what you're
working on so do post your notebook as
well and finally today we have looked at
a couple of real interview questions
from amazon and google and how to go
about solving them
and we also
addressed a few issues that we faced
along the way
so that was a helpful exercise
and that's it so now you can review the
lecture video execute the jupyter
notebooks complete the assignments and
attempt the optional questions so that
the topics that we've covered they get
consolidated and you do not ever have to
look at this lecture again right
practice is what really reinforces and
consolidates your learning
complete the assignments and attend the
optional questions to practice and
participate in forum discussions also
very useful when you participate in
forum discussions why by answering
questions a lot of your own doubts get
cleared so do participate in forum
discussions and then join or start a
study group if possible getting together
with a group of four or five people is
great it really helps you
focus
and uh
improve your understanding by discussion
so that's data structures and algorithms
in python
with that thank you very much for
joining us on this journey as we learn
data structures and algorithms in python
a very useful topic to improve your
coding skills and also something that
you will almost certainly encounter in
one of your interviews no matter which
company you're applying to so i hope
this is helpful to you do let us know on
the forum how
this course helped you if it did
you can let us know in the youtube
comments as well if you have questions
if something was not clear do post that
too when we make sure to come up with
clearer explanations and clearer
examples the next time
if you have any feedback for us do post
it in the comments or send us an email
at support jovian.ai
with that i will take leave and i will
see you in the forums this is not the
end of our journey with you so do stay
active on joven there's a lot of great
activity happening do check out the
forums the newsletter and
stay tuned for our next course thank you
and goodbye